ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL WITH
SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY ALL THE SENATORS
ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING ARE IN THE HEARING
ROOM I WOULD ASK THE CONSULTANT
TO CALL THE ROOM ROLE NOW SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH THE MEMBERS WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING. BACK IN. HERE
WHEN DOES TAN HERE. HE WENT
AHEAD TENDING TODAY OUR CENTERS
AIKMAN AND PAM. FOR THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I GUESS
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNISED IT USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE ON THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ADD MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON YOU
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING ALL
RIGHTY PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
THEM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND
I WILLANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX TWO FIVE ONE FOUR ZERO
SEVEN. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES DIM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND YOUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
TELL ONE TEN ZERO. PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE A NEEDED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
FROM. A PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HEAR FROM
YOU. LOOK FORTY HEARING FROM
YOU. AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL. MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED. FROM THE HEARING ROOM
AND OR HAVE THEIR LINE
DISCONTINUED. IN TODAY'S BUDGET
HEARING WE'RE- REVIEWING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I WILL NOTE THAT ITEM.
ISSUE THIRTY FOUR. IS BEING
PULLED OFF THE AGENDA FOR TODAY
. BUT THAT STILL LEAVES US WITH
THIRTY SEVEN AGENDA ITEMS AND SO
IT WE ANTICIPATE A LENGTHY
HEARING. WE WOULD APPRECIATE
PEOPLE BEING CONCISE AND I OUR
FIRST OUR FIRST- INFORMATIONAL
AREA IS GOING TO BE CONCERNING
OUR HEARING IMPAIRED COMMUNITY
SO WE ASK. OUR PRESENTERS TO
PLEASE PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY-
FOREVER OR NOT AT AN INCREASED
RATE JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE
HERE INTERPRETING AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE. AND FOR THAT PROCESS-
TO BE HEARD. IN TODAY'S HEARING
WE WILL BE ASKING THE DEPARTMENT
SPENT SOME TIME DISCUSSING HIS
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN CAL IN.
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE HOUSING
AND THE NEW MOBILE CRISIS
INTERVENTION SERVICES OF
BENEFIT. AFTER THE DEPARTMENT'S
PRESENTATION WILL BE COMPLAINING
CONVENING A PANEL OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS COMMUNITY HEALTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROVIDERS.
ADVOCATES FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONSUMERS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND A COUNTY
HOUSING AUTHORITY TO DISCUSS HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS.
MAY HELP CREATE. THANK YOU HELP
CREATE A COMPLETE CONTINUUM OF
CARE FOR CALIFORNIANS WILL WE
MIGHT MAKE AND WHERE WE MIGHT
MAKE ADDITIONAL IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS. TWENTY DISCUSSIONS
HAVE CONCLUDED WILL ASK THE
DEPARTMENTS TO VERY BRIEFLY
PRESENT ALL OF THEIR REMAINING
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS. AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE CHANGES AFTER
WHICH I AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. WILL ASPECTS OF
THE QUESTIONS- BEFORE GET OUR
FAMILY LIKE TO MAKE ANY COM. NO
ALL RIGHT SO LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE PRESENTATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WELCOME AND PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR VIEW. GOOD
MORNING DIRECTOR BASS. FOURTEEN
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR PAN. START
WITH THE OVERVIEW OF THE DH YES
BUDGET- THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE INTEGRATED HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE INCLUDING
MEDICAL DENTAL MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
SERVICES AND LONG TERM CARE. TO
FULFILL OUR MISSION THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES MINISTERS A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUAL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE
STATE'S MEDICAID PROGRAM OR
MEDICARE WHICH PROVIDES
HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME PERSONS AND FAMILIES TO
MEET DEFINED ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. THIS IMPORTANT
STATE FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP
PROVIDES VITAL HEALTH CARE TO
OVER FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
OR ABOUT ONE IN THREE
CALIFORNIANS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT POINT
THREE BILLION FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR OF THAT- ONE POINT THREE
FIVE BILLION AS FOUR STATE
OPERATIONS INCLUDING FOUR
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR EMPLOYEES. AT A. HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN BILLION FOR OUR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE. IN RESPONSE
YOUR QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA-
DHS WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM. AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY THIRD. FORTY SIX CHILDREN
ARE ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM OUR
VENDOR MAXIMIZES CURRENTLY
REACHING OUT TO AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY TWO FAMILIES SUBMITTED
PARTIAL APPLICATIONS IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN THE MISSING INFORMATION
AND COMPLETE ELIGIBILITY REVIEW
FOR THESE CHILDREN. PRIOR TO THE
LAUNCH IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND I'M GOING TO TEACH YES
CONVENE STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUPS
TO INFORM APPLICATION PROCESS
REFINEMENT IN BENEFIT STRUCTURE
AND ON GROWING PROGRAM
ENHANCEMENTS TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAM IS APPROPRIATELY AND
ADEQUATELY SERVING ITS INTENDED
POPULATION. WITH KNOWLEDGE
HOWEVER THE PROGRAM REFINEMENTS
ARE STILL NEEDED ON A CONTINUOUS
BASIS AND ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON A PLAN TO
INCREASE CHILD ENROLLMENT BUYING
GREEN APPLICATIONS AND
INFORMATIONAL MATERIALS WHEN
INFANTS ARE REFERRED. FOR
HEARING RELATED SERVICES DUE TO
CALIFORNIA'S NEWBORN HEARING
SCREENING PROGRAM AND EXTENDING
THE TIME ALLOWED A TOTAL OF
SIXTY DAYS FOR APPLICANTS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO COMPLETE AN ACTIVE
APPLICATION RATHER THAN NEEDING
TO REAPPLY. BUT PLAN TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION OF QUALIFIED
PROVIDERS THERE'S SOME CONFUSION
REGARDING THE PROGRAM PROVIDER
DIRECTORY PROVIDERS DO NOT NEED
TO OPT IN TO FIND A PROVIDER
WEBPAGE INCLUDES MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS. I CCS PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNICATION DISORDER CLINICS.
DHS'S TRYING TO MAXIMIZE OUR FEE
FOR SERVICE MEDICARE PROVIDERS
THROUGH THE STATE TO RENDER
PROGRAM COVERED BENEFITS. THIS
LEVERAGES PROVIDERS THAT ARE
FAMILIAR WITH EXISTING PAPER
SERVICE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AND
CLAIMS POLICIES. WE ARE ALSO
OFFERING PUBLIC PROVIDER
WEBINARS TAILORED TRAINING Q.
AND A SESSIONS FOR MEDICAL TEAMS
PROVIDER NETWORKS AND
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND DIRECT
INQUIRY SUPPORT. WE'RE ALSO
UPDATING OUR BILLING CODES ON A
ROLLING BASIS AS NEW CODES ARE
ADDED OR REVISED FOR COMPLIANCE
OR BASED ON FURTHER MEDICAL
RESEARCH AND SUBJECT TO THE
SCOPE OF THE PROGRAM AT THE
READY TO COVER HEARING AIDS AND
HEARING RELATED SERVICES.
HOWEVER WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S A
LACK OF FAMILIARITY WITH THIS
NEW RELATIVELY NEW PROGRAM AND
WE'RE ADDRESSING THIS THROUGH
TARGETED PROVIDER OUTREACH AND
SUPPORT YOUR QUARTERLY PROVIDER
WEBINARS. INCLUDING ONE
SCHEDULED FOR MARCH SEVENTEENTH.
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THE NEWBORN
HEARING SCREENING PROGRAM.
CONTINUED STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
YOUR MONTHLY UPDATES VIA THAT
MEDIC HEALTH CONSUMER FOCUS
STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUP. AND AD
HOC DISCUSSIONS WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING
PROCEDURAL IMPROVEMENTS ARE RICH
OPPORTUNITIES AND PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. YOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
. I LMAO. TOMORROW WITH THE LA-
WE'RE JUST NOT IN THE BUDGET
INCLUDES A SUBSTANTIAL PROPOSED
INCREASED- DETAIL IN GENERAL
FUND SPENDING BETWEEN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE WHICH TRANSLATES TO ABOUT
A 30% INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR OR
ABOUT 80% OF THIS EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE FOR FAST
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS WHEN THE
REMAINING 20% REFLECT NEW
DISCRETIONARY PROPOSALS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. THESE ISSUES WILL BE
DISCUSSED IN MORE DETAIL ON THE
NEXT PANEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR ANYTHING ON THIS. YES THE
DIRECTOR BOSSY MEANT I'D MAYBE I
MISSED IT I HEARD YOU SAID- THAT
WE HAVE FORTY SIX. PEOPLE
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM DID YOU
MENTION HOW MANY HAVE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED HEARING AIDS SOME
HEARING AIDS IN THE DISPENSING
THIS PROGRAM. YOU WANT ME TO
RESPOND SO- GIVEN THAT THE TIME
LAPSE IN REGARDS TO YOU WITH IT
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED VERSES
BUILD IN STAR THIS IS JC COULD
BURST OF MEDICAID DIRECTOR- WEEK
WE DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER
OF HOW MANY HEARING AIDS HAVE
BEEN DISPENSED AT THIS TIME.
GIVEN THE CURRENT CLAIMS LAG SO
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE THAT REPORT OUT AS WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION OKAY
SO I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION I
NOTED HERE FROM SOME OF THE
ADVICE OF THE ADVOCATES REPORTED
THE LEAST- AND ARE RIGHT UP-
SEVEN I REALIZE THAT. HE SAID
MAY BE CLAIMS LIKE. SO FORTY SIX
ENROLLED HOW MANY SHOULD WE BE
IN ROLLING I MEAN YOU OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE BUDGETED FUNDS IN THE PAST
YOU KNOW FOR THE PAST YEAR
ACTUALLY COUPLE YEARS- SO FORTY
SIX OUT OF HOW MANY- SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ENROLLED ARE ARE ARE WHAT
WAS OUR GOAL FOR ENROLLMENT. IN
THIS PROGRAM. SO I DON'T THINK
WE NECESSARILY HAD A- GOAL FOR
THE PROGRAM JUST TO BE CLEAR I
THINK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PROBABLY GET THE INFORMATION OUT
TO PROVIDERS TO BENEFICIARIES
COMMUNICATE PEOPLE REGARDS THE
ACCESS. I THINK IT'S A HARD ONE
FOR US TO KNOW WHAT OTHER
INSURANCES ARE AND ARE NOT
COVERING IN REGARDS TO THE%
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD. I BE
NEEDING THESE SERVICES I THINK
RIGHT NOW WE'RE TRYING TO REALLY
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES- IT'S YOU
KNOW THROUGH THE NORMAL
CHANNELS- AS DIRECTOR BOSS
MENTIONED. OUT TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE AWARE OF THE PROGRAM
AND THAT THEY COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM IF THEY
NEED TO. I'M SO IT'S A IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN OUR
NORMAL PROGRAMS WHERE WE HAVE
ENROLLED POPULATION- AND WE HAVE
SOME MORE. AVAILABILITY AND
INSIGHT INTO WHO SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE AND HOW TO GET THAT
WORD OUT SO IT IS A NEW PROGRAM
WE KNOW PEOPLE ARE GETTING USED
TO IT. I'M SO WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY I'D YOU KNOW WORK THROUGH
THOSE CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION
SO UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
THAT. A GOAL OR A NUMBER IN
MIND. HELLO MELISSA THIS WAY AT
LEAST TO DEVELOP THAT BUDGETARY
NUMBER BY WE HAVE A CS CASE
PROJECTIONS SUPPORT SOMEONE MUST
HAVE. AT LEAST COME UP WITH A
NUMBER TO SAY. WE ANTICIPATED
THIS IS HOW MANY PEOPLE KNOW
IT'S CLEARLY I GUESS WITH FORTY
SIX I ASSUME THAT'S GOING TO
LOWER NUMBER DOES THAT THAT THAT
WAS NOT WHAT WAS ANTICIPATED-
THERE WAS MUST HAVE BEEN SOME.
ESTIMATE MADE AS TO HOW MANY
PEOPLE I MEAN SOMETIMES ARE
WRONG I GET IT I MEAN I'VE BEEN
ON BUDGET FOR AWHILE- BUT-
USUALLY LIKE WHETHER IT'S THIS
OR YOU KNOW OUR WORLD MEDIC COW
CASELOAD OR- SOCIAL SERVICE CASE
LOAD HOW MANY PEOPLE SIGN UP FOR
E. I. T. C. I CAN JUST ROLL
PROGRAM AFTER PROGRAM OVER AND
THAT'S HOW WE DEVELOP A BUDGET-
SO I JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT- AND
I GUESS IN THE PAST. LAST YEAR-
WHICH IS THE YEAR YOU KNOW WE
DID BUDGET FUNDS FOR THIS. THERE
MUST HAVE BEEN SOME PROJECTION
EIGHTY FIVE WHETHER IT'S SPEECH
CS OR BY THE PART OF FINANCE FOR
NUMBER. PEOPLE EXPECTED TO BE
ENROLLED. I WOULD SAY THAT THE
BUDGET DID THIS. MYSTIC HIGHER.
NUMBER INDIVIDUAL. BASED ON JUST
A- OF THIS. WHO BUT- WE COULD. I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT THE
BUDGET ESTIMATE WAS- SITE NEAR
VERY INCREASED IN REGARDS TO
WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING- I
WOULD NEED TO GO BACK IN. AND
THEN CONSULT WITH THE TEAM- I
DOCTOR PAN AND HAPPY TO OFF LINE
IN REGARDS TO WHAT WAS ASSUMED
IN THE BUDGET. I DON'T HAVE
THOSE EXACT NUMBERS IN FRONT OF
ME I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. IT'S
TIME I GUESS IN THE TAXI. NOW
THAT THE MORE IMPORTANT QUESTION
ACTUALLY IS AND WHAT LAST YEAR
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WHAT THE
RESULT OF A LOWER BODY FOR THIS
COMING YEAR. RIGHT SO MAYBE THAT
WAS MADE BY RENEE REVISED BUT IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO KNOW. YEAH
I'D REALIZE YOU'RE TRYING TO OUT
REACH AND SO FORTH BUT- WE NEED
SOME BENCHMARKS TO MEASURE OUR-
LEVEL OF SUCCESS OR FAILURE. AND
SO WHAT IS THE ANTICIPATED
ENROLLMENT. FOR THE COMING.
FISCAL YEAR. AND AND THEN WE CAN
CERTAINLY- WHEN THERE'S ANOTHER
HEARING A YEAR LATER READ IT AND
REVISIT THAT AND SAY OKAY WERE
WE SUCCESSFUL OR NOT SO I
REALIZE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
RE DIRECT SOME RESOURCES TO.
REACH IN OTHER TYPES OF THINGS.
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ONLY HAVE
FORTY SIX ENROLLED HEADSET. SO
SOMETHING DEFINITELY DIDN'T WORK
RIGHT THERE- BUT I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THANK YOU MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAN GOING BACK LAST
YEAR PERHAPS- FOCUS THE EFFORTS
ON WAS SO WHAT. WHAT DO WE
ANTICIPATE. SHOULD BE THAN ROMAN
FOR THIS COMING YEAR. RIGHT AND
WHAT ARE YOU. AND THEN HOW THAT
FACTOR INTO THE BUDGET BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY HOW MANY PEOPLE.
SHOULD BE AND HOW WITH THE
NUMBERS COME UP YOU KNOW HOW
THAT NUMBER WAS DEVELOPED-
BECAUSE- WE CERTAINLY HAVE DATA
ON. THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
OUT THERE WHO- YOU MAY NEED THE
SERVICES I REALIZED THAT- YOU
KNOW THERE'S SOME. COMPLICATED
TERMS A FIGURE OUT OF COVERAGE
AND SO FORTH BUT WE CERTAINLY
HAVE A SENSE OF THE- I THINK
THERE'S THERE ARE. THERE'S DATA
ABOUT THE PREVALENCE OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE HEARING IMPAIRED WHO-
WHO COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM. YEAH I AGREE I MY TEAM
ACTUALLY ABLE TO PING ME- DURING
HEARING IT LOOKS THE BUDGET-
WHAT BUILT ON A- ON AN ANNUAL. A
FULL. ONCE WE GET UP. AROUND TO
SEVEN THOUSAND. SO AGAIN YEAH
BURIED. A LOT OF MORE IN THE
BUDGET THAN WHAT. I PRESUME
YOU'RE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- DO ADDITIONAL ANALYTICS
TO UNDERSTAND- WHAT DROVE TO THE
TO THE SIX OR SEVEN THOUSAND
BUT- THAT CLEARLY. LESS THAN
FIVE YOU KNOW WHAT'S CURRENTLY
ARE. SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN
WHAT'S CURRENTLY RECEIVING
PROGRAM I. GUESS SO- AND I'M
SURE WE'LL HEAR FROM- THE
WITNESSES BUT CLEARLY THIS DID
NOT WORK IF WE ONLY GOT FORTY
SIX OR DISSIPATING SIX TO SEVEN
THOUSAND SELL SOMETHING
SOMETHING'S GONE TERRIBLY WRONG
HERE. AND HOPEFULLY- WE'LL HEAR
FROM. THE WITNESSES AS TO STRAP
SOME IDEAS OF HOW WE CAN FIX IT
AND WHAT WE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
PUT INTO IT TO MAKE SURE IT
WORKS. THANK YOU- THIRTY BUCKS
TO WIN DO WE KNOW THE ENTIRE
POPULATION THAT EXISTS WHO WHO
DON'T HAVE HEARING AIDS AND
WOULD. WOULDN'T THIS WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR. DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT THAT NUMBER IS THAT
THE SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND I THINK
THAT THAT THAT IS OUR ESTIMATE
SIX TO SEVEN THOUSAND- THAT
COULD THAT COULD MEET THESE
THESE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA OKAY
AND WHAT'S THE BIGGEST BARRIER
TO GETTING THE WORD OUT DO YOU
KNOW. I MEAN IT IT'S A NEW
PROGRAM- AND SO AND YOU KNOW
IT'S- IT'S A LITTLE BIT
SPECIALIZE BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW THAT THE TRADITIONAL WAYS
WE DO OUTREACH- GENERALLY THESE.
THESE FAMILIES HAVE SOME TYPE OF
COVERAGE AND SO HOW DO WE- DO WE
NEED TO KIND OF WORK ON OUR
MECHANISMS TO DO NOT REACH THE
PROVIDER- EDUCATION- AND SOME OF
THE- BED THAT TARGETED OUTREACH
THAT WE DISCUSSED- THAT WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH. THANK YOU
WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
THIS PROGRESSES OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. I'M
SORRY. WE S. AND NOW WE'LL TURN
TO OUR WITNESSES FOR THEIR INPUT
. AN EXPERIENCE. WELCOME YOUNG
PEOPLE. WE APPRECIATE YOU COMING
TODAY AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
BRAVERY OF SHOWING UP HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE ROOM DURING A
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KIM ME
WHEN. HELLO SENATOR PAN IT'S
REALLY NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN I
WAS HERE TO TESTIFY TWO YEARS
AGO. AND THAT WAS FOR THE LEAD
CALIFORNIA HEARING BILL SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SUPPORTING THAT
. NOW I HAVE YOU KNOW THAT I'M A
SINGLE MOTHER AND I'M FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. I HAVE TWO
GIRLS WITH ME AND YOU'VE MET
THEM BEFORE THEY WERE WITH ME
THE LAST TIME I CAME TO SPEAK.
I'VE ADVOCATED FOR THIS BILL FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND I WAS REALLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THAT DIDN'T
PASS BUT IT WAS A HUGE RELIEF.
ALAS MY PLACE I'M SORRY ONE
MOMENT- IT WAS A RELIEF TO SEE
THAT THERE WAS GOING TO BE SOME
COVERAGE FOR HEARING AIDS
STARTING IN JULY. BUT I WAS
DEVASTATED TO FIND OUT THE MY
DAUGHTER'S WOULDN'T QUALIFY
BECAUSE I ME
PARTIAL COVERAGE I WORK FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I DO HAVE
SOME INSURANCE BUT THE INSURANCE
ONLY COVERS ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF THE SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
COST. FOR HEARING AIDS THAT
MEANS THAT I WOULD HAVE TO PAY
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY
THREE YEARS FOR MY DAUGHTER'S
HEARING AIDS. BECAUSE THE MOLDS
IN THE HEARING AIDS THEMSELVES
CHANGE. AND NOT ONLY THAT NOW I
WORK WHICH ALSO MEANS THAT I
HAVE TO TRAVEL TO UCSF IN SAN
FRANCISCO BECAUSE THERE'S NO
LOCAL PROVIDER IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA. SO I HAVE TO TRAVEL LARGE
DISTANCES TO FIND A PROVIDER
THAT WILL PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
NOW MY DAUGHTER SHE WROTE A
STORY ONE TIME ABOUT HOW MUCH MY
MOM WORKS AND THE STRESS THAT
THIS CAUSES. SO I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL MAKE SOME SERIOUS CHANGES
TO THIS PROGRAM THE FORMER
PROVIDE ME RELIEF AND ALSO
RELIEF TO ALL THE FAMILIES WHO
COULD BENEFIT FROM HAVING
HEARING AIDS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS NANCY. AND I AM
READY FOR THE RETIRED DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING PROGRAM
CONSULTANT AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I AM
CURRENTLY A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HANDS AND VOICES
WHICH IS THE LARGEST FAMILY
ORGANIZATION CONNECTION- AND FOR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. IF THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS WITH
THE HACCP AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TWO OF THE LARGEST
PROBLEMS FOR FAMILIES ONE IS
THAT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
PROVIDERS FOR THE PROGRAMS FOR
FAMILIES FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO TRAVEL TO THE
BAY AREA TO GET SERVICES THIS
INCLUDES FAMILIES FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY ALL THE WAY TO
THE NORTH. THE WAY NORTH TO THE
OREGON BORDER. IN FACT IS THE
FAMILY'S WHO HAVE INSURANCE THAT
COVERS PART OF THE COST F THEIR
HEARING AIDS HAVE TO COVER THE
REMAINING COSTS THEMSELVES
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND THIS MIGHT BE
SEVERAL THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FAMILIES NEED YOUR HELP THE
ACC'S FIFTY. AM IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT THE HACCP
IS NOT AS UPSET AND SAID THAT
DOES NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM THAT
FAMILIES FACE. IT THANK YOU.
NEXT PERSON PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME. I AM ELEVEN YEARS OLD AND
WEAR HEARING. I DON'T CARE IF.
OKAY. HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA I'M
A LEVIN AND WE'RE HEARING AIDS
I'VE BEEN COMING TO SACRAMENTO
SINCE FIRST GRADE TO ADVOCATE
FOR CHILDREN'S ACCESS TO HEARING
AIDS I WANT TO THANK YOU THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT NEED TO HELP
FAMILIES STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR
THEIR KIDS HERE HE IS WITH THIS
PROGRAM. IT MAKES US FEEL SEEN
CARED FOR. I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOU FOR YOUR AGAIN. I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS. PURPOSE
HEATING IN THIS PROGRAM. I HAVE
ACCESS BECAUSE MY PARENTS ARE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
PRIVATIZED. I LEARNED THAT SOME
CHILDREN ARE ARE YOU A THREE TO
SIX MONTHS TO GET IN TO SEE A
PROVIDER. I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT
IT WOULD BE LIKE. NOT TO MY
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE HALF FULL
ACCESS INSTRUCTION IN THE
CLASSROOM. FOR THAT MONTH. I
KNOW AND FEEL POWERLESS
DISCONNECTED LEFT OUT OF ME. I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SOME CHILDREN WHO NEED THE
INCOME ELIGIBILITY THAT ARE
BEING LEFT OUT. I BELIEVE WE CAN
CHANGE SIX. HOW DOES MAKE H. AC
HE WORK FOR CHILDREN IN NEED SO
THEY CAN REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL I LOOK FORWARD TO
COMING BACK NEXT YEAR JAMES
STORIES OF ALL THE CHILDREN'S
LIVES HE CHANGED. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE- THIS IS MY DAUGHTER
MARIE I'M THE CHAIR OF LET
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE WE'RE A
COALITION OF PARENTS IN
PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATES. WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE FOR RECOGNIZING
THIS NEED- THAT THAT FAMILIES
HAVE- NEARLY NINE MONTHS IN WITH
SIX POINT SEVEN TO ADMINISTER A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM. ONLY
FORTY SIX CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
ENROLLED AND ONLY SEVEN ARE
KNOWN TO HAVE RECEIVED HEARING
AIDS I HAVE SPOKEN TO THE EIGHT
CENTERS WHO HAVE OPTED IN WITHIN
THIS WEEK AND WE KEEP A RUNNING
TALLY- THE BIGGEST ISSUE PARENTS
FACE IS FINDING A PEDIATRIC
PROVIDER TO SERVE CHILDREN. DH
CS REPORTS THERE'S TWENTY EIGHT
PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
OPTED IN TO SERVE CHILDREN BUT
ONE CENTER WHO LISTED FIFTEEN OF
THEIR AUDIOLOGIST HAS DECIDED
THEY CAN ONLY AFFORD. TO
DEDICATE ONE SO THAT IS FOURTEEN
PEDIATRIC AUDIOLOGIST TO SERVE
SEVEN THOUSAND ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN. LARGE PEDIATRIC
PROVIDERS- THAT HAVE NOT OPTED
IN SIGHT ASCENTIAL PEDIATRIC
CODES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
PUBLISHED TO DATE WITH
REIMBURSEMENT RATES- AND THAT
THE THAT THE RATES ARE EVEN
LOWER THAN CCS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN UPDATED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE WENT
FROM A PROVIDER'S TWO THREE
PROVIDERS. IN LOS ANGELES IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE LARGEST
PEDIATRIC CENTER CLOSE DOWN TO
THE PARAMEDICS AND REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ANOTHER ONE WENT IN IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THEY CLOSE
THEIR DOORS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- IN DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE MANY FAMILIES WORKING
UNDER THE 6100% FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM BUT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE ONE OF TWO
SCENARIOS THEIR CHILD IS
APPROVED AND THEY CAN'T FIND A
PEDIATRIC PROVIDER IN THE COUNTY
THAT ACCEPTS THE PROGRAM. THESE
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY THOSE UNDER
THE AGE OF FIVE WILL NEED TO BE
SEEN MULTIPLE TIMES A YEAR AS
OUR LITTLE YOURS GROW THEIR
WORKING PARENTS WILL NEED TO
TRAVEL GREAT DISTANCES TO THE
NEAREST PROVIDER WHO'S OPTED
INTO X. TO EXPERIENCE THREE TO
SIX MONTHS WAIT TIME AND THEY
WILL BE MISSING CRITICAL
DEVELOPMENTAL MILESTONES DURING
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
PARTICIPATING PROVIDERS IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA. THERE
ARE NO PARTICIP THERE ARE NO
PARTICIPATING PROVIDERS FIFTY OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH 25% OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN IN LOS
ANGELES THERE'S ONLY ONE SMALL
PEDIATRIC PRACTITIONER IN
BURBANK- THIRTY. OKAY THE SECOND
NARROWS THEIR CHILD IS DENIED
BECAUSE OUR HEALTH PLAN THEY PAY
FOR HAS PARTIAL COVERAGE BETWEEN
FIVE AND A THOUSAND TO PAY FOR
SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR HEARING
AIDS. OR THEY HAVE A TEACHER
MICROTIA AND THERE YOUR CANALS
ARE NOT DEVELOPED AND THEY NEED
A BONE CONDUCTION HEARING AID
THAT CODE HASN'T BEEN APPROVED
YET. AND THEY HAVE TO CHOOSE
THEY THEY HAVE TO PAY BETWEEN
TEN AND TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THAT DEVICE. WE HEARD SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE ALLOCATION THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE RECOGNIZED THIS IS
A NEED IN OUR STATE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THIS PROGRAM IT ACHIEVES
ITS INTENDED PURPOSE. THE
ESTIMATE. YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
TWO BIRTH DATA IT IS SEVEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN THAT WERE
PROJECTED TO BE SERVED IN THE
STATE WITH THIS PROGRAM- ABOUT
TO ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THOSE-CHILDREN SHOULD BE COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR EVERY YEAR. SO
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE. BECAUSE
HEARING AIDS REPLACED EVERY
THREE YEARS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS TODAY.
OKAY DR- SO I DIDN'T HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS FOR- DH CS
AFTER WE'VE HEARD THIS TESTIMONY
BECAUSE- IF YOU KNOW YOUR
TESTIMONY TALKED ABOUT OUTREACH
AND CERTAINLY- THERE MAY BE
IGNORANCE OF THE PROGRAM BUT
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
WITNESSES THAT. THERE ARE A
PROVIDER SO I MEAN I REPRESENT
SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO REGION I
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU LIVE HERE-
WE'RE A LARGE METROPOLITAN AREA
I MEAN WE'RE IN THE TOP FIFTY
FOR THE WHOLE COUNTRY. AND
THERE'S NO PROVIDER. THE RESULTS
ARE HEARING YOU CORRECT ME IF
THE IF THEY'RE WRONG PLEASE
PLEASE CORRECT ME- ARE CORRECT
US- YOU KNOW IF YOU HEARD LOS
ANGELES. PERHAPS SOME OF THE
LARGEST METROPOLITAN AREAS IN
THE WHOLE COUNTRY- HAS SOUNDS
LIKE AS ONE. SO SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S A NETWORK ISSUE HERE AS
WELL I MEAN WE CAN WE CAN GO AND
TRY TO MAKE PEOPLE EVER PROGRAM
BUT WHEN PEOPLE GO AND TRY TO
ACCESS A PROGRAM AND THEY FIND
OUT THAT. THERE'S NO PROVIDER.
AND THEY'RE STILL STUCK WITH A
HUGE PORTION OF THE COST I CAN
IMAGINE THAT IT'S NOT LACK OF
AWARENESS ANYMORE ACTUALLY IT IS
AWARENESS TEN DAYS. THEN DECIDED
IT'S- NOT REALLY HELPING THAT
MUCH. SO SO I KNOW YOU'RE DOING
LOTS OF OUT REACH AND SO FORTH
CONTINUES PLEASE SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE OF ADEQUATE NETWORKS. LOTS
OF PEOPLE HAVE TO TRAVEL FAR
DISTANCES- TO GET. THE HELP THEY
NEED WE'RE GONNA DO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO ABOUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT PAYMENT- SO THAT
DID IT SO THAT KNOWING MORE
PROVIDERS SO THAT MORE OF THIS
GETS COVERED- SO I MEAN THESE
AND THEN YOU KNOW BUT THE WAIT
TIMES. CERTAINLY IS A
DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN.
THREE SIX MONTHS FOR A YOUNG
CHILD IS A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
FOR THEM NOT TO BE ABLE TO GET
HELP. SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
GOALS ARE IN TERMS OF WEIGHT
TIME PARTICULARLY FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN WEAR HEARING SPRINKLE
FOR LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT. AND IT
BY NOT ADDRESSING THIS CASE-
WE'RE GONNA ACTUALLY. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY OF COURSE FOR THE
CHILD IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT- BUT-
EVEN FOR THE STATE AND THEN AT
THE WHAT DOESN'T THE- INCREASES
COSTS FOR THINGS LIKE SPECIAL
EDUCATION OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
THAT- BECAUSE WE MISS CRITICAL
PERIODS OF DEVELOPMENT. SO I CAN
WE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
NETWORK ADEQUACY. REIMBURSEMENT
AND- QUALITY STANDARDS FOR.
PEOPLE. BEING ABLE TO GET
SERVICES IN THIS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING.
OVER TO JUSTIN DEPUTY ENGINE
WEIGHING. THANK YOU. MORNING
TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS- I THINK FIRSTLY JUST
TO ACKNOWLEDGE I THINK WE ARE
WORKING- VERY DILIGENTLY AND
CLOSELY AND WITH OUR AFRICAN
PARTNERS TO HAVE SHARED THEIR
TESTIMONIES BEFORE EACH DAY- AND
WANTED TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
HEARING AIDS COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAMS THE BENEFIT
STRUCTURE AND THE IT AND THE
PROVIDER NETWORKS ARE BASED ON
THE MEDIC HEALTHY FOR SERVICE
NETWORK. THE WE DO WELCOME ALL
PEDIATRIC AUDIOLOGY PROVIDERS IN
THE MEDICAL FIELD FOR SERVICE
OUR NETWORK TO ALSO PURCHASED HE
HAS AN H. K. C. C. P. OUR
PROVIDER AS WELL AND I THINK WE
DO ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT WE HAVE A
QUITE A BIT OF WORK IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
CLARIFYING- THE PROVIDER
DIRECTORY ALAN THAT'S CURRENTLY
ON THE LINE- AND DEFINITELY A
LOT MORE WORK IN TERMS OF
STREAMLINING SOME OF OUR PROGRAM
CHRISTIE. ARE BUT WANTED TO BE
CLEAR THAT WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
WORK AHEAD OF US- AND THAT THE
PROGRAM ITSELF IS BASED UPON THE
MEDIC COUNTY FOR SERVICE
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE- WE ARE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL
CODES- IN TERMS OF ADDING MORE
US THIS IS AS IN CONVERSATIONS-
WITH OUR- PROVIDER NETWORKS ARE
PARTICIPATING STAKEHOLDERS- AS
WELL AS- SOME OF THE CLOSE
REACHED. THE WORK ON- WHAT THOSE
I THINK- A LOT WORK TO BE DONE-
AND DEAF COULD BE SOME THAT WE
LOOK TO WORK ON TO STREAMLINE-
AND WE ARE LOOKING IN MARCH YOU
HAVE A MORE OF A MORE ROBUST-
PROVIDER WEB IN OUR- TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE GETTING THE WORD. OUT
ON AND THROUGH OUR- MINISTRY-
VENDOR MAXIMUS WELL WE ARE DOING
A LOT OF CONSUMER KIND OF
OUTREACH WORK IN TERMS OF
PUTTING CHEAPER FLYERS AND
NEWSLETTERS. ALSO KIND OF RE
LOOKING AT APPLICATION PROCESS-
AND LOOKING AT WAYS TO
STREAMLINE A MAKING REFINEMENTS.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS OKAY
WELL WELL OKAY AND AS I SAID
THAT THE CHALLENGE IS GOING TO
BE IS THAT IF YOU DO OUTREACH TO
FOLKS. AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE
PROVIDER NETWORK. PEOPLE GO AND
SAY OH. THIS PROGRAM ISN'T
REALLY GOING TO BE A HELP ME
RIGHT SO- SO I'M NOT SAYING
DON'T DO OUTREACH TO THE
COMMUNITY BUT WHAT WE JUST HEARD
IS FROM PEOPLE ACTUALLY TRIED.
THAT THERE'S A PROVIDER NETWORK
RIGHT SO I THINK- AND YOU SAID
YOU GOT A LOOK IN YOUR PROVIDER
DIRECTORY AND SO FORTH SO- AND
MAYBE YOU DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
TODAY BUT- WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE PROVIDER NETWORK FOR
THIS PROGRAM. AND WE'RE GONNA DO
TO ACHIEVE THAT. SO WHAT IS THE
ENDPOINT SO YOU KNOW YOU TALKED
A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT WHAT I LIKE
TO KNOW IS HOW MANY PROVIDERS
SHOULD THERE BE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT'S ITS
DISTRIBUTION SO HOW FAR SHOULD
ANYONE BE FROM ANY PARTICULAR
CELLS ANY ANY PERSON WHO'S IN
THIS PROGRAM. WHAT SHOULD BE THE
CLOSEST PROVIDER FOR THEM. WHO
ACCEPTS THIS PROGRAM HOW FAR
AWAY RIGHT WE DO WE DO WE HAVE
STANDARDS FOR THESE THINGS FOR
YOU KNOW IT AND ENDED IN THE
OVERALL. HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY AS
WELL. HOSING SOME OF THESE
STANDARDS ARE ON OUR MEDICAL
PLANS OF COURSE ON A COMMERCIAL
PLANS TO TEAMMATE SEATS AT A- SO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. SOME ANSWER
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS THE PROVIDER
NETWORK WE SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE
AT LEAST WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS
THAT IT'S AND- IT'S
INSUFFICIENT. AND THAT YOU'RE A
LOT LIKE WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
IT BUT- I'D LIKE TO KNOW LIKE
WHAT THE END GOAL IS HOW DO WE
KNOW WE'RE SUCCESSFUL WHAT WHAT
IS WHAT IS THE- WHAT WHAT ARE WE
TRYING TO GET TO YOU IN TERMS OF
THAT PROVIDER NETWORK AND THEN.
IN TERMS OF THE REIMBURSEMENT
PIECE. I WASN'T HERE A LOT OF
ANSWERS AROUND THAT SO WE- I GOT
A SO I REALLY I HEAR THAT DO YOU
TIED IT TO OUR FEE FOR SERVICE
MEDICARE OUT BUT FOR SOME REASON
AND MAYBE THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON YOUR PROVIDER NETWORK IS
INSUFFICIENT. SO I THINK
SOMETHING THERE'S GOING TO NEED
TO BE REVISITED AS WELL AM I
WRONG. PAUL STEPPED IN AND
RESPOND HERE. SENATOR PENCIL I
THINK. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO BE
CLEAR AS WELL ONE OF THE
CONFUSING PARTS RIGHT NOW FROM.
WHAT THE TEAM'S HEARING FROM
PEOPLE IS THAT ON. THE LIST OF-CLINICAL OPTED IN PROVIDERS
TECHNICALLY ALL EXISTING
MEDICARE FEE FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. NCCS PROVIDERS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES WERE TRYING TO CLARIFY
THAT BECAUSE THE PROVIDER
NETWORK IS A LOT LARGER- THAT.
THAN WHAT IS BEING ARTICULATED-
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE PROVIDERS UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY CAN. CLEARLY PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THIS PROGRAM. EVEN
THOUGH IT'S OUTSIDE OF THE OF
MEDICARE L. THE REASON WHY WE
ARE. MAKING SURE THAT ALL SEAT-
MEDI CAL AND CCS PROVIDERS. ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES IS
WHAT WE KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
LARGER NETWORK ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THAT
RIGHT. ALSO THEY UNDERSTAND HOW
TO BILL. MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE THEY UNDERSTAND HOW TO
DO- AUTHORIZATIONS IN MEDICARE
FEE FOR SERVICE AND SO. WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY'S
UNDERSTANDING- THOSE- PROVIDERS
ARE AND WE WILL WORK DILIGENTLY
WITH OUR TEAM. TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO THAT FASTER JUST TO BE
REALLY. FRANK AND THEN I THINK
ON THE REIMBURSEMENT YOU KNOW
YEAH WE ARE USING AND OURS WAS
DESIGNED. IN THE PROPOSAL THE
MEDIC HOW RATES- AND- YOU NEED
YOU KNOW. ANY VARIANCE FROM THAT
WE- NEED TO. DISCUSS HOW WE DO
THAT. I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT THE
QUESTION AROUND CCS RATES YOU'RE
THE ONLY AREA WHERE WE ARE. WE
PAY A HIGHER RATE CCS IS BROWN
PHYSICIAN SERVICES. IT'S A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE PERCENT-
THE MEDIC HOW- RATE. SO IT'S NOT
ACROSS ALL OF THE SERVICES- JUST
WANTED TO IT THAT THERE WAS A- A
COMMENT ON THAT JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HOW.
CCS RATES WORK ON THAT FRONT-
BUT AGAIN. WE ARE LOOKING AT
THAT BUT IF WE IF WE ARE MUSING
THE- MEDICARE RATE IS THE BASE.
ANYTHING DONE FOR THIS PROGRAM
SEPARATELY YOU WOULD NEED TO
DISCUSS THROUGH YOU KNOW BUDGET
ESTIMATES. OF WHAT THOSE RATES
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE. OTHER PROPOSALS ARE
FLOATING AROUND IN. SPACE THAT
WE HAVE TO ANALYZE. ANALYZE
THOSE TWO TO MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT
BASED ON THE ALLOCATION THE
BUDGET. OKAY PREPARATION THAT SO
THE HELP. THOUGH IS THAT SAID
THERE'S A LOT ACTUALLY. FROM OUT
IN- THERE THE- PERHAPS YOU'RE
SAYING THAT ISN'T AWARE OF THEY
CAN FROM. SERVICE AS PER. TO BE
HELPFUL TO KNOW WHAT IS THAT
NETWORK HOW HOW MANY HOW MANY
PROVIDERS ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
THE IDEOLOGY PROVIDERS. SAYS
AND- CERTAINLY YOU'RE DOING
OUTREACH TO THOSE PROVIDERS SO
WE NEED TO BE ON THE- GOOD TO
KNOW THAT THAT NETWORKING ITSELF
IS ADEQUATE- TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
THIS POPULATION SO WE CAN GET TO
THE- SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND THAT.
PROGRAMS PROJECTED TO GET TO.
AND SEE THEIR CAPACITY TO AGAIN
ABSORB. THE ADDITIONAL PATIENTS-
HOPEFULLY THAT. THAT WILL BE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM
SO WE CAN HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP ON
THAT- THAT WOULD BE GREAT. YEAH
MORE THAN HAPPY TO GET YOU THE
LIST OF. ALL THE AVAILABLE
PROVIDERS IN VIEW FOR SERVICE IN
CCS ACROSS THE STATE AND WE WILL
DO. OUR DUE DILIGENCE TO
COMMUNICATE TO THEM TO MAKE SURE
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS FOR THIS
PROGRAM. WE DO HAVE IT ON OUR
WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN DO IF YOU
FIND FOR THOSE PROVIDERS BUT OF
COURSE. IT CLEARLY THERE'S STILL
CONFUSION AND SO WE WILL TAKE
THAT UPON OURSELVES TO- TO
REDUCE THAT CONFUSION TO THE
LARGER NETWORK. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS COOPER THE END
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE THE TELEMEDICINE SO
HELPFUL WITH SO MANY ISSUES BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE PEOPLE THERE- ON SITE SO
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE WITH OUR NETWORK MAYBE
WE THINK ABOUT SOME MOBILE
SERVICES LIKE WE'RE WE'RE DO
HAVING TO DO WITH MENTAL HEALTH
RIGHT NOW AT LEAST TO ME TO WORK
ON THAT SEVEN THOUSAND- I WILL
BE INTERESTED TO SEE THE
PROPOSALS THAT COME TO MAYBE.
LOWER THE RATE SO WE CAN PROVIDE
SOME MORE OF THAT COVERAGE FOR
FAMILIES- MORE MORE THAN WHAT
THEIR INSURANCE MIGHT PAY SO I
THINK I THINK WE'LL FIND OUT A
LOT OF THAT IS ALSO AN ISSUE
OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUES
NUMBER TWO IN THREE THIS IS THE
PRESENTATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TO LOCAL
ASSISTANT ESTIMATES FOR MEDICAL
AND FOR FAMILY HEALTH PROGRAMS.
IT'S GOING TO DO THIS DIRECTOR
BUS OKAY WELCOME BACK. THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES- MEDICAL
LOCAL SYSTEMS THAT NEED TO BE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE POINT
EIGHT BILLION TOTAL FUNDS TWENTY
SIX POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN THE CURRENT YEAR. AT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION TOTAL FUNDS THIRTY
FOUR POINT NINE BILLION GENERAL
PLAN IN THE BUDGET YEAR I'M A
HIGHLIGHT A SOME SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND CHANGES IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM IN BOTH THE
CURRENT YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR. IN
THE CURRENT YEAR WE SHOW A
SLIGHT INCREASE OF. POINT 5% IN
TOTAL SPENDING. TOWARD FINDING.
THIS REFLECTS A FOUR POINT 7%
DECREASE IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING COMPARED TO THE
ESTIMATES. FROM THE BUDGET
ENACTMENT LAST SUMMER. MAJOR
DRIVERS OF THE CHANGE IN THE
ESTIMATED GENERAL FUND SPENDING
INCLUDED. ONE BILLION RELATED TO
REDUCE CARBON NINETEEN COSTS.
PRIMARILY RESULTING FROM
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS FROM
INCREASED F. MAP BEING AVAILABLE
THROUGH JAN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
YOU KNOW. AND THEN PARTIALLY
OFFSET BY ADDITIONAL CASE THE
COST- AT NEGATIVE FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THREE MILLION- RELATED
TO SHIFTING MULTI SPEND EACH
MONTH TO YOUR SPENDING INTO
LATER YEARS I MADE UP. SOME OF
THESE CHANGES WILL BE DISCUSSED
LATER IN THE AGENDA. A HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE MILLION DECREASE
RELATED TO YOU- INCREASED
FUNDING FROM HOSPITAL QUIET
QUALITY ASSURANCE. FOR A
CHILDREN'S COVERAGE- PORTION OF
THAT. I HAVEN'T SEVENTY MILLION
A DECREASE RELATED TO PROJECTED
COSTS BARTEL AIM TRANSITIONING
POPULATIONS. AND AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION. RELATED TO STATE ONLY CLAIM.
FOR BUDGET YEAR WE PUT A SEVEN
POINT. PERCENT AND IN TOLL
FUNDING THIS REFLECTS A 30%
INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING COMPARED TO THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. OF GROWTH IN
PROJECTED MEDICARE SPENDING AND
THE BUDGET YOU'RE RELATES TO A
VARIETY OF FACTORS- THAT AGAIN
WE'LL BE DISCUSSING IN MORE
DETAIL IN IT IF THE REST OF THE
HEARING TODAY. I'M JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW- OUR GENERAL
FUND COSTS ARE PROJECTED TO GROW
AT INCREASED FUNDING FOR MEDIC
HOUSES SAME TO END WITH THE END
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
OKAY SO IT'S REMAIN HIGHER THAN
THEY OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN-
IS CALLED LG BODIES GRADUALLY
RICHARD SHERMAN OVER THAT- THE
TWELVE MONTHS. OPEN GENERAL FINE
TO A SPENDING ALSO. BY NUMBER
PROPOSALS- FOR EXAMPLE THE FULL
SCOPE THAT COVERAGE FOR OLDER
ADULTS. THE BEHAVIOR HELP BRIDGE
HOUSING. ELIMINATION OF CERTAIN
AB NINETY SEVEN REDUCTIONS- THE
REDUCTION OF MEDIC HELP RAYMOND
PEAT PREMIUMS AND CO. PAYMENTS
TO ZERO I'M JIM TODAY MY
FUNERAL. IN IN REGARDS TO CASE
LOAD ALL CONCLUDE WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE MEDICAL KEESLER
PROJECTIONS. THE PANDEMIC HAS
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
ENROLLED IN MEDI CAL. THIS
INCREASE IS PRIMARILY DUE TO A
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE REQUIREMENT
THAT IS TIED TO THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WHICH PREVENTS
MOST IN JUST A MOMENT FROM THE
PROGRAM- WE ASSUME THAT THE CASE
THAT WILL GROW TO A PEAK OF
ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION- AND THEN-
ONCE ELIGIBILITY READ
DETERMINATIONS HAPPEN THAT. THAT
CASELOAD WILL BE REDUCED.
GRADUALLY OVER TWELVE MONTHS. I
WILL. FOR ANY QUESTION OR- J.
MOVE ON TO THE FAMILY HELPED MET
WITH MOVE ON TO FAMILY HEALTH
ASSESSMENT. OKAY SO. ENTER OF
OUR FAMILY HEALTH ESTIMATE. YOU
WILL. THE FAMILY ALSO ESTIMATE-
PROJECTS BY NEED FOR SPEED ONLY
K. CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
SERVICES OR CCS BUT JANET
GENETICALLY HANDICAPPED PERSON
PROGRAM G. H. P. P. AND EVERY
WOMAN COUNTS FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR- WE PROJECT SPEND
THE NEXT TWO HUNDRED FORTY NINE
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS TWO HUNDRED
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
THIS IS A SIX POINT 4% DECREASE
IN TOTAL FUNDING- AND- AND AS
SIX POINT 9% DECREASE IN GENERAL
FUND SPENDING COMPARED TO THE
ESTIMATES FROM FROM THAT BUDGET
ENACTED LAST SUMMER SH IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THE MAIN FACTOR IN
REDUCED. ESTIMATED SPENDING IS
REDUCED COSTS RELATED TO COVER
NINETEEN ENROLLMENT IMPACTS
ENROLLMENT IN STATE ONLY CCS HAS
DROPPED SOMEWHAT DURING THE
PANDEMIC DUE TO INDIVIDUAL
SHIFTING TO A MEDICAL CCS AND
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE UTILIZING
SERVICES IN EVERY WOMAN COUNTS
PROGRAM HAS ALSO BEEN SOMEWHAT
LOWER SINCE THE BEGINNING
CONDEMNING BEGAN ALTHOUGH WE SEE
UTILIZATION INCREASING AND
APPROACHING PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS.
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR WE PROJECT
SPENDING SHOULD BE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND THIS REFLECTS A
SIXTEEN POINT FOUR AND TOTAL
FUNDING AND A FIVE POINT 4%
INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING COMPARED TO THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. GROWTH IN THAT
PROJECTED MEDICAL SPENDING IN
THE BUDGET YEAR RELATES
PRIMARILY TO THE ASSUMPTION THAT
REDUCED AND WILL BE THE KOPET
NINETEEN IMPACTS. WILL PHASE OUT
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. I THANK YOU
. RIGHT THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT.
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU L. A. O. THANK
YOU. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
MINISTERS IN CASE THOSE OPTIONS
WE GENERALLY FIND THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ESTIMATED TO BE
REASONABLE- BUT WE WILL BE
CONTINUING EVALUATES ONLINE
ASSUMPTIONS OVER THE COMING
MONTHS. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS INCLUDE THE CO IN
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
ASSUMPTION CASELOAD AND THE
EXPIRATION OF THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION. TALKS NCO TAX.
WHAT ARE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ATTENTION THIS IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY THE
MEDICAID BUDGET. DOWN AND THIS
YOU CAN EXPIRATION DATE OF THE-
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IS
PARTICULARLY UNCERTAIN- THE END
OF WHICH WILL TRIGGER THE END UP
RELATED. OFFSET GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
AS SUCH WHEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND IT WILL BE A LARGE
INCREASE IN GENERAL COSTS. THE
BUDGET IS SEEN AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY ENDS JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. UNDER THIS
ASSUMPTION EXPRESSION AGAIN SHE
WOULD RESULT IN NEARLY TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THE OVERALL
NET GROWTH IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING JUNE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
WE FIND THAT THIS ESTIMATE. WELL
IT'S REASONABLE WE NOTE THAT
CURRENTLY THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
PURPOSES ONLY SET TO EXTEND.
INTO APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AND AGE WILL SHOULD ANNOUNCED
RELATIVE SOON. PROVIDED AND WE
NOTE THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THE JUNE TWO TWENTY WHAT IS IN
SIX. SAVING TO THE BUDGET AND
TWENTY TWO THREE. REGARDING CASE
UNDER SOME WE- UTILIZE MORE
RECENT DAY THAN WHAT AVAILABLE
THE TIME OF THE COVERS- MANY
USERS MOREOVER DATA TO TELL.
ASSUMPTIONS FIND THAT THE
LIKELY- OVERSTATE CASE JUST OR
STILL CABLE GROWTH IN RECENT
MONTHS AND IT SEEMS IN ABOUT. WE
ALSO HAVE A BUDGET CASE OF WATER
AND HAVE ON THE END DATE OF THE
CALL HEALTH CONCERN. DUE TO A-
FEDERAL. THAT LOOKS. PROHIBITS
THE TERMINATE- BALANCE OF FOR
MOST PEOPLE. ONCE AT THE PUBLIC
OFFERING C. HANDS ON RESTRICTION
WOULD GO AWAY AND ELIGIBILITY
TERMINATIONS WORK- BEGINNING.
AND THEN YOU ARE ALSO DIFFERENT
FROM THE MINISTRATION IS ALL DUE
TO A CASE OF MIX- DO THE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS AND
JUST MENTION WE PROJECTED SLOWER
INCREASE IN HIGH COST CASES ARE
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES WHICH RESULTS IN.
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS JUST ARE
HIGH RELATIVE COST COMPARED TO
OTHER MEDICAID CASELOADS. WHILE
WE DO. FIND THAT. THE COST OF
CASES CAN BE SINCERE LOWER THAN
WHAT THAT INCLUDING THE- I TIME
WE'RE NOT RECOMMENDING CHANGES.
DUE TO CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY
IN THESE ESTIMATES AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR OUR BUDGET
PROCESS. REGARDING THE MCO TAX
ON FOR OVER A DECADE THE STATE
HAS IMPOSED A TAX ON MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATIONS AND USE
REVENUES TO OFFSET GENERAL AND
COST OF MEDICAL. TAX GENERATES
AN ANNUAL NATIONAL FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OVER ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AND IS ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION INCLUDES FELT CLEAN
OF THE STATE OTHERWISE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO DRIVE DOWN. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
PROPOSE TO EXTEND THE MCO TAX
INSTEAD WOULD ALLOW TO EXPIRE
HALFWAY THROUGH TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE RESULT IN THE LOSS
OF ROUGHLY ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION GENERAL FUND BENEFIT. ON
AN ONGOING BASIS. THE MINISTRY
HAS NOTED LIKELY. ARE WHICH IS
EXCUSE. IN MEDICAL MANAGED- DATA
SCHEDULED REQUIREMENT- COULD
HAVE AN IMPACT AS WELL AS AN
ANTICIPATED VOLATILITY IN CASE
THE CALL- WHICH COULD COMPLICATE
THE RENEWAL OF THE MCO TAX. WE
AGREE THAT THE SCATTERING
BECOMING CULD COST CHALLENGES.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THEY WOULD BE
TEMPORARY IN NATURE AND BELIEVES
THAT THESE CHALLENGES COULD BE
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF ALL. I SAID
THREE RECOMMEND THREE OPTIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
FIRST ELECTRIFICATION WE KNEW
THE MCO TAX BASED ON THE
EXISTING MODEL. YEAR FOR
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THIS WOULD OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGE OF RETIREMENTS AND THE
CHANGE IN PLANS IS NOT
ANTICIPATED TO GROW UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY TWENTY FOR
LATER USE THE LEGISLATION WOULD
NEED TO CONSIDER WHEN IT WOULD
BE. FEASIBLE TO GET INTO ANY
TAX. OPTION TWO WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE. YEAR WE OFFER. OF THE
TAX CODE IN PLACE BEFORE AND
AFTER THE RIVER GERMAN. WITH
STRESSED IN BY- GOVERNMENT-
DRAWING THAT PERIOD. AND A THIRD
OPTION WOULD BE TO- THE NCO TOP
DID NOT IN YOU AT A LATER. SUCH
AS IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE STATE HAS A
BETTER IDEA WHICH INSTILLS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN. MEDICAID MANAGED. CARE IN ONE ROOM AND WILL LOOK
LIKE. REGARDING THE- HOW LOCAL
SYSTEMS. WE CANNOT CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND- YEAH APPRECIATE
PRESENTATIONS- FEW QUESTIONS ON
BOTH OF THESE ITEMS SO FIRST OF
ALL I GUESS IN TERMS OF THE
MONEY TO SAY FIRST OF ALL-
APPRECIATE ELLIE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE MCO TAX- JUST MENTIONS
CERTAINLY- MEDIC HAL AS A PLAYER
IS A LITTLE YELLOW IN PAIR.
WE'VE SPENT YEARS TALKING ABOUT
THE LOW PAYMENT RATES FOR MEDIC
HAL AND CAUSING ACCESS ISSUES
WELL THERE WAS SOME RELIEF WITH
PROPERTY SIX NINETY ONE THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR- BACK FILLING
SOME OF THE PROPERTY SIX BECAUSE
THE BACK OF THE TOBACCO TAXES A
DECLINING REVENUE SOURCE WE LIKE
THE FACT THAT THE DECLINING
REVENUE SOURCE. AT LEAST IF THAT
MEANS LESS USE OF TOBACCO NOT.
IF IT'S A BECAUSE PEOPLE FOUND
WAYS TO. FRAGILE YET- THAT TAX
BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO DECREASED
USE. THEM TO ATTACK THOSE
REPRESENTATIONS MORE STABLE.
FUNDING SOURCE AS WELL AS
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD TO BE IN THE
LEGISLATURE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. AND AND GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES. SO
FRANKLY- NOTHING ELSE I COULD
CERTAINLY SEE THE REVENUE BEING
USED TO IMPROVE ACCESS BY
RAISING RATES SO THAT. THE TEAM
THAT DID THE RATE OF MEDICAL
RATES COULD BE THE SAME AS
MEDICARE RATES WHICH SO. MANY
PROVIDERS WILL STILL TELL YOU
STILL WANT A LOWER PAYERS- BUT
AT LEAST- IT'S IT TO BE
COMPETITIVE THERE SO I'LL JUST
PUT A PIN ON THAT- THAT- I'M NOT
SURE WHY WE'RE GIVING UP ON THE
MEDIC. THE MCO TAX- AND- AND
HOPEFULLY NO ONE BEEN SAYS WE
CAN'T RAISE RATES BECAUSE
THERE'S NO MONEY BECAUSE WE'VE
JUST DECIDED TO GIVE UP ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION RIGHT THERE-
I GUESS THAT THAT. SITE SO IT'S
MORE OF A COMMENT OR QUESTION I
HAVE IS THAT- I APPRECIATE THE
IS THE UNCERTAINTY RELATED TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
WHICH ON THE POSITIVE SIDE GIVES
US A BETTER FEDERAL MATCH. AND
THE I WENT TO A NEGATIVE SIDE
BUT OF COURSE THE COST SIDE- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO RETAIN THE-
PEOPLE. THAT ARE IN TERMS OF
CONTINUATION MEDIC COW WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A GOOD THING- SO AND
THAT THIS- ON THE COST SIDE IT
IS A COST BUT I THINK I THINK
IT'S A IT IS A GOOD POLICY.
SESSION. A PANDEMIC. BUT- IF THE
EMERGENCY BECAUSE OF- WHAT DO WE
KNOW. HOW MANY. THAT CASE LOAD
WHAT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
CURRENT CASELOAD WOULD END UP.
NOT QUALIFYING ANYMORE IN THIS
RULING TO STERN ESTIMATE FOR
THAT- SO HOW MANY PEOPLE MIGHT
BE LOSING THE COVERAGE- IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ENDS THE
EMERGENCY AND THE- THE
REQUIREMENT FOR CONTINUATION. A
RECENT RETENTION AND MEDIC HOUSE
. SO HAPPY TO TAKE THIS CASE TO
COOPER- SO WE HAVE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF ANALYTICS IN REGARDS TO
THE POTENTIAL UPCOMING UNWINDING
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
AND THE REDETERMINATION OF
WHAT'S CURRENTLY CLOSE TO
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
LIVES IN MEDIC HOW- WORD
ANALYZING IT FROM A NUMBER OF
WAYS INCLUDING ON HOW MANY OF
OUR BENEFICIARIES TYPICALLY GO
THROUGH EX PARTE- HISTORICALLY
WHICH IS AROUND THIRTY SIX
PERCENT. ROCKS SO LOOKING AT
WAYS TO INCREASE THAT WITH A
NUMBER OF FACTORS TO ENSURE
COVERAGE ARE BASED ON HISTORICAL
TRENDS PRIOR TO- AS YOU KNOW
KOBE SAID. WE ARE ANTICIPATING
THAT ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO THREE
MILLION BENEFICIARIES- MAY
TRANSITION TO OTHER COVERAGE FOR
EXAMPLE THEY COULD BE TRANSITION
TO COVERED CALIFORNIA OR WE ALSO
KNOW BASED ON TRENDS IN
INFORMATION THAT WE ARE SEEING
COME IN WITH OTHER HEALTH
COVERAGE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
CURRENTLY ON MEDICARE. DO TO THE
CONTINUOUS ENROLLMENT
REQUIREMENT HAVE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED HEALTH INSURANCE FROM
THEIR EMPLOYER AS WELL SO THE
GOAL FOR US THROUGH THE
REDETERMINATION IS JUST COVERAGE
WHETHER THAT'S NOT A CAL COVERED
CALIFORNIA OUR OTHER EMPLOYER
BASED COVERAGE THE GOAL IS FOR
US TO TRANSITION SOMEONE TO
COVERAGE- AND WE ARE DOING
EXTENSIVE OUT REACH WITH OTHER
STATES TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST
WAYS TO ACHIEVE THAT- INTO
INJURE ANYONE WHO NEEDS
COVERAGE. STAYS COVERED UP I
WOULD NOTE THOUGH THERE HAS BEEN
A LOT OF MOVEMENT IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS AND BY THE TIME YOU
AND YOUR PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
ENDS AND WE RETIREMENT IT WILL
PROBABLY BE ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS- THE MOVEMENT AROUND THE
STATE AT THE LIGHTS AND MEDICAL
SIGNIFICANCE WE ARE CURRENTLY
BASED ON THE RECENT MAILER THAT
WE HAVE DONE TO EVERYONE- SEEING
ANYWHERE ROM 7210% OF PEOPLE
HAVING A CHANGE OF. ADDRESS
WHERE WE NEED UPDATED CONTACT
INFORMATION WE ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH NAVIGATORS AND-
OTHERS TO GET THE WORD OUT- AS
WELL AS OUR A MANAGED CARE PLAN
PARTNERS ARE COUNTY PARTNERS
BECAUSE WE NEED UPDATED. CONTACT
INFORMATION SO WHEN THE PUBLIC
AT THE MARGINS HE DOES A- WE CAN
REACH AN- AND SO ARE THE DIPS.
IS DOING A LOT OF ABOUT HOW WE
DO THIS LARGE COMMUNICATIONS
STATEWIDE HOW WE BRING WHAT
WE'RE CALLING AMBASSADORS TO THE
TABLE TO PARTNER WITH US TO GET
THIS OUT. WE HAVE THE- CAN'T
TOOL KITS THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
MESSAGING AFTER FLYERS AND
BANNERS AFTER ALL OF OUR
INDIVIDUALS AND SO- HOPEFULLY
THAT HELPS PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING. FOR THE
UNWINDING SENATOR PAT OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT- AND AGAIN I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR GOAL TO
THE IDEAS THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
UNCOVER ANYBODY WHO I TRY TO.
FIND A PATH CONTINUES PATH
COVERAGE SO REALIZING THAT IF
THEY MIGHT NEED TO BE DISTANT
ROLL FROM MEDIC HOW WE WANT
DEFINITELY LANHAM IN THE-
CONTINUE TO COVER. THROUGH SOME
OTHER MEANS- IT. BUT IF YOU HAVE
TWO TO THREE MILLION PEOPLE IT'S
A COMING OFF MEDIC HOW THE IN AN
EMERGENCY BUT HOW HOW WOULD THAT
AFFECT FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW YOU
HAVE CONTRACTS WITH LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS YOU HAVE A FEELING FOR
MEMBER PER MONTH- RIGHT. ARE
SOME SOME FORM THAT. IS THAT
GOING TO CAUSE DISRUPTIONS FOR
PEOPLE EDICARE CONTRACTS WITH
TO DO HEALTHCARE DELIVERY IF YOU
YOU KNOW IF WE SENT THAT AND I
KNOW YOU. AND ACTUALLY I'M NOT
SURE WHAT TIME WOULD WE HAVE TO
DESCEND ROLE- THAT WAS OUR
GUIDELINES ON THAT YET FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IF THEY LIFT
EMERGENCY. THERE IS YES SO ONCE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECLARES
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
IT'S ENDING FROM A FROM A- YOU
KNOW A FUNDING PERSPECTIVE. ON
THAT THE END OF THAT MONTH IN
WHICH THAT IS DECLARED THE
FOLLOWING MONTHLY WOULD HAVE TO
START WE DETERMINATIONS- SO LET
ME JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
CURRENTLY- IF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ENDED IN. APRIL WHICH
IS CURRENTLY FIVE FOR APRIL
FIFTEENTH WHICH WE ACTUALLY
DON'T THINK IT IS LIKELY BASED
ON WHAT WE'RE HEARING RIGHT NOW
BUT- IF IT DID. THAT MEANS THAT
WE WOULD HAVE TO TRIGGER A
REDETERMINATION PROCESS IN MAY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WHICH
MEANS THAT MEANS PACKETS WOULD
BE A START BEING MAILED TO
INDIVIDUALS FOR SOMEONE WHO'S-
UP FOR RE DETERMINATION. IN
JULY. WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM A
SIXTY DAY NOTICE- WE WOULD THEN
START ALL RE DETERMINATIONS FOR
A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD SO BASED
ON THEIR NORMAL RENEWAL MONTH WE
WILL BE SENDING PACKETS AND
STARTING THAT. PROCESS AGAIN- TO
IN ORDER TO KIND OF KEEP- THE
MONTHS DISTRIBUTED EVENLY ACROSS
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE. A HUGE
SPIKES WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS OVER A FULL TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD THAT CMS'S GUIDANCE
CURRENTLY ALLOWS FOR. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN HAVING
MULTIPLE BRAINSTORMING SESSIONS
WITH CMS AND OTHER STATES. ARE
TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST PATHWAYS
FORWARD- WE ARE WORKING ON A
NUMBER OF REQUESTS. WE CMS TO
MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS EXACTLY RIGHT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
COVERAGE. ON SO THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY GIVEN US FLEXIBILITY
EASE OF WHAT WE CAN ASK OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO DO. WE ARE
ADVOCATING BROADLY TO THE FCC
WHO CURRENTLY HAS REGULATIONS
AND RULES AROUND HOW WE CAN DO
OUTREACH. TO BENEFICIARIES. FOR
THEM UP WHAT'S COME UP. I'M IN
ADVOCATING. GIVE US MORE. AS WE
DO THE N. Y. SO WE CAN TEXT
INDIVIDUAL WE CAN DO OUR REACHED
INTO THE- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE AWARE. OF THESE PIECES
AND SO WE WILL BE- DRAFT WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF DROPPING AND
WE WILL BE RELEASING A WHAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY ANTICIPATING IN
MARCH- AND EXTERNAL DOCUMENTS
YOU. INFORM PEOPLE OF WHAT OUR
UNWINDING PLAN FOR
REDETERMINATION SPECIFICALLY
WILL BE AND SO. I ONCE WE HAVE
THAT FINAL HAPPY TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ALL RECEIVED COPIES OF
THAT AND BRIEF YOU IN ANY WAY
NECESSARY TO HELP US ACHIEVE
WHAT WE CAN'T YOU. LOSES ANY
LIVES AS POSSIBLE BUT YET WE
MANAGED CARE PLANS WE HAVE WE
ARE ANTICIPATING IT WE'RE USING
ARE QUITE CASELOAD PROJECTIONS
AND POOR. WHITE BUILDING
PURPOSES. WE HAVE TO ANTICIPATE
DROPS IN COVERAGE OVER THE- THE
NEXT DAY YOU KNOW EIGHTEEN
MONTHS DEPENDING ON WHEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ENDS. UP
AND WE WILL BE MONITORING THAT
VERY CLOSELY. OKAY YEAH I MEAN I
THINK IT AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS AND THE
MOST IMPORTANT AS SOME PATIENTS
ARE THE BENEFICIARIES. BUT ALSO
I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT THE- YOU
KNOW. THE PLANS AND THERE IS A
RENT AND HAVING SUCH A WALL WELL
IT'S A SUDDEN DROP IN REVENUE
BUT IT DECLINED REVENUE DURING
THE- CONTRACT TIME RIGHT
BECAUSE- IT DO POPULATIONS
DECREASED RIGHT. NOW AND- AND BE
SURE THAT- WE DO BECAUSE OF THAT
WE DON'T SEE EITHER DISRUPTIONS
IN SERVICES OR OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS- AND THAT THEY'RE
PLANNING FOR A- POTENTIAL
DECLINE. YOU KNOW THE CLIENT AND
REVENUE ESSENTIALLY RIGHT- THAT-
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN IT
WILL HAPPEN- BUT- THAT. CAN BE
ANTICIPATED. AT SOME POINT IT
WILL HAPPEN CORRECT. I AGREE
THAT'S WHY WANTING TO MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO BE OF OUR BIG.
PART AS MOVE. WITH THIS PLAN
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT AT STAKE
RIGHT IN REGARDS TO MAKING SURE
ANYONE WHO NEEDS TO STAY IN
MEDIC HAL. IS BEING RE
DETERMINED AND- AND CAN'T
CONTINUE THAT COVERAGE WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE CHARMER PEOPLE DROP
OFF. FOR QUITE A FEW MONTHS AND
COME BACK ON IT IS VERY
DESTRUCTIVE FOR MANAGED CARE
PLANS FOR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
AND BROTHERS AND SO. THEY WILL
BE A KEY PARTNER AS WE ROLL OUT
OUR UPCOMING TOOL KITS- AND
BUILD OUR COALITION FOR WHAT
WILL. BE BEFORE US IN TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY THREE. OKAY AND THEN
THE OTHER THAT'S ACTUALLY THE
ONLY. ISSUE NUMBER THREE I GUESS
THAT'S ABOUT CCS PROGRAM SO I
UNDERSTAND FROM WHAT YOU SAID
BECAUSE WE SEE A- PROJECTED TO.
DECREASE IN THE MEDIC HOW
CASELOAD. INCREASE IN THE STATE
ONLY THAT THAT'S PERHAPS IT
SHIFTS. BECAUSE OF THE- THAT MAY
HAPPEN- MOTHER BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUOUS ENROLLMENT OR OTHER
OTHER REASONS AS WELL. BUT I
GUESS- ONE OF THE THINGS I WANNA
JUST MENTIONED SO I KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CCS COVERS IS
FOR EXAMPLE NICKI STAYS. FOR
PREMATURE INFANTS- WE KNOW THAT-
FORTUNATELY UNVACCINATED-
PREGNANT WOMEN ARE THREE TIMES
AS LIKELY TO DELIVER PREMATURELY
IF THEY GETS COVETED AND THEN
ONCE THAT AREN'T- ARE WE
ANTICIPATING AN INCREASE
POTENTIALLY OF. THANK YOU-
BABIES- BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THIS
IF WE DON'T GET INCREASE OUR
RATES OF VACCINATION AMONG
PREGNANT WOMEN. THAT WOULD BE
COVERED BY CCS. BUT I HAVE NOT
HAD ANY REPORTS OF AN INCREASE
IN THE QUEUE STATES WE CAN
DEFINITELY RUN ANALYTICS IF IT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN DEFINITELY
WOULD HAVE PROBABLY SEEN IT BY
NOW ARE GIVEN THE LONGEVITY OF
THE- EMERGENCY BUT LET ME TOUCH
BASE WITH THE TEAM WE CAN RUN
SOME NUMBERS AND SEE IF WE'VE
SEEN AN INCREASE. OF OUR TREND
INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR WITH
NICK YOU STAYS BASED ON NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ENROLLED IN OUR
MEDICARE CCS OR STATE ONLY CCS
WILL DO IT ACROSS SO IT'S FULLY
ACROSS THE BOARD WILL HAVE TO
RUN SOME NUMBERS YEAH AND IT'S
POSSIBLE YOU MAY NOT SEE IT E.
L. F. I MEAN PANDEMICS ONLY BEEN
AROUND FOR TWO YEARS. BUT SINCE
I ONLY FEEL LIKE FOREVER BUT-
THE OTHER THING ABOUT PREGNANCY
LENGTH OF PREGNANCY IT'S ADDRESS
IT MAY JUST START BEATON'S MEETS
TO START SHOWING UP AND THEN THE
OTHER ISSUE- AND THEN IN TERMS
OF- C. C. S. C. C. S. ITSELF- IN
TERMS OF THE PROVIDER NETWORK.
ARE THERE ANY CONCERNS. CAN IN
TERMS OF- A PAYMENT- TO- THE- WE
HAD WE HAD A SHOW. OF SINCE. HE
AFFECTS OF SPECIAL. AND PEOPLE
RETIRING AND SO FORTH IT IS
THERE IS THAT IS THERE ANY ISSUE
THERE WHEN IT COMES TO ACCESS TO
THE PEDIATRIC SUB SPECIALISTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WELL WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY HAD SHORTAGES IN
CERTAIN PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALISTS
AS I'M SURE YOU'RE VERY AWARE-
GIVEN THE ROLE YOU PLAY IN
MEDICARE AS WELL. SO WE ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALISTS SHORTAGES THERE
ARE CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE
WHERE WE HAVE CLEAR- PBX YOUR-
SPECIAL SHORTAGES- OFTEN TIMES-
MANAGED CARE PLANS HAVE TO. SEND
BENEFICIARIES TOO YOU KNOW AND
PAY FOR THEM TO TRAVEL DISTANCES
TO GET TO A CERTAIN SPECIALS
TELEHEALTH HAS BEEN GREAT A
GREAT IMPROVEMENT IN REGARDS TO
THAT BEING ABLE TO CONNECT WITH
PEOPLE VIA TELEHEALTH AND-
MAXIMIZING THAT TO THE DEGREE WE
CAN'T SO. WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
NETWORK ADEQUACY BROADLY ACROSS
ALL AREAS BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
OUR CHILDREN- YOU KNOW
SUBSPECIALTIES THAT OUR
CHALLENGE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN WAY BEYOND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY JUST
TO BE CLEAR- AND WHAT WE'LL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. AND THAT'S
ACROSS ALL PAYERS NOT NOT JUST
MEDIC OUT ALSO. YES IT'S.
CERTAINLY IT- BUT I THINK IT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT MEDICARE
COVERS. OF ALL TO. AND OF COURSE
YES PLEASE I THINK THIS. BOWLS
OF HAIR FOR. FEARS OF
SPECIALISTS- THEN- THEY GET CCS
THE SURPRISED THE MARKET AND- SO
IF CCS ISN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE
ENOUGH SUPPORT- AD YOU KNOW
DOES COMMERCIAL ALONE IS NOT
ENOUGH. THEN WE END UP WITH
SHORTAGES SO LOOK FOR TO SEE IT
TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION ABOUT.
HOW WE CAN TRY TO BOLSTER OUR-
PEER SYSTEM SPECIALTY WORK
FORCE. HERE IN CITY CALIFORNIA
SURE OUR CHILDREN CCS. CAN GET
CONTINUED ACCESS OF THANK YOU.
THANK VERY MUCH- LET US MOVE ON
TO CAROLINE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. I
WILL I WILL SIMON COOPER YOU.
ALSO AS AS YOU ALL KNOW- YOU
KNOW KATHLEEN IS REALLY A GOAL
OF MOVING TOWARDS A MORE
POPULATION HEALTH APPROACH WHERE
WE PRIORITIZE BOTH PREVENTION
AND WHOLE PERSON CARE SERVICES A
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
MEETING PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE IN
LIFE- IT'S REALLY AROUND
BREAKING DOWN THE WALLS OF
HEALTH CARE- AND REALLY-
COORDINATING ACROSS THOSE SOCIAL
DRIVERS OF HEALTH I'M MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING ALL
THE NEEDS OF AN INDIVIDUAL
PHYSICAL BEHAVIORAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DENTAL LONG TERM
CARE NEEDS- AND SO WE WERE VERY
EXCITED TO SEE THE ANNOUNCEMENT-
AND APPROVAL OF THE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND I'LL KIND
OF WALK THROUGH BASED ON YOUR
REQUEST IN THE AGENDA. SOME KEY
UPDATES IN REGARDS TO THE
PROGRAM I DH CS HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTING ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT- AND WE ARE DOING
THAT IN PHASES AS YOU KNOW I WAS
SO EASY AND DID GO LIVE JANUARY
ONE IN TWENTY FIVE COUNTY UNDER
TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES ARE THOSE
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY SERVING
WHOLE PERSON CARE AND HELP COMES
MEMBERS APPROXIMATELY NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WERE-
TRANSITIONS TO ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT- AND ARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT NUMBER IS INCREASING
ITS MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
THEIR- PROVIDER NETWORKS
CONTINUE TO ENROLL- INDIVIDUALS
INTO THE ENHANCED CARE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. THE NEXT
IMPLEMENTATION DATE WILL BE JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WHERE
ADDITIONAL POPULATIONS OF FOCUS
WILL BE ADDED- MAINLY IN
COUNTIES THAT DIDN'T HAVE A
WHOLE PERSON CARE OR HELP COMES
IN- THOSE EXISTING TWENTY FIVE
COUNTIES WHERE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THAT POPULATION OF FOCUS IN THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT FOR
HEALTH PROBLEMS- THOSE
POPULATIONS INCLUDE- INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- HI UTILIZE ERRORS-
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS OR A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. NEEDS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE WILL ALSO
EXPAND YOU OF POPULATIONS. OF
FOCUS WHERE WE WOULD BE LOOKING
AT INDIVIDUALS TRANSITIONING
FROM OUR- TO THE COMMUTER. AS
WELL AS MA'AM. HAT ARE ALLEGED
FOR LAW TERM CARE ACCURATE IT IS
. INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE. IN
NURSING HOMES WANTED TO
TRANSITION TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
THEN IN JULY TWENTY THREE-
EXTENDING EXPANDING TO OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. WE HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR FROM ADVOCATES
THAT THEY WANTED MORE TIME TO
BUILD UP THE ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT- A PROGRAM FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND SO WE
HAVE. A DEDICATED GROUP WORKING
ON THAT SPECIFICALLY TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THAT RIGHT IT'S
COMPLEX WITH CCS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH CHILDREN ADVOCATES
TO BUILD THAT WITH THEM-
ADDITIONALLY DH CS ADOPTED A
LIST OF FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS AS WE HAVE REPORTED TO
THIS. COMMITTEE PREVIOUSLY- SO
SOME UPDATES IN REGARDS TO WHAT
WHAT LIVE IN AND WHAT WE'RE
ANTICIPATING. IN JANUARY TWENTY
FIVE MANAGED CARE PLANS IN FORTY
SEVEN COUNTIES BEGAN OFFERING UP
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
TRAINEES SUPPORT ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE THAT BROAD I TAKE
UP IN JANUARY- APPROXIMATELY
FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS. AS
SMOOTHLY TRANSITIONED ON JANUARY
ONE TO A COMMUNITY'S COURTS FROM
OUR WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOTS- IN
AGAIN I'VE SEEN THE INCREASE
ADDS. THE WEEKS GO BY ABSENT
THAT GO LIVE. ADDITIONALLY AS
JIMMY SUPPORTS OUR VOLUNTARY-
FOR MANAGED CARE PLANS TO OFFER
A BUT THEY HAVE ISSUED IN LET US
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GONNA BRING UP
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS CURRENTLY
THEY HAVE. THE ABILITY TO UPDATE
THAT LIST- BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
MANAGED CARE PLANS WILL BE
BRINGING THOSE UP TO WHAT WE
CURRENTLY SEE IT ON AVERAGE.
MANAGED CARE PLANS HAVE ELECTED
TO INITIALLY FOCUS THEIR
OFFERINGS ON NO FIVE TO SIX
VARIOUS COMMUNITY SUPPORTS ARE
WE PROVIDING CLEAR THESE ARE BIG
LARGE THINGS FOR MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO PICK UP AND TO BUILD. A
LOT OF NEW CONTRACTS AND SO-
PHASING A MAN IS APPROPRIATE-
AND WE SUPPORT THAT- YOU KNOW
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE SEEING MOST
PLANS INITIALLY STARTED WITH.
THE HOUSING RELATED SERVICES
THAT NAVIGATION SERVICES LIAISON
SERVICES. DEPOSITS A MEDICALLY
TAILORED ME SALES AND AS MY
ROOMIE- AND THEN THROUGHOUT
THREE AND TWENTY. YEAR TO SEE.
PLANS TO CHECK TO UP THOSE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT OF. AS ONCE
TERM KERR IS GARBAGE MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND TWENTY THREE WE
SEE A SUITE OF THE- COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS THAT REALLY LINE UP
WITH LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. I REALLY COMING OFF
ONLINE AT THAT TIME. I WOULD
JUST KNOW DHS HAS POSTED A LIST
OF ALL COMMUNITY SUPPORT BY
MANAGED CARE PLAN ACCOUNT ON OUR
WEBSITE- SO THERE'S FULL
DISCLOSURE TO EVERYONE IN
REGARDS TO WHAT WE ARE SEEING
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN REGARDS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PAYMENT REFORM- WE ARE CURRENTLY
ON SCHEDULE TO IMPLEMENT JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
AND THERE'S THREE MAIN KIND OF
INITIATIVES AROUND PAYMENT FOR
MANY OF THESE THINGS WILL BE
MOVING THIS YEAR. THERE'S THE
TRANSITION TO NEW CODING FOR OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COLLEAGUES- WE
ARE ALSO. DEVELOPING THE
INTERGOVERNMENTAL TRANSFER
PROCESS WHETHER COUNTY PARTNERS
AND THEN OF COURSE THE LARGEST
CHANGES THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
NEW FEE SCHEDULE. AND THIS WILL
BE A CROSSBOW SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER ACROSS. ALL OF OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE.
YOU BECAUSE BASED AS THAT IS BIG
. AND THERE WERE CLOSELY WITH
OUR- ADDITIONALLY- REGARDING
OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH REFORM
UPDATES IN CALAIS. I DH CS
ISSUED GUIDANCE- TO UPDATE
CRITERIA FOR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES I'M IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THE GUIDANCE REALLY
JUST CLARIFIES THAT SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES CAN BE
PROVIDED DURING THE ASSESSMENT
PERIOD. INCLUDING BEFORE A
DIAGNOSIS IS MADE ON THIS IT'S
BEEN SIGNIFICANT FOR OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COLLEAGUES.
ADDITIONALLY IT ESTABLISHES A
CEREBRAL CRITERIA FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. OUGHT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS- YOU KNOW A CLEAN
ACCESS LINE FOR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. ESPECIALLY FOR
HIGH RISK INDIVIDUALS. THAT
REALLY NEED SERVICES OR HAVE
EXPERIENCED YOU KNOW EXTENSIVE
TRAUMA IN THEIR LIVES MAKING
SURE THEY HAVE EARLY AND FAST
ACCESS TO. A HIGHER LEVEL OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. WE
ARE ALSO WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
DOCUMENT EDIT SORRY
DOCUMENTATION OR FORM- WHICH
WILL GO LIVE IN JULY OF THIS
YEAR REALLY STREAMLINING AND
STANDARDIZING THE CLINICAL
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS BOTH SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH. DRUG MEDI CAL AND- DMC
ODS PROVIDERS A LONG TIME COMING
AND REALLY CRITICAL EYE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON OUR
PROVIDERS AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
AND RETAIN THAT WORKFORCE. SO
CRITICAL FOR US ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE LAST ITEM
THAT WE ARE ALSO GROWING OUT IN
JULY OF THIS YEAR IS NO WRONG
DOOR POLICY. ALSO IN THE
INDIVIDUALS REALLY HAVE ACCESS
TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH ARE REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY INITIALLY STARTED THOSE
SERVICES- AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE ARE TRANSITIONS SMOOTHLY-
WHEN THEY START. ON THE- COUNTY
SIDE BUT IT REALLY SHOULD BE
MANAGED CARE PLAN- OR VICE VERSA
SO E'RE REALLY WORKING ON. THAT
ACROSS THE BOARD WITH MANAGED
CARE AND OUR COUNTY PARTNERS- IN
REGARDS TO SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES ARE PLANNING AROUND
THE CARBON OF LONG TERM CARE
BENEFITS- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY. WITH STAKE HOLDERS-
I'VE MANAGED. CARE PLANS THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL SOCIO ASIAN
DEVELOPMENT SERVICE PROVIDE JUST
AGEE. OTHER PARTNERS- AND
WORKGROUP REALLY HAS THANK YOU.
TO HELP IN THE OVERALL- AND HOW
WE SHOULD APPROACH THIS
INCLUDING A PROVIDER FEEDBACK ON
MEMBER COMMUNICATIONS FACILITY
COMMUNICATIONS CONTRACT
LANGUAGE- DATA SHARING OTHERS
BEEN A NUMBER OF. CONVERSATIONS
AND YOUR CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN EARNEST I'M
HOPING TO HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THAT WORKGROUP BY MAY THAT
WILL REALLY HELP US FINALISE
POLICIES YOU GET. THAT GUIDANCE
OUT TO OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS IN
ANTICIPATION OF THAT CARBON- WE
ALSO HAVE CONVENED A SUB
WORKGROUP. IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES HOW TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC
TRANSITIONS FOR THE-
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
THAT. ARE UNIQUE POPULATION WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THERE TO YOU
I'D TAKE IT TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS OF THAT GROUP AND SO.
YOU'VE BEEN GAUGING IT AND THAT.
ARE ON THE MANAGED CARE PLAN
INCENTIVES- YOU KNOW THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT A GAP FILLING PLAN IN A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT I BET THAT WAS
DUE TO US IN JANUARY- WE ARE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT THAT THE
PRIORITY AREAS. OF THAT NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND GAP FILLING PLANT
WAS AROUND DELIVERY SYSTEM
INFRASTRUCTURE. ECM PROVIDER
CAPACITY BUILDING AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. CAPACITY
BUILDING AS WELL AS THE TAKE UP
OF THOSE COMMUNITY SUPPORT AND
SO ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
MANAGED CARE PLAN PARTNERS- THEY
DO RECEIVE. SOME FUNDING IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR BASED ON THE
FILINGS OF THOSE GAPS- PLANS AND
NEEDS ASSESSMENTS AND THEN THEY
WILL BE REQUIRED TO. MEET
VARIOUS PERFORMANCE METRICS OVER
THE REST OF THE CALENDAR YEAR ON
THE NEXT PAYMENT DATE WHICH
WOULD BE SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
I'M CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THEIR MEDICARE PLANS TO SEE WHAT
THE PROGRAM YOU'RE TOO AND
PROGRAM YOUR THREE REQUIREMENTS
METRICS WOULD BE. OF COURSE
ALIGNING WITH THE NEXT PHASES OF
CAL LANE FOR EXAMPLE THE CARVING
AND OF LONG TERM CARE. OF AND
OTHER KIND OF HEAT- YOU KNOW
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
APPROACHES THERE AS WE CONTINUE
TO KIND. OF DIG IN ON THAT
FRONT. ON THE OTHER P. IS. ASKED
TO DO KIND OF WHAT THROUGH HOW.
CAN HOW CERTAIN OF POP. IN
VULNERABLE- YOU KNOW.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
JUSTICE- AND LONG TERM CARE SO
JUST A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THAT.
NO REALLY AT THE END OF THE DAY-
WE HAVE PROVIDED A SUITE OF
SERVICES FOR SOMEONE WHO IS
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. ON THE ENHANCED
YOUR MANAGEMENT BENEFITS REALLY
ALLOWS FOR- OUTSIDE THE FOUR
WALLS IT'S INTENDED TO BE A
STREET BASED INITIATIVE. OF
WHERE SOMEONE IS MEETING PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE THAT'S NOT A
CLINIC IT BASED ON A PIECE OF
COURSE A LOT OF OUR ECM
PROVIDERS HAVE BOTH WHICH IS
GREAT- AND WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE STREET MEDICINE PROVIDERS-
EAGER AND WILLING TO WORK WITH.
US IN MANAGED CARE PLANS TO YOU
TO REPEAT I JUMP IN- AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES. ALSO
THERE'S A SUITE OF COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS YOU HAVE- NAVIGATION
SERVICES- HOUSING DEPOSITS
LIAISON SERVICES SO WHEN SOMEONE
GETS HOUSE WE CAN KEEP THEM
HOUSED- OFTEN A VERY YOU KNOW.
LONG TRANSITION FOR INDIVIDUALS
BUT WE ALSO ARE COVERING WE
COULD PREDICT CARE SERVICES OR
WHAT SOME CALL HIS MEDICAL
RESPITE. AND SHORT TERM POST
HOSPITALIZATION SO IF YOU HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL DOES THAT YOU KNOW
IT MADE IT TO A HOSPITAL. ARE
THAT NEED TO BE DISCHARGED-
OFTEN TIMES THEY CAN LANGUISH IN
AN INPATIENT BED. WHICH IS A BED
THAT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
SOMEONE ELSE IF THEY HAD
SOMEWHERE TO DISCHARGE TO YOU.
NOW WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A
FULL CONTINUUM OF SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. SO THEY CAN
TRANSITION INTO MEDICAL RESPITE
OR SHORT TERM POST
HOSPITALIZATION WITH THE GOAL OF
HOPEFULLY WRAPPING AROUND THE
ECM SERVICES ROUNDED INDIVIDUAL.
CONNECTING THEM WITH HOUSING IN
REALLY FOCUSING ON CONNECTING
THEM WITH WHATEVER NEEDS THEY
NEED WHETHER THAT'S BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS. THEIR DIABETES
GETTING UNDER CONTROL AND
COMPLIANCE A NUMBER OF THINGS
AND SO- ROBUST PACKAGE TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. REALLY WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
DSS AND OTHER- YOU KNOW IN
REGARDS TO THE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES- WELL THIS FALL
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR JUSTICE INVOLVED.
INDIVIDUALS AS YOU KNOW- THE
PROPOSED IN THE BY. A ROBUST
JUST PACKAGE WE ARE STILL. THAT
WAS. BUT IT'S- WHAT IT WOULD DO
PROVIDE. IN REACHED. BY
SOMEONE'S IN. THAT PRISON JAIL
OR G. FACILITY LAW. TO COVER
OVER. OF SERVICES AND BENEFITS.
OF WHILE THEY ARE INCARCERATED
AND YOU HAVE A COORDINATED
REENTRY INTO THE COMMUNITY- WE
HAVE EXTENSIVE DATA THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT SHOWS. THAT
THIS WILL REDUCE- NOT ONLY
EMERGENCY ROOM AND INPATIENT
DAYS UPON RELEASE INTO THE
COMMUNITY. IF WE CAN ONNECT
THEM TO THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTS
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING
RELEASED FROM JAIL INTO
HOMELESSNESS. CONNECT THOSE DOTS
ARE WE REALLY FEEL LIKE WE CAN
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE- JUSTICE
INVOLVED. IN CONNECTING THEM TO
IT A NETWORK OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
EITHER HAVE. EXPERIENCE AT YOUR
PEERS THAT ARE JUST AS INVOLVED
IN OTHERS AND SO WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT. OUR JUSTICE
INVOLVED PACKAGE THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON DILIGENTLY WITH CMS.
AND THEN LASTLY THE INDIVIDUALS
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES A
VARIETY OF THE THINGS THAT ENDD
UP IN COMMUNITY SUPPORTS REALLY
ARE THINGS THAT YOU WOULD
NORMALLY SEE IN A NINETEEN
FIFTEEN C. WAIVER. FOR SOME OF
OUR OTHER H. C. B. S. SERVICES.
IN MAKING SURE THAT THOSE ARE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE BOTH FROM A
PREVENTATIVE POINT OF VIEW OR IF
THEY'RE IN A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY AND WANT TO TRANSITION.
TO THE COMMUNITY AND CAN SAFELY
RESIDE IN THE COMMUNITY BUT PROP
SERVICES. MAKING SURE WE MAKE
THOSE AVAILABLE FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND BY CARVING LONG TERM CARE
INTO THE MANAGED CARE PLAN AND
THEN GIVING THEM THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT. THEY REALLY
HAVE ALL THE TOOLS AT THEIR
ABILITY TO MAKE SURE SOMEBODY IS
RICK YOU KNOW ABLE TO RESIDE
SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY EITHER
PREVENTING THAT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY STAY. OR TRANSITIONING
AMMONS OR REALLY EXCITED TO SEE
THAT PACKAGE COME TOGETHER. TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
EXPANDING LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE LAST THING I
MENTIONED BEFORE OF COURSE CLOSE
AND OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS. WE
ALSO HAVE IN TELLING A PAST
FUNDING OF PROVIDING ACCESS IN
TRANSFORMING HEALTH DOLLARS.
REALLY THESE ARE DOLLARS THAT
WERE APPROVED. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION AHLERS YOU GET DOLLARS
DIRECTLY TO. WE KNOW THE IT IS A
- HOW. TO BUILD THE LARGE
IMPORTS NEWS SERVICE ACROSS
STATE A. K. WHICH PROVIDERS
HISTORIC HAVE NOT BEEN. MEDICAL
PROVIDERS THEY HAVE TO LEARN HOW
TO BUILD AND DO THINGS SO. THE
PATH PROVIDE A DOLLARS PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO. THOSE
PROVIDERS THAT PROVIDE
COLLABORATION DOLLARS LOCALLY TO
CONVENE AND DISCUSS. IT ALSO.
INCLUDES DIRECT GRANTS FOR
PROVIDERS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILDING FOR WORKFORCE
EXPANSION. OF FOR TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT. AS WELL AS I. T.
SYSTEM CHANGES THAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT CAN BILL
MEDICARE HOW. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PROVIDERS DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE THAT RISK. BECAUSE THAT
IS HARD FOR SOME SMALL COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO DO. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
PEOPLE AS WE ROLL THAT OUT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS WELL. SO
THAT IS THAT CONCLUSION MY
CONSTANT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. I HAVE NOTHING FURTHER
TO ADD THANK YOU HELLO. THANK
YOU SENATOR ADMIN- KOREA SHEET
WITH THE US LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- ON THIS ISSUE
AND WE JUST MAKE A VERY BRIEF
COMMENT AND JUST RAISE THAT
THERE'S A BEAR REALLY MAJOR
PORTION OF- CATALANES
SPECIFICALLY. A PORTION OF
FUNDING TO SUPPORT. D. PROVIDING
ACCESS IN TRANSFORMING HEALTH OR
PATH PROGRAM WHICH GENERALLY.
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
NOTED PROVIDES FUNDING TO
PROVIDERS COUNTIES AND CEOS TO
ENSURE A SMOOTH TRANSITION TO.
THE VARIOUS KALYAN COMPONENTS
WHICH ADMINISTRATION ASSUMES
WILL BE SUPPORTED BY FEDERAL
FUNDS OF ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS- HOWEVER
WE UNDERSTAND THAT FEDERAL
APPROVAL FOR THIS- TO ACCESS
SORT OF THIS THIS FEDERAL
FUNDING REMAINS. PENDING
ALTERNATELY IF FEDERAL APPROVALS
NOT RECEIVED ACCESS FEDERAL
FUNDINGFOR THIS COMPONENT THAT
ALTERNATE FUNDING WOULD NEED TO
BE- PROVIDED SUPPORT SERVICE.
COMPONENTS OF THE PATH
INITIATIVE THAT THAT WE JUST
MENTIONED. SO THOSE ARE OTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE. FURTHER
ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED. THANK
YOU MUCH AND THINK YOU. MISS
COOPER FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ON
THIS I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE.
REALLY PUT YOUR HEART AND SOUL
INTO THIS AND WE ALL HAVE A LOT
OF HOPE. AND EXPECTATIONS I
GUESS WRITING ON THIS. FOR THE
IMPROVEMENT OF HEALTH FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS-
HOW CAN YOU TELL TALK TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT SO WE'RE
DOING FORTY THOUSAND ENROLLED
NOW AND- REMIND ME WHAT'S THE
WHOLE NUMBER THAT WE THINK.
ACROSS THE STATE THAT WILL GET
TO AT SOME POINT AND ROLLED AND
CAROLINE. SO THE TICKET WERE
FORTY THOUSAND FOR COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AND WE'RE NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND FOR ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT SO- YOU KNOW PRETTY
GOOD. PICK UP FOR THE
TRANSITION- YOU KNOW WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE WE HAVE A YOU
KNOW A SCALE WHERE WE DO THINK
THAT THAT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT. A PERSON CARE IN HEALTH
TERMS WITHIN SOME OF OUR LARGEST
POPULATED COUNTIES- IT WAS LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES IT WAS LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO- I EITHER REALLY
LARGER AREAS WHERE THE
POPULATION IS. IS PRETTY HIGH WE
STILL ANTICIPATE A DOUBLING OF
THE AT. LEAST OF THOSE ERVICES.
WE DO THINK ANYWHERE FROM YOU
KNOW ONE TO YOU YOU KNOW THREE
OR EVEN SOMETIMES 5% DEPENDING
ON THE POPULATION OF FOCUS. I
WILL- COME INTO THE PROGRAM BUT
IT DOESN'T MEAN SOME DOESN'T
STAY ON THAT. IN THOSE SERVICES
FOREVER IT DEPENDS ON THE TYPE
OF SERVICE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING.
FOR EXAMPLE A HOME MODIFICATION
IS A ONE TIME YOU KNOW ODD YOU
KNOW BENEFIT FOR SOMEBODY- TO
RECEIVE- IT'S NOT LIKE THEY
WOULD BE ON GOING RECEIVING
THOSE SERVICES AND SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT WE
HAVE. STANDARDIZED REPORTING TO
LOOK AT UTILIZATION TRENDS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE BREAKING THAT DOWN BY
RACE ETHNICITY LANGUAGE
ETCETERA- AND- AS A DATA ROLLS
AND WE'RE ANTICIPATING. ABOUT
THE MIDDLE OF THIS YEAR WILL BE
ABLE TO START POSTING A
DASHBOARD FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BE
TRACKING. OUR INVOLVEMENT
NUMBERS IN THE PROGRAM. OKAY AT
CERTAIN WE'RE AFFECTED SO WE
HAVE THOSE THOSE. VETTEL PERSON
CARE IN A LOT OF THOSE KIND BUT
WE WERE PROVIDING THE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR ALL A LOT OF
THEM TO GO ALONG WITH THAT. SO
HOW HAVE THE CAR HAS HOW IS THE
COST OF. THE COUNTIES NOW.
TWITTER ACCOUNT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ACTUALLY CONTRACT. THE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT WE NEED IN THIS
NEXT PHASE ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO HOUSING. YES THE
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE- TWENTY
SUPPORT THATHAS THE LARGEST
PICKUP SO MANAGED CARE PLANS
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY BEEN ABLE TO
BUT I THINK IT WAS ALL THE WAY
TO THE END JUST TO BE CLEAR AND
SOME ARE PROBABLY CONTRACTS ARE
STILL GOING TO COURT FOR FINAL.
SIGN OFF- YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO EXECUTE THOSE CONTRACTS
WITH COMPANIES WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEMS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT'S
JUST WHAT WAS TRANSITIONING OVER
WE DO KNOW THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SEE INCREASED OUR PROVIDERS-
PARTICIPATE IN COMMUNITY
SUPPORT- AND WE KNOW MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE WORKING VERY
ACTIVELY WITH INDIVIDUALS TO
FINALIZED OR BRING ON NEW
PROVIDERS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
INCREASING THAT NETWORK OVER
TIME- BUT- THESE ARE NEW
RELATIONSHIPS AND SO WE DO KNOW
THAT. AND TRY TO SET THE
EXPECTATION THAT IT WILL TAKE
TIME TO BUILD THIS UP ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HAPPY TO
SEND YOU A LIST OF FOR EXAMPLE
ALL THE HOUSING- PIECES THAT WE
HAVE MANY COUNTIES ARE ARE
PROVIDING HOUSING RELATED
SERVICES- AND SO WE ANTICIPATE
THOSE NUMBERS TO INCREASE.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
COMING MONTHS. AND IT IS L. A.
WAS POINT ABOUT- THIS IS STILL
PENDING NEGOTIATIONS FOR THE
PAST FUNNY THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- SO IF THAT DOESN'T COME
THROUGH AND SOME AND MY QUESTION
IS REALLY JUST- AROUND BILLING.
RATE WE'RE GOING TO REDO THE
BILLING IT SOUNDS LIKE FOR CAL
AIM BUT IS THAT GOING TO BE FOR
MEDICAL AS A- AS A WHOLE. THE
WE'RE GONNA REDO THE BILLING OR
JUST FOR THE KILLING SECTION. TO
CLARIFY HERE SO I'D SEE MASTERS
BELIEVE PROVED THAT UNITY
SUPPORTS AND ALL OF THE-
SERVICES. THAT IS BUILT INTO THE
CAPITATION RATE WE HAVE THE- THE
FUNDING FOR THAT THE BUDGET
THAT'S FULLY APPROVED AND NO
ISSUES THERE- WHEN IT COMES TO
PASS. BMS HAS ALSO APPROVED PATH
AS THE FEDERAL BUT DRAW DOWN SO
THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED IT'S
CURRENTLY APPROVED IN OUR LEVIN
FIFTEEN WAIVER. FOR THE
PATHFINDER. THE PEACE THAT THE
ALLEY- WAS MENTIONING IS THE NON
FEDERAL SHARE. CALIFORNIA HAD
PUT A PROPOSAL FORWARD TO USE
WHAT'S CALLED DISH BEATS VERY
TECHNICAL TERM. BUT IT'S WHERE
WE ACTUALLY USE ADDITIONAL.
FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL SIDE. TO
COVER THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE STILL
NEGOTIATING SO IT'S JUST- THE
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE COMMITTED FOR
PATH. WE'RE TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
THE NON FEDERAL SHINES. FUNDS OF
USING DISH BE. TECHNICAL SO
WE'LL GET INTO IT TOO MUCH. AND
IF THEY ARE CORRECT CMS DID NOT
APPROVE THAT PART OF THE PEACE
WERE CONTINUING THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS. WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR IT CLOSELY BUT IF FOR
SOME REASON. IT WAS DENIED IN
THE FUTURE WE WOULD HAVE TO
THEN. REPLACE IT WITH SOMETHING
FOR THAT NON FEDERAL SHARE FOR
THOSE. FOR THOSE PATH AHLERS
BUT- THERE HAS BEEN- A GENERAL
FUND COMMITTED FOR PATH IN THE
BUDGET. CURRENTLY FOR BOTH THE
JUSTICE INVOLVED PATH PART. AS
WELL AS- IN OUR HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES PLANNED
THERE'S A PORTION OF FUNDS.
DEDICATED TO PAP AS WELL ALREADY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND SO WE
HAVE SOME. LEEWAY. AND YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS VERY CLOSELY. DO
YOU. HOPEFUL IF YOU ARE COUPLE
YEARS- YOU'RE- I DIDN'T SOME BY
YOU KNOW GETTING COMMUNITY. THE
BY THE MAZE. I DIDN'T PAY THAT
FOR WAS- THE DISHMAN PARTS GOING
TO BE A CHALLENGE. IT'S BEEN A
IT'S SOMETHING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS STRUGGLED WITH-
CONTINUING FOR A WHILE BUT- WE
HAVE A GOOD ARGUMENT THAT YOU'RE
REALLY CRITICAL PAYMENTS IT'S
FOCUSED ON EQUITY IN IT. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS BURIED YOU
KNOW. A CLEARLY WANTING TO CLOSE
EQUITY GAPS WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THEM TO CONTINUE
LOOKING AT OUR DISH BECAUSE LAW
AND WILL CONTINUE TO STRESS THAT
THE CMS. THANK YOU CLICK TO
PRINT. THANK YOU AND FIRST
MONTHS CONGRATULATIONS ON
GETTING THE WAIVERS- I KNOW THAT
WAS A LOT OF WORK AND PERSUASION
HALFPENNY I DO APPRECIATE CMS
SEEING THE WISDOM OF APPROVING
THESE WAIVERS- AND LETTING US
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS VERY
IMPORTANT. INITIATIVE CAL AIM SO
CAN THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT- DID
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF-
YOU KNOW IMPLEMENTATIONS WERE
NOW ROLLING THE IMPLEMENTATION
USED TO BE SPENT ON TIME YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PLANNING AND
SO FORTH. SO ON THE END HENCE
CARE MANAGEMENT I THINK YOU
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW CURRENTLY
GOT NINETY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN THERE WE HAVE A STILL SORT OF
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO COULD
QUALIFY- SO IS ANYONE WHO FITS
INTO THOSE CATEGORIES QUALIFY
FOR BEHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT OR-
IS THE NUMBER CAST. AT SOME
POINT- IS SO IS IT A TITLE MEANT
OPEN IT OUT SO BASICALLY IT'S
WHOEVER NEEDS IT. WHO FITS THE
CATEGORIES. QUALIFICATIONS THAT
SET OUT WE'LL GET IT OR IS IT
LIKE- WELL ACTUALLY- ME TO CAP
OUT A CERTAIN POINT AND THEN
EVEN IF YOU QUALIFY WELL YOU
EITHER HAVE TO WAIT OR- WHATEVER
SO. SO IT'S GOING TO ENHANCE
CARE MANAGER AND YOU DID MENTION
THAT- AND REALIZING THAT PEOPLE
ARE GONNA STAY ON IT FOREVER
NECESSARILY DEPENDS ON WHAT
THEIR SITUATION IS. THAT THAT
THAT- I WOULD SAY THE GOAL IS
BUT THE ESTIMATE IS THAT
EVENTUALLY 5% OF MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS OF PRICE FIT IN THAT
CATEGORY IS. SO IT DOES NOT
CLARIFY- HOW MANY PEOPLE DO
EXPECTS TO. THEN GET ENHANCED
CARE MANAGEMENT AND- IS THAT
BASED ON NEED OR STARE AT IT OR
IS THERE A CAP. BECAUSE. OF
FINES THIS CALL REASONS. SO IT
IS A BAD IS THAT ANTI. AS IT
WERE BUILT IN BUT WE CALL CORE
MEDICAID. SO IT IS. THERE'S NOT
A CAP ALLOWED IN THOSE SERVICES
I WAS LONG IF SOMEONE MEETS
BEACH ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND
THERE'S BEEN AN EVALUATION OF
NEED. BASED ON THAT CRITERIA
THERE'S DIFFERENT CRITERIA FOR
EACH OF THE POPULATIONS OF FOCUS
RIGHT ON THEN THEY WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES OKAY SO THAT'S IT.
THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR SO AND- I
GUESS WE'RE JUST ROLLING OUT OF
ITS- GIVEN EFFECTIVE OFF LITTLE
OVER FOURTEEN MILLION PEOPLE ON
MEDICARE- WE CAN TALK ABOUT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE CASES AFTER
EMERGENCIES OVER. 5% WOULD MEAN-
AT AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
SO. WE'RE WE'RE ALL OFF TO THE
START HERE NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
SO. I WOULD MAKE NOTE OF THAT AT
LEAST BUDGET TERRIBLY- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR- MEDI CAL
BUDGET R. R. DTS MATHEMATICAL
BUDGET THAT- ACTUALLY THE
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT THAT
IS. ONLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR- THIS COMING YEAR
AND FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
MILLION FOR THAT SO IT'S
ACTUALLY LESS THAN OF. THAT
FACTION OR PERCENT SO- LOOKING
FOR THAT. AND IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE PUTTING INTO. ANIMALS
SAYING THAT- THAT ISN'T ENOUGH
BUT ID- JUST WANT TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT- SO FAR- IT'S- THERE'S
NO YOU KNOW IT'S NOT LARGE CIVIL
IT THAT'S A LARGE SUM IN ITSELF
BUT AS A PROPORTION OF TOTAL
MEDICAL BUDGETS. NOT VERY LARGE-
WHEN COMES TO. SUPPORT AND- ZERO
AND I KNOW WE'VE BACK WITH DOWN
THE PLANT THE THAT EACH PLAN
GETS SITE WHICH YOU SUPPORT ARE
DOING AND I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT
IT'S STARTING ROLL OUT HERE-
DIDN'T PARTICULARLY COUNTIES
WHERE THERE'S- MORE. MOBILE PLAN
SO WE HAVE THE CODE IS ONE PLAN
BUT IN THE COUNTIES WHERE
THERE'S MULTIPLE PLANS- IT WENT
WHEN CONCERN WOULD BE IS A
STATS- OVERTIME. FANS OF FIGURED
OUT CERTAIN OF THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS MAY TEND TO ATTRACT A
CERTAIN CASE MIX VERSUS OTHERS.
AND IS THERE GOING TO BE. FROM
THE H. C. S. PERSPECTIVE-
MONITORING OF THAT AND MONTINI
SUCH IS THE CASE MIX OF. PLANS
GIVEN WHAT COMMITTEE SUPPORTS
THEIR THEIR WILLING TO OFFER AND
PROVIDE AND PERHAPS EVEN MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS TO- PAYMENT RATES
THIS PLAN SO THAT WE DON'T
DISADVANTAGE. I DON'T HAVE PLANS
CHOOSING NOT TO DO CAN YOU
SUPPORT IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE
THEY REALIZE THAT. CAUSES THEM
TO ATTRACT AN ADVERSE CASE MIX.
AND AND PUT THEM AT THE SCHOOL
DISADVANTAGE. SO IS THERE GOING
TO BE MONITORING OF CASE MIX AND
THEN PLANT SPECIALTY MULTI
PLANNED COUNTIES WERE
ESSENTIALLY PEOPLE GET TO CHOOSE
I GET THOUGH THIS PLAN VERSES
THAT PLANTS. RIGHT I MEAN IT
BECAUSE- THEY GOT THE ONE
PLANNED SO WE'RE SO WE'RE ABOUT
THAT. ALTHOUGH I THINK WE GET TO
PUT MIGHT ABOUT SIMPLICITY.
WHERE THAT MIGHT NOT BE EXACTLY
TRUE. BUT SO WE MONTREAT CHASE
MAKES- THAT MIGHT BE INFLUENCED
BY. A DECISION BY PLANS OFFER
CERTAIN COMMUNITY SUPPORTS BUT
NOT OTHERS. I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THE
GOAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT IS THAT
ALL MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE GONNA
BENCHLEY- COVER. UP ANY SPORTS
NO I AGREE WITH YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T REQUIRE THAT
YES I'D LIKE TO BUT I THINK WE
BOTH TALKED ABOUT WE CAN'T DO
THAT YET. I AGREE. BUT WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS YES WE ARE
DEFINITELY LOOKING AT CASE MIX
AND ACUITY IS A PART OF IT IN
FACT WE ARE STARTING TO REALLY
WRAP OUR ARMS AROUND- CHANGES
THAT WE ARE ANTICIPATING. IN
REGARDS TO MANAGED CARE PLANS.
ALREADY BUILDING AS YOU KNOW-
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WILL ALSO BE INCLUDING A QUALITY
INTO OUR OUR RATES. ON THE
MEDICARE PLAN SITE IN ONE OF THE
BIG THINGS THAT WERE ALSO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH. ON UP WITH
MANAGED CARE PLANS IS THAT
ACUITY FACTOR A MORE COMPLEX
PATIENTS THE CASE MAKES- AS
BEING A PART OF OUR ANNUAL RATE
SETTING PROCESS AND SO. ON THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES WE WILL BE
TAKING THAT INTO ACCOUNT OKAY
YEAH AGAIN I'D I'D- I JUST DON'T
WANT CERTAIN COMMUTE SPORTS
BEING DROPPED OFF BY PLANS
BECAUSE- AND BECAUSE THERE IS.
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'LL
BE DISADVANTAGE THE TACTIC
THIRTY CEMEX WILL BE.
DISADVANTAGED THE OTHER THE
OTHER THING I HAVE TO BRING UP
BECAUSE IT INVOLVES MY DISTRICT-
IN THE TRANSITION- FOR THE-
BETWEEN FEE FOR SERVICE AND
MANAGED CARE- AND- TERMS OF
SPECIALTY AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- THE- BUT IN A WAY
THAT'S- ONE OF THE ISSUES IS IN
JULY TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT WOULD PLEASE SEE THE SPOTS
THE KAISER BEING TRANSFERRED TO.
SOLANO SACRAMENTO COUNTIES AND-
UNDERSTAND THERE'S US THERE'S
SOME CONCERN AT LEAST. AND BY
COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY THAT.
WELL I THINK DATES FINALLY
RELEASED IN A TO GET IN AS- AND-
OF PATIENTS DATA TO PICK UP.
WHICH KIND OF STYLE TO ME THAT
COULD BE REAL VALE. BUT THEN
THE- THE COVER THE CUT THE COST
OF HAVING TO PROVIDE THAT CARE
OF BEING SHIFTED TO NOW THE
COUNTY- CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO.
TWO WHAT WHAT'S BEING DONE TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. I'M
ACTUALLY GONNA ASK WENDY
HARRINGTON WHO'S BEEN HURT HER
TEAM HAD BEEN LEADING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS OF
WENDY CAN YOU TAKE THAT ONE.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
FINANCING SO. YES AND THE TEAM
HAS CONTINUED TO WORK. ACTIVELY
WITH BOTH SUPPLEMENTAL IN SOLANO
COUNTY IS. Q. AND- TO IDENTIFY
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WE
THINK ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
TRANSITION. AS WELL ADAM IS THAT
THEY HAVE WORKED AND LANDED ON
THOSE NUMBERS. AND WE CONTINUE
TO WORK. IN COLLABORATION. FOR
FIGHTING THE- SO NINETEEN FOR
THOSE COUNTIES AGAIN THAT IS A
PROCESS. AND THIS WILL NOT. HE'S
ENTITLED TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WE'RE CONTINUING WORK WITH THEM
TO. SEE IF I CAN REQUEST REALLY
. WHAT IN THE SIDE OF THE SHOULD
BE ACTIVE PLANNING AND FOR THIS
TRIP. AND WORKING WITH THEIR
PARTNERS. WELL IT'S HARD TO WHEN
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT RESOURCE YOU
HAVE SO- IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT THAT THEY GET
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO DO THIS
I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING HARD ON
IT- THE OTHER ISSUE I GUESS
QUESTION I HAVE SO YOU KNOW
WE'RE CREATING THESE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND- APPRECIATE THE
YOU KNOW THAT HAVING THOSE
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE A BETTER
QUALITY AND SO FORTH- BUT CAN
YOU SPEAK TO IN TERMS OF THE
INCENTIVES I GUESS A COUPLE
THINGS WE KNOW WHEN WE TALK
TOUCH ON CASE MIX RIGHT SO. WE
CAN BE SURE THAT PLANS AREN'T
PENALIZED TO EITHER RATES OR
INCENTIVES BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
SECURE YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A CASE
MIX THAT'S MORE CHALLENGING AND
THEN IN THE CASE MAKE SIDE EVEN
ON THE EQUITY SIDE SO. I
REALIZED AGAIN THIS IS MEDICARE
ALSO IN GENERAL THE PATIENT NO
PATIENTS ARE LOW INCOME. BUT-
DELETED OFF THE ABOUT THE HELLO
RIGHT SO YOU CAN THE ID. AND YOU
COULD BE LIVE IN A COMMUNITY.
THAT HAS BETTER. TO WHETHER IT'S
FOOD SO- YOU KNOW THAT
APPROPRIATE FOODS OR- YOU KNOW.
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DIETITIANS
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS IT'S
BETTER- AND YOU COULD BE LIVING
IN A COMMUNITY THAT MAY NOT BE-
HAVE THE SAME SORT OF SUIT
ASSERTS AND- IT'S WHICH MAKES IT
HARDER TO FIND. ITS ADDRESS AND
SO- HOW IS THE- STATE. HOUSE IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM LOOKING AT
IN TERMS OF. WHEN COMES TO YOUR
RATE OF ELEVATION AND
INCENTIVES. BOTH CASE MIX AND
SOME OF THESE EQUITY ISSUES ARE
CONTRACTING WITH PROVIDERS WHO
ARE ACTUALLY SERVING. THAT JUST
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY LOCATED IN
THESE COMMUNITIES- AND- AND THEN
ALSO THE DRESSING THE-
DIFFERENTIAL POTENTIALLY IN
SOCIAL TERMS OF HEALTH ISSUES.
YOU KNOW FACTORS OF IT IN THE
PATIENTS ARE BEING SEEN BY
MEDICAL PARTICULARLY PATIENTS
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS. YEAH SO
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTION SO IF YOU GIVE ME THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES FROM A RATES
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE DEFINITELY
TAKING THE- CASE MESSENGER
PERSPECTIVE AND WE TOOK A LOT OF
THE EXPERIENCE- AND KNEW WHO IS
GOING TO BE TRANSITIONING FROM
WHOLE PERSON CARE INTO EACH
PLANT. TO BE ABLE TO ACCOUNT FOR
THAT THE RATES THAT- MANAGED
CARE PLANS HAVE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE R. AND FORWARD- ON THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM SITE YOU KNOW
WE ARE INCENTIVIZING A NUMBER OF
THINGS. INCLUDING ON MAKING SURE
THAT AS WE BUILD THESE NETWORKS
WE ARE MEETING THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF EACH OF THE VARIOUS COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AND DOING THAT WITH AN
EQUITY LENS. AND BY THAT I MEAN
MAKING SURE THAT THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE INCENTIVIZING
WHAT I WOULD SAY THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO CONTRACT WITH
PROVIDERS OR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE THAT
UNIQUE EXPERIENCE AND- MAKING
SURE THAT WE IT IS REFLECTIVE OF
THE POPULATION WHETHER THAT'S BY
RACE ETHNICITY LANGUAGE
ETCETERA. I'M TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
MEETING THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES ACROSS
ALL OF THOSE PIECES WITH A
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. LENDS AN
APPROACH SO THAT IS A PART OF
THE- THE MEASURES TODAY ARE
IMMENSE AND TRIED DIFFERENT
THINGS ANYWAY ANYTHING FROM YOU
KNOW EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROVIDERS. MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE SEEING- EQUITY GAP CLOSURE
ACROSS THE AREAS- AND FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAD RECORDED IN OUR
INTERIM EVALUATION OF WHOLE
PERSON CARE IS THAT WE WEREN'T
SEEING A PROPORTIONAL NUMBER OF.
INDIVIDUALS THE PEOPLE OF COLOR
APPROPRIATELY AND ROLLED INTO
THOSE PROGRAMS AND SO WE ARE
WATCHING THAT VERY CLOSELY. WITH
OUR UTILIZATION PIECES AND WE
HAVE INCENTIVES TIED IN THERE TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE PARTNERING WITH
THE RIGHT PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE. MEETING ALL OF OUR
POPULATION'S NEEDS OF AND SO I
THINK THERE'S A NICE BALANCE
WITH THE WAY WE BUILT THE
INCENTIVES THERE BUT OF COURSE.
OPEN TO OUR IDEAS AS WE BEGIN TO
BUILD. FOR YEAR WELL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE MEETING ALL OF
THOSE NEEDS RIGHT NOW I AM A
PRETTY. THAT I THINK THERE'S A
ROLLING OUT TO ME SO. WANTED
THINGS TO IN MY- IS THAT. WE
YEAH IT'S A NEW FOR THE PLAN TO.
SO THERE THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHO TO PARTNER WITH
AND SO FORTH- BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT A TOO OFTEN-
ORGANIZATIONS A PARTICULARLY
SERVE- BUT IT'S COMEY'S COLORS
OR OTHER- MORE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. SOMETIMES AS
ORGANIZATIONS- R. AS MUCH ON THE
RADAR SCREEN SO YOU KNOW MANAGED
CARE PLANS KIND OF LARGE- WE
ONLY GOT TO GET OUR PATIENTS A
LOT OF RESPONSIBILITIES- THEY'RE
INTERFACING WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT WHICH OF COURSE YOU
KNOW WE DEAL WITH PUBLIC FUNDS
SO WE HAVE CERTAIN
ACCOUNTABILITY ISSUES AND
THAT'S- THAT'S- I MEAN THAT'S
GOOD I MEAN WE WANT TO BE SURE
OF MONIES USED APPROPRIATELY. AT
THE SAME TIME. IT WILL BE SURE
THAT THEY'RE- TAKING THE EFFORT
TO OUR REACH IN TERMS OF
COMMITTEE SUPPORTS BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
THE ACTS THAT I CHAIR THE ATI
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND WE KNOW
LANGUAGE BARRIERS RATES ALREADY
CONTRACTING AND YARD TO WORKING
WITH. YOU KNOW COMEY SUPPORTERS
ASIANS FOR THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTS. THAT SHE COULD SPEAK
IN LANGUAGE. TWO PEOPLE
OTHERWISE LANGUAGE BARRIERS
BECOME AN ACCESS- YOU KNOW WE
ALSO KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW
STUDENTS FROM THE PROVIDERS- ARE
THEY GOING TO BE- YEAH I HAD A
SENSITIVE. AND TO THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY RIGHT- ARE THEY- SEEN
AS BEING PUT OUT POSITIVE TO NOT
ONLY LANGUAGE BUT ALSO
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE TO- YOU
KNOW THE BLACK COMMUNITY OR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY SO FAR SO.
HOPEFULLY WE'RE MONITORING THAT.
I KNOW THAT THE PLANS ARE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE JUST. TRYING TO
LEARN HOW TO DO SOME OF THIS.
TOO AND OF COURSE- YOU DID. BUT
OVER TIME A COURSE WE HAVE TO
DENNIS ACTUALLY LEARNING RIGHT.
THAT THAT AND THAT STUDY IS
GOING. TO SOME MONITOR. THERE
CAN YOU PUT. IT'S ALSO TO. AND
THIS IS THE LINK WITH THE LOCALS
WHICH I KNOW TO- YOU KNOW GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE TEND TO DO
MEDIC HOW. SORT OF COUNTY BY
COUNTY OR COUNTY BAR OR GROUPS
OF COUNTIES IT'S ADDRESS. TO GET
FEEDBACK FROM THE LOCAL PEOPLE
LIKE IS THAT THIS IS A MANAGED
CARE PLAN A MANAGED CARE PLANS
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE NEEDS
GOING ON THE LOCAL AREA THE
COUNTY. YOU ARE ALREADY REACHING
OUT TO THE TYPE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERS THEY'RE ACTUALLY IVING
PEOPLE ACCESS OR NOT AND SO. HE
SURE WE HAVE THAT FULL FEEDBACK
LOOPS ARE GOING ON. SO THEY CAN
SAY LOOK I'M PROVIDING TO ME
SUPPORTS BUT IT TURNS OUT THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT YOU KNOW THE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT THEY'RE
WORKING WITH AREN'T NECESSARILY
THE ONES THAT ARE. ABLE TO REACH
INTO- PARTICULAR. DEALS TAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES IT THAT OKAY. SO SO
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE PART ON MY
- PART IS. WERE ROLLED OUT I
THINK THAT. IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND- THAT WOULD.
APPRECIATE IS- THING IS HAVING
NO DEPARTMENT THINK ABOUT. HOW
YOU HAD HOW DO YU PUT TOGETHER
A REPORT LIKE THAT AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S RIGHT AT LEAST I WOULD
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE BE
VERY INTERESTED. IN AND SEEING
THAT AND SEEING HOW IS. TELLING
IS ROLLING OUT. NOW WITH A LOT
OF PROMISE NOW WE GOTTA FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE THAT PROMISE
DELIVER AND SO. DOES THAT DOES
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND SO
FORTH AND CERTAINLY EVEN YOU
KNOW R. AS IN THE LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE DISTRICT OFFICES WE HAVE
SOME SIMILARITY TO SOME THE
LOCAL FOLKS AND- WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE SOME- SOME IDEAS. OR
SUGGESTIONS THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL. YEAH I MEAN I. AGREE
WITH YOU 1100% WE TALK A LOT
INTERNALLY AROUND POLICIES ONE
THING IMPLEMENTATION AS A WHOLE
DIFFERENT PEACE AND- AND HOW WE
BUILD THIS ACROSS THE STATE WILL
TAKE TIME AND LIKE YOU SAID
MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE BUILDING
NEW RELATIONSHIPS AND NEW
PARTNERS AND I THINK A LOT OF
THEM ARE DOING. A REALLY GREAT
GREAT JOB OF LEANING IN. AND
REALLY TRYING TO WRAP THEIR ARMS
AROUND A REALLY COMPLEX NEW- NO
BENEFIT ACROSS THEIR COUNTIES-
BUT WE ARE DEFINITELY I TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE WILL. MONITOR
AND PULL THESE PIECES WE'VE
ALREADY ROLLED OUT SOME PIECES
THAT WE KNOW WILL BE LOOKING AT
LOOKING AT THE PROVIDER MAKES IS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
BENEFICIARY AS YOU RECALL. OR
ARE MENTIONING AND IT'S IT IT'S. AND THEY WERE. BUILDING A
PROPOSAL FOR HOW WE CAN GET A
FULL INVENTORY. OF THE VARIOUS
PROVIDERS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE DOING THIS
TODAY THEY'RE JUST NOT PART OF
MEDICARE ALL. ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- SO THAT WE CAN
COMMUNICATE TO THEM DIRECTLY
MAKE SURE THEY'RE AWARE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY BUILD THOSE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THEM AND
MANAGED CARE PLANS. AND THAT'S A
PART OF THOSE HALF DOLLARS WHAT
WE'LL BE DOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND LOCAL
COLLABORATION. BUT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO START WITH A FULL
INVENTORY OF THESE ARE
RELATIONSHIPS EVEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I HAVEN'T ALWAYS
HISTORICALLY HAD DIRECTLY- IT
VARIES OF COURSE ACROSS OUR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND SO- YOU
KNOW. WE DO KNOW THAT THIS WILL
TAKE TIME- BUT WE ARE TRYING TO
BUILD THE ROAD MAP FOR HOW WE
GET THERE OVER A FEW YEARS OF
GROWTH CONNECTIONS PARTNERSHIPS
AND HOPEFULLY. EVENTUALLY WE'LL
HAVE A REALLY GOOD NEXT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE MEETING. ON ALL THE
VARIOUS RACIAL LANGUAGE- AND IN
OTHER AREAS AROUND- WHAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO OUR BENEFICIARIES.
I'D LIKE. TO ALSO ADD JUST THAT
THE POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PIECE- OF CALAIS IS WELL AND
IT'S WE'RE COLLECTING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH DATA. AND
THE PLANS ARE BUILDING OUT THEIR
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES THIS IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF SEE HOW.
HOW THEY CAN DO BETTER IN TERMS
OF DRESSING ON THE POPULATION
HEALTH NEEDS. I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO HELP
US MONITOR HOW WEIRD YOU KNOW
SORT OF HOW WE'RE DOING ON THE
OUTCOMES PARKS IN THE QUESTIONS
WE FIND OUT WE'RE NOT DOING AS
WELL AS WE HOPE WE ARE. AND IT'S
GOING BACK TO OKAY HOW DO WE
CHANGE THE CURVE ON THAT SO IF
YOU HAVE ALL THOSE PIECES HAVE
TO COME TOGETHER IN A PAPER
SHEET THAT THAT THAT THE FACT
THAT WE DO HAVE A POPULATION
HEALTH. PIECE THAT WILL HELP US.
BE ABLE TO- HAVE DATA SHOW. HOW
WELL WE'RE DOING. THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE WERE WE ARE ALL
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS AND
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO VERY
POSITIVE OUTCOMES. FOR THE
COMMUNITY TONIGHT THE NINETY.
HOPEFULLY EVERYONE TAKES NOTE OF
DOCTOR PANTS GESTIONES AND WE
SAY THIS ALL THE TIME IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT WE'RE ALL OUT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ALL THE TIME
AND WE HAVE REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS OFTEN TIME WITH
OUR NONPROFITS WHO DO A LOT OF
THE SERVICE PROVISION. AND SO
ANY ANY WE WOULD LOVE TO HELP IS
WHAT WE SAY IF YOU NEED MORE
PEOPLE TO BE CONTRACTING WITH
THE LOCAL PLANS WE OFTEN HAVE
REALLY GOOD RELATIONSHIPS. WITH
A LOT OF THOSE PROVIDERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND CAN CAN HELP YOU
UP TO FIND SOME MORE AS
RESOURCES IF NEEDED- SO AGAIN
THIS KELLY WAS GONNA I KNOW
WE'RE ALL UPSET ABOUT THIS AND
SAID THE GRENADE ONTINUE TO
COME BACK AND KEEP. CHECKING IN
ON- TO MAKE SURE THAT IT GOES IT
FULFILLS ALL OF OUR EXPECTATIONS
. OKAY SPEAKING OF EXPECTATIONS
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
AND BRIDGE HOUSING PROPOSAL.
RIGHT SO THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
OR WHAT WE CALL IT- THE H. THE
IPS ARE YOU REALLY AIMS TO
INCREASE- AND DO CONSTRUCTION
ACQUIRE EXPAND PROPERTIES ACROSS
RELIGIOUS BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES AS WELL AS ON
INVESTMENTS IN THE MOBILE CRISIS
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- DH CS IS
RELEASING FUNDS OVER KIND OF SIX
GRANT ROUNDS- TARGETING VARIOUS-
GAP POPULATIONS I'M NOT GOING TO
WALK THROUGH THOSE JUST MAKE
SURE EVERYONE'S TRACKING THAT
AND THEN ZERO IN ON THE ROUNDS
THAT ARE COMING UP SO FOR ROUND
ONE I WHICH WAS MOBILE CRISIS IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DHS AWARDED A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION. DOLLARS TO FORTY FIVE
COUNTIES AND TRIBES AT THIRTY
SIX OF THOSE WERE IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS AND NINE OF THOSE WERE
PLANNING GRANTS- IN ROUND TWO A
WHAT WE CALL THE BROADER KIND OF
PLANNING AHEAD GRANTS FOR THE
OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONSTRUCTION PIECES IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WE AWARDED
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION TO
THIRTY SIX ENTITIES ARE TWENTY
FIVE COUNTIES NINE TRIBES FOR
PLANNING GRANTS TO GET READY FOR
THE LARGER INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS IS WRONG- WE ARE
CURRENTLY. IN ROUND THREE WHICH
IS WATCH READY AT THE RELEASE OF
THE WILL OF THE R. EIGHT CAME
OUT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THAT'S PART ONE OF THOSE
WILL BE DUE IN MARCH MARCH
THIRTY FIRST WE WILL HAVE A PART
TO HAVE LUNCH READY WHICH WILL
BE DUE IN MAY MAY THIRTY FIRST
OF THIS YEAR- SO REALLY-
FOCUSING ON THOSE AREAS GROUND
FLOOR IS AROUND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND WE WILL BE HAVING A
LISTENING SESSION ON MARCH
THIRTY FIRST OKAY STARTING TO
KICK OFF OF WHAT WE CALL AROUND
FOUR AM AND THEN ROUND FIVE IN
ROUND SIX ARE A PHASE WILL BE
RELEASED LATER IN THE WINTER OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON ON AROUND THREE- BAR
LUNCH READY PROJECTS- WE ARE
REALLY LOOKING TO. YOU KNOW
EXPAND. CAPACITY TO BRING IN IN
PROVIDING SIR FIRST. WE THOSE TO
BE OF A IN TWO THREE TO FOUR IN
TAKE TIME EVEN WITH THE LINGERIE
PROJECT OF WINDING WILL START.
CAPACITY BILL. DIRECT SERVICES
BEATING IN OUR AND- A THREE
TWENTY FOUR OF IT DEPENDS ON THE
SIZE OF THE PROJECT THAT WE
WOULD BE FINDING. NEW BUILDS
WILL TAKE LONGER AS OU WOULD
IMAGINE- AND SO POTENTIAL
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN COMING
IN- YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA BE VERY-
AND WE'LL SEE WHAT. ULTIMATELY
GETS FUNDED THERE. ARE PROJECTS
FUNDED IN ROUND FOUR OF THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THEY WILL
DONNELLY AND PRIMARILY BE
PROVIDED BY BEHAVIORAL SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE- IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE AS
YOU WOULD IMAGINE- A DH CS I
WILL ESTABLISH THE- ELIGIBLE
FACILITIES. AFTER YOU FINISH THE
LISTENING SESSIONS SO WE WANT TO
HEAR FROM PEOPLE WE WANT TO
ENGAGE WITH. THE STAKE HOLDERS
TO REALLY FINE TUNE THE LIST-
ABOVE OR WHAT WE WOULD BE
RELEASING IN THAT AREA- THROUGH
THE PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF CHILDREN YOUTH AND OTHER DH
CS KIND OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH
FOCUSED EFFORTS. WE WILL ENSURE
THAT THE EFFORTS ARE COORDINATED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THREE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED IN
THE ROUND TWO PLANNING GRANTS
THAT WE MAKE AVAILABLE AND-
REALLY TRY TO CONNECT THOSE DOTS
LOCALLY FOR PEOPLE IF THEY NEED
THOSE PLANNING DOLLARS TO KIND
OF. TIE ALL THOSE RESOURCES AND
INITIATIVES TOGETHER- WE ARE WE
ARE TRYING TO EDUCATE PEOPLE ON
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU
SOMEBODY. THAT LARGE NUMBER OF
THOSE GRANTS OUT BUT
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN WE ONLY HAVE
THEM IN TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES WE
HELP OTHERS WELL- COME IN AND
ASK. FOR SOME OF THOSE PLANNING
GRANT DOLLARS AS WELL. AND THEN
WHEN IT COMES TO- THE BEHAVIOR.
NEEDS DH CS YOU DON'T. THE
BEHAVIOR HOW NEEDS JUST- TO SET
PRIORITIES. ARE REALLY
DETERMINED ELIGIBLE ENTITIES AND
FACILITIES FOR DARLENE BROWN
FIVE AND SIX OF. THOSE BEING
RELEASED LATER IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WILL BE UTILIZED ALSO
FROM SCORING OF THE APPLICATIONS
COMING IN FOR. ROUNDS THREE
THROUGH SIX SO REALLY ALL THE
WAY FROM LARGE READY CHILDREN
YOUTH. AND THOSE OTHER
FACILITIES WILL BE USING IT TO
REALLY GUIDE- SCORING
PRIORITIES. THE GOAL IS TO FILL
GAPS ACROSS STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
AND REALLY MAKING SURE WE'RE
USING THAT TO DRIVE. DECISIONS
AND IN QUALIFIED ENTITIES ARE
EXPECTED TO USE THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS ASSESSMENT WHICH WE
HAVE PUBLISHED AND- RELEASED
BROADLY. AS WELL AS OTHER LOCAL
ASSESSMENTS. TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
NEEDS WHEN THEY ARE SUBMITTING
THEIR APPLICATION TO THE
DEPARTMENTS. ARE YOU KNOW
FURTHERMORE THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
ASSESSMENT HIGHLIGHTED THE ACUTE
NEED FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
OPTIONS- THAT PROVIDE WRAPAROUND
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES SO AS
YOU WOULD IMAGINE- WITHIN THE
BUDGET- THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BRIDGE HOUSING PROPOSAL- WHICH
WOULD FUND. A CLINICALLY
ENRICHED. HOUSING SETTINGS FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
YOU HAVE SERIOUS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS BOTH. MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. SERVICES OF FUNDING
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES
AND TRIBES TO PURCHASE INSTALL
AND OPERATE WHETHER IT'S TINY
HOMES OR FOR OPERATING COSTS
UPPER BRIDGE HOUSING. AND OTHER
SETTINGS INCLUDING EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL ADULT AND SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES. ULTIMATELY
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- AMONG THOSE WITH
COMPLEX BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS.
LEADS TO COSTLY CYCLE OF
AVOIDABLE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS INPATIENT STAYS. A LONG
TERM RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENTS
INCARCERATION AND ULTIMATELY.
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS SOMETIMES-
ENCODED. HAS REALLY JUST
EXASPERATED THESE CHILD SO THE
IMPACT- WILL GIVE LOCAL B.
HEALTH SYSTEM- DEDICATE RESOURCE
- THAT THEY TO. HOUSING SETTING
JUST A IN THE WITH TERM OR IN
HOUSING- WELL THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING A SERIOUS BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CONDITIONS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE TIME
. YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SHE HAVE. THANK
YOU- CENTER ADMIN COURT SHE
TAKEN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE JUST HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS TO RAISE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BRIDGE HOUSING
PROPOSAL- FIRST THOUGH WE JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A FORTHCOMING BRIEF FOCUSED
ON. THE GOVERNOR'S MAJOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSALS
COMING OUT NEXT WEEK WHICH WILL
COVER THE BRIDGE HOUSING
PROPOSAL- AS AS WELL AS A FEW
OTHER OF THIS YEAR'S BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BUDGET ITEMS- IN IN
FURTHER DETAIL- REGARDING BRIDGE
HOUSING YOU KNOW FIRST WE WOULD
NOTE THAT WE FIND THE APPROACH
TO FOCUS RESOURCES ON BRIDGE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS HAS
MERIT- THIS SPECIFIC POPULATION
FOLKS WHO STRUGGLE WITH BOTH
HOMELESSNESS AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- HAS SEEN EACH CARE NEEDS
AND- WE DO FIND THAT THE
PROPOSAL TARGETS A KEY GAP IN
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE BY FUNDING
BRIDGE HOUSING WHICH IS NOT
NECESSARILY A FOCUS OF- CERTAIN
COMPONENTS OF. THE SIX PRIOR
SPENDING ON HOMELESSNESS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
EXISTS AT A VERY CONCEPTUAL
STAGE RIGHT NOW- WITH KEY
DETAILS OUTSTANDING RELATED TO.
HOW THIS PROPOSAL WOULD WORK IN
PRACTICE- IN ADDITION YOU KNOW
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PLANNING
TO HAVE A TRAILER BILL FOR THIS
PROPOSAL- THESE THESE TWO
FACTORS TOGETHER MAY ULTIMATELY
SORT OF LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
INPUT THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ON DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL
FURTHER. YOU KNOW WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OVERSIGHT- THIS TRAILER BILL
COULD SPECIFY KEY PROGRAM
DETAILS FOR THIS PROPOSAL SUCH
AS- FOR EXAMPLE THE SPECIFIC
DISTRIBUTION METHODOLOGY-
WHETHER A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM OR MORE FORMULA BASED
ALLOCATION WHICH- MAY ULTIMATELY
RESULT IN FINES BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO COUNTIES QUICKER-
YOU KNOW. AS WELL AS SORT OF HOW
FUNDING WOULD BE PRIORITIZED FOR
DIFFERENT REGIONS IN THE STATE
THAT MAY HAVE DIFFERENT- LOCAL
NEEDS FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH BRIDGE
HOUSING- AND SORT OF WHAT SHARE
OF THESE FUNDS SHOULD GO TOWARDS. THE CONSTRUCTION OF TINY HOMES
WHICH ARE RELATIVELY NEW CON.
FOR A- FOR. RELATIVE TO FUNDING
AND EGGS. BRIDGE HOUSING'S- IT
COULD ALSO INCLUDE ANY STATUTORY
LANGUAGE NEEDED TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS FOR LOCAL APPROVAL
OF THE CONSTRUCTION TINY HOMES-
WHICH WE OFTEN WE AT WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND IS OFTEN SORT OF HELD
UP BY BY LOCAL OPPOSITION- NEXT
WE WOULD JUST SAY THAT IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
THESE BRIDGE HOUSING UNITS
PARTICULARLY THE TINY HOMES
AFTER THE LIMITED TERM FUNDING
FOR THIS PROPOSAL IS EXHAUSTED-
EVEN AFTER THE LONGER TERM. FIND
A- LONGER TERM UNITS FUNDED BY
PRIOR SEED INVESTMENTS COME
ONLINE- IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THEY
WILL STILL NEED TO BE A BRIDGE.
I NEED FOR BRIDGER SORT OF
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OPTIONS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND OF COUNTIES
WANT TO CONTINUE OPERATING THESE
BRIDGE HOUSING FACILITIES AFTER
THIS FUNDING RUNS OUT- THEY
WOULD NEED TO COME UP WITH THEIR
OWN FUNDING TO DO SO. AND THEIR
CAPACITY TO DO SO IS ULTIMATELY
UNCLEAR- REGARDING THE TIMING OF
WHEN YOU NO LONGER TERM HOUSING
UNITS COME ONLINE WHICH ARE SORT
OF INTENDED TO BE THE ENDPOINT
FOR FOLKS THAT. START THEIR
STAYS IN IN BRIDGE HOUSING YOU
KNOW WE FIND THAT IT'LL BE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT. THE
DURATION OF THESE BRIDGE OUSING
STAYS ACTUALLY DOES ALIGN WITH
WHEN THE MORE PERMANENT HOUSING
OPTIONS BECOME AVAILABLE. IF
THEY AREN'T THEY AND YOU KNOW
INDIVIDUALS STAYING IN THESE
BRIDGE HOUSING SETTINGS. MIGHT
FACE UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS
AGAIN OR THE BRIDGE HOUSING
UNITS MAY NOT BE VACATED IN TIME
TO ACCOMMODATE ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE IN NEED OF
THEM. FINALLY ON THE LINE. MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER THE TRADE OFF
BETWEEN PROPOSED- WHICH PROVIDE
A DISH FUNDS THE B. H. C. I. P.
PROGRAM- AND POTENTIALLY
MODIFYING OR EXPANDING. EXISTING
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE HOME TO YOUR ROOM KEY
PROGRAM TO FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
INDIVIDUALS STRUGGLING WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. YOU
KNOW WE RAISE THIS TRADE OFF AS
A CONSIDERATION BECAUSE THOSE
EXISTING PROGRAMS MAY HAVE
GREATER CAPACITY TO DEPLOY A
STORE THESE BRIDGE HOUSING
OPTIONS- IN A MORE IMMEDIATE AND
QUICK MANNER BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
TRACK RECORD OF MAKING. HOUSING
AVAILABLE IMMEDIATELY FOR FOLKS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- AND
IT MAY TAKE TIME FOR BEACH
SIESTA. ULTIMATELY JUST
DISPERSED BNP'S PROPOSE FUNG
SAID TO COUNTIES- THOSE ARE ALL
OF OUR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE USED FOR THEIR
SYSTEMS WHERE NEEDED. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MR SHOULD HAVE- CAN
YOU. THAT COURSE MS COOPER JUST
ABOUT THE AND I WILL SAY I AM
ONE WHO OF COURSE IS VERY HAPPY
TO SEE THIS. THIS BRIDGE BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT. THE INFRASTRUCTURE
MONEY IS JUST GONNA TAKE A LONG
OR IT WILL TAKE AWHILE TO GET
THINGS BUILT GET THINGS
CONSTRUCTED APPROVALS ALL OF
THAT. AND OUR OUR OUR NEED IN A
CRISIS IS NOW IS A REMINDED US
THE TEMPERATURE DIPS DOWN TO.
TWENTY SIX AGAIN TONIGHT- HOW
THAT MUST BE TO BE UNSHELTERED
ON THE STREETS- SO CAN YOU CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
DISCONTINUING THE BRIDGE. IS IT
REALLY THE BEST WAY TO DO IT.
AND HOW ARE YOU COORDINATING
WITH ROOM KEY AND HOME KEY AND
HEAT. AND ALL THE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE DOING SOME OF HIS MORE
SHORT TERM HOUSING. SURE SO WHAT
I'M GONNA DO IS ASK MARLEY'S
PREZ ON TO REALLY ADDRESS SOME
OF YOUR QUESTIONS SHE'S BEEN.
ARE THE LEAD ON THE- BEHAVIOR
HEALTH C. I. P. PROGRAM HAS DONE
AN AMAZING JOB GETTING THE
ROUNDS UP. AND RUNNING- IN
COORDINATING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE SS AND OTHERS IN REGARDS TO
ALL OF THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS IN
PIECES. AS WELL AS SHE WILL BE
LEADING THAT BRIDGE HOUSING
PARTS AND MAKING SURE THERE'S
CONNECTIONS AND- ONE OF THE
PIECES AROUND THE BRIDGE HOUSING
AND MAKING SURE THERE IS A LONG
TERM PLAN OR CONNECTION TO OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT THERE IS
A- A PATH. FORWARD FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BUT- HOPEFULLY NO
CLASS- AS IT'S BEEN ARTICULATING
BUT- I WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
LEAST YOU. ADD ADDITIONAL.
CONTEXT OR INFORMATION FOR YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING ALMOST
AFTERNOON. YEAH SO TO YOUR
QUESTION WE'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY. WITH OUR SISTER
DEPARTMENT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND STANDING UP
HM AS THEY'RE ROLLING OUT THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION.
PROGRAM AND ALSO JUST REALLY
MODELING AFTER ALL THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM ROOM KEY. AND HOME
KEY AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK
WHERE WE HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN
THE BRIDGE HOUSING IS REALLY
AROUND THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COMPONENT. AND JUST THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS ALREADY ESTABLISHED
WITH OUR COUNTIES AND TRIBAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
PROVIDING THAT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. SERVICES AND REALLY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH THIS BREAK
THIS HOUSING IS PROVIDING THAT.
FUNDING FOR THE SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S THOSE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. SERVICES THAT WE
ALREADY MENTIONED IN CALLING.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAIVERS TO
ECM AND SO WE FEEL REALLY WELL
POSITIONED IN ORDER TO HELP
COUNTY STAND THIS. QUICKLY
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
IS THAT NEED THAT NEED IS RIGHT
NOW AFTER TALKING. AND THEN ALSO
JUST YOU KNOW IN THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WERE JUST BROUGHT UP
WITHOUT HAVING THAT. PLACE THE
LAND YOU KNOW THAT PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. ALSO WERE
REALLY WORKING. TOGETHER ACROSS
THE ADMINISTRATION IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS BREAK FIX ALL AND HAVE
IT BE A BRIDGE YOU SOMEWHERE.
I'M SO INDIVIDUALS. JUST DON'T
FALL OFF LIKE YOU MENTIONED. AND
IN YOUR INTERACTIONS WITH THE
WITH THE COUNTY. YOU FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A TO
ACQUIRE. THE LAND THE SPACE AS
WE READ THE NEWS THIS WEEK. THAT
RENTS HAVE GONE UP TO THE
HIGHEST EVER. IN THE UNITED
STATES AND WE KNOW THAT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THE MOST HIGH
AND I'VE JUST I'VE TALKED WITH A
LOT OF FOLKS WHO HAVE VOUCHERS
THAT THAT. THEY CAN'T USE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND A PLACE.
SO HOW. ARE WE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO. DO THE COUNTY'S FEEL HOPEFUL
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO USE
IT. EFFECTIVELY TO BE ABLE TO.
GET HOUSING. AND NOT- FURTHER
IMPACT OF A VERY ALREADY A VERY
TIGHT MARKET. YEAH AND SO IN
SPEAKING WITH THE COUNTY'S
THEY'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T TRADITIONALLY HAVE FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING AND WE
LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUAL WITH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS ON
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL HOUSING
TYPES WANT TO TAKE THAT
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY SURE. YOU KNOW HOW
TO WORK WITH THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
OR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WELL
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL COMPANIES
HAVE ESTABLISHED THESE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WITH HEALTHY
PARTNERS BUT A LOT OF THE TIMES
THEY JUST HAVEN'T HAD THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE IN ORDER TO
PAY FOR THAT BECAUSE THAT IS NOT
IN OUR SERVICE THAT IS
TRADITIONALLY PAID FOR WITH
MEDIC HOW- OTHER FUNDING SOURCE.
I'M SO THEY'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND MORE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND TO BE ABLE PROVIDE TEST FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS LIKE SPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE YOU KNOW LEAVING
THE TREATMENT I THINK MAYBE THEY
HAVE. NOWHERE TO LIVE AND THEN
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO WORD TO
LEAD THEN IT JUST YOU KNOW CAN
REPEAT THEIR CYCLE AND THEY
pSERVICES AGAIN- SO YEAH IN OUR.
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE COUNTING.
THEY'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CONFIRM
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT I SEE
LIKE. SOME OF THE SMALLER
COUNTIES CALAVERAS DELL NORT
BUILDER AUTO- THEY RECEIVED
FUNDING BUT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO CATCH THAT SET UP ANY
NEW TEAMS YET. IS THAT DID WE
EXPECT THAT FOR SOME OF THESE
THE SMALLER COUNTIES. I CAN TAKE
THAT ONE SO BAD I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS WITH OUR
BEACHES ARE ROUND ONE MOCK BROWN
RICE THAT'S CORRECT AND SO AND
YOU KNOW AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW
COUNTIES ARE ALL IN DIFFERENT
STAGES OF WHAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE WITH MOBILE CRISIS
TEAMS. AND SOME OF THE COUNTIES
JUST HAVEN'T HAD A MOBILE CRISIS
TEAM AND WE'VE SEEN THAT ACROSS
MORE RURAL AND NORTHERN AREAS
AND SOME IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE OFFER THIS
PLANNING GRANT. AND SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THIS PLANNING
GRANT IS HELPING THEM MAYBE
ESTABLISH THEIR FIRST CRISIS
TEAM THAT THEY'VE EVER HOT- AND
THEN WE THANK CRISIS TEAM YOU
KNOW IT'S THERE'S REALLY
DIFFERENT MODELS- INVERELL AREAS
THERE'S A LOT OF CRISIS TEAMS.
I'M IF THERE IS ONE IT'S REALLY
JUST A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
WITH MAYBE A CLINICIAN- WHICH IS
ALL THAT THAT THEY CAN DO AT
THAT POINT AND THAT MAY BE DUE
TO TRANSPORTATION RESTRICTIONS
OR MAYBE IT'S JUST. YOU KNOW NOT
HAVING ENOUGH WORK FORCE- BUT IN
SOME OFTHOSE AREAS THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE THAT MODEL SO WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS. THAT
HELPED THEM ESTABLISH SOME LEVEL
OF CRISIS SERVICES- SO WE'RE
HELPING THEM CREATE THIS PLAN
WE'VE ALSO YOU KNOW SAVED A
LITTLE MONEY FROM THEM SO THAT
THEN THEY'LL BE ABLE TO MOVE
INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION PHASE SO
ANY OF THOSE PLANNING GRANTS.
HAVE BEEN AWARDED WILL THEN BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOME FUNDING- TO
ACTUALLY ESTABLISH A THEME. OKAY
AND I DON'T KNOW WHO CAN ANSWER
THIS FOR ME BUT JUST. JUST AGAIN
IN IN TALKING WITH COUNTY SOME
PEOPLE'S FRUSTRATION OFTEN TIMES
WITH THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
AND THE RESTRICTIONS FOR EVERY
PART OF MONEY. BUT WE'RE JUST
HOPING THIS IS GOING TO BE AS
SEAMLESS AS POSSIBLE FOR
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO PULL THIS
DOWN- AND HOPEFULLY WITH THIS
MOBILE CRISIS I MEAN WE KNOW IT
TAKES ABOUT FORTY TOUCHES
SOMEBODY TO GO INTO TREATMENT.
UNDER THE QATARI START SOME OF
THAT WORK BEFORE WE HAVE THE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTED SO HOW WE
MAKING SURE WE'RE MAKING IT AS
EASY AS POSSIBLE. TO BE ABLE TO
PULL DOWN THIS MONEY. AND THEN
BE ABLE TO SPEND IT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. YES WE READ. AND
WHEN THE LET'S JUST. PROVE AS
FAR- YOU KNOW THAT THERE WAS AT
A- SINCE THE- THAT WHY WE- THIS
RUN. ONE ROLLED IT OUT SO
QUICKLY. AND WE ALREADY HAVE
CONTRACTS COMPLETED FOR THOSE
COUNTIES THAT WERE MENTIONED IN
TRIBAL ENTITIES- AND SO SOME OF
THEM ARE ALREADY ACTUALLY
STARTING. TO DO SOME OF THESE.
AND THIS IS REALLY GONNA BUILD
IN I KNOW LATER ON IN THE AGENDA
TALKING ABOUT FIRST. ADDING THE
MOBILE CRISIS- SERVICE IS
AVAILABLE AND EXPANDING UNDER
MEDIKAL. AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
BE ABLE JUST TO HELP COUNTIES
YOU KNOW REALLY GET- BOLSTER UP
BED CRISIS TEAMS THAT THEY HAVE.
ON AND ONCE AGAIN WE'RE ALSO
PROVIDING A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
KIND OF AT DIFFERENT LEVELS- BUT
REALLY PREPARING THEM BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS YOU KNOW I
NEED NOW BUT ALSO HELPING THEM
PREPARE. THEM FOR FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU AT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- FIRST
OF ALL I JUST- WANT TO- REALLY
WHAT CHAIR TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF- CLOSEST I BELIEVE SO WE GET
TO HEAR ALL OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I HEAR YOU YOU SAID
YOU'RE NOT WORKING WITH. YOUR
SISTER AGENCY DSS AND SO FORTH I
THINK IT'S BEEN NOTED ON THOSE
THAT ELLIE OR THE AUDITOR THAT-
WE HAVE A LOT OF THEM FIRST-
HOMELESSNESS- NO HEALTH RELATED
ILLNESSES I SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT NOT ALL HOMELESSNESS IS DUE
TO MENTAL HEALTH. SOMEONE WENT
OUT ON A CONFLICT TO. BUT THAT-
WE HAVE A LOT HOUSING PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT WE DON'T GET IT IN AND
THEN THE PLETHORA OF HOUSING
PROGRAMS AND PROGRAMS ARE
ADDRESSED HOMELESSNESS. WE JUST
DON'T WANT THEM TRIPPING UP
AGAINST EACH OTHER SO CERTAINLY
HILLARY SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE
HOUSING- PREVIEW WHAT THE ELIA
SAID ABOUT THAT- APPRECIATE
YOU'RE GONNA TRY TO COORDINATE
WITH OTHER HOUSING PROGRAMS. BUT
ALSO JUST THE CONCERNED ABOUT
FRAGMENTATION AND SO WE HAVE ONE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A PROGRAM IS
AND THEN YEAH YOU HAVE THE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND TRYING TO
NAVIGATE OKAY YOU KNOW IT GOES
THIS HOUSING PROGRAM THAT
HOUSING PROGRAMS. WE HAVE THIS
MANY UNITS IN THIS HOUSING
PROGRAM WE DON'T HAVE AS MANY
UNITS IN THAT ONE WE COULD USE
ONE OVER HERE BUT THE ONLY
QUALIFY FOR THAT ONE SO. SO I
DON'T I DON'T WANT TO TRIP OVER
OURSELVES HAVE DIFFERENT. OTHER
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS EACH ONE
CERTAINLY MEETING A NEED THAT'S
THEY'RE NOT DENYING THAT. BUT
THAT WE HAVE EACH ONE IN A
NARROW WAY AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO.
MAKE IT COMPLICATED PEOPLE
HAVING TO NAVIGATE RIGHT SO- THE
INTERNET TO NAVIGATE ALL THESE
PROGRAMS SO- SO AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU SAID THAT
YOU ARE WORKING WITH IT I JUST.
HOPE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL
THESE VARIOUS HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT WE'RE TRYING. TO SIMPLIFY
THINGS SO THAT WE DON'T END UP.
AND I HEAR WRONG. NOT OTHER
THINGS BUT I. DON'T JUST DON'T
WANT TO CREATE GREATER
COMPLICATION- SO LOOKING FOR. TO
HEARING HOW THAT. OUT BOTH MY
LOCALS AND FROM YOU AS WE ROLL
OUT IMPLEMENT. THE OTHER. I
GUESS THE QUESTION I DID HAVE
HIS ON- OBVIOUSLY ON CHILDREN
YOUTH ACTUALLY OBVIOUSLY BEING
PEDIATRICIAN- SO YOU SAID IN
TERMS OF THE TYPES OF PROJECTS
YOU KNOW YOU WANNA DO IT AFTER
YOU LISTENING SESSIONS AND SO
FORTH- WHAT IT WHAT'S THE
TIMELINE ON DETERMINING. THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE
FUNDED SO- EIGHT THINK YOU AND
TURN OVER WHICH TEACH YOU SAID
YOU'RE LISTENING SESSIONS WILL
TAKE PLACE SO WHAT WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE TIME LINE GOING TO BE
WE'RE GOING TO BETTER DEFINE.
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS THEY'LL BE
FUNDED. IN ROUND FOUR WITH THE
USING FUNDING ROUND. SO I'LL
TAKE THAT ONE- SO WHAT WE ARE
DOING LIKE YOU MENTIONED WE HAVE
OUR LISTENING SESSION IN MARCH.
AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO BE
PUTTING OUT SOON FTER WHAT
WE'RE CALLING A PROGRAM UPDATE
WE DID THAT. WITH OUR EARLY
AROUND AS WELL. IT'S JUST REALLY
IT'S KIND OF A SNEAK PEEK. OF
THE RFA. SO ELIGIBLE ENTITIES
CAN START LOOKING TO SEE YOU
KNOW. WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING FOR ITEMS
LIKE THE MATCH ALL THOSE TYPES
OF REALLY IMPORTANT DETAILS. I'M
SO THAT'LL BE COMING OUT A FEW
MONTHS AFTER. AND THE LISTENING
SESSION AND THEN WE'RE EXPECTING
TO RELEASE. ON THE RFA I'M
SOMETIME. EARLY THIS SUMMER-
MAYBE SOMETIME AROUND JUNE OR
JULY OR AUGUST WE'RE KINDOF
LOOKING AT THAT TIME FRAME-
BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN. YOU KNOW GET
THE RFA OUT THERE AND GET THESE
GRANTS AWARDED BECAUSE I'M LIKE
CHIEF YOU MENTIONED IT TAKES
TIME. I'M FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS IS. REALLY
NEEDED ESPECIALLY FOR THIS ROUND
AND FOR OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FACILITY OKAY
SO YOU MENTIONED IS THAT.
LISTENING SESSION A MARSHALL
PROVIDE AT LEAST SOME INITIAL
GUIDANCE TO PEOPLE PROBABLY IN
THE SPRING AND THEN THE ACTUAL
RC ON THE SUMMER SO. THAT SOUNDS
LIKE JUST PERFECT TIMING FOR ME
REVISE SO CERTAINLY WOULD
APPRECIATE AN UPDATE WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY BETTER ARTICULATE.
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS OBVIOUSLY
IT'S NOT THE FLOOR SAY BUT-
THAT'D BE HELPFUL. IT WOULD BE
SITTING OUT. THE INFORMATION ON
WHAT. AFTER LISTENING SESSION
WHAT TYPE OF PROJECTS YOU ARE
NOW SEEKING. TO BUT OFFICIALS
YOU KNOW. ASK PEOPLE OUR FAITH
FOR. WELL MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX MEDICO QUALIFYING COMMUNITY
BASED MOBILE CRISIS INTERVENTION
SERVICE BENEFIT. PERFECT BECAUSE
OF THE BUDGET REQUEST A HUNDRED
AND EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
TOTAL FINES- AFFORD THE BUDGET
EAR TO IMPLEMENT THE MOBILE
CRISIS PROGRAM BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. CURRENTLY
THERE S NO STATEWIDE
STANDARDIZED MEDICARE BENEFIT
COVERING MOBILE CRISIS RESPONSE
SERVICES AS DOUBLE SEVERAL
FACTORS ARE DRIVING THE NEED FOR
THE CHANGE. INCREASING ACUITY OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS CAUSED
BY TRAUMAS OF THE PANDEMIC I
NEED TO DIVERT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CRISIS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENCOUNTERS- TWO TREATMENTS ARE
PREVENTING INAPPROPRIATE
INVOLVEMENT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM JUST PARTIALLY AFFECTING
PEOPLE. OF COLOR- AS WELL AS THE
NEW OPPORTUNITY IN THE AMERICA
RESCUE PLAN ACT UP FOR ENHANCED
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS FOR THE
FIRST THREE YEARS I'M A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD BEGINNING APRIL
TWENTY TWO THROUGH MARCH OF
TWENTY SEVEN. WHILE CRISIS
INTERVENTION SERVICES ARE
CURRENTLY AT LIMITED MEDICAL
BENEFITS SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
DRUG MEDI CAL INDIAN CO DS THERE
IS NO STATE WIDE REQUIREMENT
ABOUT A STANDARDIZED SET OF ON
CALL A GENE BASED CRISIS
RESPONSE SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE-
THROUGH THIS MOBILE MENTALITY
FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. I SAID YES YES
PLANS TO ENGAGE WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
PROVIDERS CONSUMER ADVOCATES AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO REALLY INFORM
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE MOBILE
CRISIS BENEFIT MEDIKAL INCLUDING
THE COVERED SERVICE COMPONENTS
THAT SERVICE CRITERIA. A
COMPOSITION OF THE MOBILE CRISIS
TEAM AS WELL AS OTHER KIND OF-
YOU KNOW PROVIDER QUALIFICATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE CONSIDERED A
FEDERAL GUIDANCE REGARDING THE
MOBILE CRISIS OPPORTUNITY
DESCRIBES. VERY SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROVIDERS
DELIVERING MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES- UNDER THIS AUTHORITY
INCLUDING THE REQUIREMENT FOR
THE TEAM TO INCLUDE AT LEAST ONE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
WHO IS QUALIFIED TO PROVIDE AN
ASSESSMENT WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE ALSO WE WILL HAVE. TO
COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE
AND OUR THE OPPORTUNITY AS WELL.
THE GUIDANCE ALSO IN. THAT OTHER
TEAM MEMBER MAY INCLUDE OUR
SYSTEM WORKERS ARE PEER SUPPORTS
. AND OTHER YOU KNOW PEOPLE WITH
RELEVANT EXPERIENCE AS WELL ALL
OF THOSE FACTORS WILL COME INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE BILD THAT
THE BENEFIT- THE GUIDANCE ALSO
SETS FORTH A NUMBER OF
REQUIREMENTS FOR SKILL SETS AND
COMPETENCIES THAT ARE REQUIRED.
I'M IN SERVICE DELIVERY
STANDARDS FOR THE MOBILE CRISIS
TEAM- THAT WILL BE NEEDED- AND
DCS IS REVIEWING BEST PRACTICES
AND LITERATURE- WE ARE LOOKING
AT STRONG EXAMPLES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THIS HAS BEEN
DONE VERY WELL- AND APPROACHES
THAT THAT OTHER STATES HAVE
IDENTIFIED IN REGARDS TO BEST
PRCTICES. AS WE REALLY KIND OF
BUILD THAT ARE MOVING FORWARD-
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE ASSESSING A
VARIETY OF COMPONENTS ON THE
REIMBURSEMENT APPROACH FOR
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES- UNDER
THE CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY I G. H. T. S.
PROVIDES- YOU KNOW. COST BASED
REIMBURSEMENT TO OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS WHICH INCLUDES ARE
COSTING HER TO PAY EMPLOYEES
WHEN THEY ARE NOT ACTIVELY
RENDERING SERVICES- THAT IS A
PART OF. B. H. A PAYMENT REFORM
AS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IN
THE AGENDA WHICH WILL BE GOING
LIVE EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A PAYMENT
FOR THIS A SERVICE WILL
TRANSITION EVENTUALLY TO EIGHTY.
P. FOR SERVICE SCHEDULED- AND
THERE IS A DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
RATE MODELS FOR MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES AS WE BUILD THAT BEEPER
SERVICE RATE SCHEDULE- THAT
COULD BE IMPLEMENTED AFTER JULY
FIRST- OF COURSE WHEN WE BROUGHT
THAT OUT. AND THAT INCLUDES
OPTIONS AROUND PER DIEM PAYMENTS
EPISODIC PAYMENTS- AND SMALLER
KIND OF INCREMENTAL PAYMENTS ON
SUCH AS FIFTEEN MINUTES OR
HOURLY UNIT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALL OF THOSE OPTIONS AND
DISCUSSING. THOSE WITH OUR
PARTNERS- BUT YOU REALLY
REGARDLESS OF THE RIGHT MODEL
AND THE RATE SETTING PROCESS. IT
CAN COPERATE YOU KNOW KEY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR ENSURING ALL-
ON CALL AVAILABILITY FOR MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICE. WHICH COULD BE-
YOU KNOW FACTOR IN IDLE TIME
EXAMPLE. WE ARE WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT MAKE SURE WE'RE VERY COCKY
OF THAT WE BUILD- COVERAGE FOR
CHRIST SERVICES THE MEDICARE
REPRESENTS A Y. OF THE THREE G.
PILLARS. CHRIST CARE CAN. HELLO
WITH PRICES YOU KNOW CALL
SERVICES AND CRY STAPLES. START
ALL CREDIT COMPONENTS- IN- K.
JUST IS PREPARING TO LAUNCH
STAKEHOLDER. EFFORT TO SUPPORT
THE DESIGN AND PLANNING EFFORTS
FOR THE NINETY DAY CISIS.
HOTLINE IT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
THAT THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY- IN
NEED OF MOBILE CRISIS CAN BE
CONNECTED TO THOSE SERVICES AND-
DAC. FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH-
KELLY JUST AS AN AGENCY AND
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THAT- DESIGN
PROCESS. AND THAT IS THE
CONCLUSION OF MY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IN
YOU NO ADDITIONAL. HELLO. THANK
YOU AT SENATOR ADMIN KOREA SHE
DID WITH THE LA- I CAN- WE JUST
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS RAISE ON THE
NEW MOBILE CRISIS BENEFIT- FIRST
WE JUST FIND THAT YOU KNOW
ADDING THIS NEW BENEFIT TO MEDIC
HAL DOES HAVE MERIT AS IT
APPROPRIATELY TARGETS A GAP IN
THE BEATER HEALTH CRISIS
CONTINUE- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE MANY COUNTIES THAT
EITHER DO NOT OPERATE ANY MOBILE
CRISIS TEAMS OR OPERATE JUST A
FEW- IN ADDITION DECSS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT
REPORT ALSO IDENTIFIES MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICES. AS A KEY AREA
TO ADDRESS IN THE HOUSE PRICES
CONTINUE ON HOWEVER WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
GATHER ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
BEFORE TAKING ACTION ON THIS
PROPOSAL IT WE WOULD KNOW THAT
THEREARE SOME KEY DETAILS
RELATED TO THIS PROPOSED NEW
BENEFIT WHICH ARE NOT YET
AVAILABLE TO FULLY ASSESS ITS
MERITS- SOME OF THESE YOU KNOW
KEY DETAILS THAT ARE OUTSTANDING
THE ADMINISTRATION JUST JUST
WENT THROUGH. THEY WOULD INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE HOW STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR THESE MOBILE
CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES
WILL BE DETERMINED HOW THE
PAYMENT RATES FOR THESE SERVICES
WILL BE DEVELOPED- ON THE
PAYMENT RATES YOU KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE RATES WILL
INCLUDE CERTAIN NON SERVICE
COSTS LIKE IDLE TIME WHILE
MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS ARE ON CALL-
POTENTIALLY TRANSPORTATION
COSTS. THESE ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS MAKE THIS A KEY
DETAIL TO HAVE AVAILABLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN IT REFUSED THIS
PROPOSAL- WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES PLAN TO
HAVE A TRAILER BILL FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH MAY PROVIDE
FURTHER INFORMATION ON ON THESE
ISSUES BUT THAT LANGUAGE. IS NOT
YET AVAILABLE FOR REVIEW. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WE KNOW THAT THE
DEGREE OF NEED FOR A DISH MOBILE
. RESOURCE LIKE ME VERY BY
COUNTY- ALTHOUGH THE ESTIMATE
WERE VERY ROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THESE
ESTIMATES MAY NOT SHOW. THE
WHOLE PICTURE OF THE NEED FOR
MOBILE CRISIS RESOURCES- DECSS
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ASSESSMENT
RECORD REPORT DOES INDICATE
THAT. YOU KNOW THE LEVEL OF NEED
FOR MOBILE CRISIS- WIDELY
BETWEEN COUNTIES- THESE
DIFFERENCES BY COUNTY MAY RELATE
TO DIFFERENCES IN THE LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
COUNTIES MAY NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
WORK FORCE TO STOP THESE TEENS-
THESE DIFFERENCES IN LOCAL
CAPACITY RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW BY ABILITIES FOR COUNTIES TO
MEET. THE STATEWIDE MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THIS NEW
BENEFIT- FOR EXAMPLE WORLD
COUNTIES MAY HAVE A TOUGHER TIME
MAKING SURE THAT MOBILE CRISIS
TEAMS ARE AVAILABLE TO MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES ON A TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN BSIS. WHICH IS WEATHER
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE NEW BENEFIT- THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO CONSIDER
HOW WE CAN ENSURE THAT COUNTIES
HAVE SUFFICIENT LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET SORT OF
THESE NEW STATEWIDE
REQUIREMENTS- FINALLY WE WOULD
KNOW THAT FEDERAL GUIDANCE
SURROUNDING THIS NEW BENEFIT.
INCLUDE SOME SUGGESTIONS FOR
MOBILE CRISIS BEST PRACTICES TO
INCLUDE IN THE DESIGN OF STATES
MOBILE CRISIS BENEFITS- DO
MINISTRATION JUST INDICATED THAT
THEY'RE WORKING INTERNALLY ON
GIVE FIGURING OUT WHAT WHAT SORT
OF BEST PRACTICES TO AND TO
INCORPORATE. THESE BEST
PRACTICES INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW HOW TO REDUCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT SUCH
THAT INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
CRISIS OUR FIRST MET WITH PETER
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS RATHER THAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT- OR PARTNERING
WITH SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
YOUTH- WHICH WE UNDERSTAND MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS THAN ADULTS. WHEN IT COMES TO MOBILE CRISIS
CARE- ALTHOUGH THE MISTER WORK
ON OF LOOKING IN THESE BEST. THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL DOES NOT
INCLUDE. A STRATEGY FOR HOW TO
INCORPORATE THESE BEST PRACTICES
INTO THE DESIGN OF THIS THIS NEW
BENEFIT- YOU KNOW IN ADDITION AS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING AT THE
AGENCY LEVEL TO DEVELOP. A
STRAIGHT PAST THE WHITE STRATEGY
FOR THE- ENTIRE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CRISIS CONTINUE- INCLUDING
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES CRISIS
FACILITIESAND THE NEW NINE
EIGHT CRISIS HOTLINE. THIS
REPRESENTS A POSITIVE STEP
TOWARD TAKING A COMPREHENSIVE
LOOK AT IMPROVING THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE BUT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO MONITOR THE STATUS OF
THE DEATH THE UPDATED ELEMENT OF
THAT STRATEGY. FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION- THOSE ARE ALL OF
OUR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE FURTHER
ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR AND I WOULD I WOULD- I WOULD
GREAT THINK THIS IS VERY
AMBITIOUS AND OF COURSE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT WE HAVE TO DO IT-
IT IS GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE
AND SOME ARE MORE RURAL AREAS
ESPECIALLY. WITH WITH WEATHER
WITH SPACE WITH TERRAIN WITH ALL
A LOT OF THINGS SO WE'RE GONNA
BE HAVE TO BE VERY CREATIVE
ABOUT HOW WE THINK ABOUT THIS- I
DON'T KNOW IF. MISS COOPER'S CAN
YOU TALK A I DON'T I GUESS I
DIDN'T. I THINK UNDERSTAND THE-
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT AN ONLINE AT AND THE
MOBILE CRISIS ARE THERE. THEN I
KNOW WHAT I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
ONE IS ALREADY. WE'RE DOING IT.
THE NEXT ONE BUT THOUGH HOW HOW
ARE THEY GONNA BE CONNECTED. SO
I'LL START AND THEN TYLER US OUT
WITH OUR ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH MAY
BE ABLE TO DISH MY CHIME IN. YOU
KNOW I THINK RIGHT NOW THE
BUDGET PROPOSES A MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES- I TO BE ROLLED OUT
ACROSS THE- SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH THE NC AND INDIAN C.O.
D. S. WE DO KNOW THAT WITH THE
UPCOMING IMPLEMENTATION OF NINE
EIGHT EIGHT. THERE IS A NATURAL
INDICATION OF A CONNECTING THOSE
TWO PIECES- AND I THINK THAT IS
WHY- I KELLY JUST AS- AN AGENCY
OR ARE GOING TO ENGAGE IN A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
DETERMINE. HOW THOSE LINKAGES
WHAT HAPPENED WHAT IS THAT ALL
PRICES CONTINUE ALMOST LIKE IN
THE FUTURE- AND ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGH THAT
PROCESS BUT A TYLER FEEL FREE TO
ADD ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
YOU THINK. IS NECESSARY FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION. THANK
IT I THAT'S A- I. THAT THE- TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS TIME
LIMITED OPPORTUNITY THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS OFFERING
WITH RESPECT TO- ENHANCED
FEDERAL FUNDING RATES UNDER
MEDICARE OUT- MEANS YOU KNOW.
WE'RE LOOKING AT. A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD THAT BEGAN. BEGINNING
APRIL OF THIS YEAR-
SIMULTANEOUSLY AGENCY IS
BEGINNING THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO BEGIN SOME OF THE-
HIGHEST STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
AND DESIGN DISCUSSIONS RELATED
TO NINE EIGHT EIGHT SO I.
IDEALLY IF THERE WOULD BE
ULTIMATELY INTERCONNECTIONS
BETWEEN THE TWO WE KNOW TODAY
THERE IS TREMENDOUS- DIVERSITY
WITH RESPECT TO HOW MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICES ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. WE KNOW MANY COUNTIES
ARE CURRENTLY OPERATE MOBILE
CRISIS NUMBERS AND HOTLINES AND
SO I THINK WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH AGENCY AND WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON- IDENTIFYING AND
EXPLORING. THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE INTERCONNECTIONS. THANK
YOU HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU SEE IT
OR IS THERE A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN- GOING BACK TO THE- YOUR
HEALTH CONTINUUM IN THE BRIDGE
WITH THAT THE MOBILE CRISIS. AND
THIS MOBILE CRISIS IS THERE I
MEAN I KNOW ONE IS FOR. YOU CAN
PUT MORE PERSISTENTLY MENTALLY
ILL FOLKS BUT THESE THESE THESE
CAN BE THE SAME POPULATIONS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND ARE
THEY GOING TO BE THE SAME TEAMS
ARE THEY DIFFERENT TEAMS ARE WE
ASKING THE COUNTY TO DO TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS OR- IS THERE
COORDINATION. YES THE- B. H. C.
A. P. DOLLARS FOR MOBILE CRISIS
WAS REALLY TO. FIND DOLLARS TO
THE COUNTIES TO PREPARE FOR THIS
MOBILE CRISIS BENEFIT THAT WILL
BE GOING STATEWIDE SO YOU KNOW
THAT TAKES TIME- WE NEEDED TO
HAVE THE- THE BEATING OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS OF WHAT THEY
ARE NEEDING LOCALLY. TO FUND
THOSE WITH THE BC I. P. DOLLARS
TO GET THAT UP AND RUNNING TO
TRAIN STAFF TO GET THOSE
CONNECTIONS AND YOU KNOW. MOBILE
TEAMS TOGETHER- AND SO REALLY IT
WAS THE INTENT BEHIND THE B.
ACHT DOLLARS AND WHY WE MOVED SO
QUICKLY MARLEY'S AND HER TEAM
JUST REMARKABLE AND HOW FAST
THEY WERE ABLE TO PULL THAT
APPLICATION GET THOSE OUT. AND
IN DOING OTHER ROUNDS WAS REALLY
SO THAT COUNTIES ARE READY WHEN
WE GO LIVE. WITH THIS NEW
BENEFIT- ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE SAME TEAMS
BUTDIFFERENT TEAMS. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT BUT
THEN AGAIN THIS IS SOMETHING
REPUGNANT LOT MORE INFORMATION
ON- BUT. BUT VERY NEEDED A
TWENTY. THAT YOU AND IS WHY SAY
THE- APPRECIATE THE EFFORT IN
THE PRO- AND- TOUGH CD
IMPLEMENTATION BE SURE IT
ACTUALLY WORKS AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AS WELL- I
KNOW YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT-
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE OF
THE ENHANCED MATCH BUT- I ASSUME
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO I MEAN THIS
IS GONNA BE AN ON GOING- THANK
YOU FOR THAT I MEAN DO WE KNOW
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
TERMS OF ONGOING FUNDING. THE
CURRENTLY AT THIS TIME THE
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES ONLY FOR
THAT FIVE YEAR PERIOD SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT A TIME IT
IF THAT CHANGES OKAY SO LET'S
SEE I GUESS WILL. HAVE SOME WORK
TO FISHER THAT CONTINUES- BEYOND
THE FIVE YEARS THAT OKAY THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR PANEL-
FRIEND WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR THEM
FOR THE COMMUNITY ABOUT- ABOUT
HOW THINGS ARE GOING AND SO
TODAY ON THE PANEL TODAY WE
HAVE. A WYNAND COOKMAN SHOULD
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA. DR
RYAN QUIST BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO.
THE UNDERCARD KIRBY CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMEY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES. KIM
PETERSON. SENIOR ATTORNEY MENTAL
HEALTH PRACTICE GROUP FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. IN
IT. NO WAY SENIOR POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. TERROR GAMBHIR
GONNA EASTMAN LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE. AND PETER RAGSDALE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HOUSING AUTHORITY IN ABOUT IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. SO THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM AND
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN ASKED TO
RESPOND TO CERTAIN QUESTIONS SO
WHY DON'T WE START WITH- HEALTH
PLANS. ARAFAT GOOD AFTERNOON
DEAR ADMIN AND SENATOR PANNED
OUT WHEN A GOOD MAN THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS IN CALIFORNIA AT
REPRESENTING THE SIXTEEN NON
PROFIT COMMUNITY BASED HEALTH
PLANS THAT SERVE OVER 70% OF
CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED IN MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE. AND I WANT TO
START BY NOTING THAT LOCAL PLANS
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF TELLING. SENTENCE IF CONFECTIONERIES
GAS COMPANIES AND PROVIDERS TO
MAKE IMPLEMENTATION DIFFICULT
FOR OUR MEMBERS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE STATEMENT AGAIN
AND BEST MAN AND CALLING THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED BENEFITS AND
SERVICES. ALL RESPOND DIRECTLY
TO THE QUESTIONS YOU ASK AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND THE
FIRST THE FIRST BACK
IMPLEMENTATION OF EASY AND THEN
CONTINUED TO PARK- WE ARE NOW IN
WEEK EIGHT OF TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT YOU CELEBRATE EARLY DATE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION AS DIRECTOR
COOPER INDICATED EARLIER- LEAN
UP TO GO LIVE A LOT OF HARD WORK
WENT INTO PREPARING FOR THE
INITIAL TRANSITION. LOCAL PLANS
WORK PARTICULARLY CLOSELY WITH
THEIR COUNTY PARTNERS TO ENSURE
A SEAMLESS TRANSITION FROM WHOLE
PERSON CARE AND HELP RUN
PROGRAMS. OVERALL WE HEARD THAT
CONDITION HAS GONE VERY SMOOTHLY
AND MEMBER CARES NOT BEEN
DISTRACTED THE REALLY PLEASED
ABOUT THAT AND OVER THE COMING
MONTHS THE FOCUS WILL BE ON
ENGAGING OTHER MEMBERS ARE
ELIGIBLE TRAINING AND CARE
MANAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. LEVERAGING BTS AND
CENTER FINDING TO SUPPORT THE
ONBOARDING OF ADDITIONAL
PROVIDERS AND THEN CONTINUING TO
EDUCATE PROVIDERS AND PARTNERS.
ABOUT THESE NEW THERMOSTAT.
SECOND WITH RESPECT TO- WHICH I
. LOCAL PLAN ARE CALM. LEICESTER
EACH AND COMMUNITY. AND THERE'S
A RANGE OF PER. ARE THAT OR WILL
BE PROVIDED THE THIRD. THAT
CRASH BUT PLAN. AND DELIBERATE
VIA PLAN ARE CALM. WITH COUNTY
THAT LED. I LED. OR THE PER IS
BACK COM WITH ORACLE PERSON CARE
. SERVICES INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- I YOU IF EITHER ANOTHER
IMPORTANT ON HER. AND MANY OF
PREVIOUSLY AS ON PROVIDERS WELL
. AND I IN TERMS OF COMMUNITY
COURT AT PROVIDER TAKE REALLY
GOOD ON WHAT COMMUNITY APART
EACH PLAN I'M OFFERING. GIVEN
THAT MANY LOCAL PLAN ARE OFF TO
HELP THE COMMUNITY. PROVIDERS
INCLUDE COUNTY AND COMMUNITY DAY
HOUSING ORGAN THE. I'M VERY HAVE
REGARD HOW THE BENNETT FLOW
PLANS TO FOR THE HIGHEST NEED
THAT ACCOUNT EARLY AND AS YOU
KNOW. EASY AND IS REALLY FOCUS
ON THE MAN. WITH ABOUT COMPLEX
HEALTH AND SOCIAL CAN. SO CARING
HAS ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT PLANS
HAVE PROVIDED A DIFFERENT LAW OF
IN. ECM IS AT THE MEDIC HAL
COVER BENEFIT THAT A BOTH MORE.
AND HAS OF A FOCUS ON DRAFTING
OF ENTERPRISE. THE EASY MODEL OF
K. AT A AND GUIDANCE FOR PHD
INCLUDE VERY. AND COMPREHENSIVE
. COORDINATION AND CARE
MANAGEMENT HEALTH EDUCATION AND
CLOSED LOOP REFERRALS. BUT
HAVING ONE CARE TEAM THAT WILL
REALLY WORK ACROSS THE FENCE
WILL BE CRITICAL FOR SUPPORTING
MEMBERS. TO GET. GET NUMBERS
THAT SERVICES AND CARE THAT THEY
NEED. AND LASTLY OUTFIT HOW
LOCAL PLANS ARE COORDINATING
WITH PARTNERS TO CREATE A
COMPLETE CONTINUUM OF CARE-
GENERALLY THIS IS OCCURRING BY
ESTABLISHING BOTH DIRECT
CONTRACTOR ECM AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES. AND
OTHER DEVELOPING REFERRAL SYSTEM
THE OTHER SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE PLAN DIRECTLY.
AND FOR EXAMPLE LOCAL PLANS ARE
ENGAGING WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT YOU DIRECTLY
CONTACT AT ECM PROVIDERS. MANY
LOCAL PLANS ALREADY HAVE THE
CONTRACT WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH EXECUTED TODAY AND THAT
ARE STILL WORKING WITH THEIR
COUNTY I'M READING AN ONBOARDING
BUT EXPECT THAT THE CONTRACT
WILL BE FINALIZED. SO INCLUDING
REPRIEVE THAT INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE- ACCORD
HAS GONE BADLY 
FORWARD TO LEVERAGING THE
INVESTMENT THAT DAY AND MADE IN
CALLING TO GROW CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THE
MULTI YEAR EFFORT- THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK I'LL
WAIT TILL THE ENDLET'S MOVE ON
TO DOCTOR- DOCTOR QUEST. AGAIN
DISCUSSING THE- CREATING THE.
COMPLETE CONTINUE OF CARE FOR.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY CHAIR MY
NAME'S DOCTOR RAN QUITE I'M TO
BE A TO HELP FIRST COUNTY AS
ELECT THE COUNTY BE REAL
DIRECTOR SO. BUT CAN YOU BE HERE
TO HELP DIRECTOR ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A MAN TRANSFER ME IN
INVESTMENT LAFACE XTREME
CHALLENGING CERTAIN ON GROUND
THERE'S A LOT OF UP RIGHT NOW
AND IT'S IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
HOWEVER IT'S AT A TIME WHEN
WE'RE EXPERIENCING OUR GREATEST
WORKFORCE CHALLENGE EVER.
THANKFULLY THE LEGISLATION AND
THE ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN LAST YEAR-AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BUDGETS
LIKE NEVER BEFORE. JOHNNY
STARTED THIS YEAR WITH THE FIRST
OF SEVERAL MAJOR CALLING REFORMS
TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. NAMELY THE
MEDICAL NECESSITY CHANGES WHICH
WILL ALLOW THE SPECIALLY
DELIVERY SYSTEM. DESTRUCTIONS
EXISTING RESOURCES BY MAKING
MORE OF OUR SERVICES ON DOUBLE
FOR FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT UNDER
MEDICARE AL. THIS INCLUDES THE
ABILITY FOR COMPANIES TO DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR PRE
DIAGNOSTIC SERVICES AND
AUTOMATIC ELIGIBILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND FOR YOUTH WHO
ARE CHILD WELFARE AND JUVENILE
JUSTICE INVOLVED. THIS DOESN'T
CHANGE YOU ARE SERVING OR THE
ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THIS MAKES IT POSSIBLE
FOR COUNTY SOME PROVIDERS TO
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
LEGITIMATE MEDICAL SERVICES AND
STARKLY. HAVE BEEN DISALLOWED.
WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE
STATE'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN A
STATE WIDE MOBILE CRISIS BENEFIT
WHICH WOULD OPT CALIFORNIA INTO
THE 85% MEDICAL MATCH WE JUST
DISCUSSED- WE'RE EXCITED FOR THE
POSSIBILITY THAT- STARTING NEXT
YEAR. WHEN A CALIFORNIAN CALLS
NINE EIGHTY FOR EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THAT WE WILL HOPEFULLY
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND. WITH THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- MOBILE CRISIS TEAM. TO
GET TO THAT POINT THOUGH WE
COLLECTIVELY HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO WE NEED TO BUILD OUT A
ROBUST CONTINUUM OF ONE. PHONE
TRIAGE STABILIZATION LINKAGE
REFERRAL AND DISPATCH TO- MOBILE
CRISIS AND FIELD STABILIZATION
AND THREE FACILITY BASED. CRISIS
RECEIVING SERVICES AND
STABILIZATION SERVICES. WE'LL
TAKE YEARS- WANT TO BE. CLEAR
THAT THIS ISN'T GOING TO HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY AND IT WOULD TAKE A
LOT OF COLLABORATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND- WITH A LOT OF
COORDINATION AT THE STATE LEVEL
. TODAY JUST OVER TWO THIRDS OF
COUNTIES HAVE SOME MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES ALREADY. NOT GETTING
THESE SERVICES BUILT OUT ON PAR
WITH EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
WILL TAKE SIGNIFICANT TIME
INVESTMENT. TODAY NEARLY ARE ALL
TWENTY MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS SERVE
ANY INDIVIDUAL REGARDLESS OF
INSURANCE STATUS MEANING
COUNTIES ARE FINDING A BROADER
COMMUNITY SERVICE THAT INCLUDES
COMMERCIALLY INSURED UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS ON THAT ACCOUNT-
BECAUSE WHEN SOMEBODY IS IN A
CRISIS YOU DON'T STOP AND ASK
SOMEONE TO CONFIRM THEIR
MEDICARE ELIGIBLE ELIGIBILITY
BEFORE RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS.
TO SENATOR EDMONDS POINTS REAL
COMMUNITIES FACED AN EVEN MORE
DAUNTING TASK OF TRYING TO
DEVELOP A MOBILE CRISIS BENEFIT
FOR REMOTE AND HARD TO REACH
PARTS OF OUR STATE OR SOMETIMES
EVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT
PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
COVERAGE FOR EMERGENCY. BUT
BOTTOM LINE THOUGH IS THAT WE
ARE ALL IN FOR THE VISION OF A
WELL FUNDED AND SUPPORTED
PUBLIC. HEALTH SYSTEM. THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
REPRESENTS AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD OUT
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
WORKING WITH OUR JOINT POWERS A
STORY MESA COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DIRECTORS COMMISSIONED
AROUND STUDY LOOK AT BACK TO
PASS THE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS IS IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT
GAPS WITHIN THE CONTINUAL
PARTICULARLY AT THE SUB ACUTE
LEVEL THIS IS THE LEVEL OF CARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NO
LONGER AN ANCIENT SITE CHECK
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY. BUT ARE
NOT PREPARED TO GO BACK TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE COMMUNITY. SHE
CAN GIVE YOU AN IDEA IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ARE THREE MAIN
PRIORITY AREAS ARE SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES USED CRISIS
FACILITIES AND S. U. D.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
RESIDENTIAL. AND TALKING WITH MY
PEERS FROM OTHER COUNTIES I HEAR
VERY SIMILAR PRIORITIES ACROSS
THE STATE IN ADDITION SOME
COUNTIES THAT PRIMARILY USE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS OUTSIDE OF
THEIR COUNTIES ARE ALSO
PRIORITIZING. PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
FACILITIES WHICH ARE SMALLER AND
FACILITIES THAT CAN BE CLOSER.
TO HOME INVENTED WITHIN OUR
COUNTY. ALTHOUGH WE ARE TO-
ALTHOUGH WE HEAR A LOT CLEARER
TO APPLY FOR. UNDER THE- THE
PROGRAM. I AND I'VE BEEN
BUILDING UP MY REQUEST FOR
FUNDING THESE DOLLARS ARE NOT
STRAIGHTFORWARD REQUIREMENTS
SUCH AS A COMPETITIVE GRANT
STRUCTURE. THIRTY YEAR SERVICE
COMMITMENT AND THE REQUIRED 10%
MATCH ADD UNNECESSARY COMPLEXITY
AND BARRIERS. ESPECIALLY IN THE
CONTEXT OF ALL OF OUR WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES. CHALLENGES WE'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT COUNTIES
WILL NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO EXPAND OUR CONTINUING BEYOND
BRICKS AND MORTAR INVESTMENTS WE
WILL NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
EXPAND SERVICES AND NOT JUST
BEDS. WE ALSO NEED SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN A
WORKFORCE OF THE FUTURE WE NEED
TO PAY WAGES THAT WILL ENTICE
FUTURE GENERATIONS TO PURSUE THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. TO ENTER
WORK FORCE AND DO THIS IMPORTANT
WORK. FINALLY WE KNOW THAT OUR
CLIENTS SUFFER NEEDLESSLY AND
ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
INCARCERATION AND EARLY
MORTALITY. I CAN'T FIND OR KEEP
BEFORE PORTABLE CAP HOUSING.
MANY OF OUR CLIENTS RELY ON
HOUSING VOUCHERS THAT'S ASSIGNED
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR
HOUSING NEEDS BUT WE SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH. SO THE
PROPOSED BEHAVE BRIDGE HOUSING
INVESTMENT OF ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS I NEED A PIECE
OF THE HOUSING PUZZLE. TODAY OUR
CLIENTS ARE SENT TO THE BACK
LINE FOR HOUSING RESOURCES
BECAUSE OF SHORT SIGHTED HAD
RULES THAT DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS COMING OUT OF
TREATMENT FACILITIES IN JAILS.
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS URGE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER A
BRIDGE HOUSING PROGRAM THAT
LOOKS MORE LIKE PROJECT ON KEY
THEN. THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
SO THANKS THANKS TO MY LEASE FOR
THE NEWS THAT YOU'RE MODELING
THIS PROGRAM ALONG THOSE LINES.
WE ALSO HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE LA- REGARDING
THE SHORT TERM NATURE OF THESE
FUNDS BUT BOTTOM LINE WE ARE
STILL VERY THANKFUL FOR THESE
RESOURCES. CENTER PAN BEFORE I
CONCLUDE THANK YOU FOR RAISING
OUR SHARED CONCERNS RELATING TO
TRANSFER RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FROM KAISER. TO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY LLANO COUNTY.
YOU CANNOT BE HALF OF ACCOUNT
BOARD OF SUPER. AND C. B. H. T.
EIGHT. WE DO BELIEVE WE CAN
PROVIDE GOOD CARE. SO IN ORDER
TO SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION
SERVICES WE NEED A COMMITMENT OF
FUNDS TO OBTAIN BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AUTHORITY TO EXPAND
SERVICES. THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WITH SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AND ASTRINGENT
TRANSITION NEEDS TO BE DONE
RIGHT. WITH THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
FUNDING AND SUFFICIENT TIME TO
EXPAND SERVICES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR. OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON WITH A- HUNDRED CLARK
HARVEY PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M NOT
SURE ANYONE. UNDERSTAND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS.
PONTUS SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THE
FIRST IS ABOUT HOW THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS CAN BE LEVERAGED
TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS AND CLIENTS
OKAY CDJ IS VERY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT COUNTY WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON IMPLEMENTATION
WE DO REMAIN CURIOUS ABOUT HOW
HEALTH PLANS INTEND TO IMPLEMENT
COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO. ENHANCE
CARE MANAGEMENT MORE EVENLY WE
DON'T CURRENTLY SEE CONSISTENT
OFFERINGS FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY
WE WERE TRULY BELIEVE THAT YOUR
ZIP CODE SHOULD NOT DETERMINE
WHAT ACCESS ONE HOUSE TO SERVICE
DESK FIND OUR PLANS ARE WORKING
VERY HARD THERE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. THE BEHAVIORAL
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
WILL BE ADVANTAGEOUS TO THOSE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHO HAVE ADEQUATE STAFF IN TIME
AND RESOURCE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS SO WE
ENCOURAGE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TAKE EVERY EFFORT TO BE FLEXIBLE
WHEN WORKING WITH- CASHIN
WORKFORCE STRUCK WRITERS WORK
FINE FOR THESE GRANT FUNDS THAT
ARE STILL NECESSARY. WE ALSO
WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON CONTINUING TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
THAT A FEW OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED BEFORE BY BUILDING
UPON ROUTINE HOME CARE AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO LOCAL
PARTNERS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BRANCH HOUSING INITIATIVE. WE
WANT TO SEE US AS WAS JUST
MENTIONED BY DOCTOR QUEST MORE
LONG TERM INVESTMENT HERE MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICES AND THE
IMPENDING JULY IMPLEMENTATION
DEADLINE OF OUR NATIONAL NINE
EIGHT HOTLINES ARE CRITICAL
COMPONENTS TO OUR SYSTEM OF
CRISIS CARE. AND THERE IS A
NEXUS I HEARD YOUR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS AT DOCTOR EGGMAN THERE
IS A NEXUS BETWEEN THE MOBILE
CRISIS IN NINE EIGHT EIGHT SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS ARE RUNNING CALL
CENTERS AND WE REALLY SEE THIS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
EARLY INTERVENTION. THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE OFTEN STARTS
WITH BACK CALL TEXT OR CHAT
MESSAGE SENT TO YOU WHAT WILL BE
THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT OPERATORS
AND PROVIDERS WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THIS CAREBUT
INTENTIONAL. INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED HERE TO. I THE COMMITTEE
IS ON IN QUITE ABOUT FURTHER
INVEST. IN ALL SHARE MY COMMON.
WORKFORCE WORK WORK. YOU HEARD
DISTANT. ON THE INCREASE MEDICAL
AND WALL EARLY FROM D. CS ARE
PROVIDED ARE IN. UNPRECEDENTED
STOCK ISSUE. COMMUNITY BASE OR-
HAVE SHUT DOWN BAD AND CO SPACE
DUE TO LACK OF. THAT'S REALLY
GOES HAND IN HAND WITH AN ISSUE
OF REIMBURSEMENT RATES THAT
PROVIDERS ARE EXPERIENCING IT'S
TOO LOW WHEN THERE WE GO
SHOOTING CONTRACTS WITH THEIR
COUNTIES. AND LET ME SAY SOME
COUNTIES HAVE DONE AN AMAZING
WORK AND HAVE INCREASED RATES
AND WORKED WITH AND BEEN
FLEXIBLE WITH OUR PROVIDERS. BUT
IN SOME CASES RATES ARE SO LOW
THAT STAFF CAN'T BE RETAINED
WE'VE HEARD FROM MEMBERS. AND
THEY SHARED THAT THEY'RE
COMPETING WITH AMAZON TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN A WORKFORCE. OUR
PROVIDERS NEED AN IMMEDIATE
SOLUTION TO ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES
TO MINIMUM WAGE THE TIRE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES DUE TO
PANDEMIC AND ALSO TO ALLOW FOR
MORE COMPETITIVE WAGES FOR
RETAINING AND RECRUITING.
WORKFORCE LAST YOU HEARD I'S
TESTIFY BEFORE ABOUT
DOCUMENTATION BURDEN. NOW WHILE
HOW HE WAS POISED TO INSTITUTE
SOME EFFICIENCIES THROUGH
CHANGES IN BILLING AND WE
COMMEND DH CS FURTHER
DOCUMENTATION REFORM WORK GROUP.
THERE IS STILL A LACK OF
STANDARDIZATION AND
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS COUNTIES WHICH LEADS TO
LOSS OF PRODUCTIVITY. AND
RESOURCES MANY CDOS HAVE STAFF
WHOSE SOLE FUNCTION IS
MONITORING HOW TO DOCUMENT EACH
AND EVERY COUNTY WHERE THEY
HAVEN'T SERVICES PROVIDE IT. AND
LET'S NOT FORGET THE CLIENTS WHO
ALSO HAVE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
OF PAPERWORK TO COMPLETE AND
IMAGINE WAITING FOR MONTHS FOR
AN APPOINTMENT AND THEN SPENDING
THE FIRST. CLIENTS BEFORE WORK
NO I SHARED SOME CRITIQUE ON
BEHALF OF THE PROVIDERS WE
REPRESENT I ALSO WANT THE
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND DH CS HAS
WORKED TO HAVE WE TRANSFORM. OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEM OPERATES AND IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC AT.
SIXTEEN H. A. AND ITS MEMBERS
COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION. WE
STAND BEHIND OUR EFFORTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR
CLARK KIRBY. KIM PETERSON PLEASE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
HELLO MY NAME IS COMPUTER STAND
AND I AM A SENIOR ATTORNEY
FOCUSING ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ON THIS PANEL. MY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM OF CARE FOCUSED ON
OPPORTUNITIES TO INVEST IN
COMPREHENSIVE UPSTREAM SERVICES
AND THE REALMS OF CRISIS
RESPONSE AND CRISIS TREATMENT.
SUCH INVESTMENTS CAN YIELD
POSITIVE PROGRESS TOWARDS
STOPPING THE CYCLE OF
HOMELESSNESS HOSPITALIZATION AND
INCARCERATION THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED HERE AND WERE
DISCUSSED IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS HEARING TWO
WEEKS AGO. FROM OUR WORK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE DRC HAS
SEEN HOW MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
ALMOST UNIFORMLY RESULTS AND
PLACEMENT OF A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLD ON A CALL FOR HELP IS MADE.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE STATE'S
CONTINUUM OF CARE OVERWHELMINGLY
DOES NOT SUPPORT ALTERNATIVES
RESTRICTIVE OPTIONS. THIS RESULT
IN A STRAIN ON EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS BACKLOGS OF PEOPLE
WAITING FOR A LIMITED INPATIENT
BEDS AND UNTOLD TRAUMA FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO FIND THEMSELVES
DETAINED. FIRST THIS TREND WE
ENCOURAGE DH CS TO FOCUS ON THE
FOLLOWING TYPES OF PROJECTS WHEN
CHOOSING HOW TO AWARD IT'S B. H.
C. I. P. FUNDING. AND
CONSIDERING HOW TO ROLL OUT THE
MOBILE CRISIS BENEFIT. CURRENTLY
EACH OF THESE PARTS OF THE
CONTINUUM ARE NOT OFFERED IN
SUFFICIENT QUANTITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. EXPANDED THESE
SERVICES CAN PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
ALTERNATIVES TO INVOLUNTARY
HOLDS AN ACUTE HOSPITALIZATIONS
. FIRST YES DH CS SHOULD INVEST
HEAVILY IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY
BASED CARE SUPPORT AND SERVICE.
BACKEND DH CS SHOULD ADOPT CLEAR
STANDARDS THAT REQUIRE MEDIC HOW
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES TO MEET
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE AND
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE CRISIS
INTERVENTION TREATMENT SERVICES
GEARED TOWARDS HELPING A PERSON
RESOLVE THE CRISIS WHENEVER
POSSIBLE AND MAKING LINKAGES TO
APPROPRIATE FOLLOW UP CARE.
THIRD B. H. C. I. P. IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR DH CS TO HELP
BUILD OUT THE STATE'S CAPACITY
TO PROVIDE CRISIS INTERVENTION
SERVICE. THESE SERVICES ARE
BRIEF INTERVENTIONS DESIGNED TO
QUICKLY RESOLVE A CRISIS WHEN
APPROPRIATE CRISIS INTERVENTION
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED IN
LOCATIONS LIKE MENTAL HEALTH
URGENT CARE IS WALK IN CENTRES.
SPECS AND SOBERING CENTERS.
FOREST DH CS SHOULD USE B. H. C.
I. P. FUNDING TO EXPAND THE
STATE'S CAPACITY FOR CRISIS
TREATMENT OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
CRISIS STABILIZATION SERVICES.
THIS COULD INCLUDE INVESTMENTS
IN INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
LICENSE CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNITS AND EXPANSION OF CRISIS
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS
WHICH CAN BE USED AS
ALTERNATIVES TO HOSPITALIZATION
. AND IT IS SANDY R. C. WAS
ASKED TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES
THAT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
FACE WHEN ACCESSING MEDICAL
SERVICE. TIME AND TIME AGAIN
I'VE HEARD FROM MY CLIENTS THAT
THE SYSTEM IS JUST TOO
COMPLICATED TO NAVIGATE. THEY
DON'T KNOW THE RIGHT ACCESS
POINT ARE THE SERVICES THEY MAY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR OR EVEN THE
SERVICES THAT EXIST IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THE RCS CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE ENHANCED
CARE MANAGEMENT BENEFIT WILL
HELP WITH THE LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES THAT MANY PEOPLE FACE
WHEN ACCESSING AND MAINTAINING
APPROPRIATE SERVICES. OUR
CAUTION COMES FROM OBSERVATIONS
THAT MISCOMMUNICATION CAN OCCUR
BETWEEN PROVIDERS ESPECIALLY IF
THEY WORK FOR DIFFERENT AGENCIES
AND OUR INTERESTS ACTING WITH
DIFFERENT PARTS OF A PERSON'S
LIFE. WE ARE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN MONITORING HOW
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT AS WELL
AS THE COMMUNITY SPORTS BENEFIT
WORKS FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MEDICAL SERVICES THROUGH BOTH A
MANAGED CARE PLAN AND ACCOUNTING
MODEL HEALTH PLAN. LASTLY A LACK
OF CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
LANGUAGE ACCESSIBLE SERVICES IS
ALSO A BARRIER TO MANY CLIENTS.
WE OFTEN HEAR THAT PEOPLE FIND
IT EASIER TO ENGAGE AND SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED BY CLINICIANS
TO SHARE THEIR CULTURAL
BACKGROUND OUR PRIMARY LANGUAGE.
TO THE EXTENT THAT DH CS HUSBAND
BUT REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT PROPOSALS.
D. R. C. ARE JUST AN EFFORT TO
EXPAND THE POOL OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKERS WHO MATCHED
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE CULTURAL
AND LINGUISTIC POPULATIONS.
INCLUDING LGBTQ I A PLASTIC
PEOPLE AS WELL AS PURE AS A
PROJECT. AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THE PANEL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY ON
THE- WAY. GOOD AFTERNOON IT WENT
AWAY WITH WHAT BETTER ONLINE
COPY WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
WITH THE GAME FOR CALAIS BUT
REMAIN SKEPTICAL OF CREDIBILITY
TO PROVIDE ENHANCED CARE
MANAGEMENT FOR COMMUNITY SUPPORT
GIVEN THEIR TRACK RECORD. I'M
REQUIRED PREVENTIVE SERVICES.
ONE NOT CONVINCED BUT LIKE THE
NOW THIRD. THERE IS A LOT THERE
HOW CAN THEY EXPECT TO ENGAGE IN
CASE MANAGED AND- SO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS THAT THEY HAVE NO
EXPERTISE. IT IS CRITICAL CLANS
PARTNER TRUST COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF ORGANIZATION
SERVING INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND JEFF BALD
INTERNATIONAL WORK BUT
PROVIDERS. PROVIDERS SHOULD NOT
ONLY HAVE EXPERIENCE SERVING THE
POPULATION BUT ALSO HAVE
EXPERIENCE SUCCESSFULLY OFFERING
ME- ABOUT POPULATION. COURAGE BY
THE DEPARTMENT MANDATE THAT
PLANNED ATTEMPT TO CONTRACT
WORKERS AND CARE AND HEALTH HOME
PROGRAM PROVIDERS. BUT THE WHOLE
PERSON CARE SUBCONTRACTORS I'M
SURE THAT I COULD NOT REACH OUT
TO THEM TAKE THAT CONTRACT. IS
RAISING CONCERNS THE CLASSICAL
RESORT. NOW WE ARE PRACTICING
AND CONTRACT WITH PROVIDERS BUT
THEY HAVE AN EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP WITH RATHER THAN
PARTNERING WITH. ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE EXPERTISE. YEAH
PORSCHE A CONTENTION MAKE HOW
FOR SERVICE WHICH- HELP LINKING
WITH HOW AND RENTAL DEPOSITS A
STATE MATTER HOW BETTER. AND
LACK PROVIDER COMCAST. LIMIT
MAKING CURRENT THAT. CONSIDERING
THAT THE WEATHER BETTER THE
PROVIDING. IN BUILDING COMCAST
COULD AND HOUSING HOMELESS BUT
THE PROGRAM. WE WRECK MOVING
THAT GOAL THE STAFF CHANGE. HOW
SERVICES IMPROVE HEALTH OUT THE
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE HOMELESS. BUT
THE SERVICE ARE ONLY MEANING IF
THEY IS A PORTABLE FOR PEOPLE TO
MOVE INTO ADDRESS. PAYING ALL
CALIBERS FILM BASED MAJOR ABOARD
HOUSING SHORTAGE ARE OUT OF DATE. MEDI CAL A MISSION ARE FOCUSED
ON HIGH YOU KNOW I WITH GET BACK
GREAT RACIAL. AND WHITE PAGE
COMPUTER HAD GREATER ACT TO
HEALTHCARE. ALTHOUGH PLANS ARE
ENCOURAGE TO PARK WITH SHELL AND
COMMUNITY. HAVING PLANNED I AND
NOW WE TALENT MEMBER WILL LIKELY
RESULT IN GRAND. ON HIGH
POPULATE. ALREADY ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE IS THE BEST RATHER
THAN THOSE WHO BENEFIT MARCH BUT
IN HER OUTREACH. THREE HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW CAN ABLE
DRIVING AND HELP OUT. AND REDUCE
POWER DISPARITIES TO ENSURE THAT
THE CAR A CALL THE GOAL OF THE
ARE TO. PROJECT MATCH TARGETS
AND CLASS. WILL BE EXPECTED TO
ACHIEVE THE NEGATIVE TO HOLD
CRIME ACCOUNTABLE PUBLIC REPORT
ON THE PROGRESS TOWARD OUR
TARGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH LET'S MOVE ON TO TARA CAMP
EASTERN FROM STEINBERG AND
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON TOM AGAIN
E. WITH STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
WE'RE IN IN THE NON PROFIT
PUBLIC INSTITUTE DATA TO
ADVANCING PUBLIC POLICY AND
INSPIRING ISSUES INSPIRING
LEADERSHIP ON ISSUES OF BRAIN
HEALTH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO JOIN TODAY AND TO
SPEAK TO ANY OUTSTANDING GAPS IN
THE PROGRAMS BEING DISCUSSED.
AND SPECIFICALLY HOW THEY CAN
ACT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WHILE I'M BEING ASKED TO SPEAK
TO THE GAPS THAT REMAIN I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE JUST
IN THE LAST YEAR THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. I'M WELL FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE MORE WORK IS
NEEDED WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR IT
THE BIGGEST AND BEST- BUDGET FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
NINE EIGHT EIGHT AN EXCELLENT
EXAMPLE OF HOW MUCH WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH IN A YEAR BUT
ALSO HOW FAR WE HAVE TO GO. IN
THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE SECURED
FEDERAL FUNDING AND INVEST IN
OUR OWN DOLLARS INTO EVERY
COMPONENT OF THE NINETY EIGHT
SYSTEM. IN AN ATTEMPT TO ENSURE
EVERY CALIFORNIAN HAS SOMEONE TO
CALL SOMEBODY COME AND SOMEWHERE
TO GO. BUT THE PROBLEM IN OUR
VIEW IS THAT THESE ARE ONE TIME
OR LIMITED TERM INVESTMENTS THAT
AT THIS POINT DO NOT APPEAR TO
BE COORDINATED. CALL CENTER
FUNDING IS ONLY AVAILABLE THIS
YEAR AND NEXT AND FALL SHORT OF
ACTUAL ESTIMATED COSTS. BEACH A
DOLLARS FOR MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS
AND CRISIS RECEIVING AND
STABILISATION CENTRE
INFRASTRUCTURE. INSIGNIFICANT
BUT SIMILARLY FALL SHORT OF THE
REQUIRED SCALE TO REDUCE
UNNECESSARY LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVEMENT AND DIVERT PEOPLE
AWAY FROM OUR JAILS AND ER. FOR
EXAMPLE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MOBILE CRISIS
TEAMS HAVE BEEN CREATED OR
ENHANCED USING THE MOBILE CRISIS
TEAM. INVESTMENT DOLLARS AND
THEY APPEARED TO BE. CLUSTERED
IN ONLY A FEW COUNTIES. I MEAN
WE ARE THAT CLOSER HUNDRED
MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS ARE NEEDED
STATEWIDE TO MEET THE DEMAND
UNDER NINETY EIGHT. THE SHOCK
AND ONGOING FUNDED IT IS CLEARLY
NEEDED HERE. AND JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY PEACE DOLLARS MUST
BE WELL INTEGRATED WITH A PLAN
FOR HOW THESE FINDINGS OF COURSE
SOURCES SUPPORT NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. NINE EIGHT EIGHT FITS
WITHIN OUR BROADER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH REFORMS AND HOW IT
FURTHER LINKS WITH OTHER
INVESTMENTS OUTSIDE OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION LIKE
THE CRISIS ACT. EVEN OF CALL
CENTERS MOBILE CRISIS TEAM TO
END CRISIS FACILITIES ARE FULLY
FUNDED THE NINETY EIGHT SYSTEM
ONLY WORKS IF THERE IS SEAMLESS
COORDINATION BETWEEN SYSTEM
COMPONENTS. AND THAT THE
LINKAGES BETWEEN THEM ARE ALSO
FINDING. WE WERE THRILLED TO SEE
THAT HHS WILL BE UNDERTAKING AND
I NEED A PLANNING EFFORT AND
HOPE THAT IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE
THIS BROADER CONTEXT. AND AS AN
EXAMPLE IN TIME BACK TO THE
EARLIER CONVERSATION AROUND HOW
MOBILE CRISIS TEAM BENEFIT
CONNECTS TO NINE EIGHT EIGHT. I
KNOW THAT THE 85% AFTER MAP WAS
DESIGNED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPECIFICALLY FOR NINE
EIGHT EIGHT AND YET WE HAVE.
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT DIRECT
CONNECTION REFLECTED IN
DISCUSSIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE FEEL THAT THE QUESTION SHOULD
BE HOW DOES THE BENEFITS SUPPORT
NINE EIGHT EIGHT AND NOT HOW
DOES NINE EIGHT EIGHT INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BENEFIT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH YOU TO BUILD OFF THE
TREMENDOUS WORK ACCOMPLISHED
TODAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND.
NOW LET'S GO. Q. HOW TO MISTER
PETER RAGSDALE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK VERY MUCH FOR UP TO
DISCUSS- THE B. H. C. I. P. AND
SHE'S SEEN RESTAURANTS AS PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
HOUSING AUTHORITY IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY- HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY ON- WHAT HE'S YOU KNOW
SORT OF A PRODUCTION FOCUSED-
RELATIONSHIP TO PRODUCING
ADDITIONAL HOUSING FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS. YOU
KNOW WE TEND TO BE VERY
PRODUCTION FOCUSED AND WALLER'S
INTEREST IMPRESSIVE PROVIDERS
AND PEOPLE WORKING IN THIS SPACE
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY THE
SOLUTIONS ARE HOUSING WILL
BOLSTER- THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUPPORT- YOUR SERVICE DELIVERY
FOR INDIVIDUALS. WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. WHICH WAS
TRUE WHAT MUCH OF WHAT HE'S IS
BILL IS JERRY BY THE FINANCE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. UP FOR
MISSION DRIVEN BUILDERS LIKE THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY- HE WOULD RENT
SUPPORTS THERE IS A NATIONAL
CHALLENGE AMONG THE COST OF
ACQUISITION CONSTRUCTION AND
SERVICE DELIVERY. C. R. T. AND
C. C. E. WOULD BE EXCITING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A MORE ROBUST
HOUSING CONTINUUM. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED
FAMILIES AND SAMPSON COUNTY EVEN
WITH RENTAL SUPPORTS CURRENTLY
LOOKING FOR HOUSING THE
INTENTIONALITY AROUND- BRINGING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
SPECIAL NEEDS HOUSING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CONSUMERS. IS SORT OF A
MODEL THAT WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN TAPPING INTO BUT I THINK THAT
COULD BE EXPANDED WITH
ADDITIONAL WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. EXAMPLES OF LIKE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME AND PROJECT ON
HE REALLY CREATED IN SHORT ORDER
OPPORTUNITIES TO PRODUCE AND
INCREASE OUR HOUSING STOCK. FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CONSUMERS. THERE
HAS TO BE AN EXPANSION OF ALL
TYPES OF HOUSING- THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES IN DESIGN AND-
AVAILABILITY BUT- CERTAINLY
CODE- AND COMMUNITIES HAVE TO.
EMBRACE HOUSING OF ALL TYPES AND
HOPEFULLY THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH THESE- BROAD AND-
DIFFERENT- HOUSING TYPES
AVAILABLE WITH B. H. C. I. P.
AND C. C. A. THERE COULD BE
AGAIN A CHRISTIAN CHRISTOFFERSEN
ET TO INCREASE PERMIT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WHICH ULTIMATELY WE
BELIEVE. WE'LL HAVE A BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR OUR MENTAL HEALTH
CONSUMERS HAPPY ALSO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NIGHT I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANEL FOR TAKING TIME
OUT OF YOUR DAY AND OFFER YOUR
EXPERTISE AS FAR. AS WE'RE
ENTERING THIS JOURNEY ALTOGETHER
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ALL VOICES AT THE TABLE AS
POSSIBLE- AND I AND I WILL SAY
THAT'S THE KIND OF UNDERSCORES.
ALL OF THIS CONVERSATION IS
AROUND WORK FOR SO. YES
WORKFORCE WORKFORCE WORKFORCE.
AND AS I FEAR THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE FIGHTING. FIGHTING HOUSING
DOLLAR POACHING THE SAME POT I
FEAR THAT WE'RE GONNA DO THAT
WITH. OUR WORK FORCE AS WELL SO.
I MEAN THAT'S FOR ANOTHER DAY TO
TALK ABOUT BUT WE REALLY MUST.
FOCUS ON ON ON HAVING THE WORK
FORCE TO BE ABLE TO DO ALL THIS
WORK THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT-
DOCTOR CASEY. MANAGEMENT DR
QUEST I WANT TO ASK ABOUT. AND I
INVENTED MR RAGSDALE AS WELL SO
THIS NEW. TICKET SO YOU YOU HAVE
SAID YOU'VE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THE WAIT THERE'S A- HUGE
NEED FOR MORE STEP DOWN HOUSING
UP PEOPLE MOVE OUT OF IT AND
KEEP CENTER. THEY GET WEAK AND
YOU NEED A PLACE FOR THEM OFTEN
TIMES AT LEAST RESTRICTIVE
CENTER- DO YOU SEE. THAT THIS
THAT THIS BRIDGE HOUSING IS
GONNA ABLE WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
FIND. THE ROOMS AND THE
FACILITIES. TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THIS. I DO
BELIEVE WE IT I DO BELIEVE IT
WHAT WILL BE HELPING US OUT YES-
SO. WE DO DIFFERENT HOUSING THAN
A LOT OF THE OTHER HOUSING
INITIATIVES THAT FOCUSED ON
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
WORK WE'RE LOOKING FOR-
SPECIALIZED HOUSING- SO- FOR
EXAMPLE HOUSING. SO CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND SO. THAT MIGHT HAVE
RESULTED FROM HOPE HOMELESSNESS-
MAKES- EMPLOYMENT AND ACCESS TO
TREATMENT MORE CHALLENGING OVER
THE LONG RUN- WE- NEED TO WORK
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS WE
DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LANDLORDS- IN ORDER TO- GIVE
THEM ASSURANCES THAT WILL BE
THERE WITH THEM TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT. ARE NEEDED FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. AND SO WE
ACTUALLY TYPICALLY LOOK FOR
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT STOCK IF YOU
WILL. THEN THE TYPICAL PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- CONTACT SO
BORED AND CARE FACILITIES AND
TERM HOUSING PERMITS FOR
HOUSING. BUT BUT THEN ALSO
RECOVERY RESIDENCES- HOUSING FOR
TRANSITION AGE USE. OTHER
DIFFERENT CONTEXT AND SOME OF
THE MORE TRADITIONAL- HOUSING.
OPTIONS AND THOSE ARE AVAILABLE
YOU JUST NEED THE FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR THE BEDS THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. THERE WE
STILL HAVE TO WORK AT IT BUT YES
WE'RE WE'RE ABLE TO FIND THOSE
OPTIONS OKAY. AND THEN TO
MISDIRECT STILL DOES THIS THIS
IS A NEW PART OF MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW GET PEOPLE AT
HOME SO WE CAN BETTER CARE FOR
THEM AS YOU SAID. IT THIS WILL
ALLOW YOU MORE FLEXIBILITY IS
THAT CORRECT WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE. WE SAY BUT
WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL FIGHTING FOR
THAT SAME POT OF MONEY FOR IT
FOR WITH THE HOUSING CREDITS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT THIS WILL BE
MORE CLEAN DIRECTLY TO YOU IS
THAT CORRECT. THAT'S DEFINITELY
TRUE AND I THINK WHAT ALSO
HAPPENS IN FOR THOSE OF US TO DO
THIS WORK IT IS A LAYER CAKE OF
FINANCING. TO GET ANY OF THESE
PROJECTS- ACTUALLY. IN THE
GROUND SO. I THINK YOU CAN STILL
KEEP COUNTY- THERE'S A
PROGRESSIVE HOUSING MODEL WHICH
WHICH TALKS ABOUT YOUR HOUSING.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE EXITS AS
PEOPLE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR
WITH THEIR TREATMENT PROGRAMS
YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE TO BE
PRODUCTION FOCUSED. SO OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM A HUD PROGRAMS AS THOSE
BONDS AND- THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HOPEFULLY WITH. WITH
THIS LEGISLATION TO BRING
RESOURCES. THAT ARE WILL ALSO
MEET SOME OF THE GAPS IN
BRINGING ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING ONLINE. SO
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- IT DOESN'T
JUST HAVE TO BE THE TYPE OF
HOUSING THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
BUILDING WITH- THE CAPITAL STACK
FROM THE HOUSING PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT ANY MOVE ANY
MONEY THAT'S BROUGHT IN THAT WE
CAN ADVOCATE FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
CONSUMERS. I THINK IT GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY OF A TRAUMA TO A
BOX. TO INCREASE OUR HOUSING
STOCK AND WE ARE IN A
COMPETITIVE COMPETITIVE
ENVIRONMENT STATEWIDE. SO I SEE-
DEDICATED DOLLARS AS AS AGAIN
BENEFITING OUR COMMUNITY. TO
INCREASE- UNITS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CONSUMERS. THANK YOU. A
TIP. TO MAYBE. MISS RB OR- MISS
COOK. AND BECAUSE BECAUSE-
COMPUTERS OF THIS RIGHTS TALK
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE COME INTO THE SYSTEM
THROUGH A FIFTY ONE FIFTY WHICH
IS OF COURSE A CRISIS AND IT'S
TOO CUTE. HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF- S. A. Q. WAYS INTO OUR
SYSTEM OFTENTIMES CAL AIM. I
THINK ATTEMPTS TO DO THAT SO
YEAH SO WE CAN TREAT CHRONIC
ISSUES CHRONIC ISSUES AND NOT AS
AS A CRISIS AND CUTE ISSUE- WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT DO
YOU SEE CALLUM IS REALLY BEING
ABLE TO MOVE US AWAY FROM THE
ACUTE FIFTY ONE FIFTY CRISIS
INTO THE MORE CARING FOR CHRONIC
ISSUES. IT SAID REALLY COMPLEX
QUESTION RIGHT- AND SO I'M VERY
HOPEFUL. IT'S A COMPLEX QUESTION
AND SO WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT
CAL AND WILL ALLOW US TO REALLY
TRANSFORM THE DELIVERY SYSTEM I
KNOW THAT SOUNDS BIG AND IN OUR-
OFFICE RISTIC BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I DO BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INVESTED AND
WE'RE YOU KNOW INVESTED IN AS
WELL WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S CAPACITY- TO MAKE THE
CHANGES INCLUDING THE
TRANSFORMATION AND THAT'S WHY
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED IN KEY
AREAS. INCLUDED CRISIS SERVICES-
SO ALSO PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION WE HAVE TO- INVEST
ON THE FRONT END AS WELL SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY STOP THE BLEEDING-
SO WE REMAIN HOPEFUL- BUT I
AGREE THERE DOES NEED TO BE MORE
INVESTMENT- STRATEGICALLY IN
ORDER. TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT
WE ALL WANT. THANK YOU BECAUSE
WHEN THE AN ADD ANYTHING TO THE
- SURE YEAH BRIEFLY I THINK I
MEAN SIMILAR SENTIMENTS IN TERMS
OF THAT THE GOAL. AND I THINK TO
THE EXTENT THAT DOES MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES CRISES CAN BE
PRECIPITATED BY ON THAT-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS OR
HEALTH CARE NEITHER SOCIAL
NEEDS. I THINK THOSE ARE THE
TYPE OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THE UPSTREAM.
INTERVENTIONS THAT CALENDAR
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON IN THE
IN THE COORDINATION FOR HIGHEST
NEED MEMBERS- WELL EVEN BETTER
OUTCOMES THERE SO CERTAINLY I
THINK THAT IS THE GOAL. THANK
YOU DOCTOR PRINCE. THANK YOU-
SO. I SHOULD QUESTION FOR
WESTERN CENTER LAW POVERTY
FIRST- IF YOU STARTED OFF YOUR
TESTIMONY- BASICALLY EXPRESSING
SOME SKEPTICISM ABOUT THE HEALTH
PLANS BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS ACTUALLY THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTS AND THE- CORONATION OF
KERR- DANCE CORONATION OF KERR-
WHAT IS SO I GUESS I WONDER
WHAT'S THE ALTERNATE BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE GOING DOWN THIS PATH
SO HOW HOW WHAT KIND OF WHAT WAY
WOULD YOU- WELL I GUESS WHAT WE
SHOULD WE HOLD THE PLANS
ACCOUNTABLE AND- WHAT WOULD MAKE
YOU. MORE CONFIDENT PERHAPS THAT
THE PLANS ARE ABLE TO CARRY OUT
THE WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING OF THEM
TELLING. THE QUESTION. WITH DAY
DOES THE WHOLE CLAN FOR
ACCOUNTABLE AND CONSIDERING THAT
THE BIG TICKET INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE GOING IN THROUGH INCREASED
CAPITATION RATE THAT'S LOWER
BENEFIT PAYMENTS THAT THERE BE
ACT METRICS IN PLACE TO MEASURE
THE ABILITY OF CLAMS. ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE INCLUDING
FIVE CONTRACTING WITH SPECIFIC
PROVIDERS THAT HAVE EXPERTISE IN
SETTING ALONG THOSE LINES THE
CRITERIA OF WHAT- PARTY- THOSE
PROVIDERS ARE ABLE TO- PROVIDE
THAT AS WELL THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUAL SERVERS NETWORK
MEASURING INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
ADDICTED TO YOUR- PREVIOUS POINT
OF A NEXT INSURING THAT- THAT
ARE ACTS IT CARRIED. OKAY
SUPPORT ART OF FOCUS- ON THOUGH
HAVE ARE BEEN RECEDING THAT BACK
I DON'T HIGH UTILIZE YOURS BUT
ALSO THE THAT. I WOULDN'T WANT
BENEFIT THING CAN GROW ENERGY
CHARACTER HOMELESS. OR I
RECENTLY ENCOURAGED INDIVIDUALS. OKAY SO I GUESS I KNOW
QUESTION FOR LOCAL HEALTH PLAN-
YOU OR SAW SKIPPED- WE ALSO
PREVIOUSLY YOU MAY EVEN IN I'LL%
PLAY TO DISCUSS- THAT- CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE WERE ASKING. US HEALTH
PLANS TO DO SOMETHING WITH
SOMEONE NEW THAT'S- ALTHOUGH
CERTAINLY HELP PLANTS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW
CORONATION CLINICAL CARE AND
SOMEOF THOSE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES- THIS THIS MADE THIS
IS PROBABLY A SOMEWHAT NEW AREA.
TO KIKI AND YOU TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
IMPLEMENTING THE ECM AND TO ME
SERVICES BUT- IN THE TYPE OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND FRANKLY I
THINK WHEN I HEARD THE ANSWER
FOR THE TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS-
THEY SOUND LIKE THE USUAL
CLINICAL OBSERVATIONS USED TO
WORKING WITH AND NOT AND NOT
JUST FOR THIS LIFE FOR EXAMPLE.
I MEAN I MEAN IF YOU'D SEE
DOCTOR I KNOW R. F. KEYS OFTEN
TIMES HAVE A LOT OF RELATIONS
WITH THE COMMUNITY SO THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE WRONG PARTNER TO
HAVE TO REACH COMMUNITY BUT- I
GUESS BEYOND. THE. USUAL
SUSPECTS I WOULD SAY- ARE. HOW
PLANS DOING IN TERMS OF REALLY
REACHING OUT TO COMMUNITY. TO
PROVIDE THE CHICORY THESE
COMMITTEE SUPPORTS- ALSO THE
ENHANCED CARE MANGEMENT- DC
HELP YEAH WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES FOR HEALTH PLANS TO
DOING THAT- WHAT DO YOU SEE YOUR
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
SHOULD BE IN PLACE WE HEARD FROM
LESSONS ARE LONG POVERTY- IT IS
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT. THE PEACE
COMMITTEE SUPPORTS AND THE ECM
THAT DANCE CARE MANAGEMENT IS
ACTUALLY REACHING. THE ENTIRETY
OF THE PROBATE MEDIC COW
POPULATIONS Y. SE PROPRIO YES I
MEAN- THE- THE WHAT ONES THAT
MAY HAVE LANGUAGE ACCESS. TO
THEY HAVE OTHER ACCESS BARRIERS
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE IN THE IN
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE- PERHAPS
THE COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE IS
THAT. IT IS MORE IT LET'S PUT IT
THIS WAY IT'S STRONG BUT
INFORMAL SO IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT GONNA FIND
SOME ORGANIZATION THAT HAS A LOT
OF FUNDS AND- ACCOUNTANTS WHO
CAN SPREAD TO THE FINANCIALS BUT
YET YOU NEED TO PARTNER WITH
THEM IN CONTACT WITH THEM. YOU
REALLY DON'T REACH THAT
COMMUNITY SO WHAT DO YOU WHAT
WHAT'S APPROACH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS PLAN TO TAKE TO. TO INSURE
THAT WE- THEY CAN CARRY OUT THE-
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE SERVICES. THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION AND- THOUGH YOU'RE
RIGHT MY REMARKS LARGELY FOCUSED
ON THE EXISTING CONTRACT IN THAT
THE NATIONAL COUPLE OF MONTHS OF
CALAIS MENTAL MEDICATION THAT.
REALLY DID LARGELY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING CONTINUITY WITH WHOLE
PERSON CARE AND THE MEMBERS.
THAT WERE SERVED BY THE PILOT SO
BY AND LARGE THOSE WERE COUNTY-
ASKING AGENCIES WORK CORE PART
OF HEALTH FROM PROVIDERS. THEY
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT THOSE.
SAME PROVIDERS WERE ALSO BROUGHT
INTO CALAIS IN- THERE ARE
EXISTING CONTRACTS WITH BETWEEN
PLANS AND VIDEOS ALREADY. BUT I
THINK THAT IS- AN AREA WHERE
THAT WILL GROW OVER THE COMING
MONTHS AND I THINK. YOU KNOW.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF- MANY OF
THE METRICS IN THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT WAS REFERENCED
EARLIER. THERE ARE SPECIFIC
MEASURES AROUND- YOU KNOW
TRAINING AND BRING ON ADDITIONAL
PROVIDERS AND PROVIDERS THAT
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
TEY LIVE IN. AND SO I THINK- I
THINK THOSE. METRICS WILL REALLY
SUPPORT BRINGING ON ADDITIONAL
VIDEOS. SO THE QUESTION ON ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES. I DO
THINK PART OF THE REASON THAT
THAT A CLAIM. IS THAT THESE ARE
NOT TRADITIONAL. BETTER HALLER
HELL CARE FOR- AND MANY OF THEM
AS NEVER CALL. WITH EIGHT BEFORE
SO I THINK SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES OR THING THAT ARE TO
GOING TO TIME TO WORK ON. IS
REALLY FUN OF THAT THE CORE
REQUIRE ARE BOTH EASY AND
COMMUNITY. EVEN JUST
FUNDAMENTALS OF CLAIM SUBMISSION
AUSTIN YOU KNOW SURE THAT THAT'S
NOT A BARRIER CLAIMS AND
ENCOUNTERS. SOMETIMES THE
STOPPER ARE EVEN- JUST
ADMITTING- COCKFIGHT IN A
SPREADSHEET AND INVOICING AND
NOT WAIT BEFORE THEY CAN. GAIN
THE CAPACITY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DO. CLEANING- EDUCATION HOW
TO SECURELY HANDLE P. I- AND
THEN ALSO JUST. THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE SUCH ROBOTS REPORTING
. THAT IN ITSELF I THINK IS A
CHALLENGE THOUGH- I THINK THOSE
ARE NOT INSURMOUNTABLE
CHALLENGES BUT THEY'RE JUST
GONNA TAKE TIME TO WORK THROUGH
AND AGAIN I THINK THE DEFENDANT
DOLLARS WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL
THERE. SO I THINK THAT TOUCHES
ON THE FIRST QUESTION AND THE
SECOND YOU ASKED ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY. I GUESS I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A ROUTE EIGHT ACTIVITY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE
CIRCULATED LAST FALL AND THAT
WERE DRAFTED. AND THEY WERE THE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT PROCESS INTO
THAT AND NOW THOSE QUARTERLY
REPORTING METRICS ARE ALL
POSTED. ONLINE A WHAT PLANS WILL
BE REPORTING ON A REGULAR BASIS
IT EACH ASK AND THEN. I'D SAY
YOU KNOW I HEARD FROM DOCTOR
COOPER EARLIER ON. THAT THERE
WILL BE DASHBOARD THAT WILL
REGULARLY BE COLLECTED SO I DO
THINK THE MECHANISMS ARE IN
PLACE AND WE REALIZE THAT THE
BIG HUGE LEFT IN THAT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING TO BE A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR SUCCESS.
AND AGAIN IT'S JUST GOING TO
TAKE TIME AND WORKING ON THAT.
OKAY SO- IF YOU YOU DID MENTION
THAT- CERTAINLY PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH FILLING CLAIMS AND
THAT DOLE NEED TO LEARN. TO THE
HUNT CLAIMS BUT- NO THE- FIVE
I'M A PHYSICIAN WHO PRACTICES IN
EFFECT IN BETWEEN CENTER IN YOUR
WE HAVE ENTIRE BILLING TO. I AM
ALSO SCHOOL PHYSICIAN I KNOW
EVEN SCHOOLS WHICH ARE ACTUALLY
LARGE BUREAUCRACIES IN THE CELLS
OFTENTIMES CANNOT FIGURE OUT HOW
TO FILE CLAIMS. WITH HEALTH
PLANS- FERTILITY SCHOOL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SO FORTH THEY'RE
CHALLENGED- SO I AM A LITTLE
NERVOUS WE SAY WHAT WE HAVE TO
TEACH THEM HOW TO FILE CLAIMS
BECAUSE I'LL TELL YOU FILING
CLAIMS IS A PAIN IN THE NECK
NINE AND I'M TRYING TO NOT USE
OTHER LANGUAGE IN THIS PUBLIC
FORUM SO- SO WHAT WHAT WHAT OUR
PLANS GOING TO BE DOING AND I
REALIZE THERE'S ALSO I MEAN THIS
IS PERHAPS ALSO CONVERSATION FOR
DTS TO BECAUSE- DID ON THE ON
THE BILLING FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTABILITY SIDE OUT SOCIAL
KINDLY SIDE BUT- IT'S- I MEAN.
DO YOU ARE YOU HAVE TO GO LOOK
AT YOUR WHOLE CLAIMING PROCESS
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE TYPES OF
SERVICES SO WE DON'T. END UP.
HAVING- COMMITTEE ORGANIZER.
HAVING HAVE ENTIRE. DEPARTMENTS
IN ORDER TO CLAIM FOR- IT'S THE
END OF SPENDING MY MONEY ON
OVERHEAD FOR THESE SERVICES.
KNOWING HOW COMPLICATED AND-
TIME CONSUMING AND BUREAUCRATIC
CLAIMS PROCESSES HAVE BEEN. FOR
I MEAN IT DOES. CAN WE TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT THAT YEAH. SO I
THINK YOU KNOW. A GOOD KNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S A CHALLENGE
FOR SMALL PROVIDERS THAT WERE
CONTRACTED BAND HERE POINT- AND
REALLY NOT YOU KNOW AN EASY
PROCESS I THINK THAT I ALSO
MENTIONED THAT THERE IS. A
PROCESS BY WHICH PROVIDERS CAN
FIT MANY MANUAL INVOICES- AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH OTHER SIGNIFICANT
TRANSITION BEFORE IN MEDIC COW
WHERE NONTRADITIONAL PROVIDERS
ARE BROUGHT INTO MANAGED CARE
NETWORK AND IT DIDN'T. AGAIN I
DON'T THINK IT'S AN
INSURMOUNTABLE PROBLEM AND WHEN
I WAS TALKING WITH SOME OF THE
LOCAL PLANS ABOUT KIND OF THEIR
APPROACH DURING THAT TRANSITION
I THINK THERE IS AN EFFORT TO
HAVE AN APPROACH THAT'S NOT- YOU
KNOW. THE INITIAL RESPONSE AND
THEN DENYING A CLAIM BECAUSE
IT'S NOT MEETING YOU KNOW ALL OF
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE WORK
WITH THE PROVIDER CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL AND NOT ONLY
DELIVERING. THE SERVICE TO
GETTING PAID FOR IT. OKAY I HOPE
YOU DID OUT OF IT FROM. TO I
KNOW KNOW HOW TO MEET A SIMILAR
CLAIMS TIGHTEN AUTUMN REJECTED
DISMISSING THAT AGAIN BEFORE YOU
GET PAID AND SEEM LIKE IT'S ALSO
ALMOST AUTOMATIC. BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT NO IT'S GONNA BE
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM IS IF WE MAKE IT TOO
DIFFICULT. NO WE'RE NOT CONFINED
COMMUTE ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
OTHER ISSUE AGAIN AS I SAID.
SOME OF THE COMMUNICATIONS YOU
NEED TO WORK WITH ARE NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO YOU KNOW
THEY'RE- NOT REACH. MANY OF
THEIR MEDICAL. COMMUNITY TO ME
IS COVERED WITH THE SAME MEDICAL
PATIENTS- MADE HIM A VERY
INFORMAL ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW. IF
YOU CAN GET SPREADSHEET THAT'S
GREAT. SO BUT IF YOU DID BUT
THEY THE ONES WHO CAN ACTUALLY
REACH SO. I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING TO REALLY THINK ABOUT.
HOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO REACH
THOSE MUCH MORE INFORMAL
ENTITIES. THAT CAN ACTUALLY
PROVIDE MANY SERVICES. THEN I
GUESS THE- QUESTION FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS I MEAN YOU YOU
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
BARRIERS AND APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING UP LANGUAGE ACCESS
BARRIERS. WHAT DO YOU SEE AS- F.
AGAIN FOR CAL TEAM. IN TERMS OF
FEATURE. THE POPULATION YOU
REPRESENT ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
PROMISE OF CAL AIM IN TERMS OF
THESE. COMMUNITY SUPPORTS AND-
INDIANS CARE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES- WHAT DO YOU THINK PLAN
SHOULD BE DOING TO REDUCE THE
BARRIERS TO THE POPULATIONS THAT
YOU REPRESENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THIS IS JIM PETERSON
AGAIN FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- I THINK. WHAT WE SEE
AND WHAT I HAVE SEEN AND THE
TIME THAT I HAVE WORKS WITH
CLIENTS LIVING WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS IS THAT. THIS IS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH REALLY
BENEFIT FROM A FEW THINGS. THEY
BENEFIT A LOT FROM HAVING LIKE A
ONE STOP SHOP WHICH IS A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN GO GET THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT GOT
THEIR PHYSICAL HEALTH TREATMENTS
AND NOT HAVE TO GO TO TOO MANY
PHYSICAL LOCATION. BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE DEALING WITH
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES OR
THEY HAVE WORK OR THEY HAVE
CHILDREN OR THEY HAVE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THEIR LIVES
AND CAN'T STAND. ALL DAY GOING
BACK AND FORTH TO MEDICAL OR
SOCIAL SERVICES APPOINTMENTS-
ANOTHER THING IS THAT. PEOPLE
REALLY BENEFIT FROM SITE VISITS
TO WHERE THEY LIVE OR WHERE THEY
ARE OR OTHER PLACES IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE. THEY ARE
COMFORTABLE ACCESSING SERVICES
SO I THINK THAT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. FIGURING OUT HOW
TO DESIGN THESE PROGRAMS AND
WAYS ARE GOING TO BENEFIT THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE INTENDED TO
BENEFIT I THINK THINKING ABOUT
FLEXIBILITY AND HOW THE SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED AND WHERE THEY'RE
DELIVERED SHE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. IN ADDITION TO THAT-
ISSUES THAT I TALK ABOUT
REGARDING CULTURAL CULTURAL AND
LANGUAGE ISSUES. WE TALK TO
CLIENTS ALL THE TIME YOU ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THEIR PROVIDERS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY UNDERSTAND THEIR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND- BECAUSE OF THAT
ARE NOT LIKELY TO STAY ENGAGED
IN TREATMENT SO I THINK I'VE
GOTTEN- GOING ON ABOUT THE
ISSUES LIKE WORKFORCE AS
EVERYONE ELSE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WHICH I REALLY APPRECIATE-
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME ATTENTION
PAID TO DIVERSITY. OF THE
WORKFORCE OUR RECORDING OKAY I
APPRECIATE THANK YOU- SO WELL
THIS IS OKAY AND AGAIN I WANNA
THANK ALL OF THE PRESENTERS I
KNOW THAT CENTER ADMIN COVERED A
LOT OF GROUND SO- I JUST WANNA
MAKE KNOWLEDGE AGAIN THE VERY
IMPORTANT. THINGS THAT- THAT
YOU'VE PRESENTED AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE PRESENT-
I THINK THAT- YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO. AND SO VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT- BUT I THINK
I'M I GUESS THE CHALLENGES- TO
THINK BEYOND THAT LIKE ALL THE
USUAL SUSPECTS. IS WERE TRYING
TO REACH INTO THE COMMUNITIES
ARE TRYING DRESS SOCIAL TERMS
HEALTH AND SO FORTH. AND REALLY
FIGURE OUT HOW WE MIGHT HAVE TO
CHANGE OUR PROCESS SEES TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN TO BUILD THAT
CONTINUE OF CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TO ACTUALLY. BUILD THAT
OUT ON THE ON THE SOCIAL SIDE TO
DRAW SOCIAL TERMS OF HEALTH. AND
SO I GUESS THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
THE CHALLENGE. FOR US AND THEN
STATE NEEDS TO TRY TO. YOU KNOW
THE- TRY TO MAKE THINGS. AT OUR
END. IT IS ALWAYS A CHANCE- BUT
THEN AT THE SAME TIME WE GO BE
SURE- YOU- ARE I GUESS THAT THE
ENEMY. ARE WELL AND TO TRY TO
BUT BASICALLY YOU'RE THE YOU'RE
YOUR INTERFACE WITH PEOPLE THE
FRONT LINE. TO MAKE THINGS.
SIMPLE FOR THEM AS SO- FIGURE
OUT ITS SIMPLEST THAT NEEDS TO
BE IN. TO IMPROVE ACCESS AS WELL
AS ENSURING THAT- WE DON'T JUST
TURN TO A THE USUAL SUSPECTS
THAT THAT WE'RE USED TO WORKING
WITH BUT FIGURE OUT HOW WE REACH
OUT TO. PEOPLE WHO REALLY ARE
CONNECTED TO THE COMMUNITY AND
MAKE THAT SUCCESSFUL SO AGAIN
WHAT I THINK THE. PANELS FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN. WE WITH REASON YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO
EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ESPECIALLY FOR TODAY DETECTING
TIME OUT TO COME AND- TALK TO
THE COMMITTEE. AS WE'RE HEARING.
ABOUT OUR TRANSFORMATION- LEASES
BUT PART OF. MEDICARE OKAY SO
WITH THAT I THINK WILL MOVE ON
THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER. EIGHT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE IMPLEMENTATION. UPDATE YOUR MUTE DIRECTOR
CORPORATE HELP THANK YOU YES IT
WAS INEVITABLE THAT HAPPEN ONCE
RIGHT IT HAS TO THANK YOU FOR
FLAGGING. I SO WITH THIS
INITIATIVE IT IS A MULTI YEAR
INITIATIVE MULTI DEPARTMENT
PACKAGE OF INVESTMENTS ARE YOU
REALLY AIMING AT TRANSFORMING
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS. IN DONNELLY YOU KNOW
FOR ALL CHILDREN- ZERO TO TWENTY
FIVE REGARDLESS OF HERE- IT IS
IT IS MEANT TO REALLY BE
UPSTREAM OUGHT TO REALLY FOCUS
ON ON GOING IN WITH A
PREVENTATIVE LANDS. AND BUILDING
AN ECOSYSTEM WHERE ALL CHILDREN
AND YOUNG ADULTS ARE IN EVERY TV
SCREEN SUPPORTED SERVER- I KNOW
FOR MERGING AND OUR EXISTING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. YOU
KNOW I THINK WE ARE TRYING TO
GROUND OURSELVES IN SOME
PRINCIPLES REALLY FOCUSING ON
EQUITY- CENTERING EFFORTS AROUND
CHILDREN AND YOUTH VOICES
STRENGTH NEEDS PRIORITIES
EXPERIENCES. AND REALLY DRIVING
TRANSFORMATIVE SYSTEM- CHANGES.
AND USING ONGOING LEARNING AS A
BASIS FOR CHANGE AND IMPROVEMENT
IN THE OUTCOMES AS WE AS WE
CONTINUE THROUGH THIS
INITIATIVE- IT IS A LARGE SCALE
EFFORT AS YOU KNOW- WHICH
REQUIRES YOU KNOW VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND PURPOSEFUL STEPS
ARE TO ESTABLISH THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE FUTURE PROGRESS- AND TO
ALLOW FOR EFFECTIVE EXECUTION OF
THE INITIATIVE- WE- ARE. YOU
KNOW HAVE A MULTI YOURS YES WE
ARE KIND OF APPROACHING IT IN
KIND OF THREE DISTINCT PHASES OF
THE DEPARTMENT BUT THE
INITIATIVES THAT WE ARE. NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR- IT IN REALLY
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE ENGAGE IN
THESE ACTIVITIES OVER KIND OF.
THIS FIRST PHASE WHERE AND- YOU
KNOW MAJOR FOCUS IS INCLUDED
AROUND A DEFINING THE SPECIFIC
GOALS THAT ARE ARE LINKING TO
THE OVERALL KIND OF PLAN- WITH
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS AND MORE
MONTHS ON THAT SHE DID. YOU
REALLY JUST HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE I'M CONNECTING THOSE
DOTS EARLY ENGAGING WITH OUR ART
OUR SISTER DEPARTMENTS AND OF
COURSE AGENCY- TO REALLY MAKE
SURE WE ARE. BUILDING OUT THE
BOX TOGETHER AND FINDING THOSE
DEPENDENCIES ACROSS. THOSE
INITIATIVES- REALLY STANDING UP
A PERFORMANCE IN FIRST. I CAN
STATE. IN REALLY PREPARE FOR
KIND OF DETAIL LAN AND STATE
DESIGN ITEM THAT CURRENTLY THE
STATE THAT WERE IN. OUR RIGHT
NOW THAT NEXT PHASE RALLY THE
KIND OF DETAIL. DESIGN FOR
FUTURE STATE- AND THEN LASTLY OF
COURSE DELIVERING AN
ACCELERATING- YOU KNOW THE FULL
SCALE EFFORTS. IN IMPLEMENTING
THEM AND THEN REFINING THEM OVER
TIME SH THIS INITIATIVE IS LARGE
AND IT WON'T NECESSARILY JUST BE
SOMETHING THAT. GOES LIVE AS IT
IS IN AND IS IT REFINED OVER
TIME IT WILL HAVE TO BE
CONTINUALLY REFINE THE DAYS IN.
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A NUMBER OF
PIECES OF THE CHILDREN YOUTH
THAT NEED TO BE IMPLEMENTED
BEFORE CERTAIN PARTS THAT THERE
IS AN ORDER OF OPERATION. TO
MAKE SURE IT'S SUCCESSFUL
INCLUDING THAT WORKFORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECES- OF.
EVIDENCE BASED GRANTS IN
SCHOOLING BRIDGES YOU REALLY
NEED TO MAKE SURE THOSE THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE ITEMS THAT HAVE
LAID AN IMPLANTED. PRIOR Q. YOU
KNOW VARIOUS OTHER LARGE SCALE
STATEWIDE INITIATIVES THAT ARE
PART OF THIS THIS ITEM. I THINK
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE SCALE AND
COMPLEXITY OF THIS TYPE OF AN
EFFORT- STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT FOCUS FOR
THIS FIRST YEAR HERE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE ENGAGEMENT
STRATEGY INCLUDES MULTIPLE
GOALS- FROM KIND OF KEEPING
STAKEHOLDERS INFORMED ABOUT THE
INITIATIVES ARE GATHERING INPUT
ON PRIORITIES- AND THE CURRENT
DAYS TO KIND OF JOINTLY CO
DESIGNED DENTAL SOLUTIONS WITH
PARTNERS TO IMPLEMENT. THIS
GOING FORWARD- THE ENGAGEMENT
MODELS WILL BURY DEPENDING ON
THE INITIATIVES- OF COURSE YOU
KNOW HOW YOU APPROACH THE-
VIRTUAL PLATFORMS CAN BE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN EVIDENCE BASED-
PIECES AND SO THERE ARE
MULTIPLE. I KNOW STAKEHOLDER
WORKSTREAMS AT. TAKING OFF AND-
IN FACT THE ACS IS WITH AGE IN
OUR SISTER. TO CONDUCT DEPLOY
WHY. CHILDREN YOU'D BE HOW CHECK
UP WHETHER ARE IN MAY MARCH-
WHICH WILL BE- WILL HELP CUT OF
STAR GAUGING X. NEEDY DOING IT.
INTERNAL WORK AROUND- THIS- BUT
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN START TO
REALLY ROCK OUR ARMS ARE. THAT
EXTERNALS TO. ENGAGEMENT TO
WORK. A LOT OF DETAILS. DH WELL
ALSO WATCHING NOT STATES ENGAGE
STRATEGY AND EIGHT. INCLUDE
LAUNCHING. A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TANK- AND CONDUCTING A SERIES OF
ROUNDTABLE MEETINGS WITH KEY
INFORMANTS ARE REALLY TO DRIVE
IN AND START THAT ENGAGEMENT AT
A DEEP LEVEL- THERE WILL BE
MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
INPUT AS WELL SO EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT AT ALL OF THESE FORMAL- AS-
INFORMING INTERVIEWS. WE WILL
HAVE PUBLIC INPUT OPPORTUNITIES
ALONG THE ENGAGEMENT AS WELL.
AND SO NOW I'M KIND OF JUST GO
THROUGH EACH OF THE INITIATIVE
YOU WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
PROVIDING AN UPDATE ACROSS THE
VARIOUS THINGS THAT THE ACS IS
LEADING. US TO KIND OF WALK
THROUGH THOSE VARIOUS AREAS SO
REGARDING THE SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
BETWEEN JULY TWENTY ONE IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWO DEC HAS
CONDUCTED A VERY ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT- AND
EDUCATION BUT WITH BOTH HEALTH
AND EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS WE
DEVELOPED METRICS-
INTERVENTIONS. OUR GOALS ARE FOR
THE DOLLARS AND DETERMINE THE
PAYMENT STRUCTURE FOR THE
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS. IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR DH YES
RECEIVED LETTERS OF INTENT FROM
ALL MEDICARE MEDICARE PLANS ARE
THAT THEY PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THIS
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WHICH IS GREAT
TO SEE. ADDITIONALLY
PARTICIPATING MEDICAID MEDICARE
PLANS I HAVE THATKIND OF PRE
DEFINED GOALS AND METRICS- THEY
WILL AS THEY NEED THOSE THOUGH
THE RECEIVE THE PAYMENTS WERE
ANTICIPATING RELEASING INCENTIVE
HATED STARTING IN OCTOBER. OF
THIS YEAR FOR THAT INITIATIVE.
REGARDING THE SCHOOL LINK
PARTNERSHIP AND CAPACITY GRANTS
IDEAS YES- HAS JUST STARTED- OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS PARTICULAR ACTIVITY- AND
ARE SEEKING VARIETY. OF INPUT
ACROSS MULTIPLE SECTORS
INCLUDING EDUCATION. AND WILL BE
REALLY WRAPPING OUR ARMS AROUND
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE- WE ARE
REALLY FOCUSING ON GRANT DESIGN
AN ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA TO
START. BUT WE PLAN TO RELEASE
THE GRAND THE FUNDING FOR THIS.
TO FOLLOW OF TWENTY. YEAH PERIOD
I THAT- THAT WOULD BE OPEN
THROUGH DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR-
WE ARE INTO HIS. PAIN WOULD
BEGIN FLOWING IN EARLY TWO
TWENTIES- AND GRANTS AND IT'S AN
WILL ADMIN THROUGH A THIRD PARTY
. WHICH THE DEPARTMENT IS
ACTIVELY WORKING TO YOU. BRING
ON AT THIS TIME AS WELL SO WE'RE
KIND OF BUILDING UP THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE STARTING
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT TO
DEFINE. THESE PIECES WITH THE
HOPES OF GETTING THOSE GRANTS
AND APPLICATIONS OUT BY THE END
OF THE YEAR. REGARDING THE
GRANTS TO KIND OF SCALE OF
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES IT'S A
SIMILAR TIME LINE THAT YOU'D
EXPECT. A REALLY FOCUSING ON
STAKEHOLDERS THE FIRST THING
THAT WE NEED TO DO IS ENGAGE
THAT THINK TANK THAT I WAS
MENTIONING TO COLLECT THE-
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SCALE UP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AND REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE USING
ROBUST EVIDENCE FOR
EFFECTIVENESS. IMPACT ON RACIAL
EQUITY ASSISTING ABILITY. IMPACT
TO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
AND SO I WILL BE FOCUSING FIRST
ON THAT- AS WE EGAGE OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WORK TAKING THAT
OFF IN MARCH OF. THIS YEAR SO
THAT'S RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER-
WE WILL BE USING THAT AGAIN TO
REALLY DEFINE ULTIMATELY WHICH
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES WILL DO
HI WE WILL DESIGN- THOSE
APPLICATIONS THEN- ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA. AND THEN ROLLING THOSE
OUT ON A SIMILAR FASHION ALL BY
B. THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HM IT'S GOING IN TWENTY THREE.
ALSO WILL BE DONE BY A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE STATEWIDE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH VIRTUAL
SERVICES PLATFORM. AND E.
CONSOLE PLATFORM BUT WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH PARTNERS
TO COMPLETE A COMPREHENSIVE
MARKET SKI ON ART AND LANDSCAPE
ANALYSIS TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
CAPABILITIES FOR THE SERVICE
PLATFORM. BEGINNING IN APRIL OF
TWENTY TWO AND CONTINUING
THROUGH THE SUMMER IDA CS WILL
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THE NATIONAL AND STATE LEVEL
SUBJECT MATTER. EXPERTS ARE
THROUGH MULTIPLE FORM MS TIPPED
. IN ON DESIGN CAPABILITY OF THE
- IN BUDGET THAT. WILL YOUR A
BUSINESS SERVICE BY TO LAUNCH
THE BIRCH POP. AND YOU SALT- AND
WE'RE STILL WORKING TO REALLY
DID THE BEST. PROCUREMENT OF FOR
EXAMPLE WE DON'T KNOW IF THERE
WILL BE MULTIPLE PROCUREMENTS OR
IF THERE WILL BE ONE- AND SO WE
ARE CONTINUING TO DO THAT AS WE
DIG INTO THAT- NATIONALS. ON A
DH CSIS ON TRACK TO EMPLOYMENT
DYADIC SERVICES AND JANUARY
TWENTY THREE- AND REGARDING- THE
CAL HOPE STUDENT SERVICES- THAT
IS SUPPORTED IN THE INITIATIVE.
REALLY THE GOAL HERE IS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE
IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY-
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. TO REALLY
ENHANCE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS I DH CS IN
COLLABORATION WITH KEY PARTNERS
IS ENGAGING USE OF PARTNERS AND
CONTRIBUTING TO POSITIVE.
SUPPORTIVE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT'S GOALS TO HAVE
CONTRACTS AT ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. BY JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND LASTLY REGARDING
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SCHOOL
LINKS A STATEWIDE FEE SCHEDULE
IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDER
NETWORK- DH CS WELL. I'M
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MHC ARE
WILL BE DEVELOPING AND
MAINTAINING. A SCHOOLING
STATEWIDE FEE SCHEDULE AND A
STATEWIDE PROVIDER NETWORK OF
SCHOOL SITE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS FOR OUTPATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH OR- SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE AGE OF.
TWENTY FIVE OF COURSE I'M
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
WORKSTREAM WILL BEGIN SOMEWHERE
AROUND APRIL OR MAY- AND- WE
WOULD BE. YOU KNOW NOT
IMPLEMENTING THIS INTEL COURSE
LATER DOWN THE ROAD SO I JUST
STARTED THOSE ENGAGEMENTS AND
DISCUSSIONS. SHORTLY SO THAT IS
THE CONCLUSION OF MY UPDATE ON
HOW TO GET YOUR QUESTIONS THE
TIME IS RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING. NOTICE COMMENTS ARE
FINANCE THANKS THANK YOU EARLIER
. THANK YOU SENT ADMIN I WE HAVE
ANY ANY FOR COMMENTS ON THIS
ISSUE OKAY THANK YOU- DIRECTOR.
ON THE SCHOOL TO HEALTH. OF
THOSE GRANTS ARE ALREADY OUT THE
SERVICE ALREADY BEING PROVIDED
DOES THAT CORRECT. I'M SO WE
HAVE TO FINISH THE DESIGN
ELEMENTS WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUP- AND THE WE'VE GIVEN ALL
THE DIRECTION TO THE MANAGED
CARE PLAN AND ALL MANAGED CARE
PLANS HAVE SAID THEY INTEND TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE- THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM- BUT- LET ME
JUST SEE IF WENDY HARRINGTON HAS
ANY UPDATES IN REGARDS TO. A WIN
ALL OF THAT WILL START ACTUALLY
FLOWING. BUT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THAT WILL START FLOWING I
BELIEVE IT IS OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS WHAT WE ANTICIPATE
THE FUNDS WILL START FLOWING
INTO THE MANAGED CARE PLANS FOR
MEETING. THEIR METRICS. OKAY
THANK YOU GOOD IF WE THAT I WAS
FROM THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SO THAT'S THERE'S ALREADY THE
MONEY'S ALREADY OUT THERE FOR
THE PLANNING AND THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE GRANTS CORRECT. YES SO
WE'VE GIVEN THE DIRECTION IN
REGARDS TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO
SUBMIT THERE'S A THERE'S A KIND
OF FEW MEASURES. SO YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY SUBMIT THEIR PLAN
THERE'S A PAYMENT THAT THEY HAVE
TO MEET METRICS ALONG THE WAY-
AND SO THIS ONE IS WELL ON ITS
WAY WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH INDIVIDUALS
HERE. AND HAPPY THAT EVERYBODY-
PICKED UP THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN IN
REGARDS TO THE- ADULT THE MOBILE. THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES
INTO THE SUPPORT PLATFORM HOW
WILL THAT I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE GOING TO GO OUT LOOK TO
SEE IF SOMEBODY CAN DO THAT BUT
HOW WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT
IT TIES BACK. TO OUR TO OUR NINE
EIGHT EIGHT AND THE MOBILE
CRISIS TEAMS. IT ACTUALLY HAD
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THAT I
THINK IT'LL DEFINITELY BE ONE OF
THE PIECES THAT NEED TO BE
DISCUSSED IN AGENCIES NINETY
DAYS. STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS TWO YEARS THIS WALL
COURSE GET THE TABLE WITH THAT
ARM BAR LEAVES INTERNALLY SHORT
LEADING THE CHILDREN USE A
WORKER ALSO VERY ENGAGED IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I DON'T HAVE A
DIRECT ANSWER FOR YOU YET BUT WE
ARE TRACKING THE NEEDING
CONNECTION THERE AND THE CODE
AND SEE IF THOSE ITEMS. THAT'S I
THINK IT'S IT IS EXCITING TO
HAVE ALL KINDS OF NEW PROGRAMS
AND IT'S ALSO. YOU KNOW I'M GLAD
YOU'RE THERE TO BE EVERYONE FOR
KEEPING TRACK OF ALL THIS MONEY
AND THE OVERLAP ATTENTION
OVERLAP. AND REDUNDANCY OF THE
PROGRAMS AND THEN WE KNOW. THAT
TAKES AWAY FROM ACTUAL DIRECT
CLIENT CONTACT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THAT
WHICH SYSTEM. THEY SHOULD BE
INVOLVED IN. A DIRT PATH. THANK
YOU AND- AND I KNOW WE HAD A
CHANCE TO HEAR SOME OF THESE
ELEMENTS. IN A PRIOR HEARING
THAT- NOT WITH THE TEST BUT SOME
OF THE OTHER AGENCIES SO-
PATRICK BAGS COUPLE QUESTIONS SO
ON THE DYADIC SERVICES- THERE
WAS A PEDIATRICIAN OF COURSE
SALE RIGHT NOW LET'S TAKE CARE
OF I TAKE A CHILD BUT I KNOW THE
FAMILY HAS A TREMENDOUS
INFLUENCE- AND- FROM THE CHILD'S
HEALTH CERTAINLY WE WORK WITH
FAMILIES. D. HI HOW DO YOU SEE
THAT ACT SERVICES WORKING WIND-
WITH IT WITH PROVIDERS LIKE
PEDIATRICIANS OR ARE WE ALLOWED
TO BUILD IN FOR SERVICE FOR THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO THE
PARENTS. BUT YES SO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF. ADDITIONAL CODES THAT
WILL BE ROLLING OUT. RUSSIANS OF
COURSE WILL BE ELIGIBLE TO ACT A
BILL FOR THOSE SERVICES- THERE
ARE CRITERIA FOR WHEN AND HOW
YOU BUILD THOSE EVEN IF YOU'RE
SEEING THAT THE CHILD FOR
EXAMPLE BUT THAT- THAT YOU
COORDINATION- THAT WORK IS WITH
THE APPARENT ON WE WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ISSUE A LOT OF-
GUIDANCE IN DETAILS AROUND THIS
HAPPY TO GET THAT TO YOU. A
SENATOR PAN SO YOU CAN LOOK AT
THAT- AND HAVE ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT'S NEEDED AS WELL
YEAH BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS
CHILD COMES INTO THE CLINIC
THEY'RE REGISTERED RIGHT. WE'RE
NOW SEEING THE CHILD WITH THE
FAMILY AND THEN WE PROVIDE
SERVICES THEN DO WE HAVE TO
CHECK IN THE FAMILY. SO JUST TO
BE SURE WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T MAKE IT OVERLY
COMPLICATED- IN TERMS OF WIND
WINDSHIELD PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES- AND THEN. IN REGARDS.
TO THE PLATFORM- SO I KNOW YOU
GUYS A SO. AND THIS. WAS A- YEAH
I MEAN THIS IS ONE OF THE
CENTERPIECE. OF THIS INITIATIVE
SOME AND ANYTIME WE'RE STARTING
TO TALK ABOUT IT PLATFORMS- YOU
KNOW LIKE TO AVOID ANY PROBLEMS-
SO. I MEAN ARE WE LOOK AT I KNOW
YOU'RE GATHERING INFO AND SO
FORTH BUT I MEAN IT IS THE
INTENTION TO GO TO A CONTRACTOR
AND BUILD THIS THING FROM GROUND
UP YEAH- WE ARE THEIR EXISTING
PLATFORMS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT HAVE BEEN READY USE
UNTESTED. THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
POTENTIALLY LICENSING I GUESS-
YES OF IT DEFINITELY WOULD BE
THE LATTER WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BUILD SOMETHING FROM
SCRATCH- IT'S NOT TECHNICALLY AN
IT PROJECT WE ARE GOING TO
PROCURE SOMEONE ELSE'S SYSTEM I
JUST TO BE CLEAR THAT'S WHY
WE'RE DOING THAT NATIONAL STAND
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
ENTITIES TO DO. THIS TODAY-
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE DONE IT
OTHER STATES HAVE WATCH SIMILAR
PIECES WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT
NATIONAL SCANS SO WE CAN FIGURE
OUT WHAT ARE THE VARIOUS
SERVICES OUT THERE WILL NEED ALL
OF OUR NEEDS OR DO WE NEED TO
DO- AN INTEGRATED MODEL WHERE
WE'RE KIND OF PULLING A FEW
PIECES OR IS THERE A VENDOR WHO
CAN. MEET ALLOF OUR NEEDS WITH
DIFFERENT MODULES AND SO THAT'S
CURRENTLY THE RESEARCH THAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW- IN
INTERVIEWING AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH- SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS IN THIS SPACE-
AND SO- YOU DON'T HAVE A DIRECT
ANSWER RIGHT NOW BUT THAT'S THE
EXACT TYPE OF REVIEW THAT WE ARE
DOING COMPREHENSIVELY ACROSS
ACROSS THE NATION RIGHT NOW AND
- REALLY HELPFUL AND I THINK
I'VE ASKED THIS BEFORE BUT IT BE
HELPFUL IN THIS NON TERMS OF
WHICH WHEN YOU GOT A LICENSE OR
SOMETHING BUT- IF YOU'RE DOING
THIS AGAIN SAYING THAT. THESE
ARE THE EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE
OUT THERE THAT AT LEAST TWO WERE
YOU KNOW WE THINK ARE EXAMPLES
OF WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO RIGHT
NOW WHETHER YOU END UP LICENSING
THAT ONE OR SOMETHING ELSE OR
SOMETHING YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THAT'S THAT'S A DIFFERENT ISSUE.
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS HEAR ABOUT
THIS PLATFORM WE SEE THE
PLATFORM IS GOING TO DO X. Y.
AND Z. BUT IT BE HELPFUL TO SAY
OKAY IN OUR SKIN. THIS IS THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE KIND OF LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S LIKE OKAY WE
HAD THERE'S A PLATFORM OUT AND
YOU KNOW THIS STATE OR THIS
COUNTRY THAT DOES THIS AND SO.
THIS IS SOMETHING THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE. OF HOW IT CAN BE DONE.
AND HOW WELL IT'S WORKED EIGHT.
THE IT IS SO IT'S A OF FEEL THE
- WE THIS PLATFORM. IT'S A
LITTLE NEBULOUS OUT THERE. ABOUT
THESE. WHAT IT. GOING TO ME WE
HAVE A DISK. OF TO THINGS IT'S
POTENTIALLY GOING TO DO BUT IT'S
- I'M ALWAYS A LITTLE MORE
ANXIOUS ABOUT SO. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TESTED. EXAMPLES THAT SHOWS
THAT WE CAN DO THIS AND HOW WELL
DO THEY ACTUALLY WORK. AS WAS
WERE ABOUT TO. YOU KNOW AT
LEAST- BUDGETED TO SPEND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE ON THIS. SO
IT'S A BIG CHUNK OF MONEY- AND
AS I THINK KELLY IS SO YOU'RE
DOING THE SCAN AGAIN THIS IS NOT
TRYING TO. GUESS WHO YOU'RE
FINALLY GOT A LICENSE BUT JUST-
LIKE HEY WHAT ARE SOME EXAMPLES
YOU CAN SHARE WITH US TO SAY.
THAT THE GIVE US A MORE CONCRETE
EXAMPLES. OF WHAT YOU'RE HOPING
THE PLATFORMS IT IS ABLE TO DO
WITH IT WITH THIS TEST WITH AN
EXAMPLE THAT ACTUALLY. HAS
DEMONSTRATED- IT WORKS. YES THE
WE BACK. ALSO LOOKED. AND
AUSTRIA. HAVE A GOOD MODELS OUT
THERE WE ACTUALLY MET WITH
CANADA- AND WHAT THEY PUT UP- I.
HAVE LEARNED A LOT FROM THEM. I
THINK. OUR CURRENT SCHEDULES
THERE'S ABOUT OVER YOU KNOW TWO
HUNDRED DIFFERENT PLATFORMS TO
DATE- AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
CATEGORIZING THOSE BY
CAPABILITY- WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON ONES
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND NOT. ALL OF THE
PLATFORMS HAVE A HISTORY OF. OF
THAT INTERSECTION AND SO AGREE
WITH YOU WE WANT TO LEARN FROM
OTHERS WHO HAVE DONE THIS
ALREADY. ARE WE ONE OF THAT
THOSE PIECES AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE- ON ON THOSE.
CONVERSATIONS OKAY AND I THINK
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO. START
IDENTIFYING WHICH PLATFORMS I
PRESUME YOU'RE ENGAGING. LIKE
THE PART TECHNOLOGY AND OTHERS
WHO. YOU HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND PERHAPS
SYSTEMS OF CARE. ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE TO BE SURE WE
HAVE A PLATFORM THAT GROWS. AND
EVOLVES AND DOESN'T THAT. THE IT
JUST GET OUT YOU. THIS FIX AND
GETS OUT DATE I AGREE IT IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THERE WILL THERE
WILL BE PHASES TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION THERE WILL BE NEW
YOU KNOW FUNCTIONS THAT WILL
COME OUT LATER WE'LL HAVE TO
HAVE A MINIMUM SET OF PIECES BUT
WE AGREE WITH YOU THIS IS AN
EVOLUTION WHERE WE WILL HAVE TO.
CONTINUALLY BE EVOLVING AND
LOOKING AT WHAT IT OFFERS- AND
SO YOU KNOW WE ARE APPROACHING
IT WITH THAT SAME FRAME OF MIND
AS YOU ARE YOUR REFERENCE AND
THEN OF COURSE- IT USUALLY WHEN
IT SYSTEMS DON'T WORK IT'S
ACTUALLY HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT. THIS WITH THE SYSTEM SO
AND- THE END USERS FIND THAT THE
SYSTEM IS NOT VERY FUNCTIONAL
FOR THEM SO- WELL TO FIGURE OUT
SO HOPEFULLY YOU ARE ALSO AND
HOW IS THIS STILL FURTHER DOWN
THE ROAD BUT- WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO ENGAGE THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
INTERFACE WITH THE SYSTEM
WHETHER IT'S- PLANS ARE
PROVIDERS ARE. PATIENTS OR
PATIENTS FAMILIES AT CETERA TO
BE SURE THAT THIS. THIS
PLATFORM. IT IS THE DAY OF THE
INTERFACES ARE ONES THAT- AND
MAKE IT YOU KNOW. D. EASY ENOUGH
TO USE AND IS INVITING FOR
PEOPLE TO USE OTHERWISE. HELLO
TO OUR PLATFORM THAT NO ONE USES
. I AGREE WE FULLY PLAN ON
ENGAGING WITH- WITH CHILDREN
YOUTH FAMILIES TO BE. END USER
I. TESTING FOR US AND INPUT FROM
BOTH THE BEGINNING DESIGN
PROCESS ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM BUILD THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO US. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE- USEFUL AND HELPFUL FOR
THEM AND THAT WE WORK OUT SOME
OF THOSE- JINX- YOU KNOW WITH
THEIR ODD YOU KNOW FRAME OF MIND
AT AT THE CORE FOCUS OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO WE AGREE. WITH
WITH THAT SENTIMENT OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL AS I SAID THIS IS THE
I MEAN THIS PLATFORM IS A MAJOR
INVESTMENTS- THERE'S BEEN A LOT
PROMISED FOR THE PLATFORM- AT
EIGHT EIGHT AM.  LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT THAT- IN THE SENSE THAT I
JUST WANNA BE SURE WE'RE NOT
OVER. COMMITTING TO- DESCENDED
PLATFORM'S GONNA SOLVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROBLEMS WHICH I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT. SAYING NECESSARILY
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO SET
APPROPRIATE EXPECTATIONS FOR
WHAT WE CAN GET FROM THE
PLATFORM. PLAY BUT- I UNDERSTAND
THE PLATFORM IS SUPPOSED TO TRY
TO PULL THINKING ON THAT THINGS
TOGETHER. AND AND I THINK IT'S
GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO SET
THE APPROPRIATE EXPECTATIONS AND
CERTAINLY- UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
FOR IT PROJECTS I DON'T KNOW I
MENTIONED THAT TO. THANKS THE
FOR THE DETAILS IT PRIDE AS WHEN
THEY WORK WELL THEY DON'T MAKE
THE NEWS ON THIS DON'T WORK
THAT'S WHEN THEY MAKE THE NEWS.
AND SO. WE'D LIKE THIS TO NOT
MAKE THE NEWS BUT WE WANT
EVERYONE TO KNOW ABOUT IT LET'S
PUT IT THAT WAY. THANK YOU I
AGREE THOSE ARE GREAT PRINCIPLES
TO EMBRACE WITH. HIS PROJECT-
AND WE AGREE WE DON'T WANT TO
OVER PROMISE YOUR I THINK THAT'S
WHY WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS AND-
WE'RE TRYING TO TREAD LIGHTLY
BEFORE WE REALLY KIND OF.
OUTLINE FOR PEOPLE EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING TO BE IN IN THE
SYSTEM AND WHAT IT CAN DO. IT
AND REALLY TRY TO. LAY OUT A
ROAD MAP OF WHAT IT COULD LOOK
LIKE- OVER MULTIPLE YEARS OF
VARIOUS FUNCTIONS AND FEATURES
BEING ADDED TO IT AND SO. ON WE
AGREE WITH THAT AND THAT IS HOW
WE WILL BE APPROACHING AT NIGHT
AND I THINK THAT CAN BE HARD FOR
PEOPLE BECAUSE THAT. IT'S
EXCITING IT'S A IT'S A GREAT NEW
OPPORTUNITY IT'S A LARGE
INVESTMENT AS YOU'RE MENTIONING.
BUT WE DO NEED TO BE THOUGHTFUL
WE DO NEED TO BUILD IT RIGHT AND
THAT DOES TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME IS THAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
THAT DUE DILIGENCE ON THE UP
FRONT PART. I HAD TO DO THE BEST. YOU CAN. OKAY THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU VERY. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL FOR ALL. ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
- I SAW OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPANDED MEDICAID
COVERAGE TO CHILDREN YOUNG
ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS AGE
FIFTY AND OVER REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THE BUDGET
BUILDS ON THOSE EXPANSION AND
INCLUDES EIGHT HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN MILLION. SIX HUNDRED
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND- IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND TWO POINT
THREE BILLION A ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
OUT FULL IMPLEMENTATION. EXPAND
FULL SCOPE ELIGIBILITY TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS AGE
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FORTY NINE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
IS TO BE BEGINNING NO SOONER
THAN JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. BY REMOVING A BARRIER TO
HELP ACCESS DUE TO IMMIGRATION
STATUS THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
PROVIDES COVERAGE TO THE
REMAINING AGE GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT AN EYE
DOCTOR. AND SATISFACTORY
IMMIGRATION STATUS WOULD ENSURE
THAT ALL LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
DOGS HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO
COMPREHENSIVE AND AFFORDABLE
CARE. WE KNOW ECHO SO TO HEALTH
. OFTEN LEADS TO IMPROVED HEALTH
OUTCOMES FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
WORKER PRODUCTIVITY. WE ARE
PROPOSING A JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- START DATE TO
ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS EXPANSION
WILL ADD APPROXIMATELY. SEVEN
HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
ADDITIONAL MEDICARE ENROLLEES
AND IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
EXPANSION OF MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY IN RECENT YEARS. AS
SUCH THIS TRANSITION WILL
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE COORDINATION
BETWEEN DH CS. COUNTY PARTNERS
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
STAKEHOLDERS- WE NEED TO DO
DEVELOPMENT OF POLICY GUIDANCE
AND NOTICES FOR AFFECTED
INDIVIDUALS TO INFORM. THEM OF
THE INSPECT EXPANSION. I
INFORMATION TO THOSE ENROLLED IN
. SCOPE MEDI CAL ABOUT THE
TRANSITION TO FULL SCOPE
COVERAGE WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
MEDICAL RATES AND MANAGED CARE
PLAN NETWORK ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS ARE APPROPRIATELY
ADJUSTED TO REFLECT THEIR BROKE
INTERNAL MEANT OF THESE
ADDITIONAL MEDIC HOW- ENROLLEES.
BETWEEN NOW AND JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR MANY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY INVESTMENTS
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED RELATIVE
TO MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY
INCLUDING RESUMING THE
ELIGIBILITY READ DETERMINATIONS
DUE TO THE END OF THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
ELIMINATION OF THE MEDICAL
ASPECT TEST- FEES ONE HUNDRED
BAGS RAISING DOUBTS THAT LIMIT
YEAH UNDER THIRTY THOUSAND
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. CONSOLIDATION OF
COUNTY ELIGIBILITY SYSTEMS INTO
ONE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM OUR SIZE AS REQUIRED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THAT
MIGRATION IS TO BEGIN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ZERO. I AND AS A
RESULT THE SALT WILL BE IN A
STATE OF TREES WERE THEY CANNOT
MAKE ANY PROGRAM CHANGES UNTIL
THEY FULLY MIGRATE TO CAL STAR.
IN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
I THIS PROPOSAL CANNOT BE PHASED
IN BY GROUP AT EACH PHASE
ESSENTIALLY EQUATES THE SAME
LEVEL OF EFFORT BOTH RIPPON AND
FIRST. OF THE FULL I. PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD BE IT COULD
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THESE
POLICY CHANGES AND SYSTEM
CHANGES NECESSARY STATES THE
PROPOSED START DATE OF JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. I
CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU A DIFFERENT FINANCE. NOTHING
ELSE TO ADD GREAT HELLO. THANK
YOU MOREOVER THE ALLEGED ANALYST
OFFICE- BASICALLY MINISTRATIONS
AT ESTIMATES THE PROPOSAL WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF UNINSURED CALIFORNIANS. THE
MINISTER IS FOR THIS EXPANSION
ALONG WITH THE EXPANSION FOR
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS AGE FIFTY
AND OLDER WHICH WAS APPROVED
LAST YEAR WE ROUGHLY ESTIMATE
THAT THE UNINSURED POPULATION
STATE REDUCED BY ABOUT ONE
MILLION PEOPLE WHICH IS ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF THE UNINSURED
POPULATION. WE DO WANT TO RAISE
A FEW ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL- FIRST
WE ARE CONTINUED EVALUATING
ESTIMATE KEYSTONE COST I KNOW
THAT ANY SUCH. EXPANSION ON ITS
SUBJECT TO CONSIDERABLE
UNCERTAINTY INSIDE THE ACTUAL
CASE LOADING COSTS COULD BE
DIFFERENT. SECOND WE WANT TO
KNOW THAT EXTENDED TIME FRAME TO
EXPANSION IN ACCESS TO COME.
YOUR IMPLEMENTATION TIME FRAME
SOME TO POP EXPERIENCE COULD
IMPROVE OUR TO HEALTH CARE SOON
. AND NO- THE EXTENDED TIME
FRAME COULD BE PARTICULARLY. FOR
PEOPLE WHO WOULD AGE OUT OF FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL IF THEY TURN
TWENTY SIX PRIOR TO GENERATE ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IT'S SUCH
CASES THESE INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE
SHIFTED. TO LIMITED SCOPE MEDI
CAL AND THEN WE MOVED ACK TO
FULL STOP AFTER JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR BECAUSE OF
THE LAPSE IN COVERAGE WE
ESTIMATE THAT ROUGHLY FORTY
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG
ADULTS WHO CURRENTLY HAVE FULL
COVERAGE WOULD LOSE THEIR
COVERAGE AS A RESULT OF THIS.
PRIOR TO JANUARY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- THIS NUMBER TO WE
HIDE. DUE TO. THE FEDERAL.
POLICY DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THAT EFFECTIVELY
PROHIBITS TERMINATING.
ELIGIBILITY WHILE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY IS IN FACT A
COUPLE MINUTES CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS IS A LOT UNDER NOT GOING
YOUNG AND OLD ENJOY TWENTY AND
WHAT IT MUST COVER DURING THE
CALL A COUPLE TREE TANK-
MINISTRATION NOTED THERE WOULD
BE CHALLENGES- TO AN EARLIER
EXPANSION AND WE RECOGNIZE THESE
CHALLENGES ARE VERY REAL-
HOWEVER WE THINK THAT A MORE
INCREMENTAL APPROACH COULD
EXPAND COVERAGE FASTER OR- WITH
MORE MANAGEABLE. MANAGEABLE
WORKLOAD IN HOT BEEN DOING A
FULL EXPANSION SOONER. FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
TAKE STEPS TO PREVENT THE LOSS
OF CUB FOODS GO COVERAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO AGE OUT OF COVERAGE
PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. IT WOULD BE HAPPY
TO DISCUSS POTENTIAL WAYS THIS
COULD BE DONE WITH THE LEAD
CHANGING THE MINISTRATION- SUCH
AS BY A CONTINUING TO- NOT TO
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS. FOR
THE IMPACT OF COPULATION. WE
WERE. I'M NOT EXCEPT. ISN'T IN
INDORE AN EX. TIMELINE FOR ALL
OF THE- IN BY THE PROPOSED. BUT
THERE. CHURCH ABROAD INFORMATION
FEES AND ADMINISTRATOR COSTS AND
K. OF AN ABOUT. AN ALTERNATIVE
MENTAL APPROACH. AND THAT THESE
POTENTIAL. COULD NOT KNOW SO
NEEDING THE ALL RAISED. TWO
AVERAGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WILL JUST SAY I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE VERY-
INVESTED IN THIS IS IN- WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE IT HAPPEN
SOONER THAN LATER SO I WOULD I
WOULD ASK- DIRECT BOSS IF YOU
COULD. LOOK AT- SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS AT THE LA- MADE
ABOUT GETTING THIS EXPEDITED-
AND THEN PRESENTING THAT TO US
AT THE LITTLE BIT LATER DATE. AT
THAT IF WE CAN DO IT OR NOT. OUR
DEFENSE. YEAH I- FULLY AGREE AND
I GUESS THAT THAT AND THAT'S
OBVIOUS RECORD ACTUALLY-
DIRECTOR BUS YOU MENTIONED THAT
IN THE TRANSITION. FOR MEDICAL
INTO SAWS THAT. IT CAN REMIND ME
WHICH WHICH WHAT THEY HEARD WAS
THAT WHAT HAPPENED A TIED TAKES
OVER THE HELLO OVER A WHOLE YEAR
OR SOMETHING WHERE WE BASICALLY
SAID WE CAN'T MAKE ANY
ELIGIBILITY CHANGES AT ALL.
BECAUSE OF THE TRANSITION THAT I
HEAR THAT CORRECTLY THE
MIGRATION- GRACIOUS. NEAR ME
MMHM YES YES THE MIGRATION
BEGINS AT. OVER TWENTY TWENTY-
AND AS A RESULT I'M SAHGAL BEING
ESSENTIALLY STATED FREEZE- OR
PROGRAM CHANGES CANNOT BE MADE
UNTIL WE'RE FULLY MIGRATED
CALZADA IN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. OKAY SO THIS. COOKBOOK I
MEAN THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KNOW NOT ONLY FOR THIS FOR A LOT
OF OTHER THNGS SO. YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT THE MIGRATION-
AND AGAIN I KNOW YOU'RE DHS
DIRECTOR SO I DON'T KNOW IF
OTHER PROGRAMS ALSO GET AFFECTED
AS WELL. SO I THINK IT'S FUN FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND THAT- ETWEEN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
OCTOBER TWENTY THREE THERE CAN'T
BE ANY CHANGES SO WHILE YOU'RE
DOING THE MIGRATION OF THE- I
WOULD DEFINITELY DEFER TO THAT-
OFF THE SYSTEM INTEGRATION IN
THE SAAS PROJECT- THE SPECIFICS
BUT THERE ARE WAYS THAT FROM
THAT TIME LINES OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YOU AT YEAH AT FIRST
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
THERE ARE WAVES. OF PHASES IN
OVER THE COUNTIES- AND SO I
THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING TRYING
TO LIMIT ANY CHANGES THROUGH
THAT THAT YOUR PUREED CHIP
ENSURE STABILITY OF THE OF THE
HOUSE IS DOWN OKAY ALL RIGHT
THAT'S WHERE I PAY LESS
ATTENTION TO IT SYSTEMS. JUST
LIKE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
PLATFORM BEFORE OKAY SO I THINK
YOU'D BE GOOD TO GET CLARITY ON
THAT BECAUSE AS WE'RE HEARING
NOT ONLY OF COURSE YOUR AGENCY
BUT OTHERS- I THINK WE NEED
CLARITY AS TO- WAS OR MAKE.
POLICY TO. WERE WE'RE ABLE TO DO
NOT BECAUSE OF THESE TECHNICAL
ISSUES AND I GUESS THE OHER
QUESTION THOUGH IS IT AS MUCH AS
IT'S NOT IDEAL- MAKE A POLICY
CHANGE ARE THERE. WELL YOU DON'T
WANT TO DESTABILIZE THE
COMPUTERS AND IT AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS BUT OVER A WHOLE YEAR-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE THINGS ARE
GONNA HAPPEN RIGHT. BECAUSE IT'S
NOT DONE THAT OTHER THINGS MAY
HAPPEN AND SO FORTH WHERE WE
NEED TO HAVE A POLICY RESPONSE.
AND WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT-
THEY'RE GOING TO BE. I MEAN WE
CAN'T TELL PEOPLE WELL BECAUSE
OUR COMPUTERS MOVING WE CAN'T
HELP YOU. SO IS I MEAN I THINK
PART OF IT'S ALSO GONNA HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT LIKE WHAT ARE THE
WORKAROUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE. IF WE DO HAVE TO MAKE
AN URGENT POLICY CHANGE- WELL
THEY COULD COME. SAYS MAY ME NOT
BE ABLE TO. I MEAN THAT. DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT- TO SIGNIFICANT
TECHNICAL. BUT. I DON'T WANT TO-
YOU KNOW HOW PEOPLE SUFFER FOR
YOU BECAUSE- BECAUSE- BECAUSE WE
CAN'T RESPOND. SO SO BUT THAT
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE IT'S A THIS
IS- IT'S FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WE STILL HAVE. SEVEN
MONTHS BEFORE. THE SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND- WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT WHAT THINGS WE NEED
TO. PUT IN PLACE THAT WE CAN PUT
IN PLACE TO PERHAPS MOVE
TRANSITIONS FASTER. BEFORE WE
GET INTO THIS- TECHNICAL WINDOW.
AS WELL AS WELL SO- WE ARE
INSTANTLY WE HAVE THIS THIS IS A
THIS EXPANSION IS. NOT AND OF
COURSE I'M NOT GONNA SAY IT'S
EASY. BECAUSE I'M NOT THE ONE
WHO HAS TO DO THE WORK BUT IT'S
PRETTY MUCH UNPARALLELED LOOK
SOMETHING WE'VE DONE BEFORE
EIGHT WERE YOU DOING IT FOR THE
OVER. SIX WE ALWAYS VERY KIND OF
FOR THE- SO WE WOULD THINK THAT
AT LEAST WE'RE NOT ASKING. THE
AGENCY TO DO SOMETHING BRAND
NEW. THE QUESTION IS CAN IS
THERE A WAY WE CAN DO IT. MORE
QUICKLY IN A WAY THAT- IF
THERE'S A TECHNICAL WINDOW THAT
WE HAVE TO AVOID. THIS IS THERE
A WAY WE CAN SET OF SYSTEMS.
THAT CAN- THE- THAT CAN BECOME.
BEFORE THE- WINDOW. DOWN I GUESS
BEGINS. I WOULD JUST NOTE THIS
EXPANSION THREE TIMES WHAT WE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING AND- AND
MADE HER OLDER DAUGHTER
EXPANSION SO THERE'S ALSO
NETWORK ADEQUACY AND READ-
CONVERSATIONS THAT WOULD NEED TO
HAPPEN I'M IN ADDITION TO THE
SYSTEM CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED YEAH WELL IT'S THIS
WAY- YOU KNOW CAN WE GET THE
SYSTEM STUFF AND I REALIZE THAT
USUALLY YOU DO THE SYSTEMS AFTER
YOU HAVE THE AGREEMENTS BUT I
MEAN IF THEY THINK. YEAH WELL I
THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING
THIS FORWARD AND REALLY
APPRECIATED BUT I ALSO KNOW
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS DEMAND FOR
HEALTH CARE RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY WITH A PANDEMIC
GOING ON- I REALIZE THAT-
THERE'S OTHERS THAT BUT THERE'S
A TECHNICAL PROBLEM IS THERE A
WAY TO AT LEAST GET. THE
TECHNICAL STUFF TEED UP- SO TO
PREVENT THE PEOPLE THEY- SET.
AND THEN- THEN I DON'T WANT TO
GET SOUND SIMPLER THAN IT
ACTUALLY IS- IT AND THEN THINK
ABOUT LIKE WHAT THIS FATHER
AGREEMENTS NEED TO BE MADE TO
FINALIZE THIS- SO. ALL RIGHT.
I'M SURE YOU'LL TRY YOUR BEST
BUT I THINK WE'RE INTERESTED
TRYING TO MOVE THIS UP. SENATOR
NOT. I SEE THE EARLIER WITH HIS
HAND UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON THE
AMERICAN ON SO. FINAL MORE
CONTACTS REGARDING THE COUNCIL'S
IMPLEMENTATION IT'S EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES THAT WOULD BE MOVED-
INTO CAL SOLACE BETWEEN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- IN TERMS OF
THAT FREEZE IT WOULD NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT CHANGES COULD HAPPEN
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD HOWEVER
IT WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN THE
NEED TO PROCESS THOSE CHANGES ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS SO ANY CASE
STUDY IN HOW TO MAKE THE POLICY
CHANGE MAY BE DONE MANUALLY.
THIS COULD CREATE- NOT ONLY
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD BUT RISKS IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
INFORMATION IS ENTERED CORRECTLY
INTO THE SYSTEM- LATER ON THE
INTERNET TRANSITION BY THE WAY
THAT SINCERITY SINCE YOU'RE
EXPLAINED YEP THAT'S TAKING
PLACE OVER A YEAR IS THAT
BECAUSE IT MEANS THAT FORTY
EIGHTEEN COUNTY IS IT JUST THAT
BETWEEN THE WHOLE YEARS IT
BECAUSE OVER THE YEARS CERTAIN
COUNTIES WILL BE AT CERTAIN
POINTS IN. THE COUNTIES OF THE
OTHER POINTS RIGHT- I'M JUST
WONDERING WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
WILL BUY A YEAR OUR OUR A YEAR
BECAUSE IT WE DO THIS COUNTY FOR
THE NEXT COUNTY THE NEXT AND SO
. YES THAT'S CORRECT IT'S A
REALLY. YEAH HE SAID THIS IS THE
SO I WOULD SAY. PERHAPS IS IN
AGAIN YOU KNOW I SAID DON'T MAKE
IT SOUND EASIER THAN IT IS- BUT-
THEN. TECHNOLOGY THAT MAYBE CAN
WE DO THIS ON A ROLLING I MEAN
IDEALLY YES WE JUST DO ACROSS
THE STATE THE SAME TIME BUT IF
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS AND WE
KNOW IT'S EIGHTEEN COUNTIES AND
THEREFORE WE HAVE OTHER COUNTIES
THAT. WE CAN DO THIS AND- RIGHT
THAT FINE WE ROLL IT WE ROLL IT
OUT IN A WAY THAT'S IN
CONCORDANCE WITH THE- TECHNICAL
ROLLOUT. BED TO MIGHT ALLOW US
TO STILL AT LEAST GET PARTS OF
THE STATE- AND THEN EVENTUALLY
BY THE END OF THIS WINDOW.
HOPEFULLY THE ENTIRE STATE. ON
ONE PLACE. WITHOUT HAVING TO DO
MANUAL ENTRY AND SO FORTH. A LOT
OF THINGS I THINK A LOT OF
THINGS TO THINK ABOUT AS AS AS
WE GO FORWARD AND I WILL- I WILL
ASK OUR POLICY STAFF TO FOLLOW
UP WITH THIS AS WELL. THANK YOU
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TEN ELIMINATION OF
PREMIUM COPAYS IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. SET A BUDGET REQUEST IF
THE THREE POINT TWO MILLION-
TOTAL FUNDS NINETEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND EIGHTY NINE MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS I'M GOING TO REDUCE
PREMIUMS. ARE FAT PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS CHILDREN AND WORKING
DISABLED PROGRAMS TO ZERO
DOLLARS EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS PROPOSAL
COVERS ALL MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES CURRENTLY PAYING
PREMIUMS AND CO PAYMENTS. BUT
THIS PREMIUM REQUIREMENT PLACES
AN UNDUE BURDEN ON INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES THAT ARE ALREADY
LIVING ON LIMITED INCOMES ARE
RESTRICTED IN THE PURSUIT OF
SUBSTANTIAL- EMPLOYMENT DUE TO A
DISABILITY. MONTHLY PREMIUM
PAYMENT REQUIREMENTS CREATE
BARRIERS IN ACCESS TO CARE AND
CAN LEAD TO UNNECESSARY BREAKS
IN COVERAGE FOR INDIVIDUALS. I'M
SURE THIS POLICY AT INDIVIDUALS
SHE WOULD NOT BE REQUIRED TO PAY
ANY OUTSTANDING PREMIUM AMOUNTS
I KNOW THAT'S A QUESTION THAT'S
BEEN THAT'S COME UP. I'M JUST TO
BE SPECIFIC ON THE POPULATIONS
THIS INCLUDES IT'S OPTIONAL
TARGETED LOW INCOME CHILDREN'S
PROGRAM THE 210050% WORKING
DISABLED PROGRAM. CHILDREN'S
HEALTH INITIATIVE PROGRAMS
MEDICAL ACCESS PROGRAM AND THE
MEDICARE ACCESS INFANT PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION- THE BUDGET ADVANCES
A PROPOSAL TO REDUCE ALL CO
PAYMENTS IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
TO ZERO DOLLARS HI THIS IS ALSO
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. TO BRING THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL REGULATIONS ALL
INDIVIDUALS ENROLLED IN MEDICARE
FEE FOR SERVICE ARE SUBJECT TO
NOMINAL COPAYMENTS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF. FOSTER CHILDREN
ARE PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS AND
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
NINETEEN YEARS OLD. EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
WITH SOME EXCEPTIONS TO PAY A
NOMINAL NON ENFORCEABLE
COPAYMENTS FOR COVERED SERVICES.
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES MAY BE
CHARGED BY PROVIDERS AND THAT
PROVIDER RETAINS THE COPAYMENTS
WHEN SERVICES ARE RENDERED AND
COPAYMENTS ARE NOT PASSED ON TO
IT TO THE DEPARTMENT. DHS IS
SEEKING TO REDUCE COPAYMENTS AT
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM TO ZERO
DOLLARS IN AN EFFORT TO REMOVE.
BARRIERS IN ACCESS TO CARE AND
TO AVOID COSTLY SYSTEM CHANGES
THAT WOULD OTHER NICE OTHERWISE
NEED TO BE MADE TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS. CURRENTLY PROVIDERS
MAY NOT TONIGHT HERE THE
BENEFICIARIES I'M ABLE TO PAY
COPAYMENTS AT THE TIME OF THE
APPOINTMENT MEANING THERE IS
LITTLE RATIONALE FOR MAINTAINING
THIS NOMINAL NON ENFORCEABLE
REQUIREMENTS FOR COPAYMENTS. THE
STATE DOES NOT RECEIVE ANY
REVENUE. BASED ON THE COLLECTION
OF COPAYMENTS. BY REACHING TO
ASSIST THAT AFFECT THE TRACKING
OF COMMITMENTS RESULT IN A C.
COST. THERE WE BOTH NOT ONLY IT
BENEFITS TO THAT- BENEFICIARY
BUT ALSO COST EFFECTIVE- TO
REDUCE COPAYMENTS. ZERO TO
ALLEVIATE THAT NEED FOR TRACKING
SYSTEM. THAT I CAN GROW MARKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ILIO. THE
MINISTRATIONS FISCAL ESTIMATES
REGARDING THE MEDICAL PREMIUM
REDUCTION- DO NOT ACCOUNT FOR A
CASELOAD INCREASE AS A RESULT OF
THESE REDUCTIONS- WHEN WE
DISCUSS THIS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN DAY ONE OF THE
RUSSIAN THAT SUCH AN IMPACT ON
THE SMALL AND DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT HOWEVER BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF STUDIES RETHINK
REDUCING PREMIUMS WOULD LIKELY
RESULT IN SOMETHING NOT INCREASE
IN ENROLLMENT. DUE TO THE
REDUCTION IN THE TRUCK AND THAT
WAS IT- MENTIONED YOU KNOW AND
THEN MINISTRATIONS TESTIMONY AS
WELL AS REMOVING A DETERRENT
EFFECT PREMIUMS HOP ON
ENROLLMENT. WELL THERE IS
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY THAT
COULD RESULT IN INCREASED
GENERAL FUND COSTS POTENTIALLY
IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WE AGREE WITH THE POLICY
BASIS FOR THE PROPOSAL OUR
BEFORE APPROVAL WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ASKING MINISTRY
ADMINISTRATION WHY THERE'S
SOMETHING OPEN OKAY SO THE
IMPACT IS REASONABLE AS WE THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT. INFORMATION
TO DETERMINE ITS APPROACH SO%
SHOULD BE APPROVED AS IS OR WITH
MODIFICATIONS TO THE COST.
ESTIMATES THANK YOU. NOT GOING
TO CUT INTO UNITED. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M MICHELLE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. SO HOW.
THANK YOU. THE DRUG ABOUT CAN
YOU CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE ABOUT
THE AND I WILL GO ON THE SINGLE
VERY SUPPORTIVE THIS ISSUE IT'S
A FROM THE NUMBER WE'RE DOING IT
BUT CAN YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
NOT PROTECTING ANY- INCREASING.
IN CASELOAD. FOR THIS I WOULD
TURN IT OVER TO YOU DO YOU ENJOY
. IN REGARDS TO THE CASE FOR
PEACE. OKAY EIGHT IN JULY AND-
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS AND
ELIGIBILITY- THE WANTING TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS OF
THE FISCAL MODEL THAT WE HAVE
USED TO PROJECT- CURRENTLY IT IS
A VERY COMPLEX MODEL GIVEN THAT
WE ARE CURRENTLY WAVING- THE
PREMIUMS ARE FOR THESE VERY
POPULATIONS- AND AGAIN WITH THE
UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS OF THE
INCREASED- BUT WITH THAT-
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THE TWO NEXUS AT
THIS TIME- IS KIND OF DIFFICULT-
FOR US TO PROJECT WHETHER THERE
WILL BE AFTER SCHOOL- DIFFERENCE
OR INCREASED I'M IN KIND OF THE
TOTAL CASE LOAD FOR THESE
POPULATIONS WITH THE REDUCTION
OF THE PREMIUMS TO ZERO AT THIS
TIME- I THINK WE'D KNOWLEDGE
THERE PROBABLY IS SOME
ADDITIONAL MODELING WE CAN DO
YOU- AS WE ARE. LOOKING FOR KIND
OF THE END OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN TERMS OF ITS
IMPACTS IT'S VERY DIFFICULT THIS
TIME TO ISOLATE IT THIS CALL
MODEL THAT WE HAVE IN THE.
UNCERTAINTY WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THANK YOU WE
CHECK IN BACK ON A DOCTOR
FRIENDLY THING ON THIS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S MOVE
ON TO THAT AND LET ME ASK ON
ISSUE. ELEVEN TWELVE THIRTEEN-
DOES LMAO OR DEPARTMENT FINANCE
HAVE ANY. ANYTHING TO SAY ON
MOST. ON AN ISSUE FOR ISRAELI
HONESTLY THIRTEEN WE JUST WANTED
TO STATE THAT WE BELIEVE THERE A
STRONG CULTURE RATIONAL FOR THE
PROPOSAL- AND WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THAT OKAY SO- TO
DIRECT BUS WHY DON'T WE DO
ELEVEN THROUGH FOURTEEN AND THEN
WE'LL STOP AND GO BACK TO LA- IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND THEN
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
AFTER THAT. ACCORDING TO COUNTER
RIGHT. THAT'S OUR MEDICAL THAT'S
CORRECT SORRY WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT MUCH. I WAS PUT IN THE OVEN
. YES THE GOAL OF LIVING THROUGH
FIFTEEN. OKAY SO ALIGNED MEDICAL
RIGID TERMINATIONS WITH FEDERAL
AT. THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES THE
BUDGET REQUEST ONE TIME SYSTEM
COST OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND- TO UPDATE
NOTICES OF ACTION AND THE
INDIANS ARE SOFT SYSTEM. WE ARE
PROPOSING TO OUTLINE STATE LAW
WITH FEDERAL GUIDELINES FOR
MEDICAID REDETERMINATION
PROCESSING TO AVOID LOSS OF.
FEDERAL FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION
AND REDUCE- BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENTS FOR BENEFICIARIES
AND COUNTY ELIGIBILITY WORKERS-
IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY- THE
CMS RELEASED A BULLETIN
CLARIFYING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE NINETY DAY CURE PERIOD.
STATES MUST DETERMINE THE
DISCONTINUED RECORD
BENEFICIARIES ELIGIBILITY. A NEW
APPLICATION BASED ON THE DATE OF
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
SUBMITTED AND GRANT RETROACTIVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR ANY OF THE
PREVIOUS MONTH ONLY. IF THE
INDIVIDUAL REQUEST RETROACTIVE
ELIGIBILITY AND IS ELIGIBLE FOR
THOSE MONTHS. ADDITIONALLY CMS
CLARIFIED THAT SETTING AN ANNUAL
RENEWAL DATE FOLLOW NORMAL AN
APPLICATION PROCESSING RULES.
CHANGE CONFORMS TO UPDATED
FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND INVOICE ANY
POTENTIAL AUDIT FINDINGS OR
FISCAL CREDIT ANALGESICS- WITH
THIS PROPOSAL- WE PROPOSE. THREE
TRADABLE MODIFICATION IN STATE
LAW BY REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT
FOR THE BENEFICIARY TO REVIEW
INFORMATION PRE POPULATED. ON
THE CHANGE IN CIRCUMSTANCE FARM
AGREED TO WERE UPDATED SIGN THE
FORM UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY
AND RETURN THE FORM TO THE
COUNTY. THIS PREVENTS ADDITIONAL
BURDENS FOR THE BENEFICIARY AND
REDUCES THE WORKLOAD FOR COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY. ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
. THANK YOU FOR WE'LL TAKE THE-
ISSUE. SO FOR THE CHILDREN AND
JUST KERR OF PRO ARE WE IS NOW
AS THE HDP- THIS PROVIDES
SCREENING FOLLOW UP SERVICES AS-
AS WELL AS CARE COORDINATION FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE WHO WERE ENROLLED IN
FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE OUT-
ADDITIONALLY IT PROVIDES WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE C. H. U. B. GATE
WAY OUT WHICH SERVES AS A
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY ENTRY
POINT FOR CHILDREN AND LOCAL
ADMINISTRATION OF THE HEALTH
CARE PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE- INDEED. CHILDHOOD
LEAD POISONING PREVENTION. IS
ALSO ADMINISTERED THROUGH THIS
YOU D. P. FOR. I JAN OF TWENTY
G. HTS ART OF CALAIS BEGAN
TRANSITIONING DOWN DUAL ELIGIBLE
MEDICARE POPULATIONS INTO
MANAGED CARE- THIS INCLUDES THE
MAJORITY OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE- BUT
JULY OF TWENTY THREE MOST
CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE- WILL
BE ENROLLED INTO A MANAGED CARE
PLAN. TODAY ABOUT HALF OF FOSTER
CARE CHILDREN AND YOUTH RECEIVE
SERVICES THROUGH FOR SERVICE IN
THE OTHER HALF RECEIVED SERVICES
THROUGH MANAGED CARE PLANS.
FOSTER CARE CHILDREN ARE ONLY-
THE ONLY REMAINING POPULATION OF
CHILDREN USE THAT WILL NOT BE
FULLY TRANSITIONED INTO MANAGED
CARE HOWEVER THIS POPULATION-
AND UNDER THE- CARE PROGRAM FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL REMAIN AS A
STANDALONE PROGRAM- WHEN I C. H.
T. P. SUNSETS ONCE THE FEE FOR
SERVICE TO MANAGE CARE
TRANSITION IS COMPLETE IT WILL
NO LONGER BE NECESSARY TO RETAIN
THE COMPONENTS OF THE C. H. T.
P. PROGRAMS SINCE MEDICARE PLANS
ARE REQUIRED TO COVER ALL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
THEREFORE THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING TO SUNSET THE CHILDREN
AND HELP THE CHILDREN HELP THE
DISABILITY PREVENTION PROGRAM BY
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IN ORDER TO SIMPLIFY AND
STREAMLINE THE DELIVERY SYSTEM
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE I THE
DEPARTMENT IS OUR PROPOSAL TO
SUNSET. WILL. NOT AFFECT YOU PSD
TEASER THIS IS AS THEIR KERR
REQUIRED TO BECOME IN BOTH. MET
FEE FOR SERVICE AND CARE
DELIVERY SO. ARE CARE ARE TO
PROVIDE YOUR- TO CHILDREN AND
USED UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY AND
- THE- APPROPRIATE AND TIMELY
ACCESS ALL NEEDED MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE
DEVELOPMENTAL DENTAL. SOCIAL AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES. AS WELL AS
COORDINATING REFERRALS FOR NON
COVERED BENEFITS. OUT FOR FOSTER
CARE CHILDREN YOUTH NOT ENROLLED
IN MANAGED CARE- SYSTEMIC
COORDINATION OF SERVICES AND
COMPREHENSIVE CARE MANAGEMENT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE PROVIDED.
THROUGH THE HEALTH CARE PROGRAM
FOR CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL REMAIN. AFTER
THE C. H. U. P. PROGRAM WITH
SUNSET. FURTHERMORE THE PROPOSAL
WILL NOT IMPACT THE EXISTING
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY
FUNCTIONS- AS KNOWN AS THE
GATEWAY PROGRAM AT DH CS IS
PROPOSING TO PRESERVE THE
AUTOMATED PRE ENROLLMENT PROCESS
FOR NON MEDICAL UNINSURED
CHILDREN. ARE CURRENTLY KNOWN AS
EACH TV GATEWAY. IN TRANSITION
THIS FUNCTION TO A NEW
CHILDREN'S PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY PROGRAM. AT THE
ELIGIBILITY PROGRAM WILL EXPAND
TO INCLUDE ALL APPLICABLE MEDIC
HELP PROVIDERS. ARE THEREBY
PREVENTING MORE PROVIDERS MAKE
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS AND EXPANDING
ACCESS TO MEDICAL SERVICES. FOR
MORE CHILDREN AND USE. ALLOWING
ALL APPLICABLE MEDICAL PROVIDERS
TO DETERMINE PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY WILL PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE COVERAGE. AT TWO MORE
CHILDREN- NOT YET ENROLLED IN
MEDI CAL OR WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
JUST ENROLLED DROPPED FROM MEDIC
HELL AND INCREASE. OVERALL
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
FURTHERMORE DH YES FOR HER-
PROPOSES TO PRESERVE. THE HEALTH
CARE PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. AS A STANDALONE
PROGRAM AND TRANSITION THE
CHILDHOOD LEAD. POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM A SPONSOR
BILL EAST TO THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS I WOULD KNOW THIS IS
ALREADY A REQUIREMENT IN THE
EXISTING MEDICARE PLANS CONTRACT
TODAY SO THAT IS NOT A NEW
FUNCTION THAT WERE REQUESTING.
THAT THEY PROVIDE. ADDITION AT
LEAST I TALK CASE MANAGEMENT
WILL REMAIN AVAILABLE IN COUNTY.
THAT USE DIFFERENT IN THE
SERVICES THE STATE PLAN I AS-
IDEAS YES IS A OF THIS- PURPLE
PROPOSED. HAS A VERY DETAILED
CROSSWALK OF ALL EXISTING
PROGRAMS POSSIBILITIES AND HOW
THOSE WOULD BE EFFECTUATED WITH
THIS PROPOSED CHANGE WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO RELEASING
THIS PROPOSAL VERY SOON
HOPEFULLY WILL BE OUT IN THE
NEXT DAY OR TWO FOR PEOPLE TO
SEE. ALL OF THE DETAILS HERE AND
I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
SHOP FOR THE NEXT ITEM. THANK
YOU. THE SHOOTER THAT FAMILY H.
P. V. XBOX HPV VACCINE COVERAGE
PROPOSAL. THE BUDGET REQUEST
EIGHT MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND I'M GOING TO INCLUDE H. P.
V. AS A COVERED BENEFIT UNDER
THE FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM FOR
FEMALES AND MALES. AGES NINETEEN
THROUGH FORTY FIVE EFFECTIVE
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
POLICY WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO
THE HPV VACCINE WHICH PREVENTS
VARIOUS CANCERS AND REDUCES THE
REST MORBIDITY AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HPV RELATED
DISEASES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
INCREASING ACCESS TO HPV VACCINE
FOR UNINSURED UNDERINSURED
ARTIFACTS UNVACCINATED OR UNDER
VACCINATED INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY
THE F. PROGRAM WHICH MAY HELP TO
REDUCE THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN CANCER
IS. INCIDENT AND OUR MORTALITY
RATES. AMONG MINORITY WOMEN AND
MEN. IT OF H. P. IS. BACKPACK
WITH A LINE THE BENEFIT WITH
MEDICARE. BOOKKEEPER SERVICE
MANAGED CARE COVERS H.
VACCINATION FOR FEMALES AND
MALES BETWEEN NINE AND FORTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE BASED ON THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES ACIP.
RECOMMENDED INDICATIONS. RIGHT
AND I WILL TAKE THE LAST ITEM
ITEM FIFTEEN- SO THE DEPARTMENT
WAS SCHEDULED TO RESUME THE
RETROACTIVE UP PHARMACY CLAIM
ADJUSTMENTS IN FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY ONE HOWEVER DUE TO
FACTORS RELATED TO ONGOING
LITIGATION. THE DEPARTMENT IS
CONTINUING TO PAS INTEL FURTHER
NOTICE THIS PART OF THE FLIGHTS
YOU ALL PHARMACY CLAIMS BILLED
THROUGH THE MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE FISCAL INTERMEDIARY AND
INCLUDES THOSE CLAIMS THAT WERE
ALSO SUBJECT TO AN ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT ARRANGEMENTS. FOR BUDGET
PURPOSES ONLY THE RETROACTIVE
ADJUSTMENTS WERE ASSUMED TO
RESUME IN JANUARY FIRSTOF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO HOWEVER AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WE ARE
CURRENTLY PASSING ALL
RECRUITMENT AT THIS TIME AND
THAT IS THE CONCLUSION OF MY
COMMENTS THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I THINK WE HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF CONFUSION ON OUR END ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT ISSUE
FOURTEEN I KNOW WE PULL THIRTY
FOUR BUT ARE YOU PRESENT. TO
PREPARE TO PRESENT ISSUE
FOURTEEN. WE CAN'T GET SHOT BUT
I. SORRY I WE ARE. YEAH I STILL
IS OUT BUT ARE A EMPLOYEE- AS
YOU KNOW MEDICARE ARE EX
LAUNCHED ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THAT WITH THE
TRANSITION OF ALL MEDICAL
PHARMACY SERVICES FOR MANAGED
CARE TOOK THE FIRST SERVICE FOR
MORE THAN FOURTEEN MILLION
MEDICAL MEMBERS. WITH MEDICARE
ARE EX ARE GOLD THE STATE IS TO
STANDARDIZE THE MEDICAL PHARMACY
BENEFITS UNDER ONE STATE WIDE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. IT MEANS THAT
NO MATTER WHAT COUNTY PERSON
LIVES IN THE SAME ACCESS TO THE
PRESCRIPTIONS AS POSSIBLE.
IMPROVING ACCESS TO PHARMACY
SERVICES WITH THE PHARMACY
NETWORK THAT INCLUDES THE FAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATES
PHARMACIES. CENTRALIZING
PHARMACY POLICY TRANSACTIONS AND
REIMBURSEMENTS ULTIMATELY
LEADING TO GREATER EFFICIENCY
FOR PHARMACIES AND OUR
PROVIDERS. AND ALSO
STRENGTHENING THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL DRUG REBATES WITH
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURERS. IN
ADDITION MEDI CAL R. X. IS
EXPECTED TO RESULT IN ONGOING
ANNUAL SAVINGS OF EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS. ABOUT THREE HUNDRED SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL SIGN. AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. SINCE FEBRUARY.
MAJO THE VENDOR WHO IS
IMPLEMENTED MEDICARE R. AG PRIOR
MORE THAN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN POINT
FOUR SIX MILLION POINT OF SALE
PHARMACY PAID CLAIMS- AND IS
TOTALLY IN ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN PAYMENTS. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
PROCESSED IN ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE THOUSAND CALLS HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED. I 1100% OF VIRTUAL
HOST CALLS- AND BOTH MUST HAVE
BEEN RETURNED. WE KNOW WITH THE
TRANSITION OF US SUCH A
SUBSTANTIAL- IMPLEMENTATION THE
MEDICAL PHARMACY BENEFIT TO A
SINGLE DELIVERY SYSTEM WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE BEEN
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES SUCH
AS LONG CALL CENTER WAIT TIMES.
AND DELAYS IN PROCESSING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS THIS WAS
PARTICULARLY I'M RELEVANT IN IN
JANUARY AND EARLY FEBRUARY. AS
SUCH IN EARLY FEBRUARY CS AND
MAGELLAN IMPLEMENTED A TEMPORARY
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION MAY GRECIAN
STRATEGY AND AGGRESSIVE STAFFING
PLAN WITH THE GOAL TO ACCELERATE
THE TURN AROUND TIME I'M PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS AND
REDUCE CALL VOLUME INTO THE CALL
CENTER SH DH YES ALSO BROUGHT ON
OUR- BOTTOM LINE OUR CALL CENTER
TO ASSIST WITH CALLS AN
ADDITIONAL DH YES STAFF. TO
ASSIST WITH THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS. JOHN IS A DRESS
IN THE CALL CENTER IN PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION CHALLENGES WITH
THE SURGE OF NEW HIRING BY
ADDING MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NEW NET STOCK AT AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT FORTY PERCENT.
BY THE END OF FEBRUARY MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NEW
ASSOCIATES WILL BE HIRED FOR THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE CENTER AND MORE
THAN SEVENTY TWO NOW HIRES FOR
THE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION I LIKE
TO ASK. THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
CENTER WILL ADD AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY NEW ASSOCIATES AND A
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY FIVE BEFORE. ON
MARCH THIRTEENTH. ALL OF THE H.
STAFF AT. RE DIRECT TO MEDIC R.
X. JUSTICE REQUIRE OPERATION
AUTHORIZATION IN JAN. AND EARLY
. HAVE BEEN READ. TO THEIR
NORMAL DUTIES. I MAYBE TO WRITE
A BRIEF UPDATE ON THE CALL
CENTER PRODUCT PROGRESS. CALLED
BAD CALL WAIT TIMES HAVE
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MEDICATION
STEPS IN EARLY FEBRUARY. BUT
JOHN HAS CONSISTENTLY ACHIEVE
CONTINUAL REDUCTION IN ALL CALL
WAIT TIMES. AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND- WE WERE AT FIFTY
SEVEN SECONDS AVERAGE SPEED TO
ANSWER OVERALL AND FORTY FIVE
SECONDS FOR AVERAGE SPEED TO
ANSWER FOR LIFE CALLS. THIS AT
THE PEAK IN IN JANUARY EARLY
FEBRUARY THIS- THE AVERAGE SPEED
pTO ANSWER WITHIN THE THREE TO
FOUR HOURS WE'VE MADE
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS. CALL
BANDMATE RATES HAVE BEEN
INCREASING CURRENTLY WE ARE AT
THREE POINT FIVE PERCENT.
INCREASE PERCENTAGES OF LIFE
CALLED ANSWERS THAT WE ARE AT A
NINETY FOUR PERCENT. WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE THE FOCUS
ON TRAINING WELL THE QUALITY OF
CALLS ONE ANSWER HAS PROVEN HIGH
TRAINING WILL ENSURE MAGELLAN
MAINTAINS QUALITY AND BRINGS
FASTER RESOLUTION. DECREASING
OVERALL WHOLE TIME. IN REGARD TO
PRIOR OTHER- PRICE SEEMS AS IF
IT IF I. OF AT THE BACK OF PRIOR
AUTH- WAS CLEARED- SINCE
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH- JOHN HAS
MAINTAINED A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CONTRACTUALLY REQUIRED
TURNAROUND TIME FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS- AND IT HAS BEEN
MAINTAINED SINCE THEN- WE'VE
DEPLOYED AND ENHANCE BENEFICIARY
AND PROVIDER ESCALATION PROCESS.
STAFF WITH THE PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS FROM EIGHT AM TO
EIGHT PM MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY.
EACH ENQUIRIES. AND UPDATES ARE
PROVIDED OUT REALLY TO THE
REQUEST YOUR INTERNAL RESOLUTION
IS ACHIEVED ADDITIONALLY
TARGETED OUTREACH TO KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IS ONGOING TO
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT THE
ESCALATION PROCESS. MORGAN SEGAL
AUTHORIZATION WAS TEMPORARILY
EXTENDED FROM THREE TO FOURTEEN
DAYS STATEWIDE FOR EVERY
PHARMACY EXTENDING THE LONG
STANDING AT A MERCHANT SEE THREE
DAY FULL POLICY TO FOURTEEN DAYS
A CHURCH ALL BENEFICIARIES HAVE
A TWO WEEK SUPPLY OF COVER
MEDICATIONS AND THE INVENTOR OF
AN EMERGENCY- WE ARE ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF ESTABLISHING A
DEDICATED CLINICAL LIAISON. LINE
STAFFED BY MAGELLAN'S FIRST
SPECIAL POPULATIONS SUCH AS THE
GENIC GENETICALLY HANDICAPPED
PERSON PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S SERVICES PROGRAM AND
ARE SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH I
COUNTY DEPARTMENT- BUT JOHN IS
ALSO WORKING WITH DHS TO
FINALIZE THE PROCESS BY WHICH-
WE WILL ALLOW THE OVERRIDING ANY
DENIAL FOR AT- THAT IS DEEMED
URGENT OR MEDICALLY NECESSARY
AND APPROPRIATE. I'M WITH THE
TWO OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
THROUGH- WE ARE REGARDING THE
CHILDREN'S SERVICES- PROGRAM AND
SPECIALLY IF THEIR PRODUCTS LIKE
INTERNAL NUTRITION REGARDING
CCS- MAGELLAN AND AT IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN ADDITIONAL
STEPS TO EVALUATE EXAMPLES OF
CCS DENIALS I WE HAVE A FEW THAT
BAD CHANGES IN PROCESS THAT ARE
EXPECTED TO GO INTO PRODUCTION
NEXT WEEK. I'M IN THIS IS
REGARDING NON BENEFIT PRODUCTS
WHICH WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CLAIMS HISTORY GRANDFATHERING
LOGIC RESULTING IN CLAIMS
DENYING FOR CCS BENEFICIARIES
WHEN I NINE- BENEFIT PRODUCT WAS
PROVIDED UNDER EPS D. T. EVEN IF
THERE WAS A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
ON FILE- WE ARE MEETING WITH
CCSD STAKEHOLDERS THIS WEEK TO
REVIEW THESE CHANGES WITH THE
BALL AGAIN TO GET THESE. CHANGES
INTO PRODUCTION NEXT WEEK.
REGARDING CPEC INTO PRODUCTS
LIKE INTER NATURE. OTHER HAVE
BEEN SOME CHALLENGES WITH
QUANTITY LIMITS WE'VE EXTENDED
THE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION TERM
ADORATION FOR AUTHORIZATION
ESPECIALLY IMPRINT PROJECTS FROM
A MAXIMUM OF TWO MONTH TERM. TO
MAXIMUM FOUR CHARM- AND- ALL
OTHER COVERAGE CARDS HERE
REMAINS UNCHANGED. LASTLY WE ARE
ENGAGED IN A ROBUST PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT PROCESS TO DETERMINE
CHANGES PLANNED FOR THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN APRIL MAY AND JUNE ARE
PRIOR TO THE ENDING OF THE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAY BRAND FRY
THIRD PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
POLICY. AS OF FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH
BUT JOHN AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
ESTABLISHED AN EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH TASK FORCE TO LEVERAGE
STREAMS ACROSS THE ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THE BOLTS YOU ACTIVELY
EDUCATE PROVIDERS PRESCRIBERS
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING
MEDIC HOW ACTS. BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE CURRENT- TEMPORARY CHANGES-
AND YOU DRESS SOME OF THAT
INITIAL OPERATIONAL CONCERNS-
THAT WILL BE ADDRESSED ONCE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAVE
TRANSITIONAL POLICY. IS NO
LONGER IN PLACE. WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW THAT- IT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
. CONTRACTUAL PROVISIONS TO HOLD
MAGELLAN FOR POOR PERFORMANCE
INCLUDING PAYMENT WITHHOLD I
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES FOR THE
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SERVICE INVOICE. WE ARE
CURRENTLY I'M ANTICIPATING
WITHHOLDING ABOUT 64% AT THE
JANUARY INVOICE OUT WE ARE STILL
UNDERGOING A VALIDATION PROCESS
TO ENSURE- AT THE SOME OF THE
METRICS ARE MATCH- OR WERE NOT
MATCH AND- I'M WITH BACK TO I
WILL IT OVER ANY. OKAY THANK
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH- SINCE WE
GROUPED A BUNCH OF- ITEMS
TOGETHER RIGHT AND I'VE- DOUBLE
DOUBLE CHECK ANY FURTHER.
BECAUSE I THINK. LISA FIRST SAID
WE WERE DOING FOURTEEN NOW WE
ARE- SO. ANY COMMENTS FROM LA L.
ON ANY OF THE ITEMS. THIS IS
REALLY GOOD FOR THE L. A. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON IT AND
FOR THE IT IS VERY UNFAIR AND
EFFICIENCY THE NEXT ISSUE WILL
HAVE COMMENTS FOR ITS ISSUE
THIRTY ONE OR SAY YES OKAY ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT SO KEEP THAT IN
MIND- FINANCE ANY ANY COMENTS
ON THE- ITEMS THAT WE WERE JUST
HEARD. ENTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO ITEMS. OR NO NO I'M-
WAS HONORED IN SISTER YOU OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS HERE SO WE'LL
JUST GO TO SCHOOL RUN THROUGH
THEM IN ORDER- AND THEN ISSUE
ORDERS SO ISSUE ELEVEN- I
APPRECIATE THAT. THAT'S A THAT'S
ABOUT TO RE DETERMINATION OF
FEDERAL GUIDELINES I GUESS THAT
THE QUESTION I HAVE HERE AND
THEN I REALIZED THAT- WE ARE
DEALING WITH- FEDERAL
GUIDELINES. WHICH WE DO HAVE TO
FOLLOW. THE SO WE'RE CHANGING
FROM THE NINETY DATES HERE WHICH
MEANS THAT ACTUALLY EXCELLENT.
BY UNDERSTANDING YOU TELL ME IF
I GOT IT WRONG SO WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT- SOMEONE'S ON MEDICARE
HOW THE I GUESS THEY BEEN. PAY
ME SOMETHING IN THE MAIL
WHATEVER ANYWAY THEY DON'T
RENEW. AND THEN THEY SHOW UP FOR
A VISIT AND THEN USED TO BE IF
IT'S WITHIN NINETY DAYS WE
BASICALLY GETS A LOOK YOU KNOW
YOU'RE STILL ELIGIBLE SO WE
SICKLY YOUNG GET YOUR STUFF AND
THEN YOU'RE NOW BACK IN BUT THEN
WE DON'T HAVE A BREAK IN
BETWEEN. BECAUSE OF THAT THAT
THEY MIGHT HAVE THAT SERVICES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND THEN.
NOW IN THIS CASE WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IS THAT WE HAVE TO RE
ENROLL THEM. SO DON'T BE
DISCONTINUITY IT IS THAT WHAT
THEY ARE AND TRYING TO STAND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE- BECAUSE WOULDN'T THAT THEN
MEAN THAT. THEY WOULD HAVE TO RE
ENROLL SO BEFORE THEY WOULD BE.
WELL WELL ACTUALLY WE COULD GO
BACK AND SIMPLY SAY THEY'RE
STILL ON A ROLL RIGHT- DEATH THE
NINETY EIGHT YEAR BUT NOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE SAYING
THAT. ACTUALLY YOUR BRAND NEW
PATIENT AGAIN BECAUSE YOU
DROPPED OFF AND THEN WE HAVE TO
RE ENROLL YOU AND WE HAVE A GAP
. IS THAT IS THAT I GET THAT
RIGHT. IT WILL TURN IT OVER TO
YOU INJURE OUR ELIGIBILITY
EXPERTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MICHELLE HI SENATOR PENN I CAN
CERTAINLY ANSWER NOT- SO IT'S A-
YOU'RE CORRECT- IN SOME
INSTANCES WHERE SOME INDIVIDUALS
DO COME IN A PREVIOUSLY DURING
THE NINETY DAY JUROR WE
REINSTATE THEM BASICALLY- SO
THERE'S NO- GAP IN THEIR
COVERAGE HOWEVER WITH OUR LINE-
WITH THE UPDATED FEDERAL
GUIDELINES WHAT WE ARE DOING IS.
THE INDIVIDUAL WILL COME IN AND
IT WILL BE THE SAME A
DOCUMENTATION AND WE ARE NOT
REQUIRING THEM TO FILL OUT YOUR
APPLICATION- BUT THEY WILL HAVE
TO REQUEST A RETRO ACTIVE
COVERAGE OF FOR THE MONTH IF
THEY BECOME A MONTH THREE AND
THERE ARE. NO FEAR WITHIN THE
ORIGINAL NINETY DAY CURE PERIOD
FOR MONTHS ONE YOU ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO HOW WE TREAT YOUR
APPLICATIONS- THE COUNTIES WILL
AUTOMATICALLY WITHOUT REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM THE-
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS COMING BACK-
BASICALLY REINSTATE COVERAGE BUT
THEY WILL TREAT THEM LIKE ANY
APPLICANT AND WHAT'S ACTUALLY
GONNA HAPPEN IS THERE WILL BE-
THE RENEWAL DATES FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL ACTUALLY EXTENDED.
PREVIOUSLY THEY ACTUALLY HAD A
SHORTENED RENEWAL BECAUSE OF THE
NINETY DAY CURE PERIOD WITH THE
UPDATED INTERPRETATION FROM CMS-
THAT WAS RELEASED ALL EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY- THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL IF THEY DO COME IN A
LATER IN THE NINETY DAY CURE
WHICH IS OUR RE APPLICATION ON
THEIR RENEWAL DATE ACTUALLY WILL
BE LONGER SO BASICALLY THERE-
THEIR COVERAGE ACTUALLY WILL
ALSO BE LONGER. AND HOW MUCH HOW
MUCH LONGER IS THIS RENEWAL OF
THE RENEWAL TIME NOW IT'S GONNA
BE TWELVE MONTHS SO SAY IF THEY
DO COME IN A MONTH THREE OF THE
ORIGINAL NINETY DAY CARE- DURING
ALL CURIOUS WILL ACTUALLY BEGIN
IN MONTH THREE- BASICALLY
MEANING THAT THEY'LL STILL HAVE
TWELVE MONTHS FROM THIRTY. OKAY
SO JUST TO CLARIFY BECAUSE LEE
SAID THAT YOU KNOW THESE USES AN
AREA- IS THAT RIGHT THERE ON THE
GROUND ROLE MEDIC HOW- YEAH
DON'T RENEW THEY'RE BUSY YOU
CAN'T FIND THEM DATE COULD TO
PAY ETCETERA RIGHT- SO IT'S
ALMOST TIME A SIZE TO GET TO
THEM. THE NATION UP FOR. THE
NUMBER ROOM THE SHOW A CLINIC.
OR SOME AND THEN WE'RE LIKE OH
YOU'RE NOT IN MAY. SO DOES THAT
MEAN THEY CAN'T GET SEEN OR THAT
MEAN THE PROVIDER THEREFORE
DOESN'T GET REIMBURSED- WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS AT THAT POINT-
BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE QUOTE. THE
NEW PATIENT BUT THEY'RE NOT
TECHNICALLY I MEAN SOMEONE WOULD
HAVE TO ENROLL THEM- SO WE'LL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS BECAUSE THAT'S
USUALLY WHAT I SENT IT OUT TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENS BUT CERTAINLY
THAT'S A SCENARIO RIGHT. THE
REASON THAT WE FIND OUT THEY'RE
NO LONGER ENROLLED THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE SHOWING UP FOR CARE. AND
DO WE SAY OH SORRY WE CAN'T SEE
YOU TODAY BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
MEDIC COW BUT HERE'S YOUR PAY
YOU KNOW GO GO GO TALK TO THE
COUNTY OR WHATEVER ELSE AND THEN
YOU CAN COME BACK LATER- AND- OF
COURSE THE PROBABLY SHOWING UP
FOR SOMETHING A CUTE BECAUSE
THAT'S USUALLY YOU KNOW. WHAT
WHY THEY SHOWED UP. ITS BUSINESS
AFTER I GET THAT RIGHT OURS IS
IT'S ALREADY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET. THE CARE AND STOKE AND THEN
THE PRIOR STILL GOING TO BE ABLE. TO GET REIMBURSED FOR THE CARE
THEY PROVIDED. YES SO WE'RE NOT.
MATER NECESSARILY. KIND OF ANY
OF THAT- THE- THE PARAMETERS
WITHIN THE NINETY DAYS AND I
THINK. I AM THE OLD ROLES BEFORE
THIS UPDATED GUIDANCE WITHIN THE
NINETY DAY CARE AT. THE BENEFIT
THREE DOES HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION. AND WE'RE
NOT CHANGING NOT- EVEN WITH THE
ALIGNMENT OF THE FEET TO THE
UPDATED FEDERAL GUIDANCE. IS
REALLY MORE A TECHNICALITY IN
TERMS OF CALLING IT A PURE
REINSTATEMENT. WITHIN THE
NINETY. EIGHT OR INTERNAL. EIGHT
EXCITED WHICH IS A RE
APPLICATION. BUT NOT HAVING THE
INDIVIDUAL ACCOUNT TO PROVIDE
LIKE A FULL OUTLOOK. OKAY SO NOW
IT'S SO OKAY SELLS. PATIENT NOW
YOU KNOW THEY DIDN'T RENEW THEIR
DEATHS NOW THEY'RE SHOWING UP IN
THE CLINIC AND THEY SAID YOU
KNOW I'M HERE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
I INJURED MYSELF. OR FOR BREEZE
AND HAVING YOU KNOW. OR
SOMETHING- IS THAT. AND THEY'RE
SHOWING UP IN A CLINIC THAT IS
THAT AND WE FIND OUT WELL YOU'RE
NOT ENROLLED IN MEDICAID HOW IT
EXPIRED. ARE WE GONNA GET PAID
OR DO WE SEND THEM OFF TO THE
MERGES THE ROOM TO BE TELLING MY
GO TO YOUR ELIGIBILITY WORKER- I
MEAN I'VE BEEN WORKING OUTSIDE
SO WE TAKE CARE OF THE PATIENT
THAT IS THE CLINIC AND GET PAID
FOR THAT. APPOINTMENT IS THE
DIGGING A REIMBURSED BY MEDICARE
OR NOT. THEY WILL THEY WILL
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE A RETRO
PERIOD IN WHICH THEY CAN'T
REQUESTS WERE TRAUMATIC CAL AND
DEPENDING ON THE PERSON'S
CIRCUMSTANCE THE WILL BE-
BASICALLY. BE PUT BACK INTO
THEIR ORIGINAL STATE OF
COVERAGE- FROM MONTH ONE TO
WHERE THEY ARE NOW SO. THE RULES
APPLY ENTRANCE RAMP HERSELF I
SENT A MAINTENANCE OUTSIDE BUT
DID NOTE THAT THE- THE CLINICS
AND THE BILL. TO THEIR MEDICAL
PLAN- THEN BE REIMBURSED.
CORRECT OKAY BECAUSE I CAN BE
ASSIGNED TO THE SAME PLAN. ZERO
FOUR YES MOST LIKELY YEAH WELL.
THE MOST LIKELY THEY COULD
AFFORD TO GET SANCTIONS RIGHT
BECAUSE NOW THEY GET PUT AND
THEN THEY GOT- WELL WAIT A
MINUTE WE DON'T TAKE THAT PLAN
WEIRD THE OTHER PLAN RIGHT SO
FORTH SO OKAY WELL. I APPRECIATE
THE ANSWER IT'S OBVIOUS YOU KNOW
WE'RE WITH IT THAT WE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T CAUSE YOU KNOW
DISRUPTIONS ARE PEOPLE NOT BE
ABLE TO GET CARE- AND LEAVING-
PATIENTS ARE THERE. ARE PEOPLE
TAKING CARE OF THE PAIN OKAY-
SO. THAT THE- STAFF ON ISSUE
TWELVE AGAIN REPEATED I GUESS I
WOULD JUST SORT OF MORE OF A
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE IS THAT-
YOU KNOW CCP WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM PARTICULARLY
SINCE WHEN WE DIDN'T. PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR PEOPLE FOR CHILDREN
OF UNDOCUMENTED- WHEN OUR
MEDICAL RATES ARE MUCH LOWER
AND- DID AND ACTUALLY HAD MORE
POSITIONS WHEN HE TAKES EACH D.
P. AND SO FORTH. AND THIS THIS
IS A WAY TO HELP ACTUALLY
IMPROVE ACCESS SO CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHY- NOW BUT I ALSO
REMINDER THAT- WE NEED TO BE
SURE. THAT THE OTHER THINGS WE
PUT IN PLACE WE CONTINUE THIS
POLICY CERTAINLY KNOWS DON'T SEE
THE CHANGE HAPPENING ANYWHERE IN
HORIZON BUT- JUST WANTING
KNOWLEDGE THE HISTORICAL ROLE
CCPS. PLAYED AS WE'RE PHASING IT
OUT. ISSUE THIRTEEN SOUNDS-
ISSUE FOR. MEDIC OR AND WITH THE
- THE FREESHEET TOWARD THE
DIRECTOR SAID I GUESS- YOU KNOW
JUST. I DO HAVE TO SAY FOR THE
RECORD HERE- THAT- YOU KNOW THE
ROLLOUT JANUARY FIRST DID NOT GO
WELL- YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUES
AND- OUR DISTRICT OFFICES ARE
HEARING ABOUT THAT- CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE- TRYING
YOU KNOW TRYING TO DRESS MANY OF
THESE THINGS- AS AS THE ROLLOUTS
CONTINUING I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IF. FOR SOME
REASON- YOU KNOW THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT STAFF ON PLACE-
OTHER OTHER REASONS- THEN WE
NEED TO SLOW DOWN. THE
TRANSITION SO THAT WE DON'T
LEAVE PATIENTS HANGING LIKE WE
DID WHAT WE SAW AT THE BEGINNING
OF JANUARY- SO THAT THAT MEANS
THAT- AND I KNOW THAT'S-
CERTAINLY NOT YOUR INTENTION
BUT- THAT THE- CERTAINLY SHOULD
BE DRIVING A TIMELINE THAT THEN
LEADS TO THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
SAW THAT HAPPEN ON THE INTERNET
AGAIN ENGINE ENDED JANUARY
FRANKLY. I GUESS THE QUESTION I
DO HAVE TO GET YOU TO TALK ABOUT
THE REST OF US YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE DIGITAL STAFFING AND SO
FORTH THAT MAGELLAN'S BRINGING
ON BOARD- IS THAT- IT IS. SO I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAVE
SERVICE CHALLENGES STAFFING
BEFORE I MEAN IT IS THERE IS%
THERE A CONTRACT- THAT THEY HAD
WITH T. H. C. S. I MEAN I GUESS
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT THE-
THE DAY CONTRACT FOR THE
SUFFICIENT STAFFING- AND THAT-
THERE. THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
I DON'T WANT THEM TO CONTINUE TO
UNDERSTAFFED BECAUSE THEY SAID
WELL TWO YEAR CONTRACTS FOR A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF STAFFING AND-
TURNS OUT WE NEEDED A LOT MORE
THAN WE DID BEFORE SO- CAN YOU
CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO THAT THAT
THE TERMS OF THE CAPACITY OF.
THE CONTRACTOR MAGELLAN TO BAD
PEOPLE TO CARRY OUT THE CONTRACT
IN A WAY THAT ENSURES SO I KNOW
THEY'RE GETTING HIT WITH
PENALTIES AND SO FORTH. BUT
MOVING FORWARD DENTURES THAT-
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THIS
TRANSITION AND- AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO FIND A CONTRACTOR WHO
GOES OH WELL YOU KNOW AND WE'RE
TRYING TO. WORK WITH THE COST OF
THIS CONTRACT IS GONNA BE MORE
THAN WHAT WE'RE GETTING FOR IT.
I WOULD SAY THERE ARE PROVISIONS
IN A CONTRACT SERVICE LEVEL
AGREEMENT REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW THE METRICS THAT
THEY MUST MEET AND YOU KNOW.
THEY WOULD NEED TO ADJUST THEIR
STOPPING TO MEET THOSE METRICS
AND SOME OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
THEY ARE USING- IS YOU KNOW
HIRING RECRUITING HIRING NEW
STAFF BRINGING- OTHER STAFF AND
FROM OTHER- MAGELLAN- THAT
PHARMACY PROJECTS AND THEN THEY
ARE ALSO- CONTRACTING WITH THEM.
A VENDOR A CALL CENTER VENDOR
THAT CAN KIND OF CONTRACT
CONTRACT AND EXPAND I'M JUST
SUPPORT. THAT THEY NEED THAT AS
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE MONTHS
AND YOU KNOW AS WE KNOW. I'VE
BEEN WITH AT ONE HUNDRED NINETY
DAY TRANSITION PERIOD ENDING IN
JULY WE ARE I MEAN OUR EYES ON
THE BALL AND HOW WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE PLANNING FOR THAT
AND THE ABILITY TO STOCK UP AS
NEEDED QUICKLY. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR BENEFICIARIES
CURRENTLY. BENEFICIARY IS THE
EXPERIENCE- AND GETTING THAT
MEDICATIONS ARE BENEFICIARIES AS
OURS OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
OKAY WELL IS IT IS IT A GUESS
I'D SAY IS THAT IF FOR SOME
REASON YOU CAN'T GET ALL THE
PIECES TOGETHER IN TIME CLEANING
THE STAFF AND WE- YOU KNOW JUST
REALIZED IT'S THE IT'S HARD TO
HIRE A- CIVIL PROTECTION A
LITTLE LATER TOO. SO YOU CAN
HAVE IT YOU CAN HAVE JOBS OPEN
THAT. ADVERTISE WE MAY NOT
ACTUALLY SOLD THEM ALL OR DID IT
HARDEN TIME FOR TRAINING SO
FORTH. I HOPE THAT WE WILL. AS
MUCH AS WE'D LIKE TO STICK TO
THAT. STILL THE TIME WHEN YOU
HAVE. THAT. THE TIMELINE
SHOULDN'T. OVERRIDE IT YOU KNOW
IT'S THE TASK SEASON. THEN WE
SLOW THE DOWN THAT WE DON'T
LEAVE PATIENTS HANGING- WE JUST
DON'T A REPEAT OF WHAT. AND
JENNY AND- I THINK THERE MAY
STILL BE SOME PEOPLE WERE STILL
DEALING WITH. OKAY AND THEN- I
GUESS. PLEASE READ THE UPDATE ON
THE FIFTH- ON THE PHARMACY
RECRUITMENT AND I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES MY QUESTIONS AT LEAST
FOR ITEMS THROUGH. ISSUE FIFTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU DR PEPPER TAKING
OVER FOR MINUTES I HAD A
TELEMEDICINE DEPARTMENT I FORGOT
ABOUT SO STEPPED UP IS EASY
RIGHT THERE IN THE HALLWAY- I
BET ALLERGIES IT TURNS OUT. SO
LET'S TAKE LET'S GO. SIXTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY IF THAT'S OKAY
JUST TO KIND OF CLIMB SOME
TOGETHER AND THEN WE'LL HEAR
FROM LA- ND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AFTER THAT. OKAY THANK
YOU. SO AND JUST TO SAY. GOOD
BYE BYE MISTER THE PRESENTATION.
BUT WE SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
WITH A DIRECT BOSS AND AT COOPER
YESTERDAY TALKING ABOUT. THIS
AND WE WILL BELABOR THE POINT- I
THINK EVERYONE EVERYONE WANTED
TO WORK- AND SO THAT THAT WILL
BE THE GOAL AND OF COURSE FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEIR MEDICATION
AND ALREADY HAVE. BEEN PRE
APPROVED. WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
SO- I WILL BELIEVE THE POINT AND
WE'LL MOVE ON BUT- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME ACTUALLY MADAM CHAIR I
BELIEVE THAT I CAN CORRECT ME IF
I HEARD. CORRECTLY THEY WON'T
HAVE ANY COMMENT UNTIL WE GET
THE ITEM THIRTY ONE. WRECKED YES
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU OKAY.
OKAY WELL LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GO
TO THIRTY ONE. BUT I MAY HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS I MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS. SEVERAL PEOPLE LOOK
LET'S JUST LET'S JUST GO TO
TWENTY AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL STOP
IN AND WILL REFLECT AND THEN
WE'LL GO FROM THERE OKAY. LET'S
DO THAT. OKAY ISSUE SIXTEEN
MEDICAL DENTAL POLICY- EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES IS THIS TRAILER
BILLING WHICH IS ALL. OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS THIRTEEN
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND- TO
IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE BASED DENTAL
PRACTICES INCLUDING. ADD A
LABORATORY PROCESS GROUNDS ON.
YOUR TEETH FOR ADULT MEDICAID
BENEFICIARIES. AS A COVER DENTAL
BENEFITS- FOR INDIVIDUALS TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER ONE
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TO RESTORE
OUR POSTERIOR CHOOSE TO NORMAL
FUNCTION. THE CRITERIA AND THE
DENTAL MANUAL- OF CRITERIA. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO REQUIRES ALL COVER
DENTAL BENEFITS. AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRIC DENTISTRY.
AND THE AMERICAN DENTAL
ASSOCIATION GUIDELINES- IT ALSO
REMOVES OUTDATED LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
EACH YES TO REDUCE THE RATE. OF
SEVEN GIVE ME ALL CURRENTLY H.
AND ROUTE PLANNING BY 41% FOR-
BY 41% FOR OUR BENEFICIARIES
CHEESY FOR YOU TO SAY. ALL RIGHT
I WILL TAKE THE NEXT ITEM. THINK
MYSELF- THE DEPARTMENT PROPOSES
TO EXTEND THE OPERATIONS. OF THE
EXISTING DENTAL MANAGED CARE
CONTRACTS FROM DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWO I HAD TO
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- THIS EXTENSION IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR DHS TO
PROCURE AND EXECUTE NEW
CONTRACTS. TO CONTINUE THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN BOTH SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELES. COUNTIES THROUGH
THE END OF THE NINETEEN FIFTEEN
B. WAIVER PERIOD. NEW CONTRACTS
RESULTING FROM THAT EXPERIMENT
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE NO SOONER
THAN JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. BY DHS IS COMMITTED
TO INCREASING MEDICARE BENEFITS
YOUR UTILIZATION OF DENTAL
SERVICES STATEWIDE. THE
EXTENSION TIME LINE OF THE-
DENTAL MANAGED CARE I WILL
CORRESPOND WITH THE TIME FRAME
NEEDED BY DHS TO PROCURE THE NEW
CONTRACTS YET COMPETITIVE.
PROCUREMENT PROCESS BY DCS
INTENDS TO MAINTAIN OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY OF ALL DENTAL
MANAGED CARE CONTRACTS THROUGH
THE EXTENDED CONTRACT PERIOD.
INCREASED MEMBER UTILIZATION AND
DENTAL SERVICES ADDITIONALLY A
CMS HAS A VERY- SHARED INTEREST
IN THIS AND IT WAS ONE OF THE
CORE PIECES OF OUR NEGOTIATIONS
ON THE NINETEEN FIFTEEN FEET.
AWAY FOR A DAY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
DENTAL UTILIZATION RATES ARE FOR
THE FOR SERVICE INCREASE- I
STARTED DENTAL. MANAGED CARE
INCREASED TO IMPROVE AND BE IN
PARITY WITH AT A MINIMUM FEE FOR
SERVICE ABOUT OF COURSE. EVEN
HIGHER- IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH CMS- THEY DID REQUIRE A FEW
THINGS THAT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
IN REGARDS TO DENTAL MANAGED
CARE WITHIN THE NINETEEN FIFTEEN
B. STANDARD TERMS AND
CONDITIONS. INCLUDING PUTTING A
MONITORING PLAN PERFORMANCE. IN
PLACE- SPECIFICALLY AROUND KEY
QUALITY MEASURES- AND THEN ALSO
CONSIDERING A PRIOR PERFORMANCE
FOR MANAGED CARE PLANS OPERATING
IN DENTAL MANAGED CARE. PROGRAM
AS A COMPONENT OF ANY PRE
PROCUREMENT- IF THAT POTENTIAL
AWARD HE'S FIVE YEAR HIS PERFORM
. ON THE- MEASURES IT'S BOTH
THAT PERFORMANCE THE STATE
BEFORE AND- PROBE. THE STATEMENT
PROVIDED THE TO SEE. AWARDING
CON. ISSUE THAT MANAGED PLAN
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE MUST
ARRANGE FOR AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION. OF THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM AND SUBMIT
THE FINDINGS- NINETY DAYS AFTER
THE END OF THE SECOND YEAR OF
THE WAIVER TO CMS. ARE THE STATE
MUST ESTABLISH A PAYMENT
WITHHOLD ARRANGEMENTS A LINK TO
PERFORMANCE- FOR THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. WE ALSO MUST
SUBMIT ANY CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLANS ADDRESSING THE IDENTIFIED
MATCHED YOUR DEFICIENCIES TO SEE
A MASS OF THE STATE ADDITIONALLY
MUST REQUIRE A PURITY OF
PERFORMANCE BETWEEN DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAMS AND THE
FEE FOR SERVICE- DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THE PARITY IS NOT
ACHIEVED IN EACH MEASURE BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BENEFICIARIES. IN
COUNTIES WITH MANDATORY
ENROLLMENT MUST BE ALLOWED TO
DESCEND ROLE FROM ANY SUCH PLAN-
THAT IS NOT SHARING THE QUALITY.
OF SERVICES AND THE STATE MUST
UNDERTAKE A REVIEW OF SUCH
MANAGED CARE PLAN WITH
INFORMANTS. AND TAKE- AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER THAT
MANAGED CARE PLANS WILL CONTINUE
TO CONTRACT OR WHETHER THE STATE
WOULD NEED TO SUSPEND AND
TERMINATE. THIS WAS A LARGE PART
OF OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH CMS WHEN
WE WENT TO RENEW DENTAL MANAGED
CARE AND THEY MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THEY WILL BE WATCHING THIS
CLOSELY AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH THEM. AS WE
CONTINUE TO DO OVERSIGHT OF
DENTAL MANAGED CARE. NOW TURN IT
OVER TO THE SHOP FOR THE NEXT
ITEM. SO A- THE CARE AND- WE ARE
. IT TO YOU LIMITED TERM REESE-
OCCUR WHEN SHE PRESERVE. AND
CONTRACT. BY NEED IMPLEMENT SP
SIXTY. OF TWO ONE. SP SIXTY- IN
REQUIRED TO DEPART YOU CAN AND
HELP LIVE IN A IT WORKS. AT BY
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO THROUGH
. AND OF- DOES DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY- THE WORKGROUP AT
SHOULD EXAMINE. IF AND DO DO
WITH. AS A NEW BAND. ENGAGED JAN
A IS HOW CARE FOR. CONSUMER AND
CAN BE AFTER ALL PLANS IN COUNTY
REPRESENT. AND PUBLISHER. BY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY. THESE RESOURCES
WILL ALLOW DH CS TO COMPLETE THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD ASSIGNMENTS
RESULTING FROM PROGRAM AND
POLICY CHANGES. ASSURE A
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION AND
TRACKING OF THE DUAL BENEFIT
AND- THAT PRODUCED BOT DRIVEN
QUALITY PRODUCTS IN A TIMELY
MANNER WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO- MAKE NEXT. BY THE NEXT
ITEM. ISSUE AT THE INDIAN
HEALTH- GRANT PROGRAM. THE
BUDGET REQUIRES TWELVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN ONE TIME FUNDING
TO RESTORE THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM A GREAT PROGRAM AND FIND
THREE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUNDLE SUPPORT FORTY
FIVE INDIAN HEALTH CLINIC
CORPORATIONS IN RECRUITING. AND
RETAINING PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE FOR AMERICAN INDIANS RECENT
DATA SHOWS THAT AMERICAN INDIANS
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE LOWER
LIFE EXPECTANCY AND
DISPROPORTIONATE DISEASE BURDEN
HEALTH STATUS A CALIFORNIA
INDIANS IS RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF
THE LOWEST OF ANY ETHNIC GROUP
IN THE STATE WITH HIGHER
PREVALENCE OF PRETERM BIRTHS. TO
SIDE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
DRUG INDUCED DEATHS DUE TO
DIABETES AND OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES- DISEASES THAN AT ANY
OF THE GENERAL POPULATION
FURTHER THE SPINE SUPPORT THE
DHS QUALITY STRATEGY CALLS. ON
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE AND
DELIVERY. AND WITH TO THE
COMMITTEE'S QUESTION REGARDING
WHY THE FUNDING IS PROPOSED
SINGLE YEAR WE WOULD REFER TO AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THE NEXT ISSUE I BELIEVE- GOING
THROUGH ISSUE TWENTY- IS
TRANSFORMING QUALITY OUTCOMES
AND HEALTH EQUITY IN MEDI CAL OR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL SH DO YOU
SEE S. REQUEST FOR POINT SIX
MILLION TOTAL FINE AND NINETEEN
PERMANENT POSITIONS FOR
TRAINING. HEALTH EQUITY QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT AND CULTURAL
PROFICIENCY TO ADDRESS AT LEAST
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT IN HEALTH
EQUITY EFFORTS FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES HI IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE CREATED A QUALITY
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. HEARD OUR FIRST CHIEF
QUALITY OFFICER AND LIFTED AND
SHIFTED- OUR OFFICE OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR TO THE QUALITY
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM- THE QUALITY HEALTH.
QUALITY POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM RECEIVE
RESOURCES IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET PRIMARILY
RELATED TO CAL AIMS- POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT WORK.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE ONGOING
EFFORT TO CONSOLIDATE QUALITY
AND HEALTH EQUITY RESOURCES AND
WORKLOAD AT YOU THIS NEW A
PROGRAM- WE WILL CREATE A
CULTURE OF. OUR PROGRAM AND DATA
DRIVEN IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE WHOLE PERSON AND
WHOLE FAMILY. IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF PREVENTIVE AND
CHRONIC CARE FOR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS ARE BY MEDICARE I'LL-
STRIVE TO ELIMINATE RACIAL AND
OTHER DISPARITIES THROUGH
COMMUNITY CENTER COLLABORATION.
AND IMPROVE THE TRANSPARENCY.
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. AS REFEREE IN THE
BUDGET PURPLE ONE IN HAVE BEEN
MADE THE MEDICAL PROGRAM QUALITY
SCORE IN GENERAL BEEN STAGNANT-
WITH SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN CARE
AND CHILDREN'S PREVENTIVE
SERVICES MATERNITY CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND DENTAL
SERVICES. NUMEROUS DISPARITIES
ALSO EXIST BY RACE ETHNICITY
YEAH GEOGRAPHICALLY LANGUAGE AND
CONTINUED AN EARLY UNDER
UTILIZATION AND ACCESS ISSUES
FOR SOME POPULATIONS. THE GOAL
OF THE B. C. P. IS TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
REORGANIZED OUR PROGRAM
RESULTING IN A DIVISION OF
QUALITY AND HEALTH EQUITY AND A
DIVISION OF POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT- THE REASON REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL SPECIFICALLY AT.
WORK TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
LADERSHIP TO BUILD AMBITIOUS
QUALITY EQUITY IN POPULATION
HEALTH AGENDA- THAT IS INCLUDED
IN OUR COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY
STRATEGY. EXPAND BEST PRACTICES
AND QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE AND MONITORING
ESTABLISHED IN THE MEDICAL
MANAGED CARE- PROGRAM TO THE
BEER HEALTH AND DENTAL DELIVERY
SYSTEMS WHICH TRADITIONALLY HAVE
NOT HAD AS MUCH OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY OR STANDARD
EXPECTATIONS. FOR IMPROVEMENT
AND ESTABLISHED PROGRAM ELEVATE-
AT EVALUATION AND MONITORING
WHICH WILL READ ALL AND WILL
LEAD ALL OF THE CAL AM
EVALUATION COMPONENTS. AS WELL
AS BUILDING INTERNAL AND DCS
CAPACITY FOR A MORE ROBUST
PROGRAM OF THE EVALUATIONS. TO
GUIDE FUTURE POLICY. SECOND
QUARTER THE PRESENTATION I ISSUE
TO OKAY. HELLO OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINE- START WE THE LA- FOR ON
ISSUES THROUGH TWENTY PLEASE.
ANYTHING TO ADD. THANK YOU
SENATOR ADNAN KOREA SHEET WITH
THE ALLEY- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO RESOLVE THESE ISSUES
AND THE NEXT TIME WE WILL RAISE
COME IT WILL BE FOR ISSUE THIRTY
ONE AT LEAST. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
INTRODUCTION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST RESPONDING TO. THAT
ONE QUESTION ON THE ON THE
pMY SINGLE YOUR FUNDING IS
PROPOSED RATHER THAN ONGOING. WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY IS MUSCLE. CONCEAL
CONSIDERABLE RISK REMAINS- AND
BUILDING STRONG REVENUES IS
CRITICAL. OR FROM RESERVES IS
CRITICAL IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT ONE
TIME RESERVE REVENUES BE USED
FOR ONE TIME EXPENDITURES IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN. FISCAL
STABILITY HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH. OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE OR- I'M- IMMIGRATION
. NOTHING ELSE ON THE OTHER I'M
ITEMS OKAY AND I THINK JUST FOR
THE RECORD THE- YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DOING A WHOLE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF EQUITY. AND SO
THIS IS A I THINK IT'S A GREAT
ISSUE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY-
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES THAT
HAVE OFTENTIMES EXPERIENCE THE
LACK OF THAT. AND SO I'M VERY
HAPPY THAT WE'RE FUNDING. FOR
THEIR THEIR ISSUES AGAIN AND
WOULD WOULD LIKE US TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT IF POSSIBLE BUT
APPARENTLY THING ON THESE ISSUES
. THANK YOU- I APPRECIATE ON
ISSUE SIXTEEN CONSIDER THIS
PRACTICE ON ISSUE SEVENTEEN
EXTENSION DENTAL MANAGED CARE
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT AN
EVER RECALL CORRECTLY AND
DEDRICK HOW AIMED AND THE REPORT
SHERMAN WERE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
ACTUALLY THE REPORTER RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO MEDICAL DENTAL AND LONG TERM
CARE TOGETHER. SO WHEN IT COMES
TO THE X. YEAH SO I GUESS THIS
PROPOSAL FOR A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION FOR THE DENTAL MANAGED
CARE. AND I KNOW THAT- YOU
TALKED ABOUT DIFFERENT
PROVISIONS FOR ENSURING THAT THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS HAVE TO MAIL
MEET UTILIZATION OTHER THINGS
COMPARISON T. FOR SERVICE SO
FAR. IS THE ATTENTION TO BECAUSE
IT. WOULD EVENTUALLY GOING TO
THEN PUT EVERYONE BACK TO
ILLUSTRATE. AT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE
TO PUT PEOPLE INTO MANAGED CARE
IN THE FUTURE PLUS WITH THE
RETIREMENTS AT RATE OF ACTUALLY
SELL BECAUSE THOSE WERE PUTTING
TOGETHER DECKS. THE MEDICAL
BILLS THE HEALTH PLAN WITH THE
DENTALS AND- AND THEN THE LONG
TERM CARE. SO IS IT IS IT IS THE
INTENTION THEN TO- TO BASICALLY-
CONTINUED EXISTING MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND THAT THE DENTAL PLANS
UNTIL AND EVENTUALLY THAT GETS
FOLDED IN AS AS EVER THAT'S NOT
ONLY OF COURSE THERE'S TWO
COUNTIES BUT EVERY OTHER COUNTY
GETS A- IT IS ROLLED INTO SOME
SORT OF A- DENTAL MANAGED CARE
AS PART OF THE LARGER.
RETIREMENT YES JUST TO CLEAR
THAT MY COMMENTS EARLIER WERE
JUST SPECIFIC TO THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS THAT EXIST IN
SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES OKAY
YOU ARE CORRECT IN THE ORIGINAL
CALLIN PROPOSAL THERE WAS
CONTEMPLATION ON A- VERY FUTURE.
A CONCEPT AROUND A CARBON DENTAL
INTO YOU TO MEASURE AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S A CEMETERY- A PILOT-
THAT JUST WENT LIVE WITH THAT
ALL RIGHT NOW. HOWEVER THAT IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT R.
F. P. THAT IS OUT FOR MANAGED
CARE PLANS THAT WOULD GO LIVE IN
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. WE ARE PRESUMING THAT WILL
BE A FIVE YEAR. CONTRACT WITH
THOSE THAT DO THE PROCUREMENT SO
THE SOONEST THAT WE WOULD ENGAGE
IN THAT IS QUITE FAR FROM NOW IT
WOULD BE NOT INTEL I YOU KNOW AT
LEAST TWENTY TWENTY NINE OR
LATER. BUT THIS TIME I WE ARE
NOT CONSIDERING THAT AS A PART
OF THAT THE PLAN HERE WE STILL
NEED TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
FROM CMS IS A PERSPECTIVE OF THE
CURRENT DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAMS- AND SO. THAT IS WHAT
WE ARE ARE FOCUSED ON BECAUSE
PROCUREMENT IF THAT'S HELPFUL
OKAY SO THERE IS THE ADDED SO
THERE WILL BE A REQUIREMENT FOR.
A RE PROCUREMENT AND DISTURBING
YOU MEET ALL STANDARDS AND JANET
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. YES
THAT IS CORRECT FOR BOTH
SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO IT'S ONE
TWENTY OKAY PREACHER TO
CLARIFICATION THERE- AND THEN ON
ISSUE EIGHTEEN- IN TERMS OF- THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF SB SIXTY
FIVE- FROM UNDERSTAND. THE AND-
WERE RIGHT TO SOME SO THAT
SOMEONE FROM. THAT WE RAN INTO
WE- TALKED ABOUT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING
REGARDING HEARING AIDS BUT THIS
TIME AROUND TO US. AND SO- SORRY
PREFIGURE YOU KNOW GETTING SOME
POSITIONS BUT CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THE STATUS OF WHAT'S IN IT
WHAT'S THE UPTAKE BY DEALERS AND
IN THIS PROGRAM I MEAN IT'S
GREAT WE'RE SAYING WE DON'T
PROVIDE COVERAGE WE SAID WE
DON'T BUY COVERAGES. FOR HEARING
AIDS AND I FOUND THAT WHILE YOU
GOT LIKE FORTY SOME PEOPLE
ENROLLED SO WHAT WHAT'S THE
STATUS ON AND INSTEAD AND
ENGAGING THE DEALER COMMUNITY AN
ACTUAL PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROGRAM. SHORT ARE YOU WANT TO
GO WITHOUT IT YEAH. WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING IN AN EXTENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS- WITH OUR-
DEALER PARTNERS- AND YOU KNOW
WITH THAT BACKING IN THAT- WE
START TO SUBMIT OUR OUR STATE
PLAN AND MANAGE IT TO CMS. WE'RE
STILL IN THAT KIND OF THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF WORKING HERE
THIS BENEFIT AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO CHASE EACH HAS ANYTHING
TO ADD. YEAH I WAS JUST GONNA
MAKE SURE MAKE SURE EVERYONE'S
CHECKING THIS THIS BENEFIT HAS
NOT GONE LIVE YET AT ALL RIGHT
WE ARE STILL DESIGNING IT WE'RE
STILL UNDERSTAND THE PARAMETERS
OF- OF WHAT THE STATE PLAN WOULD
LOOK LIKE AND WE ARE STILL
WORKING. ON THE REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGIES WE'VE HAD
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
AROUND IT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS- A LOT HAS
CHANGED SINCE WE ORIGINALLY I
DRAFTED THE ORIGINAL BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND SO. YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE THAT
CLARIFICATION OKAY SO WHAT IS
THE TIMELINE FOR THIS TO
ACTUALLY GO LIVE SO OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE GETTING MORE FOR
BUDGETING. FOR STAFF TO HELP YOU
DO THAT. YES WE JUST. REESE AND
NOW THAT THIS WILL I PUT TO JACK
BRING TO TWENTY. GIVEN THE
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
AND- AND NEEDS TO KIND OF WRAP
HER ARMS AROUND THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE WITH
PEOPLE. HERE EVERYONE THINKS WE
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO
GET IT RIGHT WE AGREE AND SO I
WE ARE COMMITTED TO DO THAT.
THAT PROCESS OKAY SO WE'RE
LOOKING HOPING TO GET SOMETHING
OUT THERE BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- THAT PEOPLE CAN
START GETTING THE SERVICES. THAT
IS THE GOAL OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
WE'LL KEEP AN EYE ON THAT. THANK
YOU- THE PRESHEAF FINANCE IT'S I
THINK I WOULD AGREE WITH THE
CHAIR ON INDIAN HEALTH GRANT
PROGRAM THAT- THIS IS ON ON
GOING AND EQUITY SO BELIEVE ME
I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO BUDGET
ISSUES HAVING BEEN HERE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION- BUT- SO I
DO APPRECIATE THE- HELP BRING IT
BACK BUT- THINKING ABOUT THIS IS
REALLY JUST A ONE YEAR THING.
AND THEN THE ON ISSUE TWENTY AND
I GUESS THIS QUESTION REALLY-
AGAIN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE BUT I
GUESS IS THE QUESTION THAT WILL
TIE TOO MANY OTHER. ISSUES WHICH
ACTUALLY INVOLVES STAFFING
INCREASES AND SO FORTH- BUT JUST
GO AHEAD AND ASK IT FOR WITH
THIS ONCE I ALTERED YES GOOD
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. SO FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT TO SAY IS THAT-
BUT SOMEONE WHO'S OF COURSE HAD
TO PARTNER WITH THE DH CS AND-
OVERSEE DHS AND THE LEGISLATURE-
JUST ONE AGAIN THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE WORK AT DHS FOR THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK. IN
TERMS OF TRANSFORMING MEDIC HAL
AND IMPROVING MEDIC HAL. AND IN
MANY WAYS- I DO BELIEVE THE
AGENCY IS SOMEWHAT SHORT STAFFED%
ACTUAL HIM BE ABLE TO DO ALL THE
THINGS THEY NEED TO DO SO I
APPRECIATE OR CD'S BCPS TO
EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF
DEPARTMENT. I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY TIMES I'VE HEARD THERE WAS
ENOUGH BANDWIDTH TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS- AND JUST KNOWING
HOW MANY YEAH. KNOWING THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK AT THE ATS HOW
HARD THEY WORK SO I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT AND I'M SUPPORTIVE
OF. THIS B. C. P.'S- I GUESS MY
QUESTION THOUGH IS THAT- AGAIN.
IN THIS PARTICULAR AND
ENVIRONMENTS- WITH THE HIRINGS
BEEN A BIT OF A CHALLENGE. FOR
PEOPLE- SO. CAN YOU JUST SPEAK
TO- WHAT'S BEING DONE TO- SO
WE'LL WE'LL- FILLED WITH GO
THROUGH THE- PROCESS HOPEFULLY
WILL BE APPROVING. BECAUSE TO
GIVE PEOPLE HIGHER AND I DON'T
KNOW THE CURRENT RATE ISN'T SEE
A AS WELL SO YOU JUST BE TO THE
STAFF OF DH IN TERMS OF. VACANCY
RATES TURNOVER AND- YOUR
CAPACITY YOU THINK TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE TO THESE TO NOT ONLY THIS
THIS PCP BUT OTHERS SOME OF THE
OTHER ONES THAT. WILL COME LATER
ON IN OUR HEARING. I CAN START
AND A. J. C. OR LOWER IF YOU
WANT TO JUMP IN AS WELL I THINK.
AT RIGHT NOW WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT
ASKING 414% VACANCY WHERE EVERY
DEPARTMENT WIDE- I THINK YOU
KNOW THIS. B. C. P. IN
PARTICULAR THAT THE QUALITY OF
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM IN KIND OF THE NEW
EFFORT THAT ARE CHEAP QUALITY
OFFICER. DOCTOR POLLOCK BUT
THERE IS A LEADING REALLY IS AN
EXCITING KIND OF I'M A- NEW
PIECE OF WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT
ART THAT JUST KIND OF THE WAY
IT'S BEING ORGANIZED I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST- FOR
FOLKS WANTING TO JOIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE PART OF SOME OF
THIS WORK HERE WITH CAL AMEN
KIND OF. THE NEW WORK WE'RE
DOING OUR CARPETS A QUALITY
STRATEGIES I THINK. I'M MORE
TRYING TO BUILD ON KIND OF GOT
THAT MISSION AND THE GOAL TO
REALLY TRANSFORM HEALTHCARE FOR
OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM AND
STATEWIDE AND SO. I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD ON THAT
MESSAGING AND RECRUIT AS MUCH AS
WE CAN- THAT DC OR I DON'T HAVE
ANY MORE OF THE TECHNICALPIECES
OUTRAGEOUS. SENATOR HANDS
QUESTIONS. YEAH NO I AGREE. I
HAVE ANYTHING I MUCH. TO ADD
MICHELLE I THINK YOU KNOW. WE
ARE TRYING TO GET REALLY
CREATIVE US AND OUR PEN AND WE
ARE SO HOW WE DO SOME OF OUR
RECRUITING. AND HIRING- BUT
DOES. BUT NOTHING ELSE OUT OF
THE NOT. OKAY I APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW BUT WE WANT TO SEE THESE
THINGS HAPPEN. MAYBE I'LL JUST
MAKE A REMARKS THAT- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE I USED TO BE THE PURSE
SHARE. THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
SHARE. AND I WOULD JUST MAKE AN
OBSERVATION THAT- YOU KNOW- AT
THE FAR HEALTHCARE SERVICES
OVERSEAS HALF THE COVERAGE OF
FOURTEEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
RIGHT. THAT'S ON THE MOST TOWNS
SOME THE MORE CHALLENGING
POPULATIONS THE COVER. AND OF
COURSE- THE STAFFING IN THE
HIRING AND THE EVEN THE SALARIES
OF THE DIRECTOR AND THE STAFF
AND SO FORTH FOLLOW CIVIL
SERVICE RULES- NINETY WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL COVERED CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM. WHEN WE HEARD COVERED
CALIFORNIA SO CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT TO. YEAH SO CERTAINLY THEY
DESERVE WHAT THEY GET BUT I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT FOR EXAMPLE
THE SECOND DOCTOR COME TELEPHONE
IS ONE THE HIGHEST PAID. PLEASE
I THINK YOU DESERVE IT- IN IN
THE STATE BUT YET THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK AT THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
pPROCESSIONS HURT THEIR THEIR
DATA FILE CIVIL SERVICE RULES
FOR YOUNG COVERED CALIFORNIA
THEY HAVE MANY EXAMPLES DITIONS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE VERY HIGHLY
PAID. NOW I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S
THE ONLY REASON I THINK MANY
PEOPLE ARE WORKING FOR THE
MISSION- BUT- IS WORK AND I
GUESS IT'S MORE OF A GENERAL
STATEMENT ON A CHARRED AND IT IS
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT DTS. IS
THAT YOUR AGENCIES DOING A LOT
OF REALLY DIFFICULT WORK AND- I
HOPE WE'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM AN
HR PERSPECTIVE THE FACT YOU HAVE
A 14% VACANCY RATE. THAT WE NEED
TO DO BETTER TO BE SURE WE CAN
ATTRACT PEOPLE TO STATES SERVICE
AND- AT THE CURRENT COMPENSATION
NECESSARY TO RECRUIT THE
APPROPRIATE PEOPLE. TO COME TO
STATES SERVICE- SO I GUESS
THAT'S A COMMENT I'M GONNA ASK
YOU TO ANSWER THAT AND DAVID
IT'S. A FOLLOW UP CONVERSATION
WE SHOULD HAVE WITH. L. HR IN
AND IT'S A- BUT I DO I RECOGNIZE
THAT- THE HARDWARE OF. THE
PARTIAL CURE SERVICES AND THE
PEOPLE THERE THE LEADERSHIP.
THIRTY PM AND GIVE YOU ALL RAISE
ITS NICE. IT'S NICE FOR HEARING
- OKAY LET'S MOVE ON- I THINK
RUN ISSUE TWENTY. DID I MISS.
YES LET'S GO TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE. I BELIEVE WE ARE ON TWENTY
ONE AND I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
LAURIE OKAY TWENTY ONE. YES
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY
WALKER AND THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER FOR THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH SERVICEMEN. WELL THE LAST
COUPLE OF ISSUES FOR. IDEAS YEAH
. ONE YEAH THE QUESTION CAN.
SESSION TO YOUR LENDER TO STARTS
WITH A QUICK ONE TO FIVE
POSITION. WHICH IS TO FARM
DOLLAR AN EXTRA AUTHORITY. TO
BUILD UPON OUR FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN BUDGET PACKAGE RELATING
TO AFRICA STRENGTHEN ARTICLE.
INCLUDING UPGRADING OUR ENHANCED
MEDICARE BUDGET ABSOLUTELY
DEFINED FOR SOME FUNCTIONALITY
OUR CASH FLOW MONITORING AND
REPORTING AND PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR INCREASING AND
COMPLEX WORKLOADS. ARE REQUESTED
PRECAUTIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
MANAGE INCREASINGLY COMPLEX
WORKLOADS INCLUDING BUDGETING
FOR EXPANDED POLICY CHANGES IN
THE BIENNIAL MEDIC OUR FAMILY
HEALTH ACROSS THE THIRTY FIFTH
MINUTE. LARGE VOLUME OF
OCCURRING A RECURRING AND AD HOC
DRILLS RELATED TO ENHANCED
FEDERAL FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
WE'LL FIND AN ACCOUNT ENHANCER
PARTY OVERSIGHT. TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
INTERNAL PARTNERS REGARDING
BUDGET DEVELOPING A FORECASTING
AND UPGRADING OUR NUMBER SYSTEM. WITH OUR LOCAL OFFICE. I
THOUGHT TO REMAIN INCREASED. IN
ABILITY. I'M NOT THAT ISSUE YOU
THANK ACTUALLY TWENTY TWO THAT'S
WHY I'M INTO PROGRAM MICHAEL THE
AGE GAP IS LIKE THIRTY ONE POINT
FIVE POSITION CONVERSION OF
LIMITED TERM STARTS THE PARK OF
THE- AND EXPENDITURE OF IF I
POINT SIX MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
THREE TWENTY INCREASED WORKLOAD
. AND BENEFITS OF I LOOK OKAY
FINANCING OF A AND MEDICARE
DENTAL DIVISION AND I MISS.BUT
AGGRESSIVELY FOR OF ALL LET
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE FOLLOW
WORKFLOW. A DOCTOR YOU KNOW
RATHER THAN HELPED POLICY THEN
YOU. MANAGEMENT CRITERIA. AS
LONG AS THE FACT THAT. POLICY
AND PRO. CREATE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CIRCLE FOR OF ON. OF
FINANCIAL CALL. AND MAINTAINING
BY GOING IN THE CRITICAL
WORKLOADS AND BEYOND THAT DOES
THAT WAS A MATTER EXPERTISE
REGARDING THE MANAGED CARE FINAL
. TRACKING MONITORING
COLLABORATING WITH OTHER PROGRAM
AREAS AND LIKE ON EITHER DATA
REQUESTS FROM STAKEHOLDERS
WITHIN THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
NFF WHAT CONTRACT WERE SIGNED OF
BECAUSE OF A FELONY. BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE INCREASED.
STAFF COUNTS BY THREE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THE FIRM AND
CONTRACT EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
WHICH REQUIRES AN INCREASE IN
OUR STANDARD COMPLEMENT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT POSITION
AND BOTH ARE CONTRACTING.
RESOURCES DIVISION. MOVING ON
ACROSS THE ISSUE ISSUE. TWENTY
OKAY YEAH THE QUEST FOR POINTS
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CURRENT
BY MEANS TWO YEARS BEFORE THE
FIGHT DRAWN ACCORDING OPERATION
ARE THE MEDICAID ENTERPRISE
SYSTEMS MODERATE. ACT THEY ARE
OVER THE THOUSAND YEAH MY FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY. THAT SUPPORTS THE
PART OF TRYING TO GET OUT OF
TITLE FUNDING AT THE PARK
ANOTHER COME FOR THEM. FIFTY
FIFTY FROM THE FINAL POLICE EVEN
PARK ON OFF OF CAR FOR THE AT
THE- GIRL DRAMA BUT BUT THAT
THAT'LL BE FOR ON BY TWO TWENTY
K. THANK YOU OKAY MOVING ON A
TWENTY. FOR I'LL BE DOING THE
ONE REALLY PRESS I'M SO. TWENTY
FOUR. GET MINUTES HERE I'M STILL
BE PROVIDES A COMPREHENSIVE
HISTORY AND OVER OF THE
COMMUNITY MEANT HEALTH AND CALL
FOR. CURRENTLY DO MENACE AND
OVERSEES SEVERAL HEALTH PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE WITHIN OUT NON
SPECIALTY MY HEALTH ARE DELAY IN
THE HOW FOR SYSTEM THE FIRST
DHARMASTHALA SYSTEM. AND THREE
MEDIC MANAGE CARE ESPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED THROUGH COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH YEAH. DH CS ALSO
ADMINISTERS FUNDING AUTHORIZED
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
AS WELL AS FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE COMMUNITY. MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT. THREE REALIGNMENT COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH ARE PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR EXPANDING THESE
FUNDING SOURCES AND IMPLEMENTING
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT SERVICES- COUNTY
OPERATED OR CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. WHAT'S GOING ON AT
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN WE'LL PASS
. I THINK THIS ONE IDEA ZERO DH
REQUESTS ARE SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND GENERAL FUNDING CURRENT
YEAR AND SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND BUDGET YEAR AND I'M GOING
TO REPEAT CMS FOR ANCILLARY
SERVICES PROVIDED IN SHORT TERM.
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
AT THIS REQUEST WOULD COVER THE
FEDERAL SHARE FOR ANCILLARY
SERVICES PROVIDED IN S. T. R. T.
V.'S- THAT ARE DETERMINED TO BE
INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL DISEASES
OUR I AM DES. WHICH ARE
PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING
FEDERAL MATCHING MEDICAID
FUNDING DURING FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. DO YOU SEE S.
KNOWS THE SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH COSTS FOR BENEFICIARIES
IN S. T. R. T. T. I AM THESE ARE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS SENSE THE
IDEA EXCLUSION PREDATES A
REALIGNMENT. DUE TO THE PASSAGE
OF FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND
INCREASED OVERSIGHT FROM CMS
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS. S. T.
R. T. PEAS THAT HAVE MORE THAN
SIXTEEN BEDS AND MEET THE
CRITERIA FOR- AND I INDEED WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS UNDER MEDIC HOW-
AS BACKGROUNDS THE ADD. UP AT
THE FEDERAL FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT INCLUDED
PROVISIONS TO REDUCE FEDERAL.
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR CONGREGATE
CARE SETTINGS FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WHO ARE CANDIDATES FOR
FOSTER CARE- THE ACTS CREATED A
NEW PROVIDER TYPE- CALLED THE
QUALIFIED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM- AS AN ALLOWABLE
CONGREGATE AT YOUR SETTING FOR
CHILDREN USE REQUIRING A
THERAPEUTIC PLACEMENT OF THE LAW
AS LONG AS SPECIFIC CRITERIA ARE
MET CALIFORNIA. ARE THESE ARE
REFERRED TO AS S. T. R. T. P.'S.
HOWEVER IN IMPLEMENTING THE
FAMILY FIRST- YOU MUST CLEAR BY
THAT YOU ARE T. V.'S THAT MEET
THE CRITERIA- OTHER NINETY ARE
CONSIDERED I AND YOU SENT US ARE
NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN IN
MEDICAID- ON JULY THIRD OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO YEARS JUST IN
A LETTER TO CMS EXPLAINING WHY
S. T. OUR G. FEES. I DO NOT MEET
THE CRITERIA TO BE CLASSIFIED AS
AN I. M. D. HOWEVER CMS
RESPONDED TO THE DEPARTMENT IN.
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS ON
A PEOPLE ARE. DEPARTMENT OF LAW
SURE OF ALL YEAR HE AND- S. R.
T. V. ARE ARE NOT I BEAT. AS A
RESULT OF THAT CMS RESPOND DH
YET HAS BEEN THE PROCESS TO COME
. A STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT OF ALL
. X. YOUR USED TO. WHAT ONES ARE
IN NINETY THIS IS A PHASE
APPROACH WHERE STARTED IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ARE WE ARE CONTINUING THIS.
THROUGH THE END OF THIS YEAR-
THIS REQUEST WOULD COVER THE
FEDERAL SHARE FOR ANCILLARY
SERVICES PROVIDED IN S. U. R. G.
E.'S DURING. THAT TIME PERIOD-
DETERMINATION US SOMETHING IS
DETERMINED TO BE AN I. N. G. IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED FUNDS TO DH CS TO
EMPLOYMENT THE- CALENDAR B. H.
Q. I. P. PROGRAM OUR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS. OF WHICH DH YES MARK A
SEVEN POINT FOUR FIVE SEVEN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IN THE SAME AMOUNT THE
FOLLOWING YEAR FOR MANAGED CARE
PLANS. ARE WORKING NEXT YEAR TWO
KEYS ON TRANSITIONS TO NEW
MODELS. A DH CS WILL PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
COUNTIES AS WELL AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANYTHING ON. ISSUES
TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY FIVE.
NO NOTHING YOU- L. ANYTHING
ISSUES TWENTY TO TWO FIVE. I
THINK IT'S ENTERTAINMENT CORE
ISSUE NO COMMENTS ON THESE ON
THOSE ISSUES OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND OF COURSE THE FIRST
COUPLED HAVING DEALING WITH AN
INCREASE PROGRAM WORKLOAD THAT
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT. FROM IS IT
THAT AND THEN TALKING ABOUT OUR-
COMMITTEE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
I HOPE THAT WE KEEP WORKING ON I
GUESS I GUESS WHEN THE QUESTION
DOES HAVE IS IT IS A TIME FOR
ANOTHER REALIGNMENT IS IT DO WE
NEED TO. RE LOOK AT. I'M DAVID
THE AMOUNT THAT'S COMING AN END.
OR DO OR DO WE THINK THAT. ALL
THE CHANGES THAT WE'VE BEEN
MAKING- SUFFICIENT FOR THE
SYSTEM. THAT'S MY QUESTION ON
TWENTY FOUR AND THEN ON TWENTY
FIVE- MY PERSONAL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THIS AND I
KNOW IT'S A PRIORITY- IN AN IN
RESPONSE TO CMS WE'VE HAD TO
DELAY BUT DO WE FEEL LIKE WE ARE
WE WILL BE ON TRACK- TO APPLY
FOR THAT WAIVER. BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR. TWENTY FOUR SO I WILL
ANSWER YOUR LAST QUESTION AND
DEFERRED THE REALIGNMENT
QUESTION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO RESPOND. I'M SO ON
THE I AM DEEP RIVER WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO BUILD
INTERNALLY- THE IDEAS THAT WE
WILL START STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT IN THE SPRING OF THIS
YEAR- AND THROUGH THE SUMMER.
WITH THE GOAL OF SUBMITTING THAT
THE WAIVER REQUEST TO CMS IN THE
FALL- OF COURSE YOU WOULD THEN
GO INTO NEGOTIATIONS AND WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT WE WERE
BEING ABLE TO GO LIVE INTO AT
LEAST- YOU'RE MOST LIKELY JULY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE GIVEN
OUR EXPERIENCE ON THE DMC ODS
WAIVER AND WHAT IT TOOK TO KIND
OF GET THAT UP AND RUNNING SO.
THAT IS UR CURRENT TIMELINE AND
WE ARE VERY COMMITTED TO MEETING
THOSE TIMELINES AND DEPARTED
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON THE-
QUESTION. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THE
REALIGNMENT QUESTIONS THIS TIME
BUT HAPPY TO. BE IN TOUCH. WE'LL
TAKE A QUESTION BACK. OKAY
WELCOME OKAY WELL I MEAN I GUESS
I GUESS MAYBE I ASK ELLIE ELSE
AND SO IT WORKS FOR US- SO IT'S
WRITTEN OUT I MEAN IT'S- AND
IT'S CERTAINLY DEALT WITH
REALIGNMENT HEARING THIS
COMMITTEE FIRM FOR MANY YEARS
AND- SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT. WE
HAVE SALES TAX VEHICLE LICENSE
FEE RATE AND- I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THE CORRELATION IS BETWEEN SALES
AND VEHICLE LICENSE FEE AND NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SO.
AND IT ALSO WITHOUT GOING INTO A
BILL WE ACTUALLY HAD A HEARING
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE TALKED
ABOUT THE REALIGNMENT HELD THE
MONEY SORT OF ACTUALLY FLOWS
THROUGH AND YOU KNOW SORT OF
LIKE A WATERFALL RIGHT AND THEN
THIS PERSON TKES AS ITS
CENTRAL. ANDS AND SOMEWHERE
TOWARD THE BOTTOM ACTUALLY IS
INTERESTING UP BOTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH- SO WE
WE'VE SEEN. WE'VE SEEN THEM
WHERE THINGS FARTHER UP THE
WATERFALL ESSENTIALLY HAVE DRIED
UP INCREASES TO FOR THOSE. SO IT
IS THAT THERE'S REALLY NO IT'S
DONE. SOME ANALYSIS AND SO THE
THOUGHTS OF. WE'D WE'D SO WE
HAVE THICK KALLONI AT THE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH PEACE OF
THE COUNTY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
AND THEN WE HAVE PROP SIXTY
THREE. NOT THAT IT'S BEEN A LOT
OF TIME TALKING ABOUT PROP SIXTY
THREEBUT- IS THERE BEEN ANY
ANALYSIS LOOKING AT- ALL TE
REVENUE FOR- EVEN A HEALTH.
CHANGES GIVEN. I GUESS THE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENTS WHICH
IS NOW I GUESS ELEVEN YEARS OLD
. AND MENTAL HEALTH DEMAND OR
EVEN JUST POPULATION SO IS IT
THE WHAT'S THE CORRELATION THERE
AND IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
ACTUALLY END UP ENDS UP. ALSO
TRICKLING DOWN OR GOING DOWN THE
WATERFALL INTO INTO MENTAL
HEALTH IS THAT WE- AS AS IT
WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. DR
VAN KOREA SHEET WITH THE L. A.
L. WE DON'T HAVE A YOU KNOW
PREPARED RECOMMENDATION ON SORT
OF WHAT SPECIFIC CHANGES TO
REALIGNMENT SHOULD- OCCUR GIVEN
SORT OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU YOU
WILL. DESCRIBE WHAT I WILL SAY
IS THAT OUR OFFICE. HAS TAKEN A
LOOK AT REALIGNMENT BROADLY IN A
REPORT WE CAME OUT WITH- I THINK
IT WAS ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO.
NOW WHERE WE SORT OF EXAMINE
THIS ISSUE YOU SPEAK OF. THE
FACT THAT REALIGNMENT REVENUES
AND VEHICLE LICENSE FEES AND
SALES TAX DON'T NECESSARILY
TRACK. WITH ANY SORT OF METRIC
OF MENTAL HEALTH THE MAN WE MADE
WE MADE WE RAISE SOME SORT OF
HIGH LEVEL. COMMENTS IN THAT
REPORT RELATED TO- ISSUE AND SIR
JUST SORT OF A RACE THAT HAS AN
ISSUE FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION BUT WE DON'T HAVE
WE DIDN'T HAVE SORT OF PREPARED
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT IN THAT
RECORD AT THAT TIME- WHAT I WILL
SAY IS THAT OUR OFFICE. NOW IS
WORKING ON A- SORT OF A PROJECT
LOOKING AT TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT BROADLY AND SORT OF
WE DON'T HAVE AN A AN
ANTICIPATED TIME. FRAME FOR WHEN
THAT SORT OF REPORT WOULD BE
RELEASED BY ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT IS SORT
OF THIS SIMILAR- ISSUE THAT YOU
RAISE AS FAR AS LIKE THE REVENUE
STREAMS NOT SORT OF TRACKING
WITH DEMAND FOR MENTAL HEALTH
THE OTHER THE OTHER POINT THAT I
WOULD. RAISE IS THAT THERE'VE
BEEN A NUMBER OF SIGNIFICANT
VERY SIGNIFICANT LIKE POLICY
CHANGES THAT HAVE OCCURRED SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN WHICH HAVE SORT OF
IMPACTED- SORT OF- WHICH MAY
HAVE SORT OF IMPACTED COUNTY. AT
LOCAL DEMAND FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO THERE'S YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A BIG EXPANSION. UNDER
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THERE
HAVE BEEN. CHANGES TO YOU KNOW
THE STRUCTURE THROUGH WHICH-
SUBSTANCE USE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH THE NEW THE
RELATIVELY NEW ODS SYSTEM AND
SO- ONE OF THE ISSUES ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING A LOOK AT IT JUST
SORT OF THERE. THE. THAT SORT OF
THESE REVENUES THEY DON'T JUST
THEY DON'T JUST NOT TRACK SORT
OF MENTAL HEALTH TO ME AND THEY
DON'T THEY ALSO DON'T TRACK SORT
OF SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGES
THAT MAY OCCUR- AFTER SORT OF
THE REALIGNMENT DATE AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A SUPER
HELPFUL ANSWER FOR YOU I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT
IT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK
INTO IT YEAH AND I THINK THAT
AND I THINK THAT'S THE POINT
THAT WE'RE THAT WE'RE WONDERING
WHY SHOULD WHY SHOULD WE REALLY
BE LOOKING AT THIS AND SO WE'RE
GLAD THAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
THAT AND LOOKING AT IT AS WELL
BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE TRACKED
SOME KINDA. IT TO SOMETHING. HAD
GET IN. THE SALES TAX VEHICLE.
LICENSE FEE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE.
EXACTLY THAT- BUT ANYWAY I AM
GLAD YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT. AND I
THINK WE'LL HAVE A LOT MORE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS GOING
FORWARD. NO NO AND- TODAY I DO
THINK THAT ALICE IS GONNA BE
REALLY IMPORTANT. RIGHT AND IN
FACT- CHEROKEE MEN- IT MEANS.
THAT I KNOW YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
MENTAL HEALTH- BUT MAY BE BOLD
TO. SUGGEST THAT WE WORK WITH
THE L. A. O. AND CONSIDER AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING JUST. YOU
KNOW WHAT. WE DON'T EVEN NEED
RECOMMENDATIONS LET'S JUST LOOK
AT WHAT THE SITUATION IS RIGHT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE. BOTH THE
REALIGNMENT MONEY FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WE HAVE PROP SIXTY THREE.
AND I UNDERSTAND. THAT YOU'RE A
MAN YOU'RE TAKING A LEADERSHIP
ROLE LOOKING AT PROP SIXTY
THREE. HOW THEY COME TOGETHER-
AND OF COURSE THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN REQUIREMENTS AND AS YOU SAID
WE'VE MADE OTHER STRUCTURAL
CHANGES. AND THE- THIS IS A
FORMER CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ALSO YOU KNOW. OPENING UP
REALIGNMENT OF BIG TIME. IS A
VERY DAUNTING TASK SO IT'S A-
IT'S A- SO I. WON'T QUITE
SUGGEST THAT YET. ALTHOUGH I
THINK I HAVE IT IN THE PAST
SAYING THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD.
KIND OF. THINK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT BUT- BEFORE ANYONE
GETS TOO FREAKED OUT HEARING ME
SAY THAT. RIGHT NOW- BUT AT
LEAST LET'S. LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
AT WHAT. KIND OF RESOURCES. DO
WE HAVE IN MENTAL HEALTH. AND
HOW. IT EXACTLY. SO IT'S NOT
IT'S A BUILT IN THE PAST AND
THEN WE HAVE PROGRAM CHANGES AND
THEN GOING TO THE FUTURE BECAUSE
OF ITS KIND OF FLAT. REVENUE
SOURCE WELL. WELL WITH THE
DEMAND IS GOING UP- WE'RE GONNA
FIGURE HOW TO CLOSE. GAP RATE
AND OF COURSE PROP SIXTY THREE
WE HAVE DEAL WITH OF ALL. RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT MAIN
REVENUE COMING SO IT'S PROBABLY
DOING PRETTY WELL RIGHT NOW-
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE- THERE'S
SOME PEOPLE DOING VERY WELL OR
VERY RICH. I THINK THE
WEALTHIEST PEOPLE DOUBLE THEIR
INCOME WHILE MANY OF US. FOR
NOT. IMPOSSIBLE TO RICH AND NOT
DONE SO WELL. WITH THE PANDEMIC-
BUT THAT HELPS OUR TAX REVENUES
SO. WE NEED TO LOOK AT THINGS
LIKE VOLATILITY WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THINGS LIKE- WHAT IS NOW
WE'RE GONNA GET THE COUNTY'S
RESPONSIBILITY AND- FOR MENTAL
HEALTH- WHAT RESOURCES. AT THE
REALLY GOTTEN IS THAT OUR DATE.
AND WE CALLED THE ALIGNMENT BUT
YOU KNOW HOW HOW THE LINES ARE
NOT ALIGNED SO EVEN JUST SIMPLY.
THEY GRAPH THAT SHOWS OKAY.
HERE'S POPULATION HERE IS THE
REVENUE. RIGHT HERE POINTS IN
TIME PROGRAM CHANGES AT CETERA.
AND HAVING AN EXPLANATION OF
THAT AND FRANKLY I THINK IT
WOULDN'T HURT TO HAVE A- OTHER
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WHAT
YOU'VE DONE HERE BEFORE A BRIEF
ONE. TO JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT
REALIGNMENT ITSELF MEANS THAT
OBVIOUSLY AFFECTS MENTAL HEALTH
BUT ALSO AFFECTS LOCAL FUNDING
FOR IBM FOR HSS EFFECTS- LOCAL
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
OTHER THINGS TO HER IN THE
REALIGNMENT. BUT BUT AT LEAST ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH. I THINK WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THE TRAJECTORY IS RIGHT IS
THAT IS THAT FUNDING PROJECT
REVIEWS FAR AS WE CAN PROJECT IS
THAT GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT OR
IS IT GOING TO BE BECAUSE OF
FALLING SHORT AND- AND SO THAT
WE KNOW WHAT KIND OF POLICIES WE
NEED TO. MAKE AND ALSO WHAT KIND
OF CONVERSATIONS WE DID HAVE
BECAUSE I WAS A REALIGNMENT IS
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE STATE
AND COUNTY STRAIGHT. AND SO
THERE'S- AND RELATION TO THOSE
REVENUE SO AS I GUESS- THIS I
WOULD PASS IT THE BEST OF THE
CHAIR ASK L. A. L. TO DO THOSE
TYPE ANALYSIS PERHAPS IN
PREPARATION FOR. A MORE IN DEPTH
EXAMINATION OF THIS ISSUE- MANY
PEOPLE SUGGEST STATS AND A HOPE
AND A PLAN ASK ELLIE- DO YOU
THINK THAT'S. SOMETHING YOU CAN
HELP WITH YOU CAN YOU CAN DO FOR
US. I CERTAINLY THINK IT'S A-
YOU WOULD WORK WITH SORT OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
PROVIDE. I YOU KNOW I DID
MENTION THAT THAT- THAT SORT OF
PROJECT THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT SORT OF SKIN IN THE WORKS
AT THE TIME AND SAID MAYBE THERE
CAN BE SOME INFORMATION THAT WE
COME UP WITH. THROUGH THAT
PROCESS THAT WE CAN SHARE BUT-
WE'LL WE'LL TAKE THAT BACK AND
WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE CAN SORT OF PROVIDE
TO THAT TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR XI YEAH AND I
AND I WAS NOT ON THE COMMITTEE
WHEN WE HAD THAT HEARING AND-
AND I KEEP WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
REALIGNMENT AND SO I WOULD LIKE
MORE INFORMATION AND TO ALLOW
STAFF TO MAYBE YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'LL BE DOING IT THIS YEAR. THE
HEARING HOPEFULLY WE WILL BUT WE
WON'T BE TACKLING ANYTHING
AROUND REALIGNMENT THIS YEAR-
BUT SO WE COULD MAYBE. SEE IF
ABOUT GETTING THAT SCHEDULED
LATER ON AND TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT I MEAN I DON'T. I DON'T
THINK IT'S OUTRAGEOUS TO SAY.
THAT OUR COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM HAS BEEN AN ABJECT
FAILURE I MEAN I DON'T THINK YOU
CAN READ ANYTHING. ANYTHING
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH IN OUR IN OUR COUNTRY
FROM THE SEVENTIES FORWARD THAT
SAYS THAT WE HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB WE HAVE STRUGGLED AT THIS.
WE ARE FORTUNATE RIGHT NOW THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES. AND
I'M AND WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T FAIL
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO DO
GOOD WORK IN TRYING THEIR VERY
BEST. WE FEEL BECAUSE THE SYSTEM
WAS STARVED AND WASN'T SET UP-
TO ACTUALLY DO COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH-THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY AFTER DE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. SO GOING
FORWARD AS WE HAVE A BUNCH OF
NEW RESOURCES AND NEW PROGRAMS-
I THINK IT IT MAKES SENSE TO
REALLY. THEN LOOK AT THAT MAP
KIND OF BASE FUNDING. GOING
FORWARD WITH REALIGNMENT MONIES.
SO ALL THE STAFF BEGIN TO WORK
ON. LOOKING AT THAT. OKAY LET'S
NOW DO- TWENTY SIX THROUGH TH.
WHAT WE DO. TWENTY SIX TO
THIRTY. ONE ABOUT THEIR- ALL
RIGHT WE'LL WE'LL START THAT. I
WILL I WILL KICK US OFF YOUR
DEPARTMENT SO I. DCS IS
REQUESTING ONE POINT THREE
MILLION I'M GOING AND THE
CONVERSION OF NINE LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES TO PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO MEET THE ON GOING WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE OVERSIGHT OF
MONITORING FOR. SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVAL
AND THE CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM- THE PCP IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
MISSION TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUOUS CARE FOR CHILDREN
THAT INCLUDES ACCESS TO QUALITY
COST EFFECTIVE OUR SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE SERVICES
WITHIN RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS. NOW
MOVE ON TO THE I. FOR THE NEXT
ITEM ARE REGARDING BEHAVIOR
HOLTZ WORKLOAD- DHS IS
REQUESTING TWENTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FOR THIRTY THREE A
NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS AT THE
CONVERSION OF ONE LIMITED TERM A
RESOURCE TO PERMANENT FIVE-
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM.
POSITION IN CONTRACT MONEY TO
BUILD OUT OUR CAPACITY TO HOLD
COUNTIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR NEW
STANDARDS EXPECTATIONS AND
SERVICES AT THIS REQUEST
INCLUDES- AN ADDITIONAL
EXECUTIVE POSITION- TOTALLY
DIRECTED MONITOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO EXPAND
THE CRISIS CONTINUOUS CARE I. G.
H. C. S. AS REQUESTS THAT
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT OVERSEE
SEVERAL SEVERAL CRITICAL
BEHAVIOR EALTH PROJECTS
INCLUDING. THE NINETY DAY
JUSTICE INVOLVED IN REACH
PROGRAM THE FEDERAL NINETY DAY
HOTLINE- DEED MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES MANAGED A NEW FEDERAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES INTENSIFYING
OVERSIGHT OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS I SUPPORT FOR THE
CHILDREN'S CRISIS CONTINUING
PILOT I SUPPORT FOR THE FAMILY
FIRST. PREVENTION SERVICES ACT I
. AND THAT IS. CONCLUSION ABOUT
I WILL ALSO DO AT THE NEXT I IS
BOUGHT BY DCS WORK EIGHT
POSITION AND ONE POINT THREE
MILLION EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT- SP TWO TO TWELVE-
THE- WHICH REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO PERFORM COMPLIANCE
OVERSIGHT OF- MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS A TIMELY ACCESS TO
CARE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
FOLLOWING A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES SPECIFICALLY WE WILL
DEVELOP AND COMMUNICATE POLICY
OF PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO MANAGED CARE PLANS MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS- AND A DRUG THAT
CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY SYSTEMS
OUR DMCS COUNTIES. PERFORM
MONITORING ACTIVITIES I WORK
WITH ARE CONTRACTED EXTERNAL
QUALITY REVIEW ORGANIZATIONS TO
UPDATE THE TIMELY ACCESS SURVEYS
IN METHODOLOGY R. S. SP TWO TO
ONE ODDS A NEW REQUIREMENTS-
THAT WILL APPLY TO YOU MANAGE
YOUR FRIEND'S MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS INDIAN CODIS COUNTIES-
ADDS AN APPOINTMENT TIME
STANDARD FOR NON URGENT FOLLOW
UP APPOINTMENTS WITH NON
PHYSICIAN MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
REQUIRES REFERRALS TO A
SPECIALIST BY A PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER OR ANOTHER SPECIALIST
BE SUBJECT TO A RELEVANT TIME A
LOT STANDARDS REQUIRES
INTERPRETER SERVICES TO BE
COORDINATED AT THE TIME OF THE
APPOINTMENT AND REQUIRES OUT OF
NETWORK COVERAGE OF MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TREATMENT OF A MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER IS NOT.
AVAILABLE IN THE PARK. BUT
REGARDING TO NINE OUT TURN IT TO
SPREADS THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
DON'T ACT NINE AS OUR MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT EXPANSION
PROGRAM. AND SO DH IS THE EXCESS
IS REQUESTING FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND CONTRACT
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY AS WELL AS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF A HUNDRED AND ONE
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS TO FURTHER
REDUCE OVERDOSE AND DEATH
RELATED- GET TO OPIOID MISUSE BY
EXPANDING NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION
PROJECT. WITH A FOCUS ON
PROVIDERS AND ORGANIZATIONS
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. BY SUPPORTING ONE
HUNDRED NEW MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT ACCESS POINT STATEWIDE
WITH A FOCUS ON UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. EXPANDING
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT IN
COUNTY JAILS AND DRUG COURTS
WONDERFUL BE USING GRANT FUNDING
TO CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR THIRTY
TWO CURRENT COUNTY EAST AND
EXPANDING TO ADDITIONAL
COUNTIES. INCREASING MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT SERVICES
WITHIN STATE LICENSED
FACILITIES- PRODUCT TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND MEDICATION UNITS
PROVIDING START UP COSTS
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THEN ALSO- MOBILE
METHADONE. THE UNITED STATES
SENATE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION REPORTED
A TWENTY EIGHT POINT 5% INCREASE
OF DRUG OVERDOSES FROM ONE YEAR
AGO IN ADDITION TO DOUBLING OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS. IN
CALIFORNIA OVERDOSE DEATHS HAVE
REACHED A HISTORIC HIGH AND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. TEAM
FUNCTIONAL RELATED OVERDOSE
DEATHS HAVE INCREASED. BY MORE
THAN A 100% COVERED NINETEEN HAS
EXASPERATED THIS CRISIS DUE TO
THE HABIT OF ISOLATION CAUSES
WITH THIS DISEASE. AND THIS IS-
NOT INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE WORKING
TOWARDS LONG TERM RECOVERY BUT
ALSO THOSE. THAT ARE ALREADY IN
LONG TERM RECOVERY AND ALSO THEY
DECREASE IN ACCESS TO AS YOU DO
SERVICES CAUSED BY COBIT
EMPLOYMENT CHANGES FINANCIAL
LOSSES AND THE STRESS OF THE
KINGDOM. THANK YOU REGARD TO
ISSUE THIRTY OVERSIGHT OF
INSURANCE POLICIES FOR RECOVERY
OR TREATMENT FACILITIES AT
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND I'M
GOING TO FIND THE ENGINE MONITOR
THE COMPLIANCE OF INSURANCE
POLICIES FOR LICENSED ALCOHOL OR
OTHER DRUGS A. O. T. A RECOVERY
OR TREATMENT FACILITIES AND THE
PROMULGATION OF REGULATIONS TO
ENABLE THE ENFORCEMENT OF A. B.
A LOT OF FIFTY EIGHT. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE EIGHT ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT REQUIRES DHS TO ESTABLISH
POLICIES PROCEDURES AND
REGULATIONS CONTINUE TO CONDUCT
COMPLIANCE REVIEWS OF AOD
RECOVERY AND TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND ADMINISTER
PENALTIES OR DISCIPLINARY ACTION
FOR NON COMPLIANCE WITH
SPECIFIED MINIMUM. INSURANCE
LEVELS ADDITIONALLY THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A FEE INCREASE
FOR RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
RECOVERY OR TREATMENT PROGRAMS
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE PROPOSED FEE
INCREASES THAT'S SCARY BECAUSE
LICENSE AND CERTIFICATION FEES
FOR RESIDENTIAL OUTPATIENT.
PROGRAMS ARE INSUFFICIENT TO
COVER OUR REGULATORY COSTS. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF FINALIZING
THIS PROPOSAL- OUR INITIAL
ESTIMATES THAT BIT THE INCREASE
WILL BE ABOUT 45% BUT WE ARE
STILL REFINING THE NUMBERS. COST
OF INCREASED OVER TIME OFF FEES
HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THAT CONCLUDES
THIS ITEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CLOSE TO THIRTY ONE. ALL RIGHT-
THAT SO A PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED
INTO THE AMERICAN RESCUE UP PLAN
ACT IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE A DISH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
THE ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT WHAT'S
CALLED THE HUMMING COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES SPENDING PLAN OF
ESSENTIALLY THE ACT PROVIDED
STATES WITH AN ADDITIONAL 10% OF
FEDERAL. DOLLARS OUR MATCH- FOR
A CERTAIN EXPENDITURES IN THE
EAST YES PROGRAMME FROM APRIL OF
TWENTY ONE THROUGH MARCH OF
TWENTY TWO ADDITIONALLY IT
REQUIRES THAT STATES USE THE
FEDERAL FUNDS ATTRIBUTABLE TO
THOSE ENHANCED F. MAP DOLLARS TO
SUPPLEMENT NOT SUPPLANT EXISTING
STATE FUNDS EXPENDED FOR
MEDICAID H. C. B. S. SERVICES-
AFFECTIVE APRIL ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDING PROVIDES CALIFORNIA WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING POPULATIONS THAT ARE
AGING DISABLED HOMELESS AND
THOSE WITH SEVERE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS ARE THE AGE CBS
SPENDING PLAN INCLUDES TWENTY
EIGHT INITIATIVES ACROSS SEVEN
DEPARTMENTS TOTALING
APPROXIMATELY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AN ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDING AT FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR TOTAL FUNDS. OF
IN A VARIETY OF CATEGORIES OF
THOSE CATEGORIES INCLUDE INCLUDE
WORKFORCE- NAVIGATION SERVICES
TRANSITION SERVICES- ARE
SERVICES THEMSELVES ENHANCING
CAPACITY AND MODELS OF CARE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUPPORTS- THE
QUESTION WANTED US TO GO OVER DH
YES THIS PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY
THE STATE SPENDING PLAN ARE
CERTAIN ONES SO I WILL GO OVER
THAT NOW. UPPER CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IDEAS YES IS
LEVERAGING THIRTY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDS. IN A ONE TIME FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT AS A
MEDICAL BENEFITS UNDER A PILOT
PROGRAM WITH OUR DM C. O. DS
SYSTEMS OF THE AGENCY MANAGEMENT
IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE TREATMENT
FOR STIMULUS USED DISORDER IT
HAS A ROBUST BODY OF CLINICAL
RESEARCH EVIDENCE THAT
DEMONSTRATES IT LEADS TO
REDUCTIONS. OF STIMULANT USE AS
WELL AS IN RETENTION ENTRY. ARE
THE INTERESTING OF PROVIDING
MOTIVATION AND SENT FOR THE
TREATMENT. SUCH A NON USE OF.
ARE DEMONSTRATED BY RESULTS OF
URINE DRUG SCREEN. AT THE
MOTIVATIONAL INCENTIVES WILL BE
A GIFT CARD- BUT LOW RETAIL
VALUE- WHICH ARE PROVIDED DURING
A SET AT A SET DURATION OF TIME
WHICH HAS A TWENTY FOUR WEEK
PERIOD OF TREATMENTS. ARE THESE
MODEST MOTIVATIONAL INCENTIVES
ARE CENTRAL TO CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT THERE BASED ON THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE FOR TREATING STIMULANT
USE DISORDER AND IMPORTANTLY
THEY ARE NOT IN INDUCEMENT. TO
USE OTHER MEDICAL SERVICES I.
DAC S. AS PARTNERED WITH
NATIONAL EXPERTS COUNTIES
PROVIDERS AND CLINICAL TRAINING
PARTNERS DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT-
THIS BENEFIT. IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY ONE CMS APPROVED OUR
REQUEST TO COVER CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT THIS MAKES CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST STATE. IN THE COUNTRY
TO COVER CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
MEDICAID UNDER CALAIS AND- THE
DEMONSTRATION PROGRAM
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED AS A PILOT PROGRAM
UP FROM JULY OF TWENTY TWO
THROUGH MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. SPECIFICALLY CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS AN OPTIONAL
SERVICE UNDER DMC ODS THE DMC
ODS COUNTIES CAN ELECT TO COVER
IT ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS. AND
PARTICIPATE IN TRAINING QUALITY
MONITORING AND EVALUATION
ACTIVITIES AS A PART OF THAT
PILOT PROGRAM. THERE ARE TWO
PHASES TO THE PROGRAM SOME
COUNTIES IN PHASE ONE WILL BE
GOING LIVE JULY OF TWENTY TWO IN
SOME COUNTIES AND STATES YOU
WILL. GO LIVE SOMETIME BETWEEN
SEPTEMBER. AND DECEMBER OF THIS
YEAR. REGARDING THE HOW AND HOME
IN. PROGRAM MEDIC MANAGED CARE
PLANS BE ABLE TO EARN INCENTIVE
FUNDS FOR MAKING INVESTMENTS AND
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS KEEPING PEOPLE
HOUSE. A PARTICIPATING MANAGED
CARE PLANS MUST WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL HOMELESS
CONTINUUM OF CARE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS. COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES AND LOCAL HOUSING
DEPARTMENTS TO DEVELOP AND
SUBMIT A LOCAL HOMELESSNESS
PLAN. MANAGED CARE PLANS MIGHT
EARN UP TO ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS ACROSS TO PROGRAM YOURS
BOOK CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWO.
AND TWENTY THREE FOR MEETING
SPECIFIC PROGRESS- AND OUTCOME
MEASURES. REGARDING THE
COMMUNITY BASED RESIDENTIAL
CONTINUE PILOT DH CS IS
LEVERAGING A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN. POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE ONE TIME FUNDING
TO LAUNCH A COMMUNITY. BASED
RESIDENTIAL CONTINUING PILOTS
ARE TO PROVIDE A MEDICAL AND
SUPPORT SERVICES IN HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED CARE SETTING. TO
AVOID UNNECESSARY HEALTHCARE
COSTS INCLUDING EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND FUTURE LONG TERM
CARE PLACEMENTS INTERESTING
COLUMNS. OF THE PROGRAM WILL
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO LIVE IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE SETTING
POSSIBLE BY PROVIDING ACCESS TO
HOME BASED HEALTH AND OTHER
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES TO
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THE
FUNDING WILL BE PROVIDED TO
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
DELIVER THESE BENEFITS TO
MEMBERS OF MANAGED CARE PLANS
WILL CONTRACT WITH LICENSED
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE NEEDED
MEDICAL. AND OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS.
IN THEIR HOMES ARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS RESIDING IN OR
NEEDING THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMUNITY CARE SETTING MANAGED
CARE PLANS- WILL- CONTRACT
EITHER DIRECTLY WITH THE LICENSE
COMMUNITY CARE SETTING TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES. OR A
LICENSED. PROVIDER TO DELIVER
SERVICES ON SITE. REGARDING THE
CAL H. B. HEALTH HI PROGRAM. DHS
AS LEVERAGE. A THIRTY ONE SEVEN
ENHANCED FEDERAL FUNDING IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE CALVARY CHURCH
PROGRAM. THE CAL BRIDGE-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NAVIGATOR
PILOT PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS TO
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS TO SUPPORT
HIRING TRAINED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NAVIGATORS IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS TO SCREEN PATIENTS.
AND IF APPROPRIATE OFFER
INTERVENTION AND REFERRAL TO
MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM. APPLICANTS
WILL INCLUDE A GENERAL A CUTE. A
CARE HOSPITALS OR HEALTH SYSTEMS
HOSPITAL FOUNDATIONS OR POSITION
FOR. THE FUNDING WOULD ALSO
SUPPORT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING FOR PURCHASE FEEDING
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
SUPPORT FOR DH CS TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM ABOUT COVERAGE IS
NOT A NEW PROGRAM THE PROPOSED
FUNDING IS DEDICATED TO NEW
ACTIVITIES EXPANDING THE ROLE OF
THE NETWORK NAVIGATOR TO BETTER
ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
AS WELL AS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. NEW SERVICES ARE
COVERING THE COST OF HOSPITALS
ALREADY PARTICIPATING IN
COVERAGE TO ADD NEW NAVIGATORS
AND EXPAND HOURS OF COVERAGE OR
PATIENCE SIR A NEW GRANTEES SO
EXPANDING TO COWBRIDGE HOSPITALS
THAT HAVE NOT YET PARTICIPATED.
FOR THE NON I'D ASK YOUR ECONOMY
OB PAYMENTS THE- PAYMENTS AN
ISSUE THAT WILL PROVIDE ONE TIME
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH CURRENT-
DIRECT CARE NON IG SAYS PROVIDER
IN THE MEDICAID EACH CBS
SERVICES. DURING THE SAME A
SPECIFIED TIME FRAME OF AT LEAST
TWO MONTHS BETWEEN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWO- SORRY MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND IS
CURRENTLY PROVIDING H. C. B. S.
SERVICES. THE PROPOSAL WILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO PROVIDERS AND
COULD INCREASE RETENTION OF
CURRENT PROVIDERS COVERING
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DIRECT CARE ATS
PROVIDERS AND WOULD FOCUS ON
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS FOR RETENTION
RECOGNITION. AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE H. YES PLANS-
THESE PAYMENTS TO BE OUT BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND
THE LAST ITEM YOU REQUESTED AN
UPDATE. WAIVER AS SERVICE
MEDICARE ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
AGES TWENTY ONE AND OLDER AND
BRIDGES THE GAP BETWEEN
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND NURSING
HOME CARE. OF THE L. W. OFFERS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO NURSING
FACILITY PLACEMENTS AND PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO TRANSITION OUT OF NURSING
FACILITIES. THE OBJECTIVE OF THE
SPENDING PLAN INITIATIVE IS TO
ELIMINATE THE EXISTING ALE W.
WAIT LIST AND ALLOW ROOM FOR A
CONTINUED LABOR GROWTH BY
EXPANDING WAIVER PARTICIPANTS
LOTS BY SEVEN THOUSAND. THE
CURRENT ALE W. WAIT LIST IS AT
SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED BUT
INDIVIDUALS TODAY. ON JANUARY
SEVENTH- THIS YEAR CMS APPROVED
DH YES AT THE MOMENT TO DO W.
WAIVER TO ADD SEVEN THOUSAND
SLOTS TO EXPAND WAIVER CAPACITY
RETROACTIVE. EFFECTIVE JUNE JULY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE D. A.
C. S. IMMEDIATELY COMMUNICATED
APPROVAL OF THE AMENDMENT
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING PROVIDERS
AND HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
PROVIDERS TO PROCESS THE MOMENTS
THAT CMS APPROVAL. AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU UNDER FIND. NO
COMMENTS THANK YOU. HELLO THANK
YOU FOR THAT LMAO OUR OFFICE
RECENTLY PUBLISHED A PUBLICATION
ON EACH CBS SPENDING AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR ITS
IMPLEMENTATION WE WANT TO
DISCUSS POTENTIAL CONSIDERATIONS
FOR LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OUTCOMES OF THE
H. CVS SPENDING PLAN. THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS
PREVIOUSLY REQUESTED THE
MINISTRATION KEEP THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY UP TO DATE ON PROPOSE
PROGRAMMATIC AND FUNDING.
CHANGES TO THE INSIDIOUS
SPENDING PLAN. NOT NOT A
REPORTER THE GOVERNMENT RECORD
REPORT. IN ADDITION TO THESE
REQUESTED UPDATES ALLEGED COULD
CONSIDER WAYS TO USE THE BUDGET
PROCESS FOR THE STRENGTH IN
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT- TO
POTENTIAL WYS WOULD BE TO ADOPT
LEGISLATION THAT ESTABLISHES A
PROVIDES MORE DETAIL ON INTENDED
PROGRAM STRUCTURE OF LONGER TERM-EACH CVS ANNOUNCEMENTS. AND THEN
ALTERNATIVELY WRITTEN ON A
DOCKING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
REGARDING THE OUTCOMES OF THE
HDS AND SPENDING PLAN. WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CERTAIN ECS ENHANCEMENT IN ORDER
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER
ANY STATE FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THE MISSION. AFTER THE ENHANCED. FEDERAL FUNDING IS EXPIRED.
ALL IN. TERMS UP HERE PROCESS IS
. NOT THE NEXT COMMENTS ON THIS
ISSUE. THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ON. ON THE
ISSUE. IF YOU WERE TWENTY EIGHT-
I KNOW THIS IS BEEN AN AN
ONGOING ISSUE WITH- TIMELY
ACCESS FOR FOLLOW UP I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS AROUND IS THAT IS IT
MOSTLY JUST A WORK FORCE ISSUE
AND AN UP- NOT ENOUGH CONTRACTED
PEOPLE IN A NETWORK THAT THE
REFERRAL SAID DON'T TAKE PLACE
AS QUICKLY- I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY A NUMBER OF FACTORS I
THINK THAT. WE HAVEN'T FORMALLY
I MEASURED THIS ACROSS ALL THE
RESPECTED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AREAS-THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE
AND BUILD WE WILL BE ABLE TO
BETTER ANALYZE AND LOOK AND SEE
WHAT WE ARE SEEING ACROSS
VARIOUS COUNTIES BOTH ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE ON AND THE
MANAGED CARE SIDE. AND THEN BE
ABLE TO ACCESS- YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS OR
OPPORTUNITIES. TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY HOW WE CAN ENSURE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING- APPROPRIATE
YOU KNOW TIMELY ACCESS TO THOSE
FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS I THINK
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
THE PROCESS OF EVALUATING THAT
MEASURING THAT REPORTING ON IT
AND THEN LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU ON ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY NINE- THE PROBLEM KEEPS
GETTING WORSE SHOULD OUR ****
OUR FUNDING CONTINUED TO GROW
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE- YOU'RE ASKING
FOR LESS MONEY IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AM HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT WE'LL REACH SOME
KIND OF- LEVEL. BY THEN. BECAUSE
OF OUR LEASE I WILL DEFER TO YOU
ON THE SPOT. SURE YEAH SO-
YOU'RE DEFINITELY CORRECT THAT
THE RATES OF OVERDOSES HAVE BEEN
INCREASING I'M NOT ONLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT BASICALLY ACROSS
THE WEST COAST AND THAT'S REALLY
BEEN ON TO THE FACT THAT. THE
INCREASE OF THAT NOW THAT'S BEEN
COMING OUT HERE ON THE WEST
COAST AND NOT JUST FUNCTIONAL-
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE USING
BATHROOM PHANTOM KILLS- SO A LOT
OF COUNTERFEIT- YOU KNOW NOT IT
USED TO BE THE OPIOIDS CAME OUT
ON THE STREET FOR PRESCRIPTIONS
BUT NOW THEY'RE JUST BEING
MANUFACTURED. ON AND SO IT'S
REALLY JUST EXASPERATING ON THE
OVERDOSE CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE THEM THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AND IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS BEEN
PUTTING A LOT OF EFFORTS TOWARDS
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND WE HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF SUCCESSES. BUT
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW FENNEL HAS
REALLY BEEN IMPACTING YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA AND THE SYSTEMS AT
LARGE I'M SO I KNOW I DIDN'T
FULLY ANSWER A QUESTION ABOUT
THE FUNDINGWE HAVE. OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS RECEIVED
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO ASSIST WITH
THIS- AND OF COURSE WE HAVE
FUNDING THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
THROUGH OUR WAIVERS TO HELP
TREAT- INDIVIDUALS WITH A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER ON THIS
FINDING IS JUST GOING TO EXPAND
SOME OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M MOST NOTABLY YOU
KNOW PROVIDING THE LIFESAVING.
REVERSAL MEDICATION NALOXONE.
WHICH IS REALLY IMPAIRED AND ONE
OF THAT KEY PIECES OF YOU KNOW
INSURING WHEN SOMEONE'S IN OVER
TO HAVE A AVAILABLE. AND IN THIS
MANY HANDS POSSIBLE. THIRTY
EIGHT PERPLEXING PERPLEXING
ISSUE AND- HE WAS SAYING TO ME
WELL IT'S THEY'RE GETTING A
PRESCRIPTION I KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE MANUFACTURING IT NOW AND
DO ARE YOU WORKING WELL THE MAN
IS NOT YOUR DEPARTMENT BUT BEING
REALLY ABLE TO GET TO THE CRUX
OF THAT THAT. THAT IS VERY
DANGEROUS I'M NOT HERE STOP IT'S
COMING IN ANYWAYS IT'S VERY
DISTRESSING- TO THE ILLEGALS LA
ROSA IS. POSITION ABOUT. NEEDING
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT ON ON EACH OF THESE
ALL OF THESE ARE ARE MOSTLY- SEP
NOT SUPPLEMENTING BUT AT AT
ADDITIVE TO WHAT WERE ALREADY
DOING IT IS THAT CORRECT OR OR
IS ANY OF THEM MAYBE WITH THE
NINETY JUST AS THE WAIVER. THAT
IS DIFFERENT BUT EVERYTHING ELSE
WE'RE ALREADY PAYING FOR AND THE
FEDERAL MONEY IS IN ADDITION IS
THAT CORRECT- SO IT'S A VARIETY
OF PIECES SO FOR CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT- THIS IS A NEW
INITIATIVE- THAT WE- PROPOSE
THAT THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
TIME IN DRYING DOWN- FEDERAL
FUNDS. UP FOR THAT- PROGRESSIVE
PROGRAM- FOR THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
AND THIS IS YOU KNOW VERY
COMPLIMENTARY TO THE
CONVERSATION WERE HAVING
EARLIER. IN REGARDS TO ENSURING
THAT WE ARE BUILDING THOSE LOCAL
CONNECTIONS. TO GET DOLLARS BUT
AGAIN A NEW. INITIATIVE HERE ALL
OF THOSE PIECES- SAME THING WITH
THE CONTINUING PILOTS AT CAL
BRIDGE WAS AN EXISTING PROGRAMS
OR ADDING DOLLARS- THERE I'M NOT
I JUST THIS IS A ONE TIME
PAYMENT. TO HELP SUPPORT WORK
FORCE- AND THEN YES THE ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER- IT'S BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
AND THIS IS JUST AUGMENTING IN
ADDING SLOT SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF VARIETY- ARE THESE ITEMS AND-
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. AND THEN FOR EACH OF
THEM DO WE ACTUALLY HAVE METRICS
IN PLACE IT WILL BE ABLE TO
MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS AND-
ANALYZE WHETHER THE STATE WOULD
THEN CONTINUE. PROVIDING THAT
LEVEL OF FUNDING AFTER THE
FEDERAL MONEY GOES AWAY. SURE SO
FOR CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT OUR
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE WAIVER-
ARE WITH CMS ON THE WAIVER WE
DID IT. IT TOOK ALL OF THAT YOU
PATIENT INDEPENDENT EVALUATION
OF THAT PROGRAM TO DEMONSTRATE
ITS EFFECTIVENESS- AND IN IN AND
OUT COMES THERE- FOR THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS INCENTIVE
PROGRAM IT'S ALSO A VERY. A
MEASURE BASED INITIATIVE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO REPORT OUT OF
WHICH MEASURES WERE MET IN
METRICS WERE MET FIRE ANAGED
CARE PLANS IN THEIR- LOCAL.
COUNTY AT PARTNERS IN REGARDS TO
THAT PROGRAM. A NUMBER AND I
WILL BE SEPARATE FROM THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY DOING OR
DISTRACTED THAT IS. IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE DESIGNED AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WITH DEDICATED FUNDS FOR
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS HOW
PIECES JUST KNOWING THAT THE
REALLY LARGE LIFT LOTS OF NEW
PARTNERSHIPS. I NEED TO MAKE
SURE IT'S SIX LAST FOUR IN AND
MEASURING. GETTING CAN TO THE
SERVER. GETTING THEM. KEEPING
THEM- THE GOAL OF THOSE THOSE.
AND ON THAT IS CORRECT THAT IS
NEW BOB THERE WILL BE CLEAR
MEASURES THAT THEY WILL BE
REPORTING TO US. MR HOUSER
CALIBRATION THE OTHER SO I THINK
THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES ALL OF
THEM ARE GOING TO BE VERY CLEAR
WHAT WILL HAPPEN MEASURES AND
METRICS WE CAN REPORT CMS IS
GONNA EXPECT THAT AS WELL GIVEN
THE DOLLARS THAT THEY- HAVE PUT
ON THE TABLE- AND SO OUT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO REPORT THAT OUT. AS
NEEDED. THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU- SORRY GO BACK ISSUE TWENTY
NINE- AND INTEREST- TRIGGERMAN
**** THAT I'M NOT SURE QUITE GOT
THE ANSWER SO THE FUNDING GOES
FROM A HUNDRED AND ONE- MILLION
DOWN THE SIXTY ONE MILLION THE
SUBSEQUENT YEAR- SO THAT THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FORTY
MILLION DROPPED- FROM ONE YEAR
TO THE OTHER. ITEMS IN THE
APOLOGIZE AND TRY TO PARSE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT GETS WHAT ARE YOU
FINDING THAT ONE FOR ONLY A YEAR
AND THEN AND THEN ELIMINATING-
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT- WE'RE
INCREASING THAT SERVICES THE
LICENSE FACILITY THAT'S THAT'S
GONNA BE ON GOING TWENTY THREE
AND A HALF IN A TWENTY ONE POINT
EIGHT ON GOING. THE NEW MATTE
AXIS. THAT WAS JUST A ONE YEAR
THING TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS THE I MEAN DON'T WE DO
HAVE TO MAINTAIN THOSE ACCESS
POINTS OR- TO START- AND THEN IT
CERTAINLY I MEAN IN AN ACT OF
THE KNOX OWNED DISTRIBUTION
PROJECT IS THAT THE ONE ONE YEAR
EFFORT AND THEN WE STOPPED OR-
SO JUST LIKE CLARIFY WHAT'S-
WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE FUNDING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. DOLLARS
NOT FUNDING AT TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A WEEK CUT THE
FUNDING REQUEST. FIVE CENTS A
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS. GREAT
I'LL TAKE THAT AND I APOLOGIZE
THAT I WASN'T CLEAR EARLIER. I'M
SO ALL OF THESE PROJECTS STARTED
WITH FEDERAL DOLLARS SO THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT THERE'S A
STATE INVESTMENT ARM AND THE-
CALIFORNIA MATRIX PENSION
PROJECT- I'M GONNA LOCK SOME
PROJECT IS. GOING TO BE ONGOING
FUNDING- WE HAVE ACTUALLY WITH
THAT PROJECT ALREADY HAD OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND. RECORDED
OVERDOSE REVERSALS JUST FROM
THAT PROJECT ALONE- AND THAT'S
JUST IMPERATIVE RIGHT NOW THAT
THE THOUGHTS ON GOING FUNDING
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY- AS- I
STATED THIS IS AN EASY TO SOLVE-
SOME OF THE OTHER PROJECTS HOW
AND HOW MUCH IS THE- ACTUAL
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT. SORRY HOW
MUCH WAS THAT. HOW MUCH OF IT
SO. IT'S A LITTLE OVER. THIRTY
MILLION OKAY. I'LL JUST HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBER RIGHT IN FRONT AS
GOOD ENOUGH FOR YEAH REALLY SENT
THEM NOW. TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT. THAT M. A. T. ACCESS
POINTS SO WE'VE ALREADY
INCREASED ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
ACCESS POINTS. IN VARIOUS KIND
OF NONTRADITIONAL SETTINGS AND A
LOT OF THAT WORK IS MORE
HELPINGS AND- YOU KNOW STUFF
ABOUT. HAVING A PRESCRIBER
ONSITE GETTING INITIAL START UP-
THERE'S SOME FUNDING AND GIVEN
FOR. UNDER INSURED OR UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS ABOUT MOST OF IT IS
REALLY JUST TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
OF BREAKING THROUGH WHATEVER YOU
KNOW BARRIERS FROM THERE OF. WHY
THE NBA TEAM HASN'T BEEN
PRESCRIBING. ON VENDORS BY THERE
SO THAT IS KIND OF YOU KNOW-
BASICALLY MORE AROUND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND NOT SAME WITH THE
JAIL PROJECT BECAUSE BOX ONE
TIME FUNDING AS WELL- WE ALREADY
HAVE BEEN WORKING. WITH MANY
JAILS THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHING MHD. HADN'T IN THE
PAST AND SO WE JUST WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT AND THAT SUPPORT
FOR THE INITIAL COUNTIES- AND
THEN GET OTHER COUNTIES ON
BOARD. THE JUST THE CLARIFY FOR
THE- NEW MATT ACCESS POINT SO
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME IS THAT
YOU JUST NEED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THEN ONCE YOU
LAUNCH THEM THEY RUN ON THEIR
OWN- SO THAT WE DON'T NEED TO
FUND THE MANY MORE. OR EXIT
TENDER STAND HOW THAT WORKS AND-
YOU CAN ALSO INTO YOUR ANSWER.
TALK ABOUT THE ONES THAT WERE
VERY FINE DETAIL OF COURSE FEE
FUNDED WITH FEDERAL FUNDS AND
OTHERS OTHER MAXIS. POINTS I
THINK WAS SIX HUNDRED OR
SOMETHING- ACCESS POINT- SIX
HUNDRED. YOU FOR- SO HOW MANY OF
THOSE ARE KIND- SO HAVE. TO
HUNDRED SO. HOW MANY OF THOSE
ARE STILL ONGOING OR DO THEY
START FADING AWAY AFTER WE KICK
THEM OFF AND THEN TELL SOME OF
THEM CLOSE ITS ADDRESS SO CAN
YOU JUST TALK ABOUT. THE RE JUST
LAUNCHING THEM AND THEN THEY RUN
ON THEIR OWN OR DO IS WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS WHAT HAPPENS IS THESE
ACCESS POINTS. WE DO THIS NO
PROBLEM YES THEY'RE ALL A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT- BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY DIFFERENT SETTINGS. AND
THAT WE'VE BEEN EXPANDING. THEM
AND SOME OF THEM. HAVE BEEN IN
OUR LICENSING OUR LICENSING
SYSTEM- SO PERHAPS THEY'VE BEEN
PROVIDING. MEDICAL SERVICES BUT
THEY HAVEN'T PROVIDED MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT SO THE
ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE. AS THE
MEDIC HOW THEY JUST HAVEN'T. YOU
KNOW DONE THAT AND THEY'RE
SETTING TYPE OKAY- OTHERS ARE
CONNECTED MAYBE TO. THE BROADER
ETHICAL HEALTH MEDICAL SYSTEM
WHICH ALSO PROVIDES A MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT MAYBE IT'S AN
INDIVIDUAL. PHYSICIAN THAT JUST
NEVER CAUGHT THEIR ACT WAIVER
AND NOW IT'S STARTING TO
PRESCRIBE BUPRENORPHINE. AND WE
ALSO HAD SOME SPECIAL PROJECTS%
FOR OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS. AND SO
ONCE AGAIN THEY HAVE FEDERAL
DOLLARS AS WELL SO THEY'RE ALL A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. IN THE
SENSE OF. WHAT THAT THE FUNDING
SOURCE BECAUSE WE'RE NOT. USING
THIS MONEY FOR SERVICES THAT'S
REALLY MORE JUST TO HELP THEM
SET UP. ON THE PROGRAM AND THEN
THEY HAVE THAT THE FUNNY TO ME.
OKAY SO THE- PROJECT THAT SO I
THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL TO KNOW
IS THAT. OF THE SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY NOW PLUS ANOTHER HUNDRED
WERE BUDGETING FOR. HOW MANY OF
THEM AFTER WE SORT OF LAUNCH
THEM OFF AND HE SAID WE COULD.
STAY CONTINUE YOUR ROOM SO WE'RE
TEACHING THEM HOW TO DO THIS NOW
THERE BUT NOW THEY LEARN HOW TO
DO IT THEY CAN GET MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENTS WHATEVER ELSE.
HOW MANY OF THEM CONTINUE TO DO
IT AS NOW THAT WE TRAIN THEM
THEY SAY HEY I WANT TO DO THIS
YOU TRAIN THEM. I'M NOW AN
ACCESS POINT. AND THEN. THEY
STILL CONTINUE TO BE AN ACCESS
POINT I MEAN THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT REASONS SOMEONE MAY
STOP FOR EIGHT NINE. FOR SOME
REASON NO PATIENTS ARE COMING
EVERY FEW PATIENTS ARE COMING
ARE DEFINED AT THE- YOU HAVE TO
BE TRAINED AT IT'S- JUST BECOME
VERY ONEROUS OR THEY'RE JUST TOO
BUSY DOING EVERYTHING ELSE AND
SO FORTH I. THINK IT'S JUST
HELPFUL TO KNOW- HOW ME THEM
STILL IN THE- RIGHT ARE STILL
ACT. DOING IT RIGHT SO WE- WHAT
WE- I'M STILL CERTAINLY IT'S THE
END. OF THE C. HUNDRED. PLUS NOW
- DO WE STILL HAVE SIX HUNDRED
UP TO DO WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
UP DO YOU STILL HAVE ALL THE-
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY UP. I THINK
I'D BE HELPFUL TO KNOW BECAUSE
ALSO. IDENTIFYING WHAT THE
REASON PEOPLE DROP OFF IS GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT RIGHT- AND THEN
IF WE KNOW WHY AND IF IT TURNS
AND IT'S WE KNOW WHY PEOPLE ARE
DROPPING OUT WE MAY NEED ME MAY
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT WE MAY NEED
TO DO. TO EITHER KEEP THEM
STANDING UP OR EVEN MAYBE
PERHAPS IDENTIFY WHO ARE THE
BETTER ACCESS WANTS ME TURNED
OUT LIKE WE TRAINS ON THEIR
EAGER TURNS OUT TO NOT REALLY
GET ACCESS POINT AND THAT'S WHY
THEY ENDED UP DROPPING OUT
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW PEOPLE JUST
WHEN ACCESSING THAT ACCESS POINT
RATE SO. ENDED THAT MAY HELP
WITH INFORM US IN TERMS OF FOR
FUTURE ACCESS POINTS- WHICH
WHICH WHAT CHARACTERISTICS WOULD
MAKE THEM MORE SUCCESSFUL YOU
KNOW ONE BECAUSE IN THE END THE
SUCCESS OF THE ACCESS POINTS
ALSO HOW MANY PEOPLE THEN TURNED
TO THAT SITE TO ACCESS. RIGHT SO
WE TRAINS ON THE PROVIDE ACCESS
NOW THE QUESTION IS THAT OUR
PEOPLE PARTAKING OF IT IS THAT
IS THAT FACILITY NOW WELCOMING
OUR DAY SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW THAT COULD PROVIDE THAT
SERVICES EFFICIENTLY IN OTHER
WAYS SO THAT PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
COME TO THAT SITE SO WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE CAPACITIES OF
THE COMMUNITY. THE SENSE.
DEFINITELY AND WE CAN PROVIDE
YOU WITH- SOME OF THAT OKAY THE
CURRENT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY THAT
WE HAVE STOOD UP BECAUSE WE HAVE
A LOT OF DATA AROUND NOT SUBJECT
TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT OF COURSE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE
HUNDREDS YET BUT WILL BE- BUT-
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S HELPFUL
BECAUSE THEN WE WANNA BE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE MEETING THAT
CAPACITY BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
LOOKS LIKE THE OPIOID CRISIS
ISN'T GOING AWAY AND DECIDED NOW
AND NOW IT'S NOT PRESCRIPTIONS
IT'S- PEOPLE MANUFACTURING
IMPORTING SO WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO BE SURE WE STILL HAVE THAT.
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY AND IN THE
COMMUNITY AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
NUMBERS ARE STILL GOING UP SO.
MMHM WE NEED TO PUT. MORE FOCUS
ALL RIGHT I APPRECIATE THAT- SO
THE FORTY SOUNDS LIKE THE FORTY
MILLIONS MAINLY THE- THE ACCESS
POINTS AND THE JAILS AND DRUG
COURTS AT LEAST WE'RE JUST
RUNNING FOR. THE NEW ONES FOR
ANOTHER YEAR HOPEFULLY THEY
CONTINUE GOING ON CORRECT. FOR
MOST CORRECT OKAY AND THEN- SEE.
I GUESS ON THE ISSUE- IN REGARDS
TO ITEM NUMBER SORRY THIRTY ONE-
FIRST OF ALL I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THEY WERE PUTTING FUNDING
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT I NEED TO
RECOGNIZE MY GOOD FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE- SIR WINNER WHO'S BEEN
A BIG CHAMPION FOR THAT IT IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH SO
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE DOING
THAT- IN TERMS OF- AND I KNOW
THIS IS WHAT BEGAN WHEN THESE
THINGS WERE WERE. ALSO BAILEY
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
SOME. FUNDING TO OUR- TO- VERY
SIMILAR HSS ECONOMY PAYMENTS AS
WELL- THEY DIDN'T WORKING VERY
HARD AS WELL AND THAT- EDITOR'S
INCENTIVE PLAN PAYMENTS- CTG
DEALERS AND ASK- ALL RIGHT WELL
IT SO I GUESS THE- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THE- WELL I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE HELPFUL IS- AND
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION IS GETTING SOME
MORE DETAIL ABOUT EXACTLY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO CARRY SOME OF
THESE GOOD IDEAS OUT AND- HOW
YOU GONNA BE COORDINATED WITH
OTHER OTHER THINGS SO. THERE'S
ROOM HOPEFULLY AND I UNDERSTAND
FROM ILIO- IS THERE SOME DETAIL
OF THAT THAT WE STILL NEED MORE
DETAILS ON SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS RIGHT. SO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. ON WE ARE ON A MORE
DETAILS ARE NEEDED AT THIS TIME
AROUND IN THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
GET IT RIGHT YEAH I MEAN IF
LIMITATION RIGHT SO WE GOT THE
APPRECIATE THE IDEAS AND WE
LIKED THE IDEAS BUT THAT'S IT
THE- THE RUBBER MEETS ROAD
SCHOLAR TALLY NOW WE'RE GETTING
INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
AND SO I THINK WE LIKE OUR BUT
WE WANT TO IMPLEMENTATION SO
OKAY SO- HOPING WE CAN GET SOME
MORE INFORMATION ON THAT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU. OKAY SO
LET'S- LET'S TWO THIRTY TWO AND
TAKE US HOME. RIGHT SOUNDS GREAT
I WILL KICK US OFF OUR. GET
ORGANIZED HERE ARE- SO FOR ISSUE
THIRTY TWO ON THE HOMOGENEITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES WAIVER
PROVIDES- HOME COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES SUCH AS AND HOW ARE IN
HOME NURSING PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES AND RESPITE SERVICES TO
ELIGIBLE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
I WOULD NURSING LEVEL AT A LEVEL
OF CARE THE STATE AS TO SUBMIT
AN APPLICATION TO CMS EVERY FIVE
YEARS TO RENEW- THESE WAIVERS.
AND WE DID THAT IN IN SEPTEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HAVE
BEEN- CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WTH CMS THEY DID
REQUEST THAT WE DO A TEMPORARY
EXTENSION OF ADDITIONAL NINETY
DAYS WHICH WILL TAKE US THROUGH
MARCH OF TWENTY TWO- THIS IS
STANDARD PRACTICE- PRACTICE WITH
CMS TO KIND OF HAVE TEMPORARY
EXTENSIONS INTEL YOU CAN COME TO
A FULL REMAKE YOUR GUARDS TO THE
WAIVER TERMS A DH CS DOES-
ANTICIPATE THAT CMS WILL MAKE
THE WAIVER OF RETROACTIVE TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWO UPON
APPROVAL THAT THAT IS ALSO. A
STANDARD PRACTICE- THE BUDGET
DOES REQUEST ONE POINT ONE
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS IN CURRENT
YEAR AND EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
TOTAL FUNDS IN BUDGET YEAR TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF WAIVER
SLOTS AS OF JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THE NEW COST IMPACTS
TO THE WAIVER WERE INFORMED BY
AN EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS BY DIVERSE
TECHNICAL WORK A GROUP. OF THE
CHANGES INCLUDED INCREASE OF
WAIVER SLOTS BETWEEN JANUARY OR
BEGINNING IN JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY FOUR EXPANSION OF THE
COMMUNITY TRANSITION SERVICES-
THE ADDITION OF ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES TO SUPPORT
ACCESS TO CARE WHILE MAINTAINING
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
PARTICIPANTS ON AN INCREASE- TO
THE PERSONAL CARE AGENCY RATE-
TO ALIGN WITH THE STATEWIDE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE- UPON US
THE MASSES APPROVAL OF THE
WAIVER OF THAT WILL BE EIGHT
LARGE CHANGES THAT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED OR- NOT LARGE BUT
JUST CHANGES I SHOULD SAY-
SOCIAL. WORKERS ARE PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE CARE MANAGEMENT
WAIVER SERVICES AS A MEMBER OF
THE. CARE MANAGEMENT TEAM WILL
NO LONGER BE REQUIRED I A MASTER
DEGREE IN SOCIAL. SOCIAL WORKERS
AT A BACK DEGREE OR- WITH THE
BACK. DEGREE IN REAL- RELATED.
INCLUDE GERONTOLOGY OUR MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPY PSYCHOLOGY
ETCETERA WILL BE AUTHORIZED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE WAIVER-
WE WILL REMOVE THE AGE
RESTRICTIONS FOR RESPITE CARE
SERVICES. WE ARE ADDING AT THE
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CARE
SERVICE- LICENSING. TO OPERATE
H. THIS CALL THE TRANSITION
HEALTHCARE NEEDS OPTIONAL ADD
SERVICE UNIT- ADDED AS A
PROVIDER TYPES FOR PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING FOR ELIGIBLE
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE. ON TWENTY
ONE- ADDITIONALLY THAT PHC
CENTRES ADDED AS A WRITER TYPE
OR FACILITY BASED RESPITE
SERVICES. ARE WE HAVE ADDED A
VARIETY OF TELEHEALTH
FLEXIBILITIES FOR CONSULTATIONS
ARE BEING AVAILABLE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO IN PERSON
SERVICES WHEN APPROPRIATE- OF
COURSE AS WELL AS ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY I WITHIN THE WAIVER-
ADDING WHAT'S CALLED PARAMEDICAL
SERVICES ARE DUE TO THE WAIVER.
AND LASTLY WILL ALLOW AN ANNUAL
REASSESSMENT EFFORT TO SPEND TO
BE CONDUCTED VIA TELEHEALTH WITH
APPROPRIATE OF COURSE AN
APPROVED IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
MEDICAID STATE PLAN AND OUR
LARGER TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL.
BECAUSE OF THAT IS THAT THE
OVERVIEW FOR ITEM. THIRTY TWO I
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM THIRTY
THREE. OF THE BUDGET REQUEST
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
AUTHORITY IN ENHANCED FEDERAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE THROUGH AT THE
H. YES SPENDING PLAN. TO
IMPLEMENT DEMENTIA WHERE FROM
MARCH FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH MARCH THIRTY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOR AN ADDITIONAL
THREE HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FOR PROVIDER PAYMENTS RELATED TO
U. S. B. FORTY EIGHT IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
THE DEPARTMENT LAUNCHING
DEMENTIA WHERE- AN INITIATIVE
THAT WILL ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE
STANDARD OF CARE FOR DEMENTIA
SCREENING THROUGH. EQUITY FOCUS
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE PROVIDER
TRAININGS DH CS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH SB FORTY EIGHT IS ALSO
PROPOSING. TO COVER A NEW
MEDICARE BENEFIT FOR COGNITIVE
HEALTH ASSESSMENT R. AS B. FORTY
EIGHT SIGNED IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALLOWS
MEDICARE PROVIDERS TO COMPLETE
THE DEMENTIA WHERE TRAINING TO
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR. COMPLETING AN ANNUAL
COGNITIVE HEALTH ASSESSMENT FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
AND OTHERWISE INELIGIBLE FOR A
SIMILAR ASSESSMENT UNDER THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION. BY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OF COURSE. OF REGARD
ITEM THIRTY FOUR I WILL TURN
OVER WE ARE THIRTY THAT IS SORRY
- MOVING ON TO. ITEM THIRTY FIVE
IT WILL TURN IT OVER TO LAURIE.
FOR THANKS FIFTEEN ADDRESSES FOR
INSPECTORS REQUESTING SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR FOR A
LIMITED TERM RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS ENTRY PREVENTION
AND A LIMITED TERM CONTRACT
BINDING TO FURTHER IMPROVE DATA
QUALITY AND MANAGED CARE AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT
WILL SET THE ACT AND MEETING
WITH CMS TRANSFORMED MEDICAID
TECHNICAL. INFORMATION THE FIRM
ACQUIRED RIGHT. WE INVITE FROM
OFFENDED BY SPENDING THANK
HEALTH MERGER. AND AT WHAT RATE
SEVEN NINETY TEN ENHANCED
FEDERAL FUNDING. FURTHER
ADVANCES CURRENT STATE QUALITY
WORK THAT SUPPORT DATA QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL THINGS CAN.
IMPACTED BY. THE CMS MANAGED
CARE FINAL WALL. EIGHT STOP WHAT
YOU'RE POOR COUNTRY AT
ACCORDINGLY THE CONTRACTOR THE
XPS PROGRAMS FOR THE DATA
QUALITY WORK. THE CONTRACT
BINDING WITH THE PARK
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS YEAH BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT BEING
PROVIDING QUALITY REPORTS
RELATED TO ENCOUNTER DATA.
QUALITY THAT CAN BE RECORDED IN
A PLAN AND PROVIDER LEVEL
SUPPORT TRAINING TO IMPROVE DATA
QUALITY AND DATA THAT'S PROVIDED
BY COUNTY PLANS AND PROVIDERS TO
SEE IF YOU HAVE. AN INTEREST IN
AMERICA. THERE ARE TWO CAMPS FOR
THEM. SECRETARY QUITE. ALL RIGHT
THIRTY SECONDS- FOR I- ISSUE
THIRTY SIX OF THE WITH YOUR
EVERY YEAR REDUCTIONS IN CROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDING IN THE GROWING
NEED TO ELIMINATE LONGSTANDING
MEDIC HOW RATE CUTS YEARS THIS
IS PROPOSING CHANGES TO HOW THE
DEPARTMENT USES PROPERTY SIX AND
THE ELIMINATION. OF SELECT
EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN REDUCTIONS
TO INFORMED- THESE CHANGES DO
YOU SEE AS FOCUSED OUR LEARNINGS
FROM THE CODE NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND USE THE
MEDICAL COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY
AND EQUITY STRATEGY TO IDENTIFY
CORE POPULATIONS IN SERVICE IS A
FOCUS ON AS WELL AS FURTHER
PREPARE THE MEDICARE PROGRAM FOR
FUTURE COVERED NINETEEN RELATED
SEARCHES AND ENDEMIC CASE RATES
ARE FOUR EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN THE
BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION
TOTAL FUND- IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY FOUR MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
ARE GOING TO ELIMINATE. EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN PAYMENT REDUCTIONS
FOR THE FOLLOWING PROVIDERS UP
FOR NURSES OF ALL TYPES OF
VIRGIN NEED SPECIFICALLY OXYGEN
AND RESPIRATORY SERVICES AND
RESPIRATORY CARE PROVIDERS OFFER
AUDIOLOGIST HEARING AID
DISPENSERS ARE CHRONIC DIALYSIS
CLINICS ALTERNATIVE BIRTHING
CENTERS EMERGENCY AIR MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION AND NON EMERGENCY. MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION. OUR
WILL ALSO. NEXT UP PERCENT ISSUE
THIRTY SEVEN ON THE EQUITY AND
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION PROVIDER
PAYMENTS- THE DEPARTMENT HERE IS
PROPOSING FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
OF TOTAL FUNDS- IN ONE TIME
FUNDS TO MAKE IT EQUITY AND
PROSTRATE FORMATION PAYMENTS TO
QUALIFYING MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO
CLOSE CRITICAL HELP KIND OF
EQUITY GAPS ADDRESS GAPS IN
PREVENTATIVE A MATERNITY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE MEASURES
AND ADDRESS GAPS THAT ARE RISING
OUT OF THE CODE NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY BY THE
DEPARTMENT ACTALLY REPORTED
VERY EARLY IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION. IN CERTAIN SERVICES
IN MEDIC HAL INCLUDING VARIOUS
PREVENTIVE SERVICES AND
SPECIFICALLY CHILDREN
IMMUNIZATION SERVICES- THAT
IMMEDIATELY HATE MYSELF
REDUCTIONS AS EARLY AS MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY- AFTER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY DECLARATION
SUCH PAYMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
REALLY PROMOTE PATIENT CENTERED
MODELS OF CARE IN PEDIATRIC
PRIMARY CARE. OBGYN IN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SETTINGS AND TO ALIGN
WITH THE GOALS OF THE MEDIC HOW
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY AND EQUITY
STRATEGY ARE THE FANS I WOULD
INCLUDE BOTH INITIAL PLANNING
GRANT DOLLARS AND PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION GRANTS OF THE
THAT THAT PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION GRANTS WOULD
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
CASE MANAGEMENT AND **** THE
MECHANICS FOR IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING UNDER UTILIZATION AND
CLOSING CARE GAPS. ELECTRONIC
MEDICAL RECORD SYSTEM UPDATES I
REALLY TO ALLOW FOR A POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT APPROACH
IMPROVEMENTS AS WELL AS
FLEXIBILITY IS NEEDED OR
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR
TELEHEALTH REMOTE MONITORING
THOSE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL HELP PRACTICES ARE REALLY
IN THEIR WORK TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR DH YES TO REALIZE.
ITS BOLD. THE GOALS OF FIFTY PER
. IMPROVE BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
IN A ROW TO A OF UP MAY THAT
JUST OUTLINED IN OUR CONFERENCE
OF QUALITY STRATEGY. AWFUL GRAND
DESIGN DETAILS ARE STILL BEING
WORKED OUT DIDN'T LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH STAKE HOLDERS AS
WE ARE DEFINED AS A VERY
IMPORTANT JOB CRITICAL GAP.
CLOSURE INITIATIVES. AND FOR THE
LAST ITEM ISSUE AT THIRTY EIGHT-
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SENATE
BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN AUTHORIZED
A PILOT PROGRAM FOR COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY BASED ACTIVITIES.
UNDER THE PROPOSED PILOT
PURCHASE SPEEDING APPS WHICH
SEES WHAT MOVE AWAY FROM OTHER
TRADITIONAL VALUE BASED PPS
PAYMENTS ARE- SYSTEM. TO ONE
THAT BETTER ALIGNS WITH THE
BOBBING FINANCING AND DELIVERY
HEALTH SERVICES. AS PROPOSED
UNDER THE FCC APM PILOT- THE PPS
PAYMENT A WRAP AROUND WOULD BE
REPLACED BY AN UPFRONT CLINIC
SPECIFIC APPLICATION RIGHT- THE
BENEFIT TO THE PARTICIPATING
ACCURACY IS THAT THEY WILL HAVE
A SIMPLIFIED PAYMENT PROCESS.
REPLACING THE PREVIOUS BILLING
APPROACH- AND ASSOCIATED DELAYS
IN PAYMENT. OF HUGE SEAS BUT
RECEIVED A COMPREHENSIVE PAYMENT
FROM THE HEALTH PLANS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS RATHER THAN
HAVING. TO WAIT UNTIL THE END OF
THE YEAR. FIRST UP WELL PAYMENT
WHICH IS PARTICULARLY BENEFICIAL
FOR CASH STRAPPED HEALTH
CENTERS. ARE THE PAYMENT REFORM
WOULD ALSO ALLOW FQHCS THE
ABILITY TO OPERATE MORE
EFFICIENTLY. AND DELIVER- AT
KAREN INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT WILL
EXPAND BEYOND PRIMARY AND
SPECIALTY CARE ACCESS. FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU EXCEED WHAT
PROVIDE NONTRADITIONAL SERVICES
ARE NOT CURRENTLY REIMBURSABLE
UNDER THE TRADITIONAL VALUE
BASED PPS- INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO GROUP VISITS EMAIL
VISIT PHONE VISIT OUR-
MANAGEMENT. CARE COORDINATION.
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER US AT
TOUCHES. ADDITIONALLY THE REFORM
REMOVES INCENTIVES TO INCREASE
VOLUME OF SEPARATE BUSINESS-
THIS PROPOSED PILOT WAS ALSO
EXPECTED TO INCREASE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
PARTICIPATING FQHCS. BUT BOTH
WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS BOTH BUT ALSO
EXPERIENCE INCREASED VALUE FOR
BETTER COORDINATION OF CARE
THEREBY HELPING TO REDUCE
UNNECESSARY UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES. AND IMPROVE THE
BENEFITS YOUR EXPERIENCE AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY HEALTH
OUTCOMES- HOWEVER DH CS. I WHAT
UNABLE TO AND- THE PILOT OUT DO
TO AN- TO RECEIVE FEDERAL. OF A
ON TRIGGERS OR REFERENCE TO
INTERACT. IS WERE REIMBURSED AT
LEAST PPS. THE REVISED DH YES
PROPOSAL- BEFORE YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION UPDATES EXISTING
LAW THAT AUTHORIZES THE DARK
DEPARTMENT TO IMPLEMENT AN
ALTERNATE PAYMENT MODELS-
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY FOR
FQHCS NO SOONER THAN JANUARY ONE
OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THE
PROPOSAL MAKES THE FOLLOWING
CHANGES TO EXISTING AUTHORITY I
CHANGES THE ATM FROM A PILOT TO
AN ONGOING REIMBURSEMENT
MECHANISM. MODIFIES LANGUAGE
WHICH TRIGGERS RECONCILIATION TO
BE ACTUAL UTILIZATION COMPARED
TO PROJECTED UTILIZATION- AND
ADDS LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH
QUALITY AND ACCESS STANDARDS AND
IF THE PARTICIPATING AFTER. DOES
NOT MEET ESTABLISHED STANDARDS
THEY WILL BE REQUIRED TO RETURN
A PORTION OF THE PMPML REVENUE
WHILE ENSURING REVENUE RECEIVED
WILL NOT BE LOWER THAN THE
AMOUNT THEY WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
BEEN. RECEIVED UNDER THE
TRADITIONAL PPS REIMBURSEMENT.
IDEAS YES BEGAN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THAT- AFFECTED STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP THE PROPOSAL IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. LEVERAGING
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE PRIOR
EFFORTS AND DISCUSSIONS TO
ESTABLISH. THE- FTC EIGHT PM. OF
COURSE. OUR TARGET GAUGE INCLUDE
- THE CAL CRIME KERR'S. THAT
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA
AND REPRESENTATIVES OF THE FTC'S
AND LOCAL AND COMMERCIAL
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS. I
DH CS CONTINUES BY WEEKLY-
MEETINGS WITH A CORE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY THE
BEST POSSIBLE WAY TO DESIGN AND
OPERATIONALIZE THE EIGHT PM. I.
DAC HAS HAS FACILITATED IT WILL
CONTINUE TO ORGANIZE A SERIES OF
FORMAL MEETINGS WITH A LARGER
POOL OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY THE NEW. METHODOLOGY
AT THE CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH
ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL AS X. WHICH
YOU PROVIDERS A MANAGED CARE
PLANS- HAS GIVEN DH CS THE
FEEDBACK NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM. FOR
BOTH PROVIDERS AND- MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES SERVED NEXT TO IT
SEES US UP THROUGHOUT TWENTY TWO
AND- NEXT YEAR TWENTY THREE DHS
WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD REQUIRING.
A SMALL WORK GROUP MEETINGS AND
LARGE SCALE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
AS WELL AS A TARGETED SUPPORT
GROUPS WHEN NEEDED. TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL LAUNCH IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AND THIS CONCLUDES. THE
DEPARTMENT'S PRESENTATION. I BET
YOU YOU'D NEVER SAY THAT-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OBAMA
HELLO. THANK YOU SENATOR ADMIN
COREY SEAGER WITH DAILY- WE JUST
HAVE- SOME COMMENTS RAISED ON
ISSUES THIRTY SIX AND THIRTY
SEVEN- REGARDING THAT LIMITATION
OF EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTIONS WE JUST
KNOW THAT WE FIND IT UNCLEAR WHY
CERTAIN MEDICAL PROVIDERS ARE
PRIORITIZED OVER OTHERS FOR
RESTORED RATES IN THIS PROPOSAL-
THE LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WISH TO
CONSIDER THE MERITS AND COSTS OF
RESTORING PAYMENT RETURN PAYMENT
RATES FOR OTHER EVEN ALL- OTHER
MEDICAL PROVIDER TYPES THAT
REMAIN SUBJECT TO GET EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN RATE REDUCTIONS- WE
ESTIMATE THE ANNUAL COST OF
ELIMINATING ALL THE EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN GREAT REDUCTIONS-
AT ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION MAY HAVE USE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE COLD AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO. INFORM THE
SELECTION OF PROVIDERS FOR
RESTORED RAIDS- THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER REQUESTING
THE ADMIN TO- PROVIDE ITS
RATIONALE FOR WHY THESE PROVIDER
TYPES WERE CHOSEN AS WELL AS
INFORMATION- SUCH AS ON THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS THE
COPING NINETEEN ON THE SELECTED
MEDI CAL PROVIDERS. RELATIVE TO
OTHER PROVIDERS TO SUPPORT THIS
RATIONALE- IN ADDITION YOU KNOW
WHILE MANAGED CARE PLANS MAY NOT
ALWAYS EXACTLY TIED THE RATES
THEY PAY THEIR PROVIDERS TO
RAISE THE MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE- WE FIND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
RESTORE RATES WOULD LIKELY
AFFECT PAYMENT RATES AND MANAGED
CARE AS WELL AS FEES FOR
SERVICE- HOWEVER THIS PROPOSAL'S
COST ESTIMATE ONLY INCLUDES THE
COST IMPACT ON THE FEE FOR
SERVICE SYSTEM. WHICH WE FIND
MAY UNDERSTATE THE ULTIMATE
COST- THE ADMINISTRATION IS
NOTED THAT IT BELIEVES THAT THAT
MANAGED CARE COSTS FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE SMALL BUT THE
LEGISLATURE. OF ME WISHES OR
REQUEST. INFORMATION JUSTIFYING
THIS ASSUMPTION- REGARDING THE
EQUITY IN PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PAYMENTS PROPOSAL
FIRST WE WOULD NOTE THAT. THIS
PROPOSAL APPROPRIATELY TARGETS
KEY AREAS OF CONCERN. RELATED TO
QUALITY INEQUITY IN MEDIC COW
WITH ITS FOCUS ON CHILDREN'S
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES AND
MATERNAL HEALTH- THE SPECIFIED
GOALS SUCH AS IMPROVING
CHILDHOOD IMMUNIZATION RATES
ALSO SEEM TO ALIGN WITH THESE
AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT- HOWEVER A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW WOULD
BE NEEDED TO SEE IF THIS
PROPOSAL- LEAVES ANY SPECIFIC
QUALITY AND EQUITY DEFICIENCIES
ARE ADDRESSED- SECOND ON THIS.
PROPOSAL WE JUST KNOW THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE A SENSE OF THE CURRENT
STATE OF CLINICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THESE AREAS OF QUALITY AND
EQUITY. I'M TOO TIRED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THIS IS A KEY
FIRST STEP IN MEETING THE GOALS
OF THIS PROPOSAL- NEXT WE WOULD
NOTE THAT A LONGER ONGOING
STRATEGY INCLUDING THROUGH
PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR.
IMPROVING QUALITY AND EQUITY IN
MEDIC COW WILL BE NECESSARY TO
CREATING SUSTAINED IMPROVEMENT
IN THIS AREA- MEAL LATE LAST
YEAR DH CS RELEASED A DRAFT
REPORT OUTLINING A STRATEGY IN
THIS REGARD WHICH MAY PROVE.
BENEFICIAL GOING FORWARD.
FINALLY YOU KNOW WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE GATHER MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE APPROVING- SOME KEY
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS RESOLVED
INCLUDE NO WAY KEY QUALITY AND
EQUITY GOALS ARE LEFT
UNADDRESSED AND SHOULD BE
INCORPORATED INTO THE PROPOSAL-
WHAT IS THE CURRENT CONDITION OF
MEDICARE ALL PROVIDERS CLINICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WEISS
CLINICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
APPROPRIATE FIRST STEP TO TAKE
IN ADDRESSING THESE THESE EQUITY
IN QUALITY GAPS- HOW WOULD GRANT
APPLICATIONS BE SELECTED AND HOW
WILL DH CS OVERSEE THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS- AND HOW
WILL DH CS AS OTHER EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE MEDICAL PERFORMANCE ON
QUALITY AND EQUITY MEASURES.
CONTRIBUTE TO ONGOING
IMPROVEMENTS IN THESE AREAS-
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR
COMMENTS. AT THIS TIME HAPPY TO
BE OF FURTHER ASSISTANCE WHERE
NEEDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE TODAY MR- THE-
TRICK COOPER ON THIRTY SO. CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY
WHY SOME RAGE AND NOT AND NOT
ALL OF THEM AND DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU MIGHT BE UNDER- PROJECTING-
SO YOU KNOW WHEN THEY'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER THE PROPOSAL DID IT
INTENTIONALLY REALLY FOCUSING ON
. REALLY SOME OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED THAT WE'VE HAD DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
SPECIFICALLY- WHICH REALLY
ALLOWED US TO ZERO IN ON THE
LIST THAT WE RECOMMENDED WE ALSO
WE'RE LOOKINGAT THE OVER
SECTION- AND CROSS OVER WITH OUR
CONFERENCE OF QUALITY STRATEGY
WHICH WE JUST RELEASED. A
RECENTLY- IT WANTED TO ENSURE
THAT ODD YOU KNOW THAT IS HOW WE
NARROWED OUR LIST I WOULD JUST
NOTE THERE ARE THERE ARE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF THINGS
STILL LEFT ON THE EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN REDUCTION LIST- AND SO I
WOULD JUST NOTATE THAT- SO WE
DID TRY TO DO AN INTERSECTION
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THINGS LIKE
NURSING SERVICES WHICH HAS BEEN
YOU KNOW GREATLY IMPACTED DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY INCH
IT WAS A CRITICAL WORKFORCE.
PRIOR TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND JUST NOTATING IT
SO CRITICAL ESPECIALLY EVEN IN
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- OBVIOUSLY THE OXYGEN
RESPIRATORY SERVICES ARE ARE
CLEAR- IN ALIGNMENT WITH SOME OF
OUR CONVERSATIONS EARLIER TODAY
AUDIOLOGISTS. AND HEARING AID-
ITEMS ADDED TO OUR LIST TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
HELP IMPROVE THE AREAS OF
REIMBURSEMENT- THERE- AND SO YOU
KNOW WE REALLY TRY TO LOOK AT IT
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE IN REGARDS
TO UNDERFUNDING YOU DO NOT FEEL
THAT WAY BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE WILL BE A DIRECT IMPACT ON
THE FOR SERVICE WE HAVE DONE AN
ASSESSMENT ON THE MANAGED CARE
RATES- AND OFTENTIMES MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE PAYING HIGHER
THAN OUR FEE FOR SERVICE RATES
CURRENTLY EACH. OF WHICH IS WHY
WE DID NOT SCORE IT- AND SO AT
THIS POINT WE FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH OUR OUR OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL- AND I WOULD
NOTE. IS NOW ON HERE THAT I.
VISITED HIM. PROSTHETIC CLINIC
AND THEY HAD A LOT TO SAY ABOUT.
NOT HAVING THEIR RATES. IMPROVED
FOR A REALLY LONG TIME AND AS WE
KNOW. OUR ISSUES WITH- DIABETES
AND LOSS OF LIMBS THAT WAY. I
JUST THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
REALLY IMPACTS PEOPLE'S QUALITY
OF LIFE. HIS ABILITY TO GET IT A
GOOD FITTING. ARTIFICIAL LAMB-
ON THE ISSUE ON THIRTY EIGHT. SO
WITH THIS NEW TRANSFORMATION
WHAT WITH THE PILOT. WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE- PATIENTS ABLE TO
SEE MORE THAN ONE- PROVIDER ON
THE SAME DAY I'M ASKING ABOUT
THE SAME DAY BILLING ISSUE
REALLY. SHORT SO- THE PILOT
HASN'T GONE LIVE YET BUT- THE
EIGHT PM MODEL WOULD ALLOW AN
FQHC TWO SEATS ON THE
BENEFICIARIES AS MANY TIMES AS
NEEDED IN THE DAY. GIVEN THE
PAYMENT IS MORE LIKE A PM PM SO
LIKE I ALMOST THINK ABOUT ALMOST
LIKE HOW YOU PAY A PLAN A
CAPITATION PAYMENT IS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT COURSES- BUT AT
TEN PM THAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE
MONTHLY- FOR THEIR SERVICES AND
SO THAT GIVES THE FTC
SIGNIFICANT. FLEXIBILITY AND IS
THAT. HE WITH YOU. IS PMP. DOES
IS DOES THAT READ CHANGE PER THE
ACUITY OF THE OF THE PATIENT. IT
DOES NOT BUT I'M GONNA TAG
LINDSAY HARRINGTON R. OB DEPUTY
OF FINANCING TO GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF HOW THAT PM PM WOULD
WORK. FIRST WHAT WE WOULD DO IS
WE WOULD BE DEVELOPING A PER
MEMBER PER MONTH BASED ON AND
THE CATEGORY OF EIGHTY FOUR. FOR
THE PARTICULAR BENEFICIARY. AND
LOOK AT ME EXPECTED UTILIZATION
HISTORICAL UTILIZATION. THERE
ARE HISTORICAL KEEP YES FREE. TO
ESTABLISH HER MEMBER PER MONTH.
PER MONTH BY CLINICS. FOR THEIR
VARIOUS AGE CATEGORIES SO IT
WOULD IN SOME WAYS ACCOUNT FOR
THAT SCENE I'M NOT EXPECTING. A
CUTIE DIFFERENCES SO FOR EXAMPLE
A SENIOR AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IT IS EXPECTED TO
HAVE A HIGHER AVERAGE
UTILIZATION. AND A CHILD. OKAY
DECIDED WE'D WANT TO INCENTIVIZE
NOT TO COMP. THE US. IT WOULD BE
LOOKING AT THAT EXPECTED
UTILIZATION FOR THAT CATEGORY-
THAT THEY HAVE HAD HISTORICALLY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR. THANK
YOU I DO HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS
THE FIRST ONE ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO DID WE GET APPROVAL
FOR THE WAIVER. THEY'RE STILL
ACTIVELY WORKING ON APPROVAL
WITH THE US YOU MUST BE HAVING
EXTENSION CURRENTLY THROUGH-
MARCH AT THIS TIME ALL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM OKAY SO
THERE'S AN EXTENSION SO
THEREFORE WE ARE ABLE. TO
BECAUSE SOMEONE OKAY SO IN OTHER
WORDS BECAUSE IT SAID THAT WHILE
THE WAIVER APPLICATIONS STARTING
JERRY FIRST WHICH OF COURSE WAS
YOU KNOW BOTTOM HALF AGO OR
MORE- BUT WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN A
WAIVER SO WE'RE NOT. WE'RE NOT
IMPLEMENTING OF THIS YET RIGHT.
ONCE WE FINISH OUR NEGOTIATIONS
WITH CMS WHAT TYPICALLY HAPPENS
IS THAT DOES GO RETROSPECTIVE-
WE WOULD BE READY AND ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT AS SOON AS IT IS A
PRETTY LONG TIME. BUT I DON'T I
ASSUME THERE'S FINE A LOT OF
PEOPLE. I MEAN ARE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY STARTING TO IT IN HOPES
THAT BECAUSE OF THE WAIVER FOR
SOME REASON ARE PEOPLE GOING TO
WAIT. I THINK MOST PEOPLE ONLY
FOR THE WAIVER TO BE APPROVED
RIGHT OR IS. IT LIKE. IT WOULD
TYPICALLY WAIT FOR THE WAIVER TO
BE APPROVED OKAY THAT'S- ALL
RIGHT SO JUST REALISTICALLY IT'S
NOT STARTED YET BUT YOU SAID.
HOPEFULLY BY MARCH IS THAT THE
GOAL. I REALIZE THAT YOU CAN'T
UNSEE MESSED DOWN. ALL RIGHT YES
THAT WE ARE WORKING THROUGH THE-
EXPECTS TENSION NOW- AND HOPING
TO GET APPROVAL ON THE NEW ITEMS
WITHIN THE WAIVER OF COURSE-
PEOPLE ARE STILL ALREADY
ACCESSING THE WAIVER SERVICES
TODAY SO IT'S JUST THE NEW ITEMS
RIGHT THE NEW ITEMS RIGHT
CORRECT OKAY I JUST WASN'T CLEAR
ON THAT SO JENNIFER SO I THOUGHT
SO. NEARLY WAS ALL RIGHT- LET'S
SEE THIRTY THREE AGAIN
APPRECIATE- PUTTING
IMPLEMENTING- THIS SO LOOKING
FORWARD. TO GETTING A SERVICES
FROM MEDIC HELL. AND WE'RE NOT
TALK FIRST- FOR THAT HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT I THINK
WE FINALLY DO- THAT'S THE ISSUE
NUMBER- LET'S SEE SO ACTUALLY WE
RECOVERED NUMBER THIRTY SIX
OKAY- ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN.
SO I WOULD MAKE NOTES AGAIN
APPRECIATE THESE EFFORTS FOR
EQUALITY AND EQUITY HOWEVER AT
LEAST OUR ANALYSIS AND PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG- THAT-
WE'RE GONNA CLOSE MATERNAL CARE
DISPARITIES FOR BLACK AMERICAN
INDIAN. ALASKAN NATIVE NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND OTHER PACIFIC
ISLANDER INDIVIDUALS. IS THERE A
REASON WHY ASIANS ARE OUT AND I
GUESS LATINOS ARE OUT. I'M SORRY
TO HAVE TO PULL OUR DISPARITY
REPORT BUT ACTUALLY LET YOU KNOW
IS OFTEN RANKED IN THE HIGHEST
QUALITY SCORES FOR ALL OF OUR
POPULATIONS IN MCALLEN OFTEN I'M
SO DO YOU- ASIAN POPULATIONS IT
DOES VERY BASED ON THE MEASURE
METRICS AND WE HAVE ALL OF OUR
HEALTHCARE DISPARITY REPORTS
POSTED ON DHS'S WEBSITE. BUT I
WOULD SAY IS- WHILE WE ARE
FOCUSED ON A CLOSING VARIOUS
QUALITY EQUITY GAPS WE ALSO
WE'RE LOOKING AT- YOU KNOW
CLOSING CARE GAPS GENERALLY ON
UTILIZATION AS WELL AND THAT
WILL BE ACROSS ALL POPULATIONS-
AND WE WILL BE FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING QUALITY ACROSS THE
BOARD REGARDLESS OF. VARIOUS
PIECES- BUT WE ARE SEEING THE
LARGEST DISPARITIES CURRENTLY IN
OUR PROGRAM WITHIN THOSE
POPULATIONS ARE CERTAINLY DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THAT BUT I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT FIRST OF ALL I
GUESS FOR THE ASIAN POPULATION I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU DISAGGREGATED
SO YOU CAN'T LUMP EVERYONE
TOGETHER- THERE'S A LOT OF.
VARIATION WITHIN- BUT ALSO POINT
OUT AT LEAST FOR THE API
POPULACE OF THE ASIAN POPULATION
THAT THERE'S NUMEROUS STUDIES
THAT SHOW AND IN FACT I'M JUST
LOOKING HERE ONE AND. FROM
JAMMEH THOSE PUBLISHED IN TWENTY
TWENTY. IT'S A SAYING THAT RISK
OF ADVERSE OUTCOME THIS AGAIN
FROM MATERNAL MORBIDITY. AND
ASIAN WOMEN IS HIGHER FOR ALL
ASIANS EXCEPT JAPANESE WOMEN
COMPARED TO WHITES I MEAN DID
THERE'S CLEARLY DISPARITIES-
THAT ARE HAPPENING. IN TERMS OF.
MATERNAL OUTCOMES- AND IN THE
ASIAN POPULATION- SO- SO I.
DISREGARDED I CAN ON THAT YEAH.
OUR FOCUS AND THE LIST OF.
LOOKING TO CLOSE ALL GAPS OF
CARE ACROSS ALL POPULATIONS-
INCLUDING ALL SUBSETS AND ASIAN
POPULATIONS INSIDE. YEAH THE
PIECES SHOULD NOT BE ASKING IN
THAT WAY WE'LL BE ABLE TO CLOSE-
ALL CARE GAPS ACROSS ANYONE WHO
HAS THOSE PARAGRAPHS ACROSS YOU
KNOW PREVENTATIVE SERVICES- BOTH
FOR CHILDREN ADULTS- THE
MATERNITY AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WITH THE PROPOSAL. ALL RIGHT NOW
I APPRECIATE THAT- BUT I WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN SEEING WHAT
KIND OF DATA DCS IS LOOKING AT
PARTICULARLY WITH THIS
AGGREGATED DATA CONCERNING THE
ASIAN POPULATION. HAS HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT WITH YOU OKAY JOHNSON
WAS VERY DISAGGREGATED IT. OKAY
THE END THEY'LL PREVIEW YOU'RE
TRYING YOU KNOW TRYING TO
ADDRESS THESE QUALITY ISSUES.
BUT- TO. I THINK IN APRIL THAT
OF THE N. H. PI AND IN PLUS A
NATIVE- PARCELLS SO. IN
RECOGNIZING THEIR CHALLENGES-
OKAY AND THEN THE- ALL RIGHT
WITH IT SORRY WE WENT THROUGH A
WHOLE BUNCH OF THEM- OKAY. ALL
RIGHT WELL AND THEN I THINK- IN
TERMS OF THE- THE ALTERNATIVE
MODEL PROJECT- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THAT IN
TERMS OF- YOU- IN TERMS OF THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT MODELS- OKAY. IT JUST IT SO YOU'RE LOOKING
AT- MOVING THIS STARTING THIS IN
JENNIFER'S TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
OCT THAT IS CORRECT OKAY ALL
RIGHT RIGHT WELL LOOK I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT-
YEAH I THINK IT'S A POSITIVE
MOVE AND- AND AGAIN SO MOVING
TOWARD VALUE BASED PURCHASING-
BUT THE- THE OTHER PART THOUGH
IS WE'RE DOING THIS- AND I KNOW
THAT IT'S WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE
TALK ABOUT THINGS LIKE PLANS AND
SO FORTH THIS IS RUBY DEVELOPERS
PURCHASING WE HAVE TO BE SURE
WE- APPROPRIATELY- MONITORED THE
RISK PART SIDE SO THAT WE GET
THE RIGHT. INCENTIVE STRUCTURE
AND I KNOW THAT- YOU YOU'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THAT AT THAT AND THEN
ALSO IN TERMS OF ON ON THE-
EQUITY SIDE AS WELL SO I
APPRECIATE THE INNOVATION THAT'S
THAT'S INVOLVED IN THAT AND- BE
INTERESTED IN HEARING MORE ABOUT
THE DETAILS OF THIS IS A BOOST
FORD. THANK YOU. OF COURSE. OKAY
BUT IF YOU DON'T. OKAY BRINGS US
TO THE CONCLUSION OF- THE
TESTIMONY TODAY WILL NOW TURN TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS- WE HAVE SOME
PEOPLE LIVE HERE THAT ARE GOING
TO. TESTIFY AND I WILL I WILL-
CAUTION EVERYBODY AGAIN THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ONE MINUTE. TO
TESTIFY- TO MAKE TO MAKE YOUR-
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS. OPERATOR
YOUR ONLINE. YES I AM OKAY- CAN
YOU REPEAT THE NUMBER FOR PEOPLE
TO CALL IN TO PLEASE. ARE THE
DIAL IN NUMBER FOR TODAY'S CALL
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR BUT THE
ACCESS CODE OF. SIX TWO FIVE ONE
FOUR ZERO SEVEN. AND IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT ONCE YOU GET
ON YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU BYE JEOPARDY AT FIRST
WE HAVE TO BUT PEOPLE HERE IN
PERSON TO LAST FOR THE FIRST
PERSON PLEASE TO THE TEST TO.
GIVE THEIR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
TIM MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS COMING ON A FEW
ISSUES FIRST ISSUE NINE WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL FOR ADULTS- REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
SECONDLY WEREN'T SUPPORT ON
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
SPECIFICALLY ON THE CALIBRATION
EXPANSION I JUST WANT TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE THIS GOES BACK TO
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN THIS
COMMITTEE WAS VERY INSTRUMENTAL
IN ESTABLISHING THIS PROGRAM
WE'RE PUTTING NAVIGATORS AND
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS. HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL SO WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR-
CONTINUE THE INVESTMENT INTO
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM IT'S
MAKING A BIG DIFFERENCE IN A LOT
OF LIVES. LASTLY ON ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX I'M ALSO REPRESENTING
NOT ONLY THE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS BUT CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PLASTIC SURGEONS AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY- THE EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN CUTS. SO IF WE GO BACK TO
WHEN THEY WERE ESTABLISHED IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE STATE
WAS LOOKING AT A BUDGET DEFICIT
IN THE TWENTY BILLION RANGE.
WE'VE COME A LONG WAYS FROM TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WE THINK THE
TIME IS NOW TO GO AHEAD AND
REVERSE THOSE CUTS FOR
PHYSICIANS SPECIALTIES- AS WE'VE
HEARD THROUGHOUT THE DAY THERE
IT CONTINUES TO BE GAPS. IN
PROVIDING OUR SERVICES FOR
SPECIALIST IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM AND WE THINK THIS WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO START A LEVY SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JUST READ. NEXT
PERSON PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
HUH. THANK YOU FOR THEM TO SPEAK
TODAY ON AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN- AT THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM GRANT FUNDING- MY NAME
IS BUCKLING SIN A MEMBER OF THE
WALKER RIVER PAIUTE TRIBE. AND A
POLICY ANALYST AT THE CALIFORNIA
RULE INDIAN HEALTH BOARD- CRIB
IS A NETWORK OF FIFTY NINE
TRIBES IN NINETEEN TRIBAL HEALTH
WORKER PROGRAMS. ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON THEIR BEHALF- FIRST
I WANT TO THANK YOU- THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
HEALTH EQUITY IN THE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE COMMITTEE MOVE
FUNDING FOR THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM FROM WHILE ONE TIME TO
ON GOING- DIDN'T HELP PROGRAM
WAS CONTINUOUSLY FUNDED- FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS FROM THE ICE
CREATION IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE- TO- TO IT WAS. A FUNNY WAS
CUT IN TWO THOUSAND NINE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION- SINCE
FUNDING WAS ELIMINATED- THE
HEALTH DISPARITIES IN TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT IMPROVED.
BUT IN FACT NATIVE PEOPLE. ARE
WE'RE THREE AND A HALF TIMES
MORE LIKELY. TO BE HOSPITALIZED
BY COVERED IN- AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE- AND SUICIDE RATES HAVE
SKYROCKETED DURING THE DURING
THE PANDEMIC. ANOTHER STARK FACT
RECENTLY PUBLISHED BY THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH.
IS THAT NATIVE CHILDREN FOUR AND
A HALF TIMES AS LIKELY IT DOES
NOT I SPEND QUITE. A TO LOSE A
PARENT OR GRANDPARENT CAREGIVER
TO COPE AND- FURTHER INFANT
MORTALITY. RATES IN CAPTAIN IN
NATIVE COMMUNITIES IS ALMOST
TWICE THAT OF NON HISPANIC
WHITES- IN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AMERICAN INDIANS WERE WERE 50%
MORE LIKELY TO BE DIAGNOSED WITH. CORONARY HEART DISEASE OR
DIABETES. THESE A FEW THE HELL
DISPARITY- IN FRONT COMMUNITIES
- BUT THEY SPEAK TO THE- NEED
FOR. ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM. ON
ANOTHER NOTE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE I'M SORRY NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR- THE STATE OF. INDORSE
PUBLIC LAW TWO EIGHTY- THIS LAW
WAS DRAFTED DURING THE TIME WHEN
TRIBES WERE BEING- TRICK
TERMINATED ACROSS STATE. AND IT
GAVE THE STATE JURISDICTION OVER
TRIBAL LANDS IN EXCHANGE. FOR
THE FOR THE PROMISE OF PROVIDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY RESOURCES TO
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES IN SOME WAYS
IT MADE THE STATE ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE FEDERAL TRUST RESPONSIBILITY
AND TREATY OBLIGATIONS- DO THE
ROLE LOCATIONS OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. HERE ONE MINUTE IS
UP OKAY OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY IN. OKAY OPERATOR LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINE TELL ME DO WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY SIX
LINES IN Q. OKAY LET'S GET
STARTED. WELCOME CALLERS. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL START WITH FLYKNIT
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING WENT AWAY WITH WHAT
YOU'VE DONE ONLINE POVERTY
WANTED TAKE THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR ITS PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
MEDICARE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AN AGE AND
APPRECIATE THE LEAGUE
LEGISLATURE'S LEADERSHIP UNLESS
WE ECHO THE CHAIR'S STATEMENT
REGARDING THE NEED- STARGATE
STUDENTS POSSIBLE. ZEROING AND
PREMIUM AND COPAYMENTS AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE BOTH ELIMINATED FROM
STATUTE RATHER THAN ALLOWING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REINSTATE
COPAYMENTS I SIMPLY REVISING THE
MEDI CAL AT THE NET. PREMIUMS
AND COPAYMENTS SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED STATUTE. ACTUALLY AT
THE DEPARTMENT KNOWS. ARE
COPAYMENTS ACT AS A BARRIER TO
CARE AND THERE'S NO FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE. WHILE THEY DEPARTMENT
UPDATING THEIR REDETERMINATION
CHATTED STATUTE WE ECHO DR PAM'S
COMMENT AND RECOMMEND THE
DEPARTMENT USED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAINTAIN THE BENEFICIARY FROM
THE AUTOMATIC HERE BACK TO THE
DISCONTINUANCE DATE. WE SUPPORT
MAKING CUSTOM CROWNS PER BACK
DETACHABLE IT CLAIMS REPORT
GOING WITHOUT NEEDED CARE CLEAN
TEETH OR INCREASED DEBT TO PAY
OUT OF POCKET. THE PBL DIFFERS
TO PROVIDER MANUAL FOR CRITERIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TIME IS
AND YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT. AN
ACCIDENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BLIND SIXTY
ONE. GO AHEAD PLEASE. ALL. NINE
THIRTY ONE WE CANNOT HEAR YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON OPERATOR OR TRY
LINE THANK YOU I AM SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO KELLY
BEING HERE WITH CAT HEALTH NET
OF CALIFORNIA AND URINE OVER
GENE SUPPORT INDEED THAT BRIDGE
TO TRANSFER MY ACCOUNT. AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD TO
COLLABORATE WITH OUR COUNTY
COMMUNITY PARTNERS ENERGY THAT
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO ENSURE THE
INITIATIVES ARE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY AND THOSE SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED TO OUR MEMBERS BY
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVE. ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NINE FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL COVERAGE FOR ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE ADULTS. AND ALSO ISSUED
SEVENTEEN INTO PART OF THE
PROPOSED EXTENSION OF THE
CURRENT DENTAL MANAGED CARE
CONTRACTS. BUT THEY OPERATE
CANNIBAL IN CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE NOT FEATURE OF THE
SECRET SERVICE DENTAL PROGRAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU RIGHT
SPENCER AFTER A FEW QUIET FEMALE
A OG IN CALGARY PRETTY AFTER
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION FIRST LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
TO ALL ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF DOCUMENTATION
STATUS AND WE HAVE ALL SEEN A
CLOG STRESSED OR SUPPORT FOR
COVERAGE OF THE H. P. B. VACCINE
UNDER THE FAMILY BACK.
ADDITIONALLY SHE MAY SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF THE TRANSFORMATION
EQUITY GRANTS FOR TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT FAILED TO ENSURE THAT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CALLS WILL
MAXIMIZE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE FOR THE
MOST UNDERSERVED. ALSO IF YOU
MAKE A CALL AND THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ARE ALSO
STRONG ADVOCATES FOR GOING BACK
TO THE PREVIOUS EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN REDUCTIONS TO PROVIDERS
BUT AGREE WITH THE L. E. L.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
THESE RESTORATIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE BEST WAY TO
COVER ALL PROVIDER TYPES. SHE
MAKES THE SUPREME PROVIDE MORE
DETAILED WRITTEN COMMENTS ABOUT
THESE OTHER ISSUES POSED DURING
THE BOARD WORK WITH ALL PARTIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU SEVEN THREE.
CALL GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ADMIN
MEMBERS TYRANT EVEN TO
CALIFORNIA'S OF ALCALA DRUG PRO
EXPECT DIRECTOR ENOUGH SO WITH
IN THAT DISORDER. I SHOULD HAVE
THOUGHT BE A MINUTE DEDICATION
FOCUS ON BUYING IT FROM. WE
SUPPORT THIS BETTER ON A AND
MAKING AN ARTIST ABOUT THE
ROLLOUT OF COMPUTER DEMAND HI MY
AND HOPE THAT YOU CAN MAKE THAT
THE FUTURE. OVERCOAT THREE ARE
AT AN TIME HIGH LARGE DRIVEN BY
SENDING AND STIMULANT INTO THE
PROGRAM ARE CRITICAL IN TIME ALL
THE MORE IT'S NEEDED OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS EXCITED ABOUT THE
PAPER HOW CAN. INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS AND WE URGE ACCOUNTS
ARE ACCURATE IF WE SPLIT BETWEEN
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PROGRAMS AND WHILE NOT THE
FOCUS OF THIS HERE AND WE WANT
TO ECHO THAT WITHOUT ATTENTION
UPON WORKFORCE IT'LL BE
DIFFICULT FOR ANY OF THESE
EXCITING INITIATIVES TO SUCCEED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING OUT
MORE ON EACH OF THESE AND
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS YVONNE AGAIN IN
THE CAB WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POLICY CENTRE CALLING FROM PART
OF IBM NUMBER NINE THE
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
THAT ACCOUNT ALL BECAUSE
ELIGIBLE TWENTY SIX OF FORTY
NINE YEAR OLD. WELL DONE PATIENT
THAT IT. WOULD- YOU CAN BUILD A
PBS. AND FOUND PROVIDE MEDIC ALL
YOU CAN CALL COLOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEGHAN TO BIRDS AND
WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLAN
ADVOCATE STUDENT COUPLE ITEMS
ARE RUN THROUGH A COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NINE HEALTH FOR
ALL. ISSUE FOURTEEN THE MEDICAL
PHARMACY TRANSITION WE
APPRECIATED THE UPDATE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT I'M FROM THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES AND
HEALTH CENTER THE REPORTED A
NUMBER ISSUES RELATED TO PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS AND CONCERNED
ABOUT PATIENT SEEING SIGNIFICANT
DELAYS IN ACCESSING THEIR
MEDICATION. HOWEVER THE PROGRAM
TOOK A FACT AFFECT ON JAN ONE
HEALTH CENTERS ARE LOSING
CRITICAL FUNDING RELATED TO
THEIR THREE FORTY B. SAVINGS
EACH DAY AD WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION INCLUDE
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL PLAN FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT WILL. HELP
MITIGATE THE FINANCIAL HARM FOR
THAT COMMITTEE HEALTH CENTER I
GUESS YOU THIRTY SEVEN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE DESIGN OF THE EQUITY IN
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION PROVIDER
PAYMENT TO GUARANTEE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE ACCESS AND
FINALLY ON ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND BRINGING UP
THE IMPORTANCE OF SAME DAY THEY
SET OUT WE ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND STAKEHOLDERS. AT
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY ALONGSIDE IT TO
CREATE AND IMPLEMENT THE APM
REVIEWING A PROPOSAL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU- ANY
ADMINISTRATION ENVIRONMENT FOR
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CALLER PLEASE. THANK RYAN
NINE CRITICAL AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MY NAME IS TERRA
NEGATING REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS. I WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE
THE BRIDGE FUNDING THE PROPOSAL
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OUTREACH
AND ESPECIALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
LA- AND C. B. H. T. GESTION OF
ALLOCATING THE FUNDING THEM
SIMILAR TO THE HAPPY PROGRAM
RATHER THAN A GRANT BASED
PROGRAM. SECONDLY WE AGREE THAT
WE DO NEED TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ON A REALIGNMENT IN THE PRE
SHAPE BUT THEN- PAN AND
CHAIRWOMAN EGGMAN INTEREST IN
THAT- AND LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING ABOUT THE NEED TO ALIGN-
THE ACTUAL NEED FOR PAYROLL
PURPOSES AND RECENT POLICY
CHANGES WITH THE FINAL THING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ADRIAN SOMETHING WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE AT CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THREE ITEMS TODAY
FIRST ITEM FIVE THE PETER HALL
CONTINUE ON INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS. YOU ARE WANTED TO CALL
ATTENTION TO THE FOURTH ROUND OF
FUNDING COMING UP WHICH WILL. BE
FOCUSED ON INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH FACILITIES
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT HE GOT
THE WORKING. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM TWENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
SUPPORT MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
FROM SHORT TERM. RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM WHICH
CURRENTLY I AM USING. THE
QUALITY CLOSURES BECAUSE OF THE
ATMOSPHERE A LAW WILL HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON CHILD
WELFARE OUTCOME. UNDERMINED THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORMS
PROGRESS. HUNDREDS OF FOSTER
YOUTH WITHOUT ADEQUATE CARE AND
SERVICES. THESE ARE ON BOTH
MOBILE AND OUT WITH YOU. AND
THEY DO THEIR ABILITY REGARDLESS
OF FEDERAL AND STATE POLICY
SHIFT. AND WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
APPLAUD THE DEPARTMENT'S.
EFFORTS TO FALL OUT. THAT THE
PILOT OF THE TRIBE I THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW COLOR. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ADMITTED BETTER
AT LEAST FOR A LITTLE HELP
ACAPELLA KOREAN COMMUNITY
COMMITTING A FEW ITEMS. WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER NINE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN SHARING THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE OFTEN
QUALIFY REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. NUMBER TWO.
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT
GRAFTING MEDIC HELD COURT
ABILITY BY. PEERING OUT BRINGING
BACK OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JUST COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR ADNAN AND DR
PAN GET AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WENDY **** PRACTICUM WORK
LOCATED IN LA COUNTY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT I AM TWENTY FIVE WHICH
WOULD SUPPORT MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. IN S. T. R. T.
P.'S DETERMINED TO BE MEDICAL I
AM D. R. STATE SPONSOR YOU NEED
ACCESS TO A FULL CONTINUUM OF
CARE THAT MEETS THEIR INDIVIDUAL
LIFE BEHAVIORAL HEALTHCARE
NEEDS. AS A RESULT OF ASSET PSA
LOCK THE DOOR HE CLOSURES AND
DOWNSIZING WILL BE DISASTROUS TO
THE ENTIRE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
UNDERMINING THE STATE MULTI YOUR
PROGRESS ON THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORMS I WILL LEAVE
HUNDREDS OF FOSTER YOUTH.
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE CARE AND
SERVICE. HOW SIMPLY CANNOT LET
HAPPEN CHART BY YOU. AGES ARE
STILL. REGARDLESS OF FEDERAL AND
HOW SHARE THANK YOU. YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR DYSTONIAS FOR
KERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION SPEAKING TO
ISSUE EIGHT THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE THE PANDEMIC HAS
BROUGHT UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES
TO OUR STUDENTS SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOLS ARE
FACED WITH NOT ONLY ADDRESSING
ACADEMIC NEEDS OF STUDENTS BUT
ALSO THEIR WELL BEING AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC. CTA
RECOGNIZES THE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES DEDICATED FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET HOWEVER WE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
COHESIVE AND COMPREHENSIVE PLANS
WHICH IN THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE IMPLEMENTED.
EFFECTIVELY AND THAT THIS
FUNDING AND ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO BE ACCESSIBLE AND
TAILORED TO SCHOOL SETTINGS IN
ORDER TO BENEFIT STUDENTS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MACROCOSM STOCKMAN
ADVOCATES CALLING IN ON THE ACT
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
AUDIOLOGY A COUPLE ITEMS TO COME
IN ON FIRST ON ISSUE THIRTY SIX
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
AUDIOLOGY STRONGLY SUPPORTS
PROPOSAL TO RESCIND THE A. B.
NINETY SEVEN PROVIDE A RATE
REDUCTION FOR AUDIOLOGIST. BUT
MANY PROVIDER TYPES PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE IMPACT THE RATE REDUCTION
DICK SENT DOWN THE DRUG
PROVIDERS OF CRUCIAL MEDICAL
SERVICES. AND ON TO THE VERY
VULNERABLE PATIENT THE RELIANT
TREAT THAT INDICATE THE STATE
LIKE THE IDEOLOGIST THE
REDUCTION IN MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES IS RESULTING
IN FAR FEWER PROVIDERS. BEING
ABLE TO DIRECTLY SERVE PART OF
GETTING RESIDENTS TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL MEDICAL CHALLENGES
NAVIGATING THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE PANDEMIC. RESTORING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WILL HELP
LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE QUALITY AND
EQUITY GOALS. AND SECOND ISSUE
ONE CA APPRECIATE THE EFFORT IN
pADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WATCH THE HEARING
AID COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
PROGRAM. WE KNOW THAT A
PERMANENT FINALIZING ADDITIONAL
COVERED BILLING CODES AND IS
COMMITTED TO EXPANDING OUTREACH
EFFORTS. THE COMPLETION OF THESE
EFFORTS ARE AND WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING THE
PROVIDER IS ABLE TO PUT IN THE
PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE WORKING
THAT LOOK FOR DISSING THEM
THROUGH OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS. THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT AT.
PRETTY HAVE. REMEMBER BEAR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PLANT PUBLIC
HEALTH NETWORK. THANKS A COURT
ISSUE NUMBER SIX BUT WE ALSO
WANTED TO MAKE NOTE THAT WHILE
WE DFINITELY SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME MODIFICATIONS TO ENSURE
RACIALLY AND TRUST EMPLOYMENT
CREATION OF MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE BENEFIT. THE BAR TO
LONG OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. UNDERFUNDING COMPLEX
SEGMENTATION AND THE LACK OF
CLEAR STANDARDS FOR COUNTY
HELLO. EVERYONE AND ESPECIALLY
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVES TO A
POLICE RESPONSE. WHICH FAR TOO
OFTEN RESULT IN HARM COULD NOT
BEGIN TRAUMA OR SOMETIMES EVEN
DEATH WHEN LOOKING AT INSTANCES
OF MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. WHEN
LOOKING AT THE OVERALL FEAR WITH
NINE EIGHT. CAL LANE THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT AND THE
CRISIS ACTOR THERE ARE NUMEROUS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CALIFORNIA TO
GET THIS RIGHT AND ENSURE THAT
PEERS AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS ARE PART OF THE RESPONSE
MECHANISM. AND THAT WORKERS ALSO
HAVE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY AND BODY TRAINING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
URGE THE COMMUNITY TO WORK.
THANK YOU. OR PLEASE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT NINETY THREE PRE TRIAL. BY NINE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I APOLOGIZE I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
KERR AND MANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS LAUREN- AND HE
CHECK ON BEHALF OF BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA WE LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NINE
EXPANDING MEDI CAL ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. HE'LL HAVE
BEEN INCONSISTENT THE QUARTER OF
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND BOARDED LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ITEM THAT EXPANDED
MEDICAID OUT THE BUILT OVER
FIFTY REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. YOU CAN SEE THE COVER
BUDGET TAKE ANOTHER LARGE STEP
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL COVERAGE. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MOVE THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURIE JOHNSON
I'M FROM. PRODUCT CARE BAY AREA
FREE CLINIC AND WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND MEDICARE TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE FROM TWENTY SIX TO
FORTY NINE YEAR OLD CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
. GIVE ME THAT WE ALSO HOPE THAT
YOU. BUILD ON PREVIOUS
EXPANSIONS AND FINALLY PROVIDE
MEDICAL TO ALL. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT'LL SAVE
YOU SAVE MONEY IN THE LONG RUN
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LAST
NAME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN ENSCO
WITH THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA WE
ALSO ARE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND THAT ACCOUNT TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE TWENTY SIX TO
FORTY NINE YEAR OLD. REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MARTY EMOTO
I'M A FAMILY MEMBER OF A PERSON
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TO BE
CANNED CALIFORNIA ABILITIES IN
YOUR COMING ACTION NETWORK I
WANT TO THANK YOU- TERRY ADMIN
FOR THE WAY YOU CONDUCTED THIS
HEARING AND ALSO SENATOR PAN. OF
THE RATING REALLY GOOD QUESTION
CONCERNS ABOUT MANY OF THE ITEMS
THE QUICK SHOUT OUT TO DC COOPER
AND THE PEOPLE AT THE DEPARTMENT
FOR MOVING FORWARD ON CAL AIMS
AND BEING VERY INCLUSIVE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND DEPENDING ON
HOW IT'S GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF COMPANIES
THAT WILL BE DONE IN THE RIGHT
WAY YOU COULD BE VERY
TRANSFORMING. IT TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN ORDER
CALIFORNIANS THOUGH JUST WANTED
THANK YOU AND ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WORK FOR
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR KIND WORDS AND FROM YOUR
LIPS TO GOD'S EARS ABOUT
TRANSFORMING. OUR SYSTEM THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHURCH MEMBERS BENJAMIN
TRANSPORTATION AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA- IN
SUPPORT OF THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
TWENTY SIX TO FORTY NINE YEAR
OLD CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS ONE OUT OF
EVERY ASIAN IMMIGRANTS IN THE U.
S. AS UNDOCUMENTED BUT THIS
MAKES THEM NO LESS DESERVING OF
HEALTHCARE ACCESS AND COVERAGE.
TO BE HONORED TO MEET MEMBERS
HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RATES OF INFECTION AND MORE TO
THE MORTALITY RATES WHEN IT
COMES TO COPING AND THIS IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHY IT IS
IMPERATIVE ESPECIALLY WHILE
STILL CALM COMBATING THE
PANDEMIC TO GET GREATER
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE I THANK YOU
FOR THE LONG RUN COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY AND HOPE TO HAVE A
GREAT EVENING. ABOUT THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MAINTENANCE AND LINDA MENDOZA A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE WORKER
COME ABOUT I WOULD DOMESTICALLY
BECAME A COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECT ALSO KNOWN AS MIKE UP. I
AM I AM COMING IN SUPPORT OF THE
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER NINE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND MEDI CAL TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE. TWENTY SIX TO FORTY
NINE YEAR OLD. YEAR OLD. I
WOULD. REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE URGE YOU TO BUILD ON
PREVIOUS EXPANSIONS AND TRYING
TO BE PROVIDING MEDICAL TOOK
ALL. CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IN
BREAKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
OR EDITION NINE TO EXPAND. BOTH
GO PARKING AMPLE SCOPE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE FOR ALL ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS I'M PRETTY SURE SUPPORT
THIS MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT AS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO ADDRESS
ACADEMICALLY AND I HOPE YOU'RE
DOING GREAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL WANT YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU CAN. TO HEAD COACH
HELLO EVERYONE. YOUR TIME IS
YOUR COLOR. HELLO MY NAME IS
FROM GOD WAS HERE AS A COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER FROM MEXICO
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY OVER THE
NEXT TWO PROJECTS- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET
PROPOSALS TO EXPAND MEDICAL
SCHOOL ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
TWENTY SIX AND FORTY NINE YEARS
OLD CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS WE URGE YOU
TO BUILD ON PREMISES
CONSTRUCTION AND TRAINING
PROVIDED MEDICAL TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU I. NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOSH DUGGAR COMMENTING ON BEHALF
OF SEVERAL CLIENTS ON MULTIPLE
ISSUES FIRST THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS YOU CAN T.
HELP EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA IN IRVINE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA IN THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS BEEN CLEVER
COUNTY SUPPORT THE MEDIC HOW
AGENTS ALL ADULTS. CHECKING ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE THE FUSION CALIFORNIA
WE MUST OPPOSE ISSUE TWELVE THE
BUNDLING OF THE CHILD HEALTH AND
DISABILITY PROGRAMS LASTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS IF YOU H.
ALONG WITH URBAN COUNTY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA
CLARA IN VENTURA COUNTY. ARE
ALSO PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S. PUBLIC HOSPITAL
FINANCING REFORM LANGUAGE WHICH
WILL PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO STRENGTHEN
MEDICAL PAYMENTS ON MEDIC HOW
ARE ACTS. JANUARY OF THE DON'T
HAVE REPORTED A NUMBER OF
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW OUR ACT WE RAISE THESE
ISSUES WITH YOU YEAH AND WITH
JALEN AND REMAIN COMMITTED TO
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET
THE ISSUE RESOLVED S QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SHE COULD BE A CAGE
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TOGETHER LIKE. YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTY PRICKLE AT. SHARE UNLESS
YOU'RE ON TWO ISSUES THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
SPECIALTY USA MAKER OF- NASAL
AND INTRAMUSCULAR FORMULATIONS
OF NALOXONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF- ITEM TWENTY NINE- WE SUPPORT
THE DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST FOR
FUNDING IT'LL- AND ABLE THE
DEPARTMENT COULD THEY CALL FDA
APPROVED FORMULATIONS AND DOSAGE
STRENGTHS. OF NALOXONE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE LOCK ON DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM ON THE OTHER LEVEL
POSITIONS OF CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NINE THE
LOCAL EXPANSION AT ALIGN OUR
ORGANIZATION WITH THESE
STATEMENTS BY OUR COLLEAGUES IN
MEDICINE THAT IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THIS OBJECTIVE IS FAIRLY
ESSENTIAL TO ROLL BACK. THE BELL
OVER DECADE OLD CUTS TO
PROVIDERS. IN THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NOT
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS TIM
LYNCH WITH PLATINUM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF LIBERTY DENTAL PLAN
ONE OF THE CONTRACTED PLANS IN
SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES- CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN TO EXPAND
THE MANAGED CARE CONTRACTS-
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY SIX. WE
BELIEVE THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM OFFERS ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE NOT FEATURES OF THE FEE FOR
SERVICE DENTAL PROGRAM AND WE
BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
PROVIDE CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES AND
PROVIDE A THOUGHTFUL PATH
FORWARD. TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION
OF CAL AIM WE WOULD SIMPLY KNOWN
AS WE'VE DONE SO BEFORE IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT EXAMINATION OF
PARITY OF PERFORMANCE- REQUIRES
PARITY. OF DATA INPUTS AS WELL
THE TWO PROGRAMS DO NOT USE THE
SAME DATA INPUTS AND THEREFORE
ANALYSIS SOMETIMES- COMES OUT
WITH SKEWED RESULTS AT THE BACK
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR TURNED
THANK YOU BYE HI I'M LOOKING FOR
THE DENTIST AND THEN CONTRIBUTE
TO CONTACT WITH THE COMMUNITY
CLINIC CUTTING BENEFICIARY THING
JOE RESTRICT MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY HOW
DO YOU SUPPORT THE DECISION BY
DOUBLING THE SONS. AND THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
SOMETHING TREMENDOUS THANK YOU
IN THE CALLIN PROGRAM THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM CONTINUES
TO HELP OUR PATIENTS WELL AND
I'M COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING IT I
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE CONTINUED YOUR CAN'T
HELLO I'M MOST I NEED A NEW TEAM
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT NOW NINE PLEASE
GO I HAVE. A MAN- BOB ACTED ON
BEHALF OF COUPLE CLIENTS ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX FIRST THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION MEDICAL
PRODUCTS SUPPLIERS PROVIDERS A
DMB MEDICAL SUPPLIES MENTAL
FORMULA WE APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT INCLUDING SOME TYPES
OF DNA ELIMINATION THE 10% CUT
BUT IT SHOULD BE APPLIED TO ALL
THE COST OF GOODS TO COST OF
SERVICE. STABBING DELIVERY
CRATER ALL INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY IT'S TIME FOR THE
10% REDUCTION BE LIMITED FOR ALL
KINDS OF PNB MEDICAL SUPPLIES
AND FORMULA SECONDLY ON BEHALF
OF RADIOLOGISTS PATHOLOGISTS WE
JOIN OUR COLLEGE OF MEDICINE IN
ADVOCATING THAT THE BABY NINETY
SEVEN COPY ELIMINATE FINALLY BUT
OVER A DECADE WITH NO JUST BEEN
REIMBURSED REACH POSITION
SERVICES. THE COST OF RENTING
SERVICE GETTING ESCALATE. AND WE
URGE YOUR. SUPPORT FOR THAT
CHANGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
OF I NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. NOT ONLY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE STAYED
STRONG COLOR QUESTIONABLE BUT IT
STILL GIVES PEOPLE CHAPTERS IN
SUPPORT OF YOU SURE NINE
EXPANDING MEDI CAL TO OR IF YOU
NEED YOUR PHONE TO THE PHONE IN
INDEPENDENTLY OF AGE ANY
QUESTIONS STATUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I AM
SICK SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LAURA KAPLAN HONESTY
OVER THE SOUTHERN INDIAN HEALTH
COUNCIL LOCATED IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WE PROVIDE HEALTHCARE
TOWARD SEVEN CONSORTIUM TRIED
ADDRESS YOU TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN MAKING MONEY FOR
THE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM
ONGOING NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION HAS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE PAST DECADE
AND THE POPULATION INCREASE
BECAUSE OF THE NEED. FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE THE DATE OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS WHEN IT IS
REIMBURSED BY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BUT GENERAL FUNDS REQUIRES THAT
THE PARTS OF THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN SCARCE. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S WORK
ON EXPANDING MEDI CAL SERVICES
ARE TELLING IT DOES NOT REFLECT
THAT MUCH AGAIN UNINSURED NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION GREATER THAN
THEY SHOULD HAVE INCREASED OUR
TURNOVER RATE THAT MAKES IT THAT
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING RECRUIT
HEALTHCARE POSITION. WE HAVE TO
BE CREATIVE ON HOW WE CAN RETAIN
TOP OF BOTH COMPETE WITH LOCAL
HOSPITALS ARE ABLE TO OFFER
HIGHER SALARIES AND BENEFITS I
ASKED YOU TO SUPPORT ONGOING
FUNDING WITHIN A HEALTH PROGRAM
THAT SUDDEN AND HELP HELP ON
OTHER NATIVE HEALTH CLINIC CAN
CONTINUE THE WORK WE DO FOR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
NINE CRITICAL AD. I'M GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR- AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE NIGHT
AND THAT MIGHT HELP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF AND
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS NEAR ELKO
TRADE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
ISSUES. THIRTEEN AND EIGHTEEN-
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY DO THAT THE
FIFTY FIVE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FULLY FUNDING- THE MEASURES OUT
BACK- LEGISLATION AND NOT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES IN MY DISTRIBUTION ARE
CALLING IN FOR. OUR PATIENTS
THIRTY SIX I'M FULLY SUPPORT-
REINSTATING THAT- IT MAY HAVE
BEEN CUT. AND WOULD ENCOURAGE-
pTHANKSGIVING FOOD- LIKE THE
DIVIDED WELL I'M VERY LABORATORY
PRACTICES- AND THAT REALLY DOES
IMPACT THE DEAL TO BE. BACK OKAY
PROVIDE AN ANSWER TO ISSUE
THIRTY SEVEN A WELL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLORFUL. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DR BENJAMIN WHO AND I AM A
PRACTICING GENERAL DENTISTRY
BENEFICIARIES THE LOS ANGELES
PREPAID HEALTH IT MIGHT ACTUALLY
KERRY. I SUPPORT DECISION BY
GOVERNOR USE THEM TO EXTEND THE
DENTAL BATCH CARE PROGRAM.
IMITATION OF DENTAL HEALTHCARE
PROGRAM CANCEL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM CONTINUES TO SERVE. MY
PATIENTS WHILE OFFERING A
CULTURE TO THE PER FROM. THE
PRODUCT ALL HAS OWN
INDISCRETIONS HAVE TO YOU WHAT'S
THE MATTER PROGRAM SH AND I
COMMITTED JUST IT AS A PRO. I
THE LEDGES FOR YOUR SUPPORT I'M
JUST. INSURE OF CARE TRUMP
HIGHLY HE DID COME MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NICE
COLOR PLAY. THANK YOU I AT THREE
CALL AT. HI THIS IS CHARLENE
THAT'S WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT ASSOCIATION CPA'S
HERE WOULD LIKE COOKS IT TO. OF
THE RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP ITEMS
FIFTEEN REGARDING PHARMACY
RECRUITMENT OPEN COMMUNITY
PHARMACY IS NOT RELIEVED OF
THESE RECRUITMENT FOR FINANCIAL
IMPACT.
WILL FORCE MANY TO
DISCONTINUE. MEDI CAL PROGRAM
HOW AND MOST ISSUE RETRO LAW
CALL BACKS IF THE DRESS WHERE
CAN THAT. TO PROVIDE CARE
PRIMARILY IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY WILL NOT ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THEIR PART. THANK YOU
FOR TIME THANK YOU FOR MUCH
THANKS FOR. THANK YOU AT FOR
PLEASE HAD. HELLO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TIME MY NAME IS JOHN
SWAP AND THE FINANCIAL OFFICER
COUNTRY UNIQUELY. I'M CALLING TO
BE OF THIS FIVE PAGE THAT WE SEE
AND FOR NORTHERN.
AND ONE INTO A
- REALLY IMPACT OUR PATIENTS
ALSO- WE HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING
A TEAM MEDICAL SUPPLIES FOR
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS WHO NEED
SPECIFIC FIVE NEEDLES IN ACCESS
TO SYRINGES FOR THEIR HOME
CORPSMAN TREATMENT. I'M IN A
COMBINATION OF TRYING TO NOT
TRYING TO GET ACCESS FOR
PATIENTS AND THEN THE LOSS OF
OUR THREE FORTY B. REVENUE I
WILL WE ARE A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF INCREASING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PLAN BY THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
GENERAL FUND WHICH IS WHERE
THREE FORTY B. REBATES ARE NOW
GOING- BLOSSOMED YOUNGER MEN'S
SHAVING. AND REIMAGINING SCHOLAR
PLEASE. THANK YOU I. NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CHAPMAN IN FRONT OF THE PANEL I
THOUGHT LET THEM TELL THEM THAT
YELP ADVOCATES AND UNDER
DIFFICULT TIMES ON IT WERE
CALLING AT THE PORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER NINE THE COMPANY'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDICAID.
COMPATIBLE TWENTY SIX TO FORTY
NINE OF THE CALIFORNIA. COAST
GRATION PADDLE. WE DON'T
APPRECIATE HOW PRODUCTS WILL
SELECT THE CALL NEED TO K.
ABSOLUTELY LIKE TRANSCENDED
EXPAND AMONG. IMMIGRANT CHEMICAL
COMPOUNDS THINGS ADVOCATE FOR
HEALTH AND RECORD TO WITH THEM
AS TO AN INCLUSIVE. YEAH THANK
YOU VERY THANKS COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M MORE ALL FIVE
PLEASE AHEAD. IT WAS. SHOOTING
THE NEXT SERIES MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
THE DECISION TO EXTEND THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM.
INDICATION OF POTENTIAL. SO A
GRAM GENTLEST RICHER FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE CONTINUITY OF CARE WRITE
HIGHLY NEEDED COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NICE COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WHAT ELSE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DR AND I AM A
PRACTICING GENERAL DENTISTRY.
SHE CAN GET YOU A GRAPHIC
PREDATOR PROGRAM AND
SENTIMENTALITY I SUPPORT THE
DECISION BUT GOVERNOR DO
SOMETHING THAT THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM CLINTON
PATIENT OF TE DENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM. THE LAND CARE PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO SERVE MY PATIENTS
WELL AND I AM COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING IT ACROSS. USING THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL. DON'T CONTINUE
THAT YOU CARE. TO THE MOST HIGH
NEED COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DR L. MITCHELL AND I'M ATTACHING
GENERAL DENNIS TO PULL CAUSES
WITH SEDATION SERVICES AND
OFFICE BETWEEN BENEFICIARIES BUT
THE SPECIAL NEEDS AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. DID
YOU CRACK MEDICARE PROGRAM AND
ELLIE COUNTY. BECAUSE OF OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH LIBERTY DENTAL
PLAN WHICH THE DENTAL MANAGED
CARE PROGRAM. WE'RE ABLE TO
FACILITATE A SHARE. FOR THE
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION WHICH
INCLUDES COMPREHENSIVE GENERAL
DENTISTRY. INDICATE ENVIRONMENT
THAT INCLUDES SEDATION. LET'S
MOVE ON I THINK WE LOST THE
CALLER. THANK YOU RIDE ONE OR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MORNING THINKING HERE AT THE
CANDY FORM OCCURRING ISSUE FIXED
MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS BENEFIT AS
WELL THE ISSUE SEVEN CONTINUUM
OF CARE. L. TWO C. DHS'S
PROPOSAL TO ADD MOBILE CRISIS
INTERVENTION CURVATURE THEM
WALKING INTO THE NECESSARY
INVESTMENT IN BUILDING OUT
NINETY AND THE STATE. WILL CLEAR
IN THIS AFTERNOON STAKEHOLDER
PANEL PLANNING AS WELL AS
SPENDING A STRONG BEHAVIOR
HEALTH EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM
ARE BOTH CRITICAL ELEMENTS
TONIGHT ACROSS LOCAL MEDITATION.
AT THE CO SPONSOR OF BOTH EIGHTY
NINETY AND NINETY UNDER REQUEST
WE HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING OF
HOW LATE IT WILL FIT WITHIN OUR
BROADER HEALTH REFORMS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND- ONE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING A NONPROFIT CREDIT. COUNSELING STATE FAIR TO BE
DONE. OF COURSE I DON'T KNOW
FIVE BEHAVIOR HEALTH I'M AT THE
JUNCTURE ON THE TICKET WE ROUND
FOR THE BENEFIT OF. THE NUMBER
OF PORTS MEDIC HOW ARE YOU. AND. EVERYBODY AT THIS THERE ARE
OTHER POSSIBLE THE PRESIDENT
PROBLEM THAT INCLUDED RIGHT THE
QUESTION OF THE PATIENT AMONG
OTHER PROBLEM ONE AND NOT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE DOWN OUT WE
START AGAIN IN ORDER TO GET THE. BASEBALL THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS PLEASE. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT LIVE IN GO OUT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND OF COMMITTEE
DID HAM THE CALIFORNIA EXPOSED
OF HEALTH PLANS I DID HEAR
VOICED HER SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
NUMBER NINE. EXTENDING FULL
CHROMATIC HELLBENT ALL OF THE
OLD GUARD OF THE DEMONSTRATIONS
THAT AT. YOU SHOULD HAVE A THE
MINISTER. WELL BEFORE AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL THE WORK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AROUND THIS
ISSUE. IN PREVIOUS YEARS- THAT
IS TO WORK EXPANDING- YOU KNOW
ACCESS TO INDIVIDUALS AND MOVING
CLOSER TOWARDS UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE SO- ONCE AGAIN AT.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH SIX
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU AND- HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DAVID LEVINE AND I'M WITH THE
HEALTH ALLIANCE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE NORTH COAST
CLINICS NETWORK TOGETHER ARE
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
MEMBERS SERVE MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND PATIENTS ACROSS FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- I'M CALLING
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
INCREASING THE NON HOSPITAL
CLINIC SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT POOL
BY FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE STATE GENERAL FUND. MANY OF
OUR REAL COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS ARE THE ONLY PROVIDERS
OF HEALTH SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
IN THE REMOTE COMMUNITIES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WITHOUT SUCH AN
AUGMENTATION VALUE PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT ARE
OTHERWISE NON REIMBURSABLE BE AT
RISK. AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT WILL BE INCREASED BY
FIFTY NINE DOLLARS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEN BALL DRAMA
WITH THE VITAMIN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF OUR CLIENT AND THE QUEST-
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT ON ITEM
SEVENTEEN RELATED TO DENTAL
MANAGED CARE IN LOS ANGELES AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTIES. MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LONG TERM MOVE
TOWARDS FULLY INTEGRATED PLANS
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE DENTAL AND
VISION UNDER CALAMP- AND WERE
ALIGNED WITH THE GENERAL THRUST
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
RESTRICT YOUR GMC CONTRACT THAT
THE MECHANISM TO IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM WHAT WE MAKE THAT
TRANSITION. WE ARE HOWEVER
CONCERNED WITH LANGUAGE IN THE
TRAILER BILL THAT DOESN'T
TECHNICALLY REQUIRE THE
REQUIREMENT TO BE INITIATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT. WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR PAM FOR QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THIS ITEM EARLIER AND
WE WERE PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
APARTMENT COMMIT TO. CONDUCTING
THE RE PROCUREMENT ON A TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TIME LINE. WE WOULD
SIMPLY SUGGEST THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE SHOULD REFLECT
THAT CONTENTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT THE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I WON SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CRAZY BOY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLINICAL LABORATORIES
ASSOCIATION I'M CALLING ABOUT
ISSUE THIRTY SIX THE RESTORATION
OF THE EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDER CUTS. THE DEPARTMENT
MENTIONED THAT THEY PICK
PROVIDERS BASED ON THOSE THAT
WERE GREATLY IMPACTED DURING THE
EMERGENCY AND THOSE THAT
PROVIDED CRITICAL SERVICES A WE
BELIEVE THAT CLINICAL LABORATORY
DID IN FACT PROVIDE VERY
CRITICAL SERVICES IN CONDUCTING
THE CODE NINETEEN TESTING. THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO MENTIONED THOSE
AT PROVIDER THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY FUTURE SURGEONS ARE
THE ONES THAT WERE INCLUDED. AND
AGAIN WE BELIEVE THAT CLINICAL
LABORATORIES WILL BE CRUCIAL IN
HELPING WITH ANY FUTURE SURGEON
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
THAT THE CLINICAL LABS BEING
INCLUDED ON THE LIST OF
PROVIDERS FOR WHICH THE EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN CUTS WILL BE
RESTORED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN WHAT EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ACCORDING
TO ONE. HELLO STRANGER DENTISTS
TREATING DANGEROUS TREES IN THE
GEOGRAPHIC MEMBERSHIP PROGRAM.
IN SEPTEMBER. ORDER TO
STRENGTHEN. DENTAL INSURANCE
PROGRAM GERMAN CHRISTIAN ALL.
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE YOU
REGISTERED YOUR FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL. TO ENSURE YOUR
CARE TO OUR MOST TRADING
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON BY THE BEACH I WILL
PROBABLY HAVE SOME RANCHOS I'M
SORRY YOUR VOICE. A I'M CALLING
TO SUPPORT NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
WHICH WILL SUPPORT. IT BUT IF
YOU SHOW. UP PROGRAMS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE
MORTAL MAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP ON ISSUE
ONE WE URGE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM AND AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE POINT THREE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. ISSUE
EIGHT THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
OFFERS THE PROMISE OF
TRANSFORMING AND EXPANDING
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. HOWEVER IT NAME MISS
SERVING THE CRITICAL NEEDS OF
INFANTS AND TODDLERS. THE
MAJORITY OF FUNDING DIRECTED TO
PROGRAMS RELY ON PARTNERSHIPS
WITH T. K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
SETTING AND COMPLEMENTARY TO THE
INITIATIVE THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP RECOMMENDS EXPANDING
INFANT AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE INVESTMENTS WITH
NO LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND. SPENDING FINALLY ON ISSUES
TWENTY AND THIRTY SEVEN. WE ARE
IN SUPPORT WITH THE HOPE THAT
THOSE FUNDS CAN BE USED TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR
CARE COORDINATION OR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THANK YOU
KATHY ON BEHALF OF ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HELLO AND WE ARE
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN ADDING THE
HPV VACCINE. FOR THE FAMILY PACK
PROGRAM PATIENT AND ISSUE NUMBER
NINE EXPANDING FULL SCOPE MEDI
CAL FOR ALL ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PRICE DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE
FEW CLIENTS AS IT RELATES TO
ITEM THIRTY SIX THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THE 10%
PROVIDER RATE CUTS CLIENT TO
BUY. EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN I'M
HAPPY WITH THAT HEARING
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS WHICH IN
THE STATE MY DECISION
REPRESENTING HERE IN DISPENSERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ALSO
ON THAT ITEM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS WE JOINED. OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE HOUSE OF
MEDICINE THAT ASKING BILLS
PHYSICIAN SERVICES ALSO BE ADDED
TO THAT RESTORATION CATEGORY AND
LASTLY AS YOU POINTED OUT- SHARE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN PROSTHETIC
ASSOCIATION WHICH THOSE
PRACTITIONERS THAT THAT PERSONAL
PROPERTY TO CUSTOMIZE OUR BODY
CAN PROSPECT THE BISONS. THOSE
MEDICAL USERS RELIABLE DEVICES
STILL PAID AN INDEPENDENT
LIFESTYLE AND PARTICIPATION IN
THEIR COMMUNITY WELCOME ACCESS
TO OWN PEACH KERR AND MEDICAL
PROGRAM LEADS TO INCORRECT USE
OF THESE DEVICES THE CLOSEST
GROUP OF DISADVANTAGE MEDICAL
PATIENTS AND A GREATER RISK FOR
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS. DECREASE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
INCREASED INDEPENDENCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE TWENTY PRE GO AHEAD-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MAX TERRAIN I
DIRECT PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR THE
REDWOOD COMMUNITY HEALTH
COALITION EIGHT SIX COUNTY
CONSORTIUM OF NINETEEN COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHAT COMMITMENT TO
HEALTH EQUITY IN IN SERVICE TO
OUR COMMUNTIES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
REGARDLESS OF AGE WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOUR ARGUMENT FOR
HER CONTINUED DEDICATION
PREVENTING SAME DAY BILLING
LEGISLATION AND WE SUPPORT HER
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC TO OUR MEMBER
HEALTH CENTERS AND THEIR
PATIENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNDER A
SENEGAL ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO EXPRESS
VERY STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE HPV
VACCINE COVERAGE IN VALLEY PARK
ITEM WE ARE EXTREMELY GLAD TO
SEE THIS PROPOSAL AND THAT WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO THIS COST
EFFECTIVE. CANCER PREVENTION
AGENT- INTERVENTION FOR THE
PATIENT I ALSO WANNA NOTE
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE EIGHT RELATING
TO YOU YOU'RE THE HERO I'LL
WORK- ISSUED NINE TO EXPAND
MEDIKAL REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AN ISSUE
EIGHTEEN RELATED TO AT THE SIXTY
FIVE AND JUST THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO THE APARTMENT AND THE
COMMITTEE IN THE ALLEY- FOR
THEIR WORK EXAMINING MANY OTHER
ITEMS I WON'T GET INTO THAT WE-
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING ON
THE BALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIXCOLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A MAN IN A
TIGHT. WHAT COULD SHE REMEMBERS
WHAT HAPPENED OKAY BY THE- OKAY
OKAY. OKAY WELL I DON'T. IF YOU
ARE VERY HELP YOUR WHAT ALL
INDIVIDUALS HE GOT IT AFTER THAT
. OF IF YOU ACCORDING TO AFFECT
THE HEALTH OF THEM. TWO HUNDRED
HOURS OF HEALTH THE REPORT THE
ONE WITH THE OF MANAGED. ALL
FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
TIME PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON RONALD
KOEMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PENDANT BIG HELP
NETWORK WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
STATUS ISSUE NINE WE ALSO
BELIEVE FUNDS MUST BE DEDICATED
IN THIS BUDGET FOR OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION OF THE NEWLY INCOMING
POPULATION OF UNDOCUMENTED FIFTY
PLUS INDIVIDUAL STARTING IN MAY.
AND FOR THE BROADER PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND ALL IT BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WE ARE WORKING TO ADVANCE
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL GIVEN THIS
GAP IN THE BUDGET THAT HAS EVEN
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION YOU CAN ALSO
SUPPORTS ITEM THIRTY SEVEN.
EQUITY IN PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PROVIDER PAYMENTS
TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF THIS
BUDGET REQUEST THE QUALITY OF
DATA MUST BE IMPROVED WE URGE
THE DEPARTMENT TO SET ASIDE
ADEQUATE FUNDS FOR ESTABLISHMENT
OF STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR THE
COLLECTION OF REPORTING OF
DEMOGRAPHIC AND HEALTH RELATED
SOCIAL NEEDS DATA. A DATA PORTAL
CALLED PLANS PROVIDERS AND
MEDICARE MEMBERS TO ACCESS AND
UPDATE THEIR DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
AND A COLD FRONT OR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY BUILDING
AND THE PEER LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES ON BEST PRACTICES
WITH REGARDS TO THE COLLECTION
REPORTING A DEMOGRAPHIC AND
HEALTH RELATED SOCIAL NEEDS THAT
WE ALSO SUPPORT ISSUE SIXTEEN ON
DENTAL KRAUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU I WANT.
PER GO. HI MY NAME IS BILL
MORROW BLOOMER B. CENSUS FROM
KEEP FAITH IN ORANGE COUNTY I'M
NOT- WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
MEDICAID OUT ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE-
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE URGE YOU
TO BUILD ON PREVIOUS EXPANSIONS
AND FINALLY PROVIDE MEDIC HOUSE
ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANY CONCERT FOR ME YEAH
HE AND OTHER PACKAGING JOURNAL
DENTISTS TREATING BENEFICIARY IN
GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
IN LOS ANGELES PREPAID HEALTH
PLAN IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. I
SUPPORT THE DECISION TO EXTEND
THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
TO GAIN COMPENSATION ON THEM TO
CALL THEIR CHILD A PROGRAM.
BUILT A LARGER PROGRAM CONTINUES
TO SERVE MY PATIENTS A WELL I'M
I'M COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING IT
AS A COLLECTOR. I THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
COOL COOL TALK TO YOU SURE
COULDN'T COMMUNICATE SHARE TO
OUR MOST HIGH NEED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK RIGHT AWAY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WIDE WORLD TRICKS- IN THE
GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
TALK ABOUT JOHNNY SHE I SUPPORT
THE DECISION TO EXTEND THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAMS
THROUGH EDUCATION OF DENTAL
INDIRECT CALLAHAM PROGRAM. I
THINK. STRAIGHTER FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OKAY TO ENSURE. I DON'T
CARE YOU ARE MOST NEEDED-
MEMBERS- THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRINGING THE
DOCTOR BURGER KING HERE THE
GENERAL DENNIS. THE LOTTERY WILL
PREPAID HEALTH AND- I. AM THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. RECALLING
PROGRAM THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAM CONTINUED TO SERVE MY
PATIENTS WELL AND- WORKING THE
PROVIDER I THANK. OUR LOCAL
PRINTER CONTINUITY OF CARE. I
NEED TO REMEMBER THAT UNDER
SERVED ON PATIENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND GOVERNOR
PATTON MY NAME IS CINDY CENTERS
I'M CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY HEALTH ASSOCIATION
AND INSULIN REGION AN
ASSOCIATION OF TWENTY TWO
ORGANIZATIONS ONE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND EVERYTHING FROM YOU KNOW
COUNTY. THANK YOU FOR CREATING
THE BASIS TO DISCUSS ISSUES WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MACAU R.
X. ISSUE FOURTEEN CLEANING HELP
ANSWER THE MOST DIVERSE
POPULATIONS HAVE BECOME KEY TO
OVERCOMING THE COOKER NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. THANK YOU
IN ADVANCE FOR WORKING TO
ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL MEDICAL
R. X. OPERATION CHALLENGES AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUPPORTING
A FIFTEEN MILLION BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THEIR NON HOSPITAL
CLINICS IMPLEMENT A PAYMENT FORM
WHICH WAS CREATED TO HELP
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
MITIGATE THE LOSSES INCURRED BY
THE MEDICAL RECORDS TRANSITION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. TIME THANK
YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT ONE FIFTH. THREE IS
GOING. GOOD. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD PLEASE ONE
THIRTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NOT ACCEPTED
ON POLICY DIRECTOR WITH MY CUP
AND THE CENTRAL COAST OF
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
INDIGENOUS AND DOCUMENT THE
COMMUNITY WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL FOR ALL ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
ARE WE URGE YOU TO BUILD ON THE
PREVIOUS EXPANSIONS AND FINALLY
PROVIDE THAT ACCOUNT FOR ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD NIGHT
ONE THREE FIVE. HE PAID HEALTH
PLAN IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IT'S
HARD TO GET INTO A GOVERNOR AND
JUDAH AND THE TEN OTHER. OKAY
OKAY OKAY I'M INTERESTED AND ALL
WE CAN CAL. OKAY I'M THE TEMPLE
. BUT I'M CONFUSED BY POINT WELL
CAN I. AS PROVIDERS I THINK. ON
HIS PART TO ENSURE CONSISTENT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIDE ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU KNOW ME THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHNNY DEPP
LIABILITIES. I AM CALLING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN VALLEY
HEALTH CENTERS AND A ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS THAT
WE SERVE AND TRISTAN ASSAULTS
WERE SAID INVOKING COUNTY. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR CREATING SPACE TO
DISCUSS ISSUES WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MEDICAL
OUR EXTRADITION WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN. ONE OF THE
STATED GOAL THAT WE KNOW THE
MEDIC HOW OUR ACTIONS TO IMPROVE
MEDICARE BENEFICIARY ACCESS TO
PHARMACIES AND- HOWEVER THIS
GOAL IS FAR FROM BEING
ACCOMPLISHED TODAY. THE LOSS OF
THIS THREE FORTY SAVINGS WILL
IMPACT PATIENT SERVICES IN
SEVERAL WAYS. INCLUDING REDUCING
THE HOURS OF OPERATION FOR BOTH
PRIMARY CARE SITES IN PHARMACY
THAT. TRULY WE ARE SERVING MORE
THE MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
IN OUR AREA. THIS TRANSLATES
INTO PRETTY LIMITING ACCESS TO
PHARMACEUTICALS INCREASING WAIT
TIMES FOR PATIENTS TO BE SEEN.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING OVERALL
PATIENT ACCESS AND REDUCE
COMMUNITY HEALTH OUTREACH
EDUCATION. THAT'S WHY I REALLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE STATE GENERAL
FINE BECAUSE THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE- THE
FINANCIAL DAMAGES THAT WOULD
COME TO COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND THEIR PATIENTS WITH THE
TRANSITION. OF THE STATE
FINANCIAL BENEFIT COMES AT A
LOSS TO COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE START
. I ALSO WANTED TO TOUCH ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE AN IMPORTANT OR LET
YOUR TIME IS UP BUT NATIONAL
ACCOUNT YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALLER. I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ROBERT
TERRORISTS ON BEHALF BESSIE I
USED CALIFORNIA. FIRST POLLY
AREN'T STRONG FOR THE MISSION
NUMBER ONE. ISSUE NUMBER NINE
JUST ABOUT LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
RECALLED ALSO WE WANT TO COMMENT
ON THAT. RESIDENTS AND
INVESTMENT AND POP COLORS OF THE
OF THE CAL AIM IDEA. ACTUALLY
COORDINATING CARE THE SOCIAL
MODEL WITH THE MEDICAL MODEL.
IT'S A GREAT THING IT'S BEEN
GONE FOR A WHILE. THE SECOND
THING I WANT TO I WAS GONNA SAY
NEED TO TALK ABOUT CONTINUITY OF
CARE BUT THAT'S BEEN USED A LOT
WELL. IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER IS
NONE OF THIS WORK NOT ONE SINGLE
BIT ABOUT WORK. WITHOUT
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS GETTING
PAID A LIVING WAGE AND WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO STICK AROUND AND THEN
STICKING AROUND IS WHAT ACTUALLY
PRODUCES THE BEST OUTCOMES-
THANKS PRETTY MUCH YET THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE HEARING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR. A COUPLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN I'M NOT I'M
NOT HITHIS IS JOE DENTISTRY
DIMINISHES IN THE CAMPAIGN
HEALTH PLAN IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. A DECISION MICHAEL SOME
TAKEN THE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PROGRAMS WITH INFORMATION I'LL
TALKING TO KYLE LAST. PROGRAM
INTO A MANAGED CARE PROGRAM
COMMUNITY SIMMER. AND I'M
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING IT AS A
PROGRAM. I THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS GROUP BECAUSE OF
SEXUAL CONTENT. OF THE QATAR
MULTI. COME MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND YOUR
PRACTICING PEDIATRIC DENTISTS
CONFISCATING IN MANAGED CARE
PLANS ONLY TO MAKE A POSITIVE
CHANGE IN THEIR LIVES BUT
DEDICATE BENEFICIARIES I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE HONORABLE
GOVERNOR IS TRYING TO KICK
MANAGED CARE IN SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELES. I'M SORRY. I'M
EXCITED TO GET BACK. WELCOME TO
A BIT AND YOUR GOAL TRANSACTION
CODE AND CONTINUE TO COOK
SERVICE TO MEDICAID
BENEFICIARIES. CONSTANTLY
POPULATION WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM MORE. THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LUKA
YELLOWFIN AND CALL I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF BILL THEY COULD
EAGLE CENTER IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WE'RE CALLING IN FULL
SUPPORT. OF THE CAB MEDI CAL
EXPANSION FOR MEDI CAL FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TWENTY SIX
TO FORTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND NOT.
ONLY ON OUR FIFTEEN MINUTE
GENERAL DENTISTS. AND- YOU
GRABBING MANAGED CARE PROGRAM IN
CRIMINAL COUNTY I. HI OVER NINE
YEARS SOME AND- DENTAL MANAGED
CARE PROGRAMS FOOD-
IMPLEMENTATION OF DENTAL AND
I'LL CALL A I. THE MANAGED
PROGRAM CONTINUES- EARNED MINE
AS WELL I AM COMMUNITY. OR MY- I
HONESTLY HEARD. THEY ARE. ALWAYS
PREACHED AND COMMUNITY- CARING.
FOR MOST I NEED. MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO MAKE
A CALL TODAY- WE DO WANT TO HEAR
YOUR INPUT SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CALL OR EMAIL THE COMMITTEE
AT A LATER TIME. WE THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION AND PRESENTATIONS
AND EVERYBODY WHO CALLED IN AND
THE STAFF HERE IN THIS BUILDING
AND WITH THAT. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.